GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME THIS
IS THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES TODAY WE WILL BE
DISCUSSING THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION FOR HEALTH PROGRAMS I
HAVE BEEN ASKED TO READ SOME
DIRECTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP INSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY
WHILE ALLOWING FULL PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION. ALL
PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA ARE
APPEARING REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY. THERE WILL BE NO
VOTES TAKEN IN TODAY'S HEARING
AS THIS IS AN ON AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING TO
DISCUSS THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS. WE ARE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THIS HEARING BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE.
THE PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS
ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND
SHOULD BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU
ARE WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET.
THE NUMBER IS TOLL FREE.
1-877-692-8957 THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT.916-319-2090 NINE
AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST
YOU. WE WILL BEGIN PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER ALL MEMBERS HAVE
CONCLUDED THEIR QUESTIONS FOR
THE PANEL. I WANT TO NOTE THAT
WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
FEEDBACK THROUGH THE SUB ONE
EMAIL ACCOUNT. AND THE ADDRESS
IS BUDGET SUB ONE AT ASM DOT CA
DOT GOV. I'D LIKE TO BEGIN
TODAY'S HEARING BY BEING BOTH
GRATEFUL AND APPRECIATIVE OF
THE ADMINISTRATION. AND THE
GOVERNOR FOR THE CONTINUED
INVESTMENT INTO THE HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
AND FOCUSING ON A WHOLE PERSON
APPROACH. I PARTICULARLY WANT
TO UPLIFT THE INVESTMENTS INTO
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OUR CHILDREN
THAT WE ARE SEEING IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. BUT
BELIEVE WE HAVE FURTHER TO GO
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
ADDRESSING EQUITY AS WELL AS
OUR WORK FORCE SHORTAGES. I
ALSO WOULD LIKE US TO CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS ON FIGURING OUT
HOW WE CAN REFINE THE HELD FOR
ALL PROPOSAL THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAD. AND LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE
DISCUSSIONS HERE TODAY. WITH
THAT WE WILL BEGIN WITH A PANEL
ONE. FOUR PANEL ONE WE WILL
HAVE FOUR PRESENTERS ON THIS
PANEL. INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
SECRETARY DR MARK GALLI THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH DIRECTOR DR THOMAS
ARAGON AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR SUSAN FINALE AND SONYA
PADDOCK WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. WE WILL HOLD
ALL MEMBERS QUESTIONS ON THIS
PANEL UNTIL AFTER ALL OF THE
PRISONERS HAVE CONCLUDED LET US
BEGIN WITH SECRETARY DR GALLEY.
THANK YOU- DR RANDALL CHAIRMAN-
AND TO ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
WITH YOU HERE THIS AFTERNOON- I
LOOK FORWARD TO KICKING US OFF
AND THEN AT FIRST- LOOK FORWARD
TO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES- LET ME BEGIN BY
SAYING WHAT IT OPERATES BAND TO
SUBURBAN THE ROLE THAT I'VE HAD
IT WITH OUR ENTIRE TEAM AND
SHOULDER TO SHOULDER- YOU KNOW
LOCKED IN ARMS- FIGURATIVELY OF
COURSE- WITH OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS. IN PUBLIC HEALTH
ACROSS THE STATE THERE ARE
SACRIFICES THEIR VISION HARD
WORK THEIR COMMITMENT TO
PROTECTING CALIFORNIANS IS
SECOND TO NONE- I'M YOU START
CALL THEM COLLEAGUES AND
FRIENDS ARE AND HAVE REALLY
ENJOYED WORKING WITH SO MANY
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA SMALL
COUNTIES THE COUNTIES ALL
ACROSS THE STATE FOCUSED ON THE
RESPONSE TO COBRA AND I USED
WHERE ARE WHERE WE ARE AT THE
MOMENT- THE TRAJECTORY OF THE
DISEASE IN CALIFORNIA- ARE
CERTAINLY HAS BEEN THROUGH LIKE
IT HAS- ACROSS THE NATION-
LONGER TORTUROUS ROAD BUT WHERE
WE ARE TODAY- GIVES ME
CONFIDENCE THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE. WORKING ON THESE
IMPORTANT EFFORTS RUN BACK TO
NATION'S MAKING SURE THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WE BUILT UP TO
TRACK THE PANDEMIC. CONTINUE I
NOT SAID WE ALL. THAT FOR MANY
YEARS THE OF HEALTH. HAS BEEN
CHEN. THAT THERE ARE UP. TO
BUILD THAT UP. AND TO BE
INNOVATIVE AND POWERFUL. AND
THE WORK DURING THE LAST YEAR
AND WHAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED WITH
COVERT HAS REALLY REQUIRED US
TO PUT ON OUR PUT OUR BEST FOOT
FORWARD AND WORK WITH SYSTEMS
THAT CERTAINLY WERE NOT. ALWAYS
AS PREPARED AS WE WOULD HAVE
LIKED THEM TO BE WHETHER IT WAS
ON THE I. T. AND DATE UP FRONT
OR THE PERSON OUTSIDE TO DO
IMPORTANT WORK OUR TESTING
CONTACT. RACINE- QUARANTINE IN
ICE- THE WORK MOST RECENTLY ON
VACCINATION MODELING THE
DISEASE ALL OF THESE IMPORTANT
ASPECTS ARE I THINK WE HAVE
DONE VERY WELL DONE AS WELL AS
WE CAN. BUT I RECOGNIZE THE
REAL OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
IMPORTANT ADDITIONS FUNDING
COMMITMENTS TO BUILD THAT
RESOURCE UP. I DO THINK AS WE
ARE COMMITTED TO MOVING FORWARD
THAT TAKING A MOMENT AND
RECOGNIZING THAT RESOURCES THAT
BUILD UPON WHAT WE HAVE NOW TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO DO
THE IMMEDIATE WORK OF
CONTINUING TO ADDRESS THE
PANDEMIC. WELL WE LOOK FORWARD
TO RETURNING TO SOME OF THOSE
OTHER UBLIC HEALTH FUNCTIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN PUT ON THE
SIDELINE OKAY IN LIEU OF THE
PANDEMIC THAT WE CAN GET BACK
TO DOING THOSE OVER THE NEXT
MANY. WEEKS AND MONTHS TO KEEP
CALIFORNIA SAFE ACROSS ALL
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES BUT ALSO
TAKE THIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY AND
WHAT IS PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO USE DOLLARS
THREE MILLION TO BE SPECIFIC.
TO BRING TOGETHER COUNTIES. THE
STATE TOGETHER TO DETERMINE HOW
WE ARE REALLY OUR INNOVATIVE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO A TWENTY
FIRST EVEN THE TWENTY SECOND
CENTURY. PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM
WE HAVE LEARNED. ABOUT THE GAPS
WE'VE LEARNED ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES WE COULD MAKE THE
DECISION TO CONTINUE INVESTING
IN THOSE EXISTING AREAS- ALL
THE SAME OR WE CAN TAKE A
MOMENT. AND AS I'VE SAID- THE
HOBBIT PANDEMIC- HAS BEEN OUR
GREAT BIG SALARY FOR CHANGE IT
HAS UNMASKED SOME OF OUR MOST.
IMPORTANT PROBABILITIES- THE
INEQUITIES IN OUR COMMUNITIES
HAVE BEEN NEVER MORE OBVIOUS
THAN THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC
AND AN OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THOSE IN INNOVATIVE WAYS MAKING
INVESTMENTS NOT JUST IN THE
CORE FEATURES OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND HELP SUPPORT US WITH A
PANDEMIC. BUT EVEN MORE I SEE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO USE SOME OF
THE WORK THAT WE DID AROUND
HEALTHEQUITY. INC OVER TO
BRIDGE THAT GAP AROUND
HEALTHEQUITY EVEN CHRONIC
ILLNESS THE APPROACH OF USING
AN EQUITY MEASURE ON TEST
POSITIVITY. AND TRYING IT TO
OUR OUR BLUEPRINT FOR A SAFER
ECONOMY RAISES IDEAS AND
THOUGHTS ABOUT HOW WE CAN USE A
SIMILAR CONSTRUCT TO BUILD. THE
BRIDGE BETWEEN TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC HEALTH AND POPULATION
HEALTH IN THE COMMUNITY AND OUR
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM THE
OPPORTUNITY IS BEING PROPOSED
IN OTHER PARTS. OF THE GOVERNOR
AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND A
REVISED WHETHER IT'S IN THE
AREAS OF COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. GIVE
US AN OPPORTUNITY TO THINK
DIFFERENTLY ON THE BACKS OF THE
CALLIN PROPOSAL AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING MORE
CLOSELY TOGETHER LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH STATE PUBLIC HEALTH WITH
OUR HEALTH PLAN PARTNERS THAT
ARE THINKING. CREATIVELY AND
INNOVATIVELY ABOUT. PERSONAL SO
THESE THE ARE OUR CHANCES THING
MUCH DIFFERENTLY ABOUT PUBLIC
HEALTH WILL BEFORE. AND
TOGETHER LOCAL. STATE LEADERS
TO IDENTIFY THOSE GAPS THAT
HAVE BEEN MOST CLEARING- I
THINK MOST INDIVIDUALS ARE
AWARE THAT THE DATA CHALLENGES
LIVED BOTH AT THE LOCAL AND
STATE LEVEL WE HAVE VARIOUS
SYSTEMS AND REGIONS AND CAL
MEANS THAT PLUG INTO THE
STATE'S SYSTEMS. IN DIFFERENT
WAYS TO DIFFERENT NETWORKS AND
THE NEED. TO NOT ONLY MAKE
INVESTMENTS IN WHAT WE HAVE A
READY TO BUILD THEM UP TO
RETHINK THE ARCHITECTURE OF
THOSE SYSTEMS ENTIRELY OUT WE
HAVE THE CHANCE TO DO THAT NOW
I THINK WE'VE SEEN THE
DIFFICULTY I'M HAVING STAFF AT
THE READY FOR ALL THE
FUNCTIONS. IN BIG COUNTIES AND
SMALL COMPANIES ALIKE AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THINK ABOUT HOW
WE- DO THE WORK AT THE STATE
LEVEL AND AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND BRING BACK TOGETHER MAYBE
EVEN SUGGESTING SOME REGIONAL
APPROACHES TO ADDRESSING PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISES WHETHER ON THE
INFECTIOUS DISEASE SITES OR
SOMEWHERE ELSE. I ALSO CALL ON
THE OPPORTUNITY WITHIN PUBLIC
HELP TO REALLY LEAD IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. THE ONE OF
THE OTHER PROPOSALS WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT AROUND CHILDREN'S
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AS A VERY
IMPORTANT- PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT
EDUCATION- CAMPAIGN OUTREACH
CAMPAIGN THAT I AND WE HAVE
ALWAYS SEEN AS CORE- TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH MISSION. AND
BEING ABLE TO ENSURE THAT OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEMS LOCALLY
AND AT THE STATE ARE POISED AND
PREPARED TO BUILD ON THAT SO.
THE PROPOSAL- THAT WE ADVANCED
AND- MAY REVISE IS ONE THIRD OF
IT KNOWLEDGE IS THE NEED FOR
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
PUBLIC HEALTH. KNOWLEDGE IS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AND WORK
AND PLAN ACROSS LOCAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS TO MAKE THOSE.
INVESTMENTS THOUGHTFUL TO MAKE
THOSE INVESTMENTS WE CAN BE
PROPER UP NOT A IN THIS RUN
JUST UP THE THAT ARE IMPRTANT
NOW BUT THAT RELEASED US UP.
FOR DEALING WITH THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISES THAT LAY AHEAD I
THINK ABOUT ROUTE I THINK ABOUT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH I THINK ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE I THINK ABOUT
THE ON GOING. IMPORTANT
CRITICAL WORK ON HEALTHEQUITY
AND EQUITY LARGE AS REAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO DO
THESE AT THE STATE LEVEL AT THE
REGIONAL LEVEL AND WORK ITS
COURSE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. SO
WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS AND- OF A TURN IT BACK
TO YOU- CHAIRMAN TO. HELP WITH
ANY ADDITIONAL PARTS. OF THE
PRESENTATION OR QUESTION. THANK
YOU DR GOLLY NECK WE WILL HEAR
DOCTOR ERICA. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SAY A FEW WORDS ABOUT THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE I
WANT TO- THINK OF THE CHAIRMAN
AND ALL OF THE FOLKS OUT IN THE
AUDIENCE ESPECIALLY THE LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH PRACTITIONERS
WERE REALLY- DO THE TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF WORK AS- PUBLIC
HEALTH HAPPENS NOT JUST THAT AT
THE STATE LEVEL BUT ABSOLUTELY
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. ONE THING I
WANT TO POINT OUT IS THAT WE
ARE STILL IN THE ACTIVE
RESPONSE AS WE OPEN UP OUR
ECONOMY WE KNOW THAT RISK IS
GOING TO INCREASE IN SO OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE IS
GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE VERY
ACTIVATED WEEK WE STILL NEED TO
DO- CASE FINDING A CASE OF
INSTIGATION CONTACT TRACING. WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
PUTTING OUT ANY FIRES ACROSS
THE STATE AS WE OPEN UP THE
ECONOMY WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO VACCINATE
FOLKS AND GET OUR COMMUNITY
IMMUNITY UP AS MUCH AS AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE. AND THEN TO ALSO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT BOTH THE
BUSINESSES THE COMMUNITIES AND
PUBLIC HEALTH IN THIS ENDEAVOR
BECAUSE WE STILL ARE AN
ACTIVATION MODE WE STILL HAVE A
LOT OF STAFF THAT ARE
ACTIVATED. SO WE'RE WE'RE GONNA
SPEND THE NEXT SEVERAL WEEKS
WORKING WITH A LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS LOOKING BETTER
SYSTEMS FIGURING OUT HOW WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT ALL
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE CURRENTLY
ACTIVATED AND ACTUALLY PUT THEM
BACK INTO CONTINUITY OF
OPERATIONS THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK THAT'S NOT GETTING DONE
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE ACTIVATED SO
THAT IT IS PLANNING TIME THAT
WE HAVE. IS REALLY CRITICAL TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE STABILIZE OUR
SYSTEM THAT WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
A POSITIVE IMPACT AND THAT WE
SPEND THE TIME DOING A
THOUGHTFUL ASSESSMENT OF HOW
WE'RE GOING TO BUILD THE PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEM OF THE OTHER OF
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY. SO
THAT'S THAT THAT'S THE WITH
WE'RE GOING TO DO IN THE NEXT
COME IN IN THE COMING WEEKS
AND- THAT'S THE ONLY THING I
WANTED TO ADD TO DR. KELLY'S
COMMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NOW WE WILL HEAR FOR CHEAP
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR SUSAN
FANELLI. I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
TO ADD TO THE SECRETARY OR
DIRECTOR'S REMARKS BUT STAND
READY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM
FINALLY WE WILL HEAR FROM SONYA
PADDOCK WITH THE L. A. L. THANK
YOU DR ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS-
SEND YOU A PIC FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S. OFFICE I
WANT TO START BY MENTIONING
THAT THIS PROPOSAL IS REALLY
THE ONLY SIGNIFICANT POLICY
PROPOSAL IN THE GOVERNOR'S MAIN
REVISION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH BUDGET. AND IN
FACT WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
GENERAL
FOR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO MOST
OF THE FUNDING 82% IS GOING TO
COPE AND RELATED ACTIVITIES.
AND WHEN YOU SORT OF REMOVE
THOSE ACTIVITIES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH'S
GENERAL FUND BUDGET. IT LEAVES
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY I'M SORRY
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE.
MILLION DOLLARS- FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. SO
NEXT I WANT TO TALK FOR A
MOMENT ABOUT THE PROPOSAL
ITSELF- IT REALLY THE END
IMMIGRANTS SPONSOR VIEW
PROPOSAL REALLY MENTIONS KEY
THREE KEY ASPECTS THE FIRST
BEING. TO ASSESS THE STATE'S
PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE TO COVER
NINETEEN. THE SECOND IS TO
REVIEW THE CENTRAL PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS AND
RESOURCES. AND THE THIRD IS TO
ASSESS THE ROOT CAUSES OF
DISPARITIES EXPERIENCED BY
THOSE WHO ARE MOST
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
THE PANDEMIC. ANDREALLY THIS
IS- THE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL-
ADDRESSES- IS THAT- NOTES THAT
THESE ACTIVITIES WOULD BE DONE
REALLY TO INFORM A PROPOSAL AT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN JANUARY.
NOW THE TIMING THE PROPOSAL
MENTIONS THAT THE STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT WOULD BEGIN NOW AS
DR ERIC ON JUST MENTIONED- AND
THAT IF THEY WANTED TO USE A
VENDOR TO HELP WITH THE STUDY
THAT WOULD BE PROCURED IN JULY.
AND THEN BY SEPTEMBER- THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF PREPARING  BUDGET
PROPOSAL. I WOULD NOTE THAT
OTHER DETAILS ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL ARE UNKNOWN FOR
EXAMPLE WHAT THE PROCESS WOULD
BE FOR CONDUCTING THE STUDY
WHAT THE DELIVERABLES WOULD BE
ASIDE FROM THE ULTIMATE- BUDGET
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD WOULD BE
PRESENTED IN JANUARY. AND WE'RE
NOT CLEAR RIGHT NOW WHAT THE
EXPENDITURES OF THE THREE
MILLION DOLLARS WOULD ACTUALLY
BE FOR ASIDE FROM THE
POSSIBILITY OF HIRING OF A
VENDOR OR OR COMP OUTSIDE
CONTRACTOR. NO WE WOULD NOTE
THAT THE TIMING AND THE
RESPONSE COMPONENT THE RESPONSE
REVIEW COMPONENT OF THE STUDY
UP HERE CAN TO WHAT'S CALLED AN
AFTER ACTION REVIEW. I'M AFTER
ACTION REVIEWS ARE CONDUCTED
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING A PUBLIC
HEALTH INVENTOR OTHER TYPE OF
EMERGENCY- FOR EXAMPLE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY- CONDUCTED THEIR AFTER
ACTION REVIEW OF HURRICANE
KATRINA JUST FIVE MONTHS AFTER
THE HURRICANE STARTED. AND IT'S
REALLY HELPED TO MEN YEAH IT'S
REALLY MEANT TO HELP KEEP
PLAYERS UNDERSTAND THE ACTIONS
THAT WERE TAKEN IN RESPONSE TO
AN EMERGENCY WHAT WENT WELL
WHAT MAYBE DIDN'T GO SO WELL
WHAT NEEDS TO BE CHANGED. SO I
JUST. WANT TO RAISE A FEW- A
FEW KEY POINTS FIRST. OUR
OFFICE RECOGNIZES THAT
CONDUCTING AN AFTER ACTION
REVIEW IS BOTH CRITICAL AND
IMPORTANT FOR IMPROVING A
PROCESS SEES AND EMERGENCY
RESPONSE. BUT WE WOULD NOT THAT
THE SCOPE OF THIS PROPOSAL
APPEARS MUCH BROADER DESPITE
THE- THE AGGRESSIVE TIMELINE.
NOT ONLY DOES THE REVIEW
PROPOSED TO ASSESS THE PUBLIC
HEALTH RESPONSE TO COPE IN
NINETEEN BUT IT ALSO PROPOSES
TO ASSESS A COMPLEX SET OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE IN RESOURCE
NEEDS AND THEN THE THIRD
ASPECT- LOOKING AT THAT THE
ROOT CAUSES OF DISPARITIES THAT
WERE EXACERBATED BY COPE WITH
NINETEEN. I NEXT WE POINT OUT
THAT THERE DOES APPEAR TO BE
SOME DUPLICATION WITH ANOTHER
STUDY THAT'S PROPOSED IN THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY. THE AGENCY IS PROPOSING
A ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION FOR A
RETROSPECTIVE ANALYSIS OF THE
INTERSECTION OF COVERT NINETEEN
AND DISPARITIES. NO GIVEN THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTS THE
CODE NINETEEN HAD ON PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND LOW WAGE WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA. A HEALTH EQUITY
LENS APPEARS TO BE ONE OF THE
APPROPRIATE LENSES THROUGH
WHICH TO CONDUCT A PANDEMIC OR
RESPONSE REVIEW. HOWEVER AT
THIS TIME IT'S UNCLEAR HOW THE-
DPH AND THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY EFFORTS WOULD
BE COORDINATED SO AS NOT TO
DUPLICATE- EFFORTS WHEN LOOKING
AT THE ROOT CAUSES OF
DISPARITIES. I'M FINALLY I'D
LIKE TO RAISE SOME ISSUES FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION.
FIRST WE SUGGEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER BREAKING
THIS PROPOSAL INTO TWO STUDIES
THE FIRST WOULD BE AN AN AFTER
ACTION REVIEW A QUICKLY. I'M
SORRY A STUDY THAT'S DONE
QUICKLY- COULD LIKELY BE DONE
IN HOUSE AND COULD LIKELY BE
DONE RELATIVELY INEXPENSIVELY
IT CAN REALLY HELP WITH NEAR
TERM DECISION MAKING CLOSING
IDENTIFIED GAPS IN CAPACITY
EXPERTISE OR OR PLANNING
CAPABILITIES. THE SECOND STUDY
WOULD THEN BE A MULTI YEAR
ASSESSMENT. THIS WOULD BE A
MORE OMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE AND RESOURCE
NEEDS OF BOTH THE STATE AND
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT
LEVEL- BUT IT COULD ALSO TAKE
A- TAKE A STEP BACK AND EVEN
LOOK AT THE ROLE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH IN CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS- GOVERNANCE. STRUCTURES.
FINALLY WE SUGGESTED THAT- THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER BRIDGE
FUNDING TO BOTH THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH AS WELL AS
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WHILE
BOTH OF THESE STUDIES ARE UNDER
WAY THE LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO
CONSIDER ESTABLISHING A RESERVE
FOR FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING. DEREK
HAS REALLY HIGHLIGHTED SERIOUS
DEFICIENCIES IN THE STATE'S
PUBLIC HEALTH CAPACITY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE BOTH AT THE
STATE LEVEL AS WELL AS AMONG
THE SIXTY ONE LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS- BOTH.
DEPARTMENTS AT BOTH LEVELS HAVE
HAVE DEALT WITH DECLINING
LEVELS OF FUNDING OVER THE
YEARS AS WELL AS FUNDING THAT'S
HIGHLY RESTRICTIVE IN NATURE.
AND WHILE BOTH- STATE AND LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE
AN INFLUX OF FEDERAL FUNDING
RIGHT NOW THAT FEDERAL FUNDING
IS REALLY- SPECIFIC TO THE
COVERT RESPONSE. ALTERNATELY
TIME LIMITED- THE LEGISLATURE
MIGHT WISH TO CONSIDER SOME
AMOUNT OF ONGOING ANNUAL
SUPPORT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND LOCAL HEALTH
JUST JURISDICTIONS BEGINNING IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE OTHER EAST
CENTRAL NON CODE NINETEEN OR-
PUBLIC HEALTH ACTIVITIES- WE
WOULD ALSO SUGGESTED THIS
FUNDING BE SOMEWHAT FLEXIBLE.
IN ADDITION THIS FUNDING COULD
HELP BOTH DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS RETAIN SOME OF THE
STAFF THAT THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
HIRE AND TRAIN DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND THEN THE
LEGISLATURE COULD REALLY TAKE A
LOOK AT THE FINDINGS FROM BOTH
OF THE STUDIES- AND SORT OF RE
CALIBRATE FUNDING LEVELS- AND
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES- ONCE
THEY HAVE THE INFORMATION FROM
BOTH THE IMMEDIATE. AFTER
ACTION REVIEW AS WELL AS THE
MULTI YEAR ASSESSMENT. AND THEN
FINALLY IF THESE- RATHER TO
PREPARE TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
FUTURE FUNDING REQUIREMENTS THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
ESTABLISHING A FUNDING RESERVES
THIS YEAR IN. TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO- SUPPORTED BY AVAILABLE
REVENUES FOR DISCRETIONARY
SPENDING PURPOSES. I THANK YOU
DOCTOR IN DELAND I'M I'M THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WOULD LIKE TO GIVE
A OPPORTUNITY TO DR ERICA PAN
WHO IS ALSO SCHEDULED TO BE ON
THIS PANEL IF SHE HAS ANY
COMMENTS- IF SHE DOES NOT WE
WILL TURN THE MEMBERS QUESTIONS
BUT DR PAM WANTED TO SEE IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ADD ANYTHING TO
THIS DISCUSSION- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I HAVE NOTHING TO ADD FROM
A DOCTOR. AND A DOCTOR KELLY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WITH THAT
WE WILL BRING IT UP FOR MEMBERS
QUESTIONS. DOCTOR WHAT. THANK
YOU I THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND
THANK YOU TO THE PANEL- I- I
JUST WANTED KNOWLEDGE A DOCTOR
GOLLY AND HIS TEAM FOR ALL OF
THE WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND ANY
KNOWLEDGE AND- HE AND I SPOKE
THIS MORNING I OBVIOUSLY HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ABOUT
PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING AND-
APPRECIATE THE SPIRIT OF OUR
DISCUSSION AND HAVE A I THINK I
NOW HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
OF WHERE THE ADMINISTRATION
WANTS TO WANTS TO GO HERE. I
GUESS MY CONCERN. IS IN A
STATEMENT ACTUALLY ONE OF THE I
COULD I WOULD WRITE THIS DOWN.
ABOUT OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN SET
ASIDE DURING COPE IT. AND AND
THAT IS ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
I FEEL STRONG SO STRONGLY ABOUT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH AT THIS POINT. I THINK
OF MY OWN COUNTIES. AND ONCE IT
ONE IN PARTICULAR. THAT
RECENTLY IN RECENT YEARS- WAS-
SEEN UPTICKS IN- SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASES HEPATITIS
C. H. I. V- AND- PUTTING THAT
IN THE BACKDROP. OF A TEN YEAR.
DECLINE IN THE FUNDING FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEMS AND
PRACTICALLY HAVING TO BEG FOR
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO COMBAT
THESE THESE SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUES THAT WERE
SURFACING IN THE COMMUNITY- I
ALSO WANNA NOTE THAT. I THAT
HE- DR GOTTLIEB POINTED OUT
ABOUT HEALTH INFORMATION- AND
THEN THE SYSTEMS THERE HAD OUR
SYSTEMS YOU KNOW. YOU KNOW BEEN
IN A BETTER SHAPE IN SOME CASES
OR HAD WE BEEN ABLE TO HAVE WE
BEEN ABLE TO IF WE ARE ABLE TO
BUILD BETTER HEALTH INFORMATION
SYSTEMS. WE WOULD BE MUCH
BETTER AT COMMUNICATING WITH
HEALTH ENTITIES ONE ANOTHER AND
WOULD ALSO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
MUCH BETTER HANDLE ON ON
DISEASE SURVEILLANCE.
THROUGHOUT THE- COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE SHOWING THE GREATEST
IS DISPARITIES IF WE CANNOT
HAVE THE DATA. TO- TO ANALYZE
IT'S GOING TO BE MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT FOR US TO GET TO THE
POINT WHERE WE CAN IDENTIFYTHE
ROOT CAUSES OF DISPARITIES WE
DON'T HAVE THE DATA TO BACK IN
THE BACKGROUND TO SUPPORT THAT.
AND THAT IS IT AND THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF THE PUBLIC
POPULATION HEALTH THE PART THAT
I THAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT- THAT DOES
TROUBLE ME A LITTLE BIT IN THE
LISTENING TO THE L. A. O. NEED
TO DIGEST A LITTLE BIT. ABOUT
WHERE THEY'RE GOING BUT- DO
WONDER IF THAT IS IF IT DOES
MAKE SENSE TO BREAK THIS INTO
PIECES- AND- AND THAT'S
SOMETHING I DIDN'T DIDN'T KNOW
OR DIDN'T EXPECT TO HEAR- AND
APPRECIATE HEARING THAT. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I KNOW WE'RE
GOING TO FACE IS A WORKFORCE
PROBLEM WE'RE ALREADY FACING
WORKFORCE PROBLEM MANY PUBLIC
HEALTH- PEOPLE WORKING PUBLIC
HEALTH HAVE BEEN BURNED OUT.
OVER WORKED. AND WE'D WE
DESPERATELY NEED TO REINVEST IN
WORKFORCE. AND THAT'S SOMETHING
WE SHOULD BE DOING NOW. YEAH I
DON'T SEE THAT WE I DON'T SEE
THAT A DELAY REALLY REALLY
HELPS US HELPS US IN THAT. AND
THEN- FINALLY- I WANNA SEE.
THAT A COUPLE OF THINGS. I'D
LIKE TO SEE THAT IF WE ARE
GIVING. RE STATE RESOURCES TO
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS THAT
GO DIRECTLY TO PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND THAT THERE BE
ACCOUNTABILITY ON THE OTHER
END- I BELIEVE NOW THAT A LOT
OF MONEY GOES TO COUNTIES IF
I'M WRONG PLEASE CORRECT ME. IN
THE COUNTIES DECIDE WHERE IT'S
GOING TO GO AND MY EXPERIENCES
THERE IS OFTEN A LITTLE BIT OF
A SHUFFLING AND THINGS ARE
GOING ON THERE AND THAT THAT IF
WE'RE DEDICATING MONEY AT THE
STATE LEVEL FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
IT NEEDS TO GO TO PUBLIC
HEALTH. BUT IN RETURN FOR THAT.
THERE SHOULD BE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO. SEE
THE SEE THE RESULTS OF THOSE
THOSE- THOSE INVESTMENTS AND SO
THOSE ARE MY COMMENTS AND- I
DON'T KNOW IF ANYBODY ON THE
OTHER END WANTS TO RESPOND ANY
OF THAT BUT I JUST WANT TO.
APPRECIATE THE SPIRIT IN WHICH
THE CONVERSATIONS I'VE HAD WITH
WITH. MOST OF YOUR OVERTIME AND
WANT TO CONTINUE THAT TO DO
THAT IN A POSITIVE AND
CONSTRUCTIVE WAY. THANK YOU.
OUR IS IT OKAY IF I RESPOND TO
A TALK TO WORK PLEASED DR KELLY.
RIGHT AND SO DR THANK YOU AND
YES APPRECIATE OUR ON GOING
CONVERSATIONS AND THE SPIRIT OF
YOUR COMMENTS TODAY CERTAINLY
I'LL JUST HIGHLIGHT ED ARE
ALSO- THIS PRODUCT COMMENTS ARE
APPRECIATE THEM AND THINKING
ABOUT THE AFTER ACTION REPORT
STYLE WHICH IS OF COURSE
NECESSARY ON. AN INTERIM AFTER
ACTIONS ARE OCCURRING ALL ALONG
pPANDEMIC RESPONSE FOR THE STATE
FOR THE NATION COUNTY BY COUNTY
IS GOING TO UNDERGO. THOSE
IMPORTANT AFTER ACTION. REPORTS
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT LOOKING
FORWARD ARM WHAT WAS PROPOSED
AS A POTENTIAL MULTI YEAR
APPROACH I THINK THAT A LOT OF
THE IMPORTANT WORK THAT CAN
INFORM SUCH INVESTMENTS OVER
THE LONG TERM- GLOBAL ROLE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH IN OUR STATE. HOW
IT'S DIVIDED AND STORMS OF
RESPONSIBILITIES AND DUTIES
WITHIN COUNTIES WITHIN THE
STATE ARE POTENTIALLY A
REGIONAL ASPECT AS WELL IN
CERTAIN PARTS OF THE STATE
WHERE WORK FORCES CHALLENGED
WHERE SOME OF THE- TOOLS ARE
NOT IN THE ABUNDANCE THAT YOU
NEED- IN CERTAIN PLACES WHEN
THERE'S ISSUES THAT ARISE
CRISES THAT ARISE. BUT I DO
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE A HEAD
START ON SOME OF THAT WORK-
COUNTY IS THE STATE HAS BEEN
CONSIDERING- SO MANY OF THESE
THINGS NOW AND THAT BEING ABLE.
TO DO THAT SOONER THAN MULTIPLE
YEARS IS WHAT OUR BELIEF IS BUT
VERY MUCH IN THE SAME SPIRIT.
THAT THE- OF VALUATION IS
COMPREHENSIVE IT'S NOT JUST
LOOKING AT ONE SPECIFIC PART OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE THAT
EXIST TODAY OF COURSE SOME OF
THOSE TOOLS WILL BE IMPORTANT
TO MAINTAIN. STRENGTHENED BUT
ALSO. WE BELIEVE THAT THE
ARCHITECTURE OF HOW HEALTH
WORKS IN THE STATE. SHOULD BE
OUR READ CANCER RIACH IN THE
AND THAT WE HAVE DONE SOME OF
THE YOUR THING. AND PROCESS OR
ON THAT POINT SO- EXACT. TWO
RICK THE FOR. HAVING TO BRING
TOGETHER THESE CONCEPTS TO
THOSE QUESTIONS IN ORDER TO BE
READY AND- THIS JAN WITH
THOUGHT. COMPREHEND PROPOSAL IT
IS ALL NEVER GOING TO- CAPTURE
EVERY LAW ASPECT OF WILL BE.
CONSIDERING PUBLIC HEALTH IS
VERY DYNAMIC WELL OF ALL.
CONTINUE TO EVOLVE AS IT HAS
OVER THE YEAR OVER TIME SO. I
WILL NEED TO REMAIN NUMBER. AND
QUICK RESPOND BUT WE BUT- THAT
OUR SICK. AMOUNT OF THE
SUGGESTED MULTI YEAR REVIEW
COULD BE DONE- TOGETHER WITH
OUR LOCAL- AS WELL AS ST
COLLEAGUES. OVER THE NEXT
MONNING MONTHS. COMMITTEE THIS
IS JUST A FOLLOW UP TONIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DR GOLLY
AND I'M VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT. I JUST WANTED A I DO WANT
TO POINT OUT JUST ONE THING AND
IT IT IT'S JUST START BE
THINKING ABOUT AS YOU WERE
TALKING- YOU KNOW IRONICALLY.
SOME OF OUR SMALLEST COUNTIES
HAVE DONE REMARKABLY WELL
DURING THIS AS FAR AS THEIR
PUBLIC HEALTH FUNCTIONS AND
I'LL POINT OUT MENDOCINO COUNTY
FOR EXAMPLE DOCTOR AND CORENT.
HAS DONE A FABULOUS JOB IN
MENDOCINO COUNTY- I COUNTY OF
EIGHTY THOUSAND PEOPLE AND WIN
THIS COBIT STARTED THEIR PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT CONSISTED OF
A PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER AND A
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE. AND THE
WORK THEY HAVE DONE HAS BEEN-
TRULY ASTOUNDING SO I HOPE THAT
AS WE START TO READ RE ENVISION
PUBLIC HEALTH THAT WE WILL LOOK
TO SOME OF THE- THE- SOME OF
THESE EXPERIENCES THAT BIGGER
IS NOT ALWAYS NECESSARILY MORE
EFFICIENT OR BETTER. LEAN AND
MEAN GOT IT DONE AND IN MANY IN
MANY MANY AREAS AND CONTINUES
TO GET IT DONE ON A DAILY BASIS
SO. I JUST A PLUG FOR MY- MY
RURAL COUNTIES. ALL ECHO THAT-
DOCTOR WOULD DIE I ENJOYED
WORKING WITH SO MANY. OF THOSE
SMALL NIMBLE ROLE COUNTIES I
GOT TO THEM VERY WELL AND PROUD
TO KNOW THEM IN THE HARD WORK
THAT THEY DID AND IT'S BEEN
TREMENDOUS. SO YOUR POINT IS A
VALUABLE ONE IN NEEDS TO BE.
TAUGHT FULLY INTEGRATED IN. ANY
ASSESSMENT BOTH IN THE SHORT
RUN AND ALONGER TERM-
ASSESSMENT THAT I THINK WE'RE
ALL COMMITTED TO DOING. THANK
YOU SEE NO MORE MEMBERS
QUESTIONS I'LL BRING IT BACK UP
TO THE CHAIR AND I WANTED TO
DIG IN ON SOMETHING THE DOCTOR
WOULD HAD MENTIONED AND- REALLY
FOCUS ON EQUITY. I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHETHER. YOUR CARE
DELIVERED IS DETERMINED BY YOUR
ZIP CODE. IT WOULD APPEAR AT
THE MOMENT THAT IT'S THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION AND THE FUNDING
LEVEL THAT DETERMINES THE
AMOUNT OF PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
THAT YOU GET. AND THAT SEEMS
COUNTER TO MANY OF THE EQUITY
PROPOSALS THAT WE HAVE AND WAS
HOPING THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
COULD COMMENT ON. YEAH DR
EMULATE THANK YOU AND YOU AND I
HAVE ENJOYED CONVERSATIONS OVER
THE COURSE OF THE PANDEMIC
ABOUT. THE ON GOING NEED TO BE
MORE EQUITY FOCUSED AND FOR US
THAT MEANS IN PART BUT NOT
ONLY. TO ENSURE THAT RESOURCES
ARE DRIVEN TO COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN GRAVELY IMPACTED I
THINK ONE THING THAT WE WIL
SEE. PLAINER AND PLAINER AS WE
DO THESE REVIEWS EVERYDAY IS
THAT UNDERLYING HEALTH
DISPARITIES STROKE COPD
OUTCOMES MORE THAN WE THINK-
THAT THE INCREASE IN MORBIDITY
AND MORTALITY EXPERIENCE BUT
CERTAIN COP COMMUNITIES.
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES BY RACE AND
ETHNICITY CERTAIN COMMUNITIES
BY ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE ARE
GOING TO BE LINKED TO THE
AVAILABILITY OF PRIMARY CARE
SPECIALTY CARE- PREVENTATIVE
CARE EXCEPT TRUCK THAT ALLOWS
US TO CONTROL COMMON CONDITIONS
SUCH AS DIABETES OBESITY- HEART
DISEASE EXCEPT FOR US SO. WE
HAVE OUR WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO
GO BUT I THINK WE HAVE DONE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF LEARNING
DURING COVERED AND CAN APPLY
THOSE. IN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH AND
HEALTH SYSTEM INVESTMENTS I
THINK THE CATALAN PROPOSAL
THAT'S IN FRONT OF. ALL OF YOU
AS WELL REALLY DOES ELEVATE OUR
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH AROUND
HEALTH EQUITY AND ENSURING THAT
WE'RE BUILDING AND- ACCESS TO
SERVICES. NOT JUST BASED ON-
ZIP CODE BUT REALLY TRYING TO
LINK SOME OF THOSE IMPORTANT
TELEHEALTH AND VIRTUAL VISITS
SOME OF THOSE TRANSITIONS IN
CARE LOOKING AT SOCIAL DRIVERS
OF HEALTH SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF HEALTH. AND THEN BRINGING IT
BACK TO BEHAVIORAL. SIDE BUT
ALSO ON THE SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS SEXUAL IMPORTANT
INVESTMENTS THROUGHOUT THIS
PROJECT WHICH I THINK REALLY TO
ELEVATE HEALTHEQUITY BUT
BRINGING IT BACK TO THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE. THANK
ONE PART OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT FRANKLY IT'S HARD TO EVEN
SAY IT HASN'T BEEN- INVESTED IN
ADEQUATELY IN SOME WAYS IT'S
INVISIBLE. AND THAT IS THE
PUBLIC HEALTH LINK TO THE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM BUT
WORK AROUND CHRONIC DISEASE AND
PREVENTION REAL OPPORTUNITY
WHEREIN WE INVEST. ONGOING
DOLLARS. IN SIGNIFICANT WAYS
AND HEALTH DELIVERY WELL WE ARE
FAILED TO INTEGRATE COMPLETELY
RAGE HAT POPULATION HEALTH AND
THAT INDIVIDUAL HEALTH.
STRUCTURE SO I THINK THIS IS A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY AND THEN
ON THE WORK FOR FIRST ARE WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT OUR
WORKFORCE FOCUSED PROGRAMS-
THROUGHOUT DIFFERENT COMPONENTS
WHETHER IT'S- GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION. OR BRINGING TOGETHER
MORE COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS
THAT IT AS I'VE SAID BEFORE
WALK TO WORK NO THE COMMUNITIES
AND CAN DELIVER ON EQUITY IN
SOME IMPORTANT WAYS THAT THESE
ARE TREMENDOUS CHANCES TO BUILD
UP THAT WORKFORCE. IN ORDER TO
MEET THE HEALTH NEEDS OF
DIVERSE. POPULATIONS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. I DID WANT TO SURE
THANK THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
THEIR WORK WITH AND CALAMP FROM
THE THOUGHT OF US AS WELL AS
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROPOSAL
AS I DO THINK THAT REALLY DOES
HELP US ADDRESS MANY OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH. CHALLENGES THAT
WE FACE AS THE STATE AND DO
LOOK FORWARD TO THE GAP
ANALYSIS THAT WILL BE COMPLETED
AS PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR.
AND OUR OPPORTUNITY AS THE
LEGISLATURE TO FIGURE OUT HOW
WE CAN CONTINUE TO INVEST INTO
PUBLIC HEALTH. I LOOK FORWARD
TO THINKING ABOUT HOW WE CAN
THINK ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH
DIFFERENTLY MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE EQUITY AT ITS CORE IN THE
WERE FOCUSED ON TAKING CARE OF
THOSE WHO ARE MOST VULNERABLE.
WITH THAT I WILL THANK VERY
MUCH THIS PANEL AND WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO PENALTIES. PANEL TWO
WILL FOCUS ON THE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE PROPOSAL WE WILL
HAVE TEN PRESENTERS ON THIS
PANEL. INCLUDING DR MARK COLLIE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES SECRETARY. WILL LIGHT
BORN IN G. C. COOPER THE
DIRECTOR AND STATE MEDICAID
DIRECTOR. FOR DH CS KELLY
PFEIFFER DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. MERRY
WATANABE WHO IS THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTH CARE. ELIZABETH
LANDSBERG THE DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT. DR
ROSHAN FRAUD. RESEARCH NOT.
OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. TO
BE DEALING WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION. AND
COREY HACIENDA AND BEN JOHNSON
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. LET'S BEGIN WITH
SECRETARY DR GOLLY. ALL THANK
YOU AGAIN DR ARAMBULA AND- THE
ENTIRE ARE- OUR GROUP- OUR OUR
ENTIRE TEAM HERE JOINT JOINED
US TODAY TO PRESENT HERE- IT'S
REALLY A GREAT PRIVILEGE AND
HONOR TO BE ABLE TO- KICK THIS
PRESENTATION TALK ABOUT REALLY
ALL OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES PANEL BECAUSE SO MANY
DEPARTMENTS. ARE INTEGRATED
COMING TOGETHER TO- DELIVERED
THIS PROPOSAL- I AM AS I'VE
SAID PREVIOUSLY ARE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BRING A PROGRAM THAT IN SO
MANY WAYS IN CALIFORNIA HAS
LAGGED- INVESTMENTS HAVE BEEN
THERE BUT NOT ALWAYS THE
RESULTS THAT WE WANT TO SEE
WHEN IT COMES TO CHILDREN'S AND
YOUNG PEOPLE'S BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH THE PROPOSAL- IN MANY
WAYS REFLECTS IN MY OPINION AND
I THINK MANY OF OUR OPINION. A
COMMITMENT TO WHAT HAS HAPPENED
OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST
YEAR TO YOUNG PEOPLE BUT WE
KNOW THAT THE PANDEMIC
EXACERBATED- DISPARITIES AND
CHALLENGES ON BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ISSUES FOR CALIFORNIA'S YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT EXISTED BEFORE
MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY THE FOUR
HUNDRED NINETEEN WAS PART OF
OUR NORMAL LEXICON. WE WERE US
PROVIDERS PRIMARY CARE
PEDIATRICIAN MYSELF WE
WITNESSED YEARS DECADES OF
INCREASING CONCERNS CHALLENGES
IN OUR COMMUNITIES ARE ISSUES
AROUND ANXIETY DEPRESSION.
INCREASED SUICIDE- AND OTHER-
MOTIONAL AND BEHAVIORAL ISSUES
THAT CHALLENGE OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
AS YOUNG AS YOU KNOW A FEW
YEARS AND ALL THE WAY THROUGH
THOSE INSTITUTE OF HIGHER
EDUCATION YEAR AS AN INTEL-
ADULTHOOD IT HAS BEEN SAID THAT
BUDGETS ARE A TRUE
MANIFESTATION OF OUR VALUES AND
THE PROPOSAL. THAT WE'RE
ADVANCING HERE TODAY- IS IN OUR
AS COMMITMENT OF THE VALUES TO.
LOOK TO LOOK AFTER YOUNG PEOPLE
AND THEIR EMOTIONAL HEALTH. WE
ARE PROPOSAL IS FOCUSED ON OUR
GOAL ZERO TO TWENTY FIVE.
CALIFORNIANS NOT JUST THE DOES
AND THE K. THROUGH TWELVE- BUT
THOSE YOUNGEST INDIVIDUALS
CHILD CARE. DOES THAT FIRST
FIVE FOCUSES ON THOSE ZERO TO
THREE ZERO TO FIVE YEARS THAT
WE AS OUR ADVOCATES OF YOUNG
PEOPLE NOW ARE SO CRITICAL.
SUPPORTER OF THOSE ON OUR
COLLEGE CAMPUSES AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WHERE WE KNOW THE
STRUGGLES OF THE LAST YEAR I'VE
ONLY MADE THINGS MORE
DIFFICULT. DOT CONCEPT IS
REALLY SEVEN PARKS- BEGINNING
OUR INVESTMENTS IN A BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH VIRTUAL PORTAL THAT IS
MEANT TO BE AVAILABLE STATE
WIDE TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK. ACCESS POINT
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IN OUR CRISIS
BUT HOPEFULLY THOSE WHO ARE IN
NEED OF EARLY INTERVENTIONS THE
FOCUS OF THE PLATFORM IS TO
IDENTIFY YOUNG PEOPLE AS EARLY
ON IN THE COURSE OF SYMPTOMS IN
THE COURSE OF CHALLENGES. BAD
BEFORE WE SEE THE JEEP AND
MANIFESTATIONS OF UNCONTROLLED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES REALLY
A DOWN PAYMENT ON. DURING THAT
OF DOOR IT'S AS ROBUST AS
POSSIBLE THAT IT'S AVAILABLE AS
FAR NORTH AS SISKIYOU AND AS
FAR SOUTH AS SAN DIEGO AND
EVERY COUNTY IN BETWEEN. THAT
WE HAVE- ANOTHER COMPONENT OF
THE PROPOSAL IS BUILDING UP OUR
CAPACITY OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
WITHIN OUR HEALTH PLANS ARE
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PLANS OUR
SCHOOLS. OUR CBO'S AND SO MANY
OTHER ENTITIES THAT TOUCH THE
LIVES OF YOUNG PEOPLE ON A DAY
IN DAY UT BASIS A THIRD
COMPONENT IS FOCUSED ON.
DEVELOPING AND BUILDING UP THE
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES THAT
WE KNOW CAN GUIDE NOT JUST THE
PLATFORM AND ALLOW YOUNG PEOPLE
TO GET STEPPED UP LEVELS OF
CARE ARE REALLY BE BUILT IN
WHAT IS SEEN BEYOND THAT FIRST
FRONT DOOR IN THE ROOMS IF YOU
WILL OF THE HOUSE OF CHILDREN'S
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE. THAT
ARE CONNECTED THE BRICKS AND
MORTAR FACILITIES TO
INDIVIDUALS AND FACE TO FACE
INTERVENTIONS WHERE AND WHEN
THOSE VIRTUAL TO OPPOSE THOSE
VIRTUAL VISITS THOSE VIRTUAL
GROUPS THAT WILL BE FACILITATED
THROUGH OUR STATEWIDE VIRTUAL
PLATFORM OR NOT ENOUGH. WE DO
NOT EXPECT OR BELIEVE THAT THE
VIRTUAL PLATFORM IS THE END OF
WHAT WE NEED TO PROVIDE WE SEE
IT AS THAT GAVE WITH THAT FRONT
DOOR BUT IF COURSE WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO INVEST. IN THAT
FOURTH COMPONENT OF THIS
PROPOSAL WHICH ARE THE BRICK
AND MORTAR INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
IS NEEDED I HAVE SEEN FIRST
HAND THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
INPATIENT BEDS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
BUT URGENT CARE CENTERS WHICH I
THINK TAYLOR WELL AND DO WELL
FOR- OLDER CALIFORNIA FOR
ADULTS AND IN OUR STATE. TO GET
THAT CRISIS CARE THAT THEY NEED
BUT BEING ABLE. TO TAKE A
STATEWIDE MODEL WITH URGING
KERR'S. ACROSS STATE GEN HELP
ON ADULTS. MENTAL CAN BE HEALTH
CHANNEL. ALSO WE DON'T SPEND
ENOUGH TIME TALKING ABOUT THE
GAPS IN SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
SERVICES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE WE
KNOW THAT SO MUCH OF BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES ARE
MANIFEST THEMSELVES BUT IN
THOSE EARLY. YEARS IT'S SAID
THAT 50% OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS ARE DIAGNOSABLE BY
THE AGE OF FOURTEEN A FULL 75%
BY THE AGE OF TWENTY FIVE. YET
WE CONTINUE TO SEE BIG GAPS IN
BOTH THE MENTAL SIDE BUT EVEN
MORE ON THE SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SIDE WHERE WE DON'T
HAVE NOT JUST THE FACILITIES
BUT THAT. THAT TAKES ME TO THE
FIFTH COMPONENT OF THE PROPOSAL
WHICH IS A BROAD INVESTMENT IN
THE WORK FORCE. TO SERVE YOUNG
PEOPLE- EARLY ON THOSE EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES BUT ALSO
BUILDING UP THE CAPACITY FOR
PROFESSIONAL CAPACITY TO DO.
WILL BE MORE- ARE ARE URGING
CRISIS CARE IN ACUTE CARE
SERVICES THIS INCLUDES
EVERYTHING FROM NEW
CLASSIFICATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COACHES. WHO
WORKED. IN COMMUNITIES CLOSER
TO WHERE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
HELPING PROVIDE DAY IN AND DAY
OUT SUPPORTS ALL THE WAY UP TO
THE PROFESSIONALS THAT CAN HELP
SUPPORT YOUNG PEOPLE THROUGH
TELEGRAM TELEVISA IT'S AS WELL
AS STAFF WAS URGENT CARE AND
ACUTE CARE BEDS. THOSE LICENSED
PROFESSIONALS THAT WE'VE COME
TO KNOW NURSE PRACTITIONERS AND
OTHERS WHO ARE SPECIALIZING IN
CHILDREN'S BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
ARE ANOTHER COMPONENT OF THE
PROPOSAL TO SIX COMPONENT IS A
RECOGNITION OF THE WORK THAT
PRIMARY CARE PEDIATRICIANS
FAMILY PRACTITIONERS INTERNAL
MEDICINE PHYSICIANS. AND. OTHER
PROVIDERS DO TO SUPPORT YOUNG
AND CRY. WE'VE SEEN RECENTLY
HOW ARE MUCH FAMILIES AN
INDIVIDUAL PEOPLE WANNA GET
THEIR CARE WITHIN THE CONFINES
OF THEIR PEDIATRICIAN'S OFFICE
THEIR FAMILY PRACTITIONERS
OFFICE THERE INTERNIST IF
THEY'RE OLDER- FOR VACCINATIONS
FOR CO GOOD THING EVEN MORE WE
SEE THOSE ACCESS POINTS. FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE WITH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS BUT WE AREN'T
ALWAYS AS EQUIPPED AS WE WOULD
LIKE TO BE TO PROVIDE THAT
ADVICE TO PROVIDE THAT CARE SO
BEING ABLE TO CREATE A STATE
WIDE PLATFORM. IN E. REFERRAL
ANTI COUNCIL PLATFORM AVAILABLE
TO ALL OF THOSE FRONT LINE
PROVIDERS TO YOUNG PEOPLE TO
GET IMMEDIATE SUPPORT IMMEDIATE
HELP STATEWIDE WITHOUT NEEDING
TO GO THROUGH THE WHOLE. PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION AM I ALLOWED TO
ASK THIS QUESTION AND GET THAT
ANSWER TO DELIVER CARE I THINK
IT'S CRITICAL I CAN TELL YOU
COUNTLESS STORIES WHERE THAT
LIFELINE WOULD HAVE ALLOWED ME
TO PROVIDE BETTER CARE MORE
IMMEDIATE CARE MORE TIMELY
CARE. TO INDIVIDUALS IN CRISIS
WITH QUESTIONS WITH CHALLENGES-
AND THEN THE FINAL PIECE THAT I
WANTED TO ELEVATE. WAS EIGHT
CRITICAL PIECE TIES INTO THE
LAST PRESENTATION ON PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE IS REALLY
FOCUSED ON- THE B. R.
ENGAGEMENT THE OUTRAGE THE
EDUCATION CAMPAIGN THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED HERE. WE KNOW THAT
NORMALIZING THE- NEED FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICES ARE
THAT TARGET SOCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL WELL BEING OF YOUNG
PEOPLE IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
IT'S GOING TO COME NATURAL COME
EASY AND MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. BUT TO BUILD A
BROAD PUBLIC HEALTH CAMPAIGN
IN. COLLABORATION WITH THE
OFFICE OF THE SURGEON GENERAL
OUR DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SO MANY OTHERS ACROSS THE
STATE WILL BE A KEY FEATURE.
THAT CAN HAPPEN NOW THEY CAN
BEGIN TO BEGIN THE- OUR- FOR
EIGHT LARGER SET OF SERVICES-
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FOR CHILDREN.
AND YOUNG ADULTS UP PROPOSAL
THE LAST COMPONENT OF THIS OUR
PROPOSAL IS TO BUILD IN SOME
ONGOING DOLLARS TO PROVIDE
SERVICES AND MEDICAID. DYADIC
SERVICES FOCUSED ON OUR CASES
WHERE CAMPAIGN AND THOSE IT
BEAT OUT. ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCE SCREENINGS- THAT
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN UNDER
WAY ACROSS THE STATE CONTINUING
RESOURCES THE BILL GOES UP I
THINK- FOCUSING ON EVIDENCE
BASED SERVICES. THAT KEEP THE
FAMILY IN MIND KEEP THE YOUNG
PERSON IN MIND- WHETHER THAT
ARE LINKED TO SCHOOLS OR-
REALLY BEYOND SCHOOLS AND IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE COMMUNITY IS
A KEY FEATURE. AND THEN LASTLY
THE COMPONENT THAT THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY WILL
BE PRIMARILY RESPONSIBLE FOR
WORKING ACROSS THE MANY
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE HERE WITH
ME TODAY. TO PRESENT THEIR
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THE PUZZLE
IS THAT COORDINATION AND
EVALUATION COMPONENT WE KNOW
THAT THE PROPOSAL IS LARGE BUT
IS MATCHED. ADEQUATELY WE THANK
TO THE SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM WE
NOW THAT IT IS A COMPLEX
PROPOSAL THAT BRAIDS TOGETHER
INEXTRICABLE PIECES OF A PUZZLE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HAVE
THAT COMPREHENSIVE VIEW WE NEED
TO ADDRESS. ALL OF THESE
COMPONENTS BUT TO DO THAT IT'S
GOING TO REQUIRE A DEGREE OF
COORDINATION A DEGREE OF
VALUATION THAT IS- THAT THAT
WILL BE IMPORTANT AND A
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. WORKING WITH
THESE DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE ON
WITH US TODAY WILL BE
PRIMARILY- IN CHARGE OF.
GETTING THAT GOING OUT BEING-
GROUP AND I'VE DONE A- PARTNERS
OUR LOW COUNTY IS FROM OTHERS.
OF HELLO- ACT- OTHER- YOU
IMPORTANT- WELL VENDORS AND
OTHERS ARE HOPE US DELIVER
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES TO
YOUNG PEOPLE- ARE ARE CURRENTLY
EIGHT REALLY. A PROPOSAL BAD-
BUILDS I THINK ON THE
INNOVATIVE SPIRIT OF CALIFORNIA
RECOGNIZING THE ACCELERATED OUR
ISSUES AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE THAT WE SAW IN
THE PANDEMIC AND- ADDRESSING
THINGS IN THE SHORT RUN BUT
REALLY LOOKING TO A SYSTEM BUT
I THINK WE CAN ALL BE PROUD OF
THAT- TIES CLOSELY TO SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE ARE TACKLING
AND OTHER PARTS OF THIS
PROJECT. WHETHER IT'S
HOMELESSNESS OR INCARCERATION
WE KNOW SO MANY ADULTS WHO
STRUGGLE IN ADULTHOOD I HAVE
EARLY SIGNS EARLY
MANIFESTATIONS OF THOSE
CHALLENGES WHEN THEY ARE YOUNG
AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY
LOOK AT PEDIATRIC SAYS THE
ALTERNATE FORMING ADULT
PREVENTATIVE MEDICINE I THINK
IS MANIFEST IN THIS IN THIS
PROPOSAL AND WITH THAT I WILL
TURN IT BACK TO. YOU ALLOW THE
OTHER SPEAKERS ON THE PANEL-
AND I WILL APOLOGIZE IN ADVANCE
THAT I CANNOT- BE AVAILABLE
DURING THE QUESTION AND ANSWER.
PART OF THE PRESENTATION BUT
I'M ALWAYS HAPPY TO ADDRESS MY
COMMENTS OR ISSUES AT A LATER
TIME AND TRUST MY COLLEAGUES
FROM ACROSS THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES ARE
MANY DEPARTMENTS WILL BE WELL
EQUIPPED TO ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS AS THEY COME UP.
THANK YOU DR GOLLY FOR YOUR
TIME AND NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
MATT SCHULER WHO IS THE CHIEF
OF STAFF FOR THE OFFICE OF. THE
CALIFORNIA SURGEON GENERAL.
GOOD AFTERNOON. SHARE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- I'D LIKE TO
GO OVER OUR TWO COMPONENTS- THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROPOSAL- WE
HAVE- ONE COMPONENT THAT IS A
PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN ON
ACES AND TOXIC STRESS AND THEN
A TRAUMA INFORMED TRAINING FOR
EDUCATORS- WE'RE PROPOSING
TWENTY FOUR MILLION FOR THE
PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN AND
ONE MILLION THAT TO THE TRAUMA
INFORMED TRAINING. SO TO START
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT BOTH
OF OUR COMPONENTS AND THE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
MENTAL AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ARE ACTUALLY NOTED AS HE NEXT
STEPS TO ATTACK THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS ACES AND TOXIC
STRESS IN THE SURGEON GENERAL'S
REPORT THAT WAS ISSUED AT THE
END OF. TWENTY TWENTY OUR ROAD
MAP FOR RESULTS. IN THE PUBLIC
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN IS REALLY
INTO FILAMENT OF THE SURGEON
GENERAL'S CHARGE TO LOOK AT THE
UNDERLYING AN UPSTREAM.
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH THAT
LEAD TO SOME OF THE MOST
SERIOUS PROBLEMS THAT WE FACE.
THE PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN
REALLY FORMS THE BASE OF OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH. TO
LOOKING AT THE PROBLEM. AND
THE- AND THE PUBLIC AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN WILL BE A PLAN OVER
THE FLAT COMING BUDGET YEAR AND
IMPLEMENTED IN ORDER TO
LEVERAGE THE WORK THAT WE'VE
DONE ON THE EAST IS AWARE
INITIATIVE TO TRAIN
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY THOUSAND
BY HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS IN
SCREENING AND RESPONDING. TO
ACES AND TOXIC STRESS. WE
REALIZE THAT. ACES AND TOXIC
STRESS HAVE BEEN EXACERBATED BY
THE PANDEMIC AT NATIONAL
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT SHOWS THAT
VISITS RELATED TO CHILD ABUSE
AND NEGLECT GONNA AT THE SAME
TIME REPORTS DID CHILD
PROTECTIVE SERVICES I HAD
DECREASED AND IT'S ALSO CLEAR
THAT THE HEALTH DISPARITIES
THAT WERE LAID BARE BY THE
PANDEMIC- NEED TO BE ADDRESSED
IN A WAY THAT WITH ADEQUATE
RESOURCES AND THIS PUBLIC
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN ON ACES AND
TOXIC STRESS IS ESSENTIAL IN
THAT WORK. BUT FOR OUR TRAUMA
INFORMED TRAINING AT SIMILARLY-
WE KNOW THAT CHILDREN HAVE BEEN
ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE TO THE
STRESSORS OF THE PANDEMIC BEING
AWAY FROM SCHOOLS FRIENDS
TEACHERS AND- AND REALLY KIND
OF GOING THROUGH THE INCREASED
PREVALENCE AND SEVERITY ASUS-
AND WE'RE AT A CRITICAL POINT.
HAS THIS FUTURE GENERATION OF
CHILDREN RETURN TO SCHOOL AND
NEED TO WHEN WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON HAVING THE EDUCATION SECTOR
TRAUMA INFORMED- IN ORDER TO
AVOID A CRISIS OF PHYSICAL
MENTAL AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
EDUCATORS ARE IN POSITION OF
PROVIDING DAILY DOSES OF STATE
STABLE AND NURTURING
RELATIONSHIPS AND ENVIRONMENTS
THAT ARE KNOWN TO BE HEALING.
FOR CHILDREN THAT ARE SUFFERING
FROM TOXIC STRESS. SO THE
DEPARTMENT- OUR OFFICE IS GOING
TO PARTNER WITH THE STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION. ARE ALSO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. TO DEVELOP THIS
TRAUMA INFORMED TRAINING THAT
WILL ALLOW EDUCATORS TO
RECOGNIZE AND RESPOND TO THE
MAN OF THE CAKE MANIFESTATIONS
OF AN OVER ACTIVE STRESS
RESPONSE THAT HAVE BEEN SHOWN
TO IMPACT LEARNING ATTENTION.
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL FUNCTION AND
BEHAVIOR AND ULTIMATELY- MAKE
AN IMPACT ON STUDENTS ABILITY
TO- HAVE EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT. I HAD STUDENTS THAT
EXPERIENCE ACES AND TOXIC
STRESS BEEN SHOWN. NOT TO DO AS
WELL IN SCHOOL AND NOT TO THE
TEAMS THAT THAT THE SAME LEVEL
OF EDUCATION THAT THOSE ARE WHO
DO NOT. EXPERIENCE IT I DO. SO
EDUCATORS ARE GOING TO NEED
STRATEGIES AND TOOLS TO MANAGE
THEIR OWN STRESS ALSO WHEN
FACING THE PROBLEM OF STUDENTS
AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
INCORPORATE THESE- THESE
CONCEPTS WITHIN THE TRAINING
THAT IS DEVELOP SO. EDUCATORS
NOT ONLY HAVE THE TOOLS TO BE
ABLE ADDRESS TRAUMA THAT IT'S
BEEN EXPERIENCED BY THE
STUDENTS BUT ALSO TO BE ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE THEIR OWN NEEDS AND
TO BE ABLE TO. RESPOND. AND- WE
ARE UP. WE ARE VERY MUCH
LOOKING FORWARD TO BEING PART
OF THIS PROPOSAL BY. AND WE'RE
VERY MUCH LOOKING FORWARD TO
THIS PROPOSAL. I'M. IS THAT THE
CONCLUSION OF YOUR TESTIMONY
SIR WHAT. MY APOLOGIES- SO WE
VERY MUCH ARE LOOKING FORWARD
TO BEING PART OF THIS PROPOSAL
THAT INVOLVES AGENCY ALL OF OUR
DEPARTMENTS IN ORDER TO YOU- MY
PUBLIC MY APOLOGIES. TAKE YOUR
TIME NO STRESS. MY APOLOGIES.
WE'RE HAPPY TO COME BACK TO YOU
IF IT SERVES THE BETTER FOR US
TO DO THAT SIR. PLEASE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. WITH THAT WE
WILL TURN TO DIRECTOR LIGHT
FORM WITH DH CS. THANK YOU-
CHERUB RENTAL- RIGALI- REALLY
COVERED THE COMPREHENSIVE
PAINFUL CHILDREN'S USE OF
CONCEPT YOU KNOW VERY FEDERAL.
SO ALMOST QUITE MY CELL PHONE
THE SCHOOL AND- TALK PIPER
PERHAPS WE CAN JUST ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT ARE SPECIFIC TO
DH YEAH THANK YOU THANK YOU
WITH THAT WE WILL TURN TO
DIRECTOR WATANABE WITH THE MHC.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR
ME OK YES MA'AM. YEAH NOT AND
I'LL EEP THIS BRIEF I DO JUST
WANT TO MENTION THAT THE BILL
DEPARTMENT DOESN'T HAVE A
SPECIFIC REPORT HOLES OR
REQUEST FOR RESOURCES RELATED
TO THIS INITIATIVE- BUT I THINK
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
UNDERSTAND OUR ROLE ONE THAT'S
AND IT REALLY IS TO ENSURE.
THAT ALL CHILDREN AND YOUTH
REGARDLESS OF INSURANCE STATUS
WILL BE ABLE TO ACCESS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES AT
SCHOOL OR THROUGH SCHOOL
AFFILIATED- I'M COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ARE CLINICS AGAIN
REALLY WANT TO EMPHASIZE WE
DON'T WANT OUR COMMERCIAL
ENROLLEES TO FIND AT A CLOSED
DOOR- WE ALSOWANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT SCHOOLS WILL BE REIMBURSED
FOR THE SERVICES PROVIDED TO
CONVERT COMMERCIAL ENROLLEES.
APPLAUSE STATURE CHANGES WERE
OUT A NUMBER OF NEW
REQUIREMENTS OF THE HEALTH
PLANS. MOST NOTABLY IS THAT
BEGINNING IN JANUARY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR THE PLANTS
WILL BE REQUIRED TO COVER
BEHAVIORAL SERVICES PROVIDED AT
SCHOOLS. REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THE PLAN HAS A CONTRACT WITH
THE SCHOOL OR THE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER. IF THE SCHOOL DOES
NOT PROVIDE SERVICES ON CAMPUS
THIS WOULD INCLUDE SERVICES
LINKED TO THE SCHOOL. SUCH AS
SERVICES PROVIDED BY COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS. ARE WE
REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S A STREAMLINED
REIMBURSEMENT PROCESS TO REDUCE
THE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN ON
SCHOOLS. SO WE'RE PROPOSING
THAT THE HEALTH PLANS WILL
REIMBURSE THE SCHOOLS- AT THE
RATE OF THE CONTRACTED RATE IF
THEY HAVE A CONTRACT. OR THE
RATE SET BY OUR DEPARTMENT
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR
MEDICARE ENROLLEES. THIS
SERVICE IS PROVIDED IN SCHOOLS
WILL NOT BE SUBJECT TO ANY FORM
OF COST SHARING SUCH AS
COPAYMENTS COINSURANCE OR
DEDUCTIBLES AGAIN REALLY TRYING
TO STREAMLINE THIS PROCESS. AND
HEALTH PLANS WOULD BE
PROHIBITED FROM REQUIRING PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION AND ONLY WOULD BE
ALLOWED TO DENY A CLAIM IF THEY
REASONABLY BELIEVE. EITHER THE
STUDENT WASN'T ROLE WASN'T
ENROLLED IN THE PLAN THE
SERVICES WERE PERFORMED OR
THERE WERE THE SERVICES WERE
NOT PROVIDED BY HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER OF PERFECT PLACE
PROPERLY LICENSED TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICE- WE RECOGNIZE
THERE'S A LOT OF DETAILS WILL
NEED TO WORK THROUGH BUT-
BEFORE THE IMPLEMENTATION IN
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. INCLUDING A
SPECIFIC SERVICES THE HEALTH
PLANS WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
REIMBURSE AND SO IN THE COMING
YEARS WE- LOOK FORWARD TO COOK
CORDONING VERY CLOSELY
OBVIOUSLY WITH THE LEGISLATURE
THE HEALTH PLANS DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE IN THE SCHOOLS- ON
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS AND
HAPPY. TO TAKE QUESTIONS AT THE
END. THANK YOU MAX WE'LL HEAR
FROM HER LAN. DIRECT OF AUSTIN.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ELIZABETH
PLANS FOR DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT AND
HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE
COMPONENTS THAT AUSTIN HAS
RELATED TO THE- INITIATIVE THAT
SECRETARY KELLY GAVE A GAVE A
THOROUGH OVERVIEW OF SO I SPENT
IS LOOKING TO. USE OUR EXISTING
HEALTH WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS AND DEVELOP NEW
PROGRAMS TO BUILD THE WORK
FORCE THAT WOULD BE NEEDED FOR
THE SIX- EXCITING AND IMPORTANT
INITIATIVES OUR PEACE IS
FOCUSED ON THREE GOALS
INCREASING THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE THAT IS
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
PROFICIENT AND CAPABLE OF
PROVIDING AGE APPROPRIATE
SERVICES. THE CHILDREN YOUTH
AND FAMILIES EXPANDING TRAINING
FOR EXISTING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND TARGETING
PROFESSIONALS IN MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREAS. SO THE FIRST
PIECES THAT WE'RE PROPOSING TO
CREATE A SCHOOL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH COACH AND COUNSELOR
WORKFORCE. THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT COMMISSION'S RECENT
REPORT OUTLINED THE NEED TO
CREATE SCHOOLS AS CENTRES OF
WELLNESS. THE REPORT EMPHASIZED
THE UNMET MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
CREATE LEARNING BARRIERS FOR
OUR SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN. TO
ESTABLISH SCHOOLS AS CENTRES OF
WELLNESS CALIFORNIA NEEDS
TRAINED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
COUNSELORS AND COACHES WHO CAN
PROVIDE A VARIETY OF
INTERVENTIONS AND ASSIST
EDUCATORS IN IMPROVING
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COACHES AND
COUNSELORS ARE ALSO VITAL TO
IMPLEMENTING A COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS MODEL WHERE SCHOOLS
OFFER A WIDE ARRAY OF SUPPORTS
AND SERVICES FOR STUDENTS AND-FAMILIES. FROM HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH TO FAMILY
SUPPORTS FROM FOOD PROGRAMS AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE PREVENTION THE
CRISIS INTERVENTION AND
COUNSELING. THESE COUNSELORS
AND COACHES WILL HELP PROVIDE
CHILDREN USE THAT CHOICE AS TO
HOW WHERE AND WHEN THEY RECEIVE
SERVICES INCLUDING VIRTUAL
SERVICES THAT ARE SECURE. THAT
PROVIDE SECURE PRIVACY AND
ANONYMITY. THIS THE CHILDREN'S
WIDE RANGE OF NEEDS. I THINK
WE'VE REALLY SEEN- FROM
TEACHING STRESS REDUCTION
TECHNIQUES AND OTHER RESILIENCY
BUILDING STRATEGIES TO SERIOUS
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS IN
NEED OF CLINICAL INTERVENTION
SO THE PURPOSE OF THE COACHES
WOULD BE TO DO THE NONCLINICAL
SUPPORTS AND INTERVENTIONS AND
BE TRAINED TO MAKE REFERRALS
FOR CLINICAL ASSESSMENTS. THE
GOAL WOULD BE TO HAVE EACH TYPE
OF PROVIDER PRACTICING AT THE
TOP OF THEIR LICENSE. DURING
THE INITIAL YEAR OSCAR ED IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS INCLUDING EDUCATION AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. EXPERTS
WOULD DEVELOP A MULTI YEAR PLAN
TO LAUNCH AND IMPLEMENT THE
SCHOOL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COACH
AND COUNSELOR SYSTEM WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS THE
SIGNIFICANT UNDERTAKING IN NEED
OF CAREFUL PLANNING AND
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT. ANOTHER
PIECE OF ASHRIDGE WORK RELATED
TO THIS INITIATIVE THAT I WANNA
HOLD UP IS THE NEED TO DEVELOP
THE SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER OR
SAD WORKFORCE. CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO EXPERIENCE A
SHORTAGE OF SUCH COUNSELORS AND
CLINICIANS AND NEEDS TO DEVELOP
A SAID WORKFORCE THAT PROVIDE
AGE APPROPRIATE TREATMENT. IT'S
CRITICAL TO BUILD THE PIPELINE
OF SAID COUNSELORS AND
SPECIALISTS TO REFLECT THE
DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. AND TO
PROVIDE TREATMENT THAT IS
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
PROFICIENT. ASHRIDGE SEEKS TO
DEVELOP THE SAID WORKFORCE BY
BOTH EXPANDING THE KNOWLEDGE OF
EXISTING LICENSED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CLINICIANS TO PROVIDE
AGE APPROPRIATE SUCH TREATMENT
AS WELL AS INVESTING
SUBSTANTIALLY TO ADDRESS
SIGNIFICANT WORK FORCE AND
DIVERSITY SHORTAGES. BY
PROVIDING FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO
INDIVIDUALS ENTERING SAID
CAREERS. SO WE WOULD LOOK AGAIN
TO COLLABORATE WITH SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS AND STAKEHOLDERS
TO DEVELOP A NEW SAID WORKFORCE
FRAMEWORK AND PLAN FOCUSED ON
YOUTH AND FAMILIES. ANOTHER
PART OF THE PROPOSAL WOULD
EXPAND TRAINING CAPACITY FOR
PSYCH. FOR PSYCHIATRY AND
SOCIAL WORK WE KNOW THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE NEEDS IN PSYCHIATRY
ESPECIALLY CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH
NURSE PRACTITIONERS AND SOCIAL
WORKERS. SO WE PROPOSE TO
PROVIDE FUNDING TO SUPPORT AND
GROW RESIDENTS IN TRAINING
PROGRAMS THAT WERE DEVELOPED
THIS MEETING WORKFORCE THAT
WOULD BUILD ON OUR EXISTING
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE WET.
PSYCHIATRIC EDUCATION CAPACITY
EXPANSION PROGRAM AND ADD
PROGRAMS THAT TRAIN NON
PRESCRIBING CLINICIANS. AND
CHILD AND ADOLESCENT SOCIAL
WORKERS AND CHILD WELFARE
WORKERS. THIS PROPOSAL WILL
ALSO BUILD THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE PIPELINE
BUILDING ON EXISTING PROGRAMS
SUCH AS I'VE SPENT MANY GRANTS
PROGRAM TO SUPPORT CAREER
EXPLORATION. I ALSO WANT TO LET
THE OTHER PIECE OF OUR PROPOSAL
TO BUILD EARN AND LEARN
APPRENTICESHIP MODELS.
PROVIDING A PATHWAY TO JOBS
CRITICAL BUT MANY CANNOT AFFORD
TO PURSUE TRAINING UNLESS
THEY'RE SUPPORTED WHILE DOING
SO. EARN AND LEARN MODELS HAVE
BEEN SHOWN TO BE EFFECTIVE IN
TRAINING AND PLACING
INDIVIDUALS AND NEEDED
OCCUPATIONS THAT WE THINK THIS
CAN BE LEVERAGED SUCCESSFULLY
ON THE WORK FORCE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE SIDE. THESE MODELS
PROVIDE TUITION SUPPORT AND ON
THE JOB TRAINING AT A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDER
ORGANIZATION WHILE TH TRAINEES
ATTEND POST SECONDARY SCHOOL OR
COMPLETE TRAINING. THE EMPLOYER
PROVIDES A POSITION FOR THE
GRADUATE AND THERE IS A SERVICE
pPROVIDE FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO
THE EMPLOYER ANSWER PER
SUPERVISE AND MENTOR THE
STUDENT. ASHTEAD WITH LEVERAGE
THIS MODEL AND WORK WITH
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS TO
DEVELOP AND BUILD A PLAN TO
BUILD THE WORKFORCE FOR SAID
COUNCILLORS INCLUDING FOR
UNLICENSED BUT TRAINED
PROFESSIONALS. AREAS OF FOCUS
COULD INCLUDE COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS AND PSYCHO SOCIAL
REHABILITATION SPECIALIST THAT
SERVE CHILDREN YOUTH ND
FAMILIES. GIVEN THE SIGNIFICANT
WEALTH GAP ALONG RACIAL LINES
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT APPROACH
TO HELP DIVERSIFYING
CALIFORNIANS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE. AND MISTER CHAIRMAN
THE INTEREST OF TIME I'M NOT
GONNA SPEND A LOT OF TIME ON
THE OTHER COMPONENTS OF OUR
PROPOSAL HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS WE WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT WE WANT A SPECIAL FOCUS ON
TRAINING TO SERVE JUSTICE AND
SYSTEM INVOLVED YOUTH- AS WELL
AS EXPANDING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TRAINING FOR PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS. THANK YOU DIRECTOR
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM DR RADHA
KRISHNA OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY
DEPUTY DIRECTOR CDPH. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND COLLEAGUES MY NAME
IS ROSE ANOTHER KRISHNA AND I
SERVED AS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT.
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY OUR OFFICES VISION IS
THAT EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA HAS
EQUAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR OPTIMAL
HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH AND
WELLBEING. TO HELP REFILL OUR
VISION WE ARE GRATEFUL TO JOIN
THIS CROSS DEPARTMENT
PARTNERSHIP TO CHANGE THE ARC
OF THE LIVES OF THE NEXT
GENERATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
LEADERS. A GENERATION THAT HAS
SUFFERED A TREMENDOUS TRAUMA
WITH THIS PANDEMIC UPROOTING
THEIR YOUTH THEIR EDUCATION AND
THEIR FAMILIES DURING CRITICAL
YEARS OF THEIR DEVELOPMENT.
VIEWING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
THROUGH A HEALTH EQUITY PLANS
PARTICULARLY A RACIAL EQUITY
LET'S WE KNOW THAT STRUCTURAL
RACISM. AND SOCIAL ACCUMULATED
DISADVANTAGE MEANS THAT THESE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CHALLENGES
ARE IN EQUITY WE BOARD. ON THE
COLORS COMMUNITIES OF COLOR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND LGBTQ
PLUS COMMUNITIES AND IN PLACES
WHERE ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES ARE MORE WIDESPREAD.
ANNING UP WITH A SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS THAT IS NOT IDENTIFIED
OR TREATED EARLY CAN TAKE
TWENTY YEARS OFF OF YOUR LIFE
I'M NOT GETTING A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA CAN TAKE MORE THAN
EIGHT YEARS OFF YOUR LIFE.
PUBLIC HEALTH IS PROUD TO JOIN
THIS PARTNERSHIP. BECAUSE WE
CHAMPION P. E. I. PREVENTION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION. AND NOT
JUST PHYSICAL. BUT ALSO MENTAL
HEALTH. AND SUBSTANCE USE.
EARLIER WE CAN INTERVENE IN THE
LIFE COURSE. THE LESS SUFFERING
AND THE LAST COST. SO OUR
OFFICE DOES HAVE EXPERIENCE AND
EXPERTISE IN THIS PREVENTION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION APPROACH
THANKS TO THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT OR
BUSINESS YEAR D. P. WHICH
CHAMPIONS CULTURAL LINGUISTIC
COMPETENCE AND ELEVATES
INNOVATIVE. COMMUNITY TO FIND
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE. THESE
APPROACHES CAN HELP REACH THE
UNREACHED EMPOWER THE
DISENFRANCHISED TO PROMOTE
WELLNESS ON THEIR TERMS WELL
THIS YEAR D. B. CAN INFORM OUR
COMPONENT OF THIS CAMPAIGN THIS
CAMPAIGN IS VERY DISTINCT AND
SEPARATE. AS A FAMILY DOCTOR
FOR TEN YEARS I'VE SEEN HOW
WHEN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ASSISTANCE OFFERED TO OUR YOUTH
STIGMA. DISCRIMINATION CULTURAL
AND STRUCTURAL BARRIERS CAN GET
IN THE WAY. KNOWLEDGE AND
AWARENESS IS A START BUT WE
NEED BEHAVIOR CHANGE SEEKING
HELP EARLY. SO THE GOALS OF
THIS PUBLIC EDUCATION AND
CHANGE CAMPAIGN ARE TO RAISE
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH LITERACY
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS. THAT MEANS
ALL AGES SO THEY CAN HELP OUR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES. THAT MEANS
NORMALIZING HOW TO RECOGNIZE
THE EARLY SIGNS AND SYMPTOMS IN
THE COMMUNITY AND THE FAMILY
ENVIRONMENT OF THAT DISTRESS IN
GETTING PEOPLE TO HELP. WHEN
THEY'RE READY. AND IT
ULTIMATELY MEANS TACKLING
DISPARITIES AND INEQUITIES BY
EMPOWERING DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
TO DEVELOP THEIR OWN CULTURALLY
AND LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE
TO ITS- WELL WE WILL WORK
CLOSELY WITH ALL THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS IN PARTICULAR THE
OFFICE OF THE SURGEON GENERAL
AND THE NEW OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION WHICH WILL BE HOUSED
WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. WE
WILL FOCUS ON THREE MAIN
COMPONENTS ONE AND GENERAL
PUBLIC ACCEPTANCE AND AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN WITH THE STRONG PUBLIC
RELATIONS AND MARKETING
COMPONENT. TO SOCIAL SPECIFIC
CAMPAIGN IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
COMMUNITY LEADERS BUILDING ON
EXISTING AND PROMISING LOCAL
EFFORTS AND THREE SOMETHING
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO OUR
SECRETARY A YOUTH EMPOWERMENT
PIECE CREATING LOCAL. YOU LAD
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ENGAGEMENT
EDUCATION EFFORTS USING SOCIAL
MEDIA OTHER PLATFORMS THAT ARE
POSITIVE IN NATURE DESIGNED BY
YOU FOR. THANK YOU I HAD TO BE
A PART OF THIS PARTNERSHIP AND
HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU DOCTOR NEXT WE WILL
HEAR FROM TOBY EWING EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS ARE TO BE DEALING ON
BEHALF OF THAT NOW SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE
TODAY AND TO OFFER SOME
COMMENTS ON THE PROPOSAL- THAT
SHOULD TO BE CLEAR THAT YEAH
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS WORKERS
REFERENCE IN THE PROPOSAL BUT
THERE'S NOT A COMPONENT OF THE
INITIATIVE. THAT IS TARGETED TO
THE COMMISSION. BUT I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS A VERY
BROAD AND IN MANY WAYS A
HISTORIC PROPOSAL. THAT TOUCHES
UPON THE KEY FOUNDATIONAL
ELEMENTS THAT ARE NECESSARY FOR
THE KIND OF TRANSFORMATIONAL
CHANGE. THAT THE QUESTION HAS
BEEN WORKING ON AND I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION IS LOOKING TO
ACHIEVE. WE HAVE SUCH AN
AMBITIOUS EFFORT. IT HIGHLIGHTS
PREVENTION. THERE'S A
DISCUSSION AROUND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT I'LL TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THAT IN A MOMENT THE
NEED FOR CONTINUOUS LEARNING.
USING INCENTIVES TO HELP
TRANSFORM THE SYSTEM THAT WE
HAVE TODAY. GIVEN THE ZERO TO
TWENTY FIVE POPULATION IT MAKES
TREMENDOUS SENSE TO FOCUS ON
SCHOOLS AS PARTNERS FOR
LEARNING AS AS WAS MENTIONED IN
ONE OF THE PRIOR COMMENTS DO
OUR WORK WE RECOGNIZE THAT
SCHOOLS. ARE WHERE YOUNG PEOPLE
HAPPEN TO BE AND IT'S WHERE
THERE'S OFTEN THE HIGHEST LEVEL
OF TRUST WHICH IS FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE BUT FOR FAMILIES IN
TERMS. OF OUR GOVERNMENTAL
PARTNERS. THIS HEALTH.
REGARDING OF PAYER IS THE RIGHT
APPROACH WE MUST TAKE THIS IF
WE'RE GOING TO AS THE PRIOR
SPEAKER COMMENTED ON. REALLY
LEAD WITH A POPULATION HEALTH
APPROACH BECAUSE WE CAN'T IF WE
SHOULD NOT BE DIFFERENTIATING
BASED ON WHO THE PARENTS WE
SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT WHAT
THE NEEDS ARE AND HOW WE
ACHIEVE THEM. AND VERY
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THIS
YEAR TO TWENTY FIVE TIMES H.
SPAM. OR FOR CHILDREN YOUTH
YOUNG ADULTS INTRODUCED IN
EIGHT YEARS- BUT I ALSO WANT TO
POINT OUT SOME VERY IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATIONS SOME OF WHICH
ARE ADDRESSED IN IN THE PLAN AS
WITH SEVERAL BASS DETAILED AND
SOMEWHERE THAT THE DETAIL IS
NOT QUITE THERE YET. IT WILL BE
VERY IMPORTANT TO DO ROBUST
PLANNING AND THE PROPOSAL TALKS
ABOUT SPENDING AS MUCH AS A
YEAR ON I'M PLANNING. EVENT
NEEDS TO INCLUDE ROBUST
ENGAGEMENT WITH LOCAL AGENCY
PARTNERS WITH AGENCIES WILL BE
DOING THE WORK. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY AS THE PRIOR
SPEAKER COMMENTED ON WHAT THE
PEOPLE ARE INTENDING TO SERVE.
OUR EXPERIENCE IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS WORKING WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE. IS THE BEST SOURCE OF
INFORMATION AND KNOWLEDGE ON
HOW WE SHOULD BE RESPONDING OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE THEMSELVES. SO THE
PLANNING PROCESS NEEDS TO
EMPHASIZE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
HELLO WE CAN BE SURE THAT THAT
THE STRATEGIES AND THE TOOLS
THAT ARE DEVELOPED IN THIS
INITIATIVE. ARE ACTUALLY
RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS AGAIN
PEOPLE HAVE AND ARE DESIGNED IN
A WAY THAT THEY WILL ACTUALLY
PARTICIPATE IN THE SERVICES.
THIS LEVEL OF TRANSFORMATIONAL
CHANGE IS CHALLENGING. BUT
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF LESSONS
LEARNED PRIMARILY FROM THE
PRIVATE SECTOR SOME PUBLIC
SECTOR EXAMPLES. FIRST IT'LL BE
VERY IMPORTANT TO ESTABLISH
VERY CLEAR GOALS. AND THOSE
GOALS NEED TO BE SHARED BY A
BROAD SET OF STAKEHOLDERS
INTERNAL TO THE PROJECT AND
ALSO EXTERNAL TO THE PROJECTS
SUCH AS THE LEGISLATURE. I'M
SUCH AS THE COUNTIES ARE OUR
LOCAL EDUCATION PARTNERS YOUNG
PEOPLE THEMSELVES BECAUSE NEED
TO BE CLEAR I UNDERSTAND. YOU
ALL OF THE PEOPLE WHO WILL BE
ESSENTIAL TO HELPING US REACH
SUCCESS. IN THAT PROCESS AND SO
THOSE CALLS NEED TO BE.
DEVELOPED THROUGH A
CONSULTATION PROCESS. WHAT DOES
GOALS IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
A WAY TO MEASURE AND MONITOR
PROGRESS THERE WERE SOME
COMMENTS EARLIER AMONG MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO. HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT WE'RE HEADED IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION WITH REAL
TIME INFORMATION ON THINGS LIKE
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT WE'RE
SERVING. AT DECLINES IN THE
NEGATIVE OUTCOMES AT
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE POSITIVE
OUTCOMES THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
SEE THAT IT'S BEEN A CHALLENGE
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
OVER THE YEARS AND IS IT AS IT
HAS BEEN A CHALLENGE IN THE
PUBLIC SECTOR. ROSS THE BOARD I
THINK CALIFORNIA IS ARE FARTHER
ALONG IN MANY AREAS THAN OTHER
STATES ARE. AND THERE'S A LOT
OF OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
IMPROVE HOW WE DO THAT. SO WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT THOSE GOALS
SUCH AS SERVING MORE CHILDREN
REDUCING EXPULSIONS REDUCING
CHILD WELFARE INVOLVEMENT
REDUCING SUICIDE BUT ALSO
POSITIVE THINGS LIKE IMPROVING
GRADUATION RATES AS WE TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER. AND IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE CAN TRANSLATE
THE INFORMATION WE HAVE AROUND
THOSE GOALS TO GIVE US REAL
TIME INFORMATION. MANY TIMES I
WOULD ADD IT LARGE
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THEM THE
UNITED KINGDOM HAVE ESTABLISHED
WHAT WE CALL PERFORMANCE UNITS
THAT ARE REALLY DESIGN.
INDEPENDENT OF THE CHANGE
PROCESS THAT'S IMPORTANT TO
REALLY MONITOR WHAT'S HAPPENING
THROUGH THE CHANGE PROCESS AND
TO EQUIP ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS THOSE WHO ARE
INTERNAL TO THE PROCESS IN
GETTING THE WORK DONE AS WELL
AS THOSE WHO ARE EXTERNAL. WELL
AS PARTNERS BUT ALSO AS AS THE
SORT OF WHAT WE WOULD CALL IT
PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY PIECE OF
THIS THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
INFORMATION FROM TRUSTED
RESPECTED SOURCES. SO THAT THEY
CAN CREATE CONFIDENCE THAT THE
WORK IS BEING DONE IN WAYS THAT
IT WAS ORIGINALLY ENVISIONED.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT THAT
INFORMATION BEGINS TO CHANGE
COLORS WHEN CHANGING COURSE IS
THE RIGHT THING TO DO BASED ON
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED. ALONG THE
WAY. THIS OF THIS. REQUIRES
VERY BROAD PARTNERSHIPS WITH
ALL OF THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
AGENCIES WHO ARE ENGAGED WITH
THIS AGE SPAN AND THE KINDS OF
SERVICES. MINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING TO PUT OUT THERE
THANKS SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED BUT OUR HOSPITALS OUR
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS IN
PARTICULAR AS KEY PARTNERS IN
DELIVERING CARE PARTICULARLY
FOR CHILDREN WHO HAVE HIGHER
LEVELS OF NEED. CERTAINLY OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
OR COUNTIES AND OTHERS AND I
APPRECIATE THE SECRETARY
COMMENTED ABOUT FIRST FIVE IN
OTHER PARTNERS THAT ARE OUT
THERE. I WANT TO MAKE A COUPLE
OTHER POINTS THIS IS ONE TIME
FUNDING AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE THINK A ONE TIME
FUNDING AS THE RIGHT KIND OF A
CATALYST. TO CREATE A SYSTEM
THAT CAN BE SUSTAINED. AND
THAT'S ANOTHER CHALLENGE THAT
WE HAVE SEEN IN THE PAST QUITE
OFTEN AND WE HAVE GIVEN GRANTS
TO LOCAL PARTNER SCHOOLS ARE
COUNTIES FOR A LIMITED PERIOD
OF TIME THEY'VE STOOD UP NEW
PROGRAMS BUT WE'VE NOT
NECESSARILY PROVIDED THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. AND
CAPACITY BUILDING SUPPORT THAT
THEY NEED TO TURN ONE TIME
FUNDING INTO SYSTEMS CHANGE
THAT CAN BE SUSTAINED WITH LONG
TERM FINANCIAL SUPPORT SO
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM
ADDRESS A LOT NOT BE ABOUT
ENGAGING OUR OUR OUR REP HEALTH
PLANS TO MAKE SURE. THAT WE CAN
BUILD OUT THE LONG TERM
SUSTAINABLE FINANCING STRATEGY
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO DO AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WILL BE
NEEDED TO MAKE SURE WE CAN DO
THAT IN A WAY. THAT HAS THESE
FUNDS. ARE STEP BACK THAT WE
CAN ENSURE THAT SYSTEMS ARE IN
PLACE TO CONTINUE TO SCALE THE
STRATEGY WITH SUSTAINABLE
FINANCES OVER TIME. I ALSO WANT
TO SAY THAT THE STATE HAS THE
FOUNDATION THAT MANY OF THE
COMPONENTS IN THIS PROPOSAL-
SHOULD BUILD UPON AND
SPECIFICALLY I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT. THE MENTAL HEALTH
STUDENT SERVICES ACT AND
COMMENTED ON THIS- IN EARLIER.
TESTIMONY TO THE COMMITTEE NO
MENTION IN THE NEXT ITEM THAT
THE COMMISSION HAS SOME SOME
COMMENTS ON WE'VE INVESTED OVER
NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
BUILD OUT EIGHTEEN SCHOOL
COUNTY PARTNERSHIPS. OUR
CONCERN IS THAT AS THE STATE
CONTINUES TO GROW THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO ENGAGE SCHOOLS
IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH YEAH WE'RE
GIVING THEM A SINGLE UNIFIED
OUR INTEGRATED STRATEGY RATHER
THAN ASKING SCHOOLS TO
PARTICIPATE AS PARTNERS WITH
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND SEPARATELY WITH
OTHER POTENTIAL PAYERS. THAT WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT THIS
INITIATIVE IS BUILDING UPON
WHAT'S ALREADY IN PLACE TO THE
EXTENT THAT WHAT'S IN PLACE IS
APPROPRIATE. AND. IF IT'S NOT
APPROPRIATE THE EN ROUTE.
WHAT'S PLACE WITH A NEW. MORE
IN A- AND- DESIGN. TEMAS THE
PROPOSAL OUT THE NEED TO
HIGHLIGHT EVIDENCE. AS TO THE
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES
COMPONENT TO IT CALLED OUT
ATTENTION ON EARLY CYCLE SINCE.
I WITH SUPPORT FROM THIS
COMMITTEE WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
ENGAGE FOURTEEN COUNTIES WITH
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
PROJECT TO BUILD A LEARNING
COMMUNITY WE ASK THAT THE MOST
EXPERIENCED AND EXPERT SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS. ON THE WEST
COAST AT UC DAVIS UC S. S. UCLA
AND STANFORD AND SO WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S A
FOUNDATION HERE THAT THIS
PROPOSAL CAN BUILD UPON.
SIMILARLY THEY USE DROPPED AN
EMPHASIS WE AGREED THAT YOU'RE
STRAPPING SERVICES THREE
CENTRAL FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO ARE IN
THE TRANSITION AND USE TIME
FRAME OR H. AGE RANGE. AND I'M
HAPPY TO REPORT DOWN JUNE
TWENTY FIFTH SANTA CLARA COUNTY
WITH OUR SUPPORT IN SUPPORT
FROM STANFORD WILL BE LAUNCHING
THE FIRST YEAR ALTHOUGH DROP IN
CENTER. SO I'M VERY IMPORTANT
TO MODEL HOW WE- STARTED TO
BUILD UPON THE MODELS. THAT ARE
ALREADY IN PLACE. SO I DO WANT
TO SAY THAT WHAT ELSE CONCERNED
THAT MANY OF THESE. ARE ARE IN
THE OUT YEARS BECAUSE OF THE
ESSENTIAL NATURE OF THAT LONG
RANGE PLANNING. THAT IT WILL BE
VERY IMPORTANT YOU KNOW FOR US
WE WANT TO WORK WITH DH CS IN
THE WORK THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
DOING IN THE WORK AS ENVISIONED
THIS PROPOSAL TO BUILD OFF OF
THIS FOUNDATION. BUT WE ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
DO SOME THINGS. TOMORROW
BECAUSE WE HAVE AS AS SECRETARY
GOLLY MENTION- TREMENDOUS
CHALLENGES. AS WE MOVE FORWARD
IN OPENING SCHOOLS OPENING OUR
ECONOMY AND- IN OUR ABILITY TO
IDENTIFY AND WORK WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE THROUGH BEHAVIOR HOUSE
GRAINS. THEY BRING CARE. TO
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES THROUGH
SCHOOLS THAT THEY HAVE AT THE
MOMENT. WE ALSO I CAN I KNOW
THE SECRETARY MENTIONED IN HIS
COMMENTS ON THAT WE DIDN'T SEE
AN ORIGINAL PLAN. I'M VERY
IMPORTANT TO WORK WITH CHILDREN.
ZERO TO FIVE AGE RANGE. MARTIN
TO WORK WITH. OLDER THE
TRADITION YET BUT WITH OUR
EDUCATION. CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
CALIFORNIA ARE POISED TO
STRENGTHEN HOW THEY RESPOND TO
THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH NEEDS OF
THEIR STUDENTS AND WE'D IT MAY
BE IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATION ADMINISTRATION TO
THINK ABOUT HOW THOSE
PARTICULAR PARTNERS MAY NEED
SOME SPECIFIC AND SPECIAL
ATTENTION IN THE KINDS OF
STRATEGIES THAT WOULD BE LAID
OUT IN THIS INITIATIVE
RECOGNIZING THAT WE CAN WORK
WITH THE EXISTING SEGMENTS TO
REALLY DIRECT SERVICES TO A
LARGE PORTION OF. STUDENTS WHO
ARE IN THOSE AGE RANGES- AND I
AND I DO WANT TO SAY THAT. WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE EMPHASIS
ON A DIGITAL STRATEGY. AND WE
HAVE SEEN BECAUSE OF COLD ED
AND ANY OF YOU WHO HAVE BEEN ST
MARSHALL'S RECENTLY RECOGNIZING
THAT THE MENTAL HEALTH FIELD IS
REALLY SHIFTING TO DIGITAL
MENTAL HEALTH. MOST OF THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE DESIGNED FOR
PEOPLE WHO CAN PAY A MONTHLY
KIND OF SUBSCRIPTION AND SO
WILL BE VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE
STATE TO THINK ABOUT HOW WE CAN
EMBRACE DIGITAL STRATEGIES.
WE'D LIKE TO SEE DIGITAL
STRATEGIES BE PAIRED WITH
MOBILE STRATEGIES AS MORE
FEDERAL SUPPORT IS AVAILABLE TO
SUPPORT MOBILE TECHNOLOGIES
MOBILE CAN ACTUALLY COMPLIMENTS
DIGITAL. IN WAYS THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY BRING SERVICES TO THE
PEOPLE WERE TRYING TO SERVE
RATHER THAN AND EXPECT PEOPLE
TO SHOW UP AT OUR DOORSTEP.
WHEN THEY ARE AT THE HIGHEST
POINT OF CRISIS OR NEEDING
INFORMATION TO DO THIS WORK IN
REAL TIME DIGITAL AND MOBILE
NEED TO GO HAND IN HAND. OUR
CURRENT MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
CAN BE VERY DIFFICULT TO
UNDERSTAND TO ACCESS AND IT
DOESN'T IT HAS NOT ALWAYS BEEN
LED BY PREVENTION OF THE
COMMISSION IS VERY ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT THE MESSAGING IN THIS
PLAN THE OPPORTUNITY THIS PLAN
REPRESENTS. A WE WOULD VERY
MUCH WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH THE DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS AS ARE STARTING TO
ROLL THIS OUT IF THIS WERE TO
MOVE FORWARD TO TALK ABOUT HOW
WE CAN HELP STRENGTHEN THE
STRATEGY. AND PLAY OUR ROLE IN
ENSURING THAT CALIFORNIA'S
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM RESPONSE
THE NEEDS OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
AS BEST AS WE CAN IN. FACT HAVE
BEEN ANSWERING QUESTIONS. AND
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. NEXT WE WILL HEAR
FOR CORE HARSH DOLLAR WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU DR ARAMBULA A KOREA
SHEET WITH THE L. A. L- I'LL BE
DELIVERING ALL OF OUR OUR
OFFICES COMMENTS ON ON- THE
INITIATIVE TODAY I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE BEN JOHNSON IS ON THE
ON THE AGENDA BUT I THINK HE
HAD PREPARED HIS COMMENTS FOR
SORT OF A LATER A LATER PANEL-
WELL WE'VE CONDUCTED OUR
INITIAL REVIEW OF THIS
INITIATIVE AND YOU HAVE SOME
CONSIDERATIONS TO RAISE. YOU
KNOW AS YOU KNOW THERE ARE
VARIOUS COMPONENTS TO THIS
INITIATIVE CUTTING ACROSS.
MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS- INCLUDING
YOU KNOW ALL OF THE PANELISTS
TODAY- SO MY COMMENTS WILL BE
OVER ARCHING IN NATURE FOCUSED
ON THE INITIATIVE AS A WHOLE-
FIRST WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT-
ACROSS THE VARIOUS COMPONENTS
OF THE INITIATIVE THE
LEGISLATURE. IS GOING TO NEED
FURTHER DETAIL ON A LOT OF
AREAS IN ORDER TO PROPERLY
ASSESS THE MERITS OF EACH
PROPOSAL- THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS INDICATED THAT THERE'S
GOING TO BE TRAILER BILL
ASSOCIATED WITH THE INITIATIVE-
WHICH MAY ANSWER SOME
OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS BUT- THAT
TRAILER BILL AGAIN IS NOT
AVAILABLE FOR- LEGISLATIVE
REVIEW AT THIS TIME- BASED ON
THE INFORMATION THAT IS
AVAILABLE ABOUT THE INITIATIVE.
WE FIND THAT IN GENERAL WHILE
THERE ARE RELATIVELY SMALLER
PORTIONS OF THE INITIATIVE THAT
RELATE TO THE ONGOING PROVISION
OF SERVICES- SUCH AS THE
ADDITION OF A NEW BENEFIT IN
MEDIC CALIFORNIA. CARE SPENDING
UNDER THE INITIATIVE WOULD
LARGELY BE FOCUSED ON ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS FOR CAPACITY IN
INFRASTRUCTURE- FOR EXAMPLE THE
CREATION OF THE VIRTUAL
PLATFORM THAT WAS DISCUSSED
TODAY- THESE ONE TIME FOR.
THESE ONE TIME INVESTMENTS TO
OVERHAUL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DELIVERY HAVE MERIT. BUT WE
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT- THE
POTENTIAL BENEFITS TO CHILDREN
AND YOUTH AS A RESULT OF THESE
INVESTMENTS. MAY NOT ULTIMATELY
BE REALIZED UNTIL SOME YEARS
INTO THE FUTURE- AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WISHES TO PRIORITIZE- GETTING
SERVICES OUT TO CHILDREN AND
YOUTH AS SOON AS POSSIBLE GIVEN
URGENT NEED- WE JUST KNOW THAT
THIS TRADE OFF EXISTS BETWEEN
PRIORITIZING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CAPACITY. AND SERVICES NOW-
NEXT ALTHOUGH THERE ARE
RELATIVELY SMALLER COMPONENTS
OF THE INITIATIVE THAT- DO YOU
PROVIDE A FISCAL ESTIMATE OF
ONGOING SERVICE COSTS. IN
GENERAL THE ADMINISTRATION DOES
NOT SCORE ON GOING COSTS THAT
MAY ARISE FROM- THE GREATER
CAPACITY FOR SERVICES THAT
WOULD HOPEFULLY RESULT FROM THE
MAJOR ONE TIME INVESTMENT OF
THE INITIATIVE- THERE'S ALSO A-
COMPONENT OF THE INITIATIVE-
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE WHICH WAS
DISCUSSED EARLIER TO REQUIRE.
COMMERCIAL AND MEDICARE PLANS
TO COVER- SERVICES IN SCHOOLS
YOU KNOW WE FIND IT ALSO
POSSIBLE THAT THAT COULD HAVE A
FISCAL ATTACHED TO IT WHICH IS
NOT SORT OF SCORED AT THIS
TIME- NEXT WE WOULD NOTE THAT
A- SIZABLE PORTION OF THE
INITIATIVE. IS PROPOSED TO BE
PROVIDED AS GRANT FUNDING TO A
VARIETY OF ENTITIES- THESE
COULD INCLUDE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS SCHOOLS COUNTIES-
UNIVERSITIES HEALTH PLANS-
GIVEN THE MANY DIFFERENT
ENTITIES THAT WOULD BE-
ELIGIBLE TO APPLY FOR GRANT
FUNDS. YOU KNOW WE FIND THE KEY
DETAILS RELATED TO HOW THESE
GRANT PROGRAMS WOULD BE
DESIGNED ESPECIALLY IN TERMS OF
THE REQUIRED BENCHMARKS ARE
METRICS APPLICANTS WOULD HAVE
TO MEET IN ORDER TO OBTAIN
FUNDS. NEED TO SORT OF BE
CLEARLY FLESHED OUT- GIVEN THATTHESE ENTITIES MAY SORT OF HAVE
DIFFERENT CAPACITY- FOR MEETING
SORT OF A STANDARD SET OF
PERFORMANCE BENCHMARKS- WE
WOULD ALSO JUST FLAG THAT-
SIZABLE PORTIONS OF THE
INITIATIVE ARE INTENDED TO
PROVIDE. SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
TO ALL CHILDREN AND YOUTH
REGARDLESS OF PAYER- SORT OF
BEYOND THE SCOPE OF PUBLIC
PROGRAMS THAT ON THE STATE
TRADITIONALLY HAD MORE
RESPONSIBILITY OVER OVERSEEING-
YOU KNOW A COUPLE OF THE
PANELISTS- BEFORE ME SPOKE ON
SORT OF THE MERITS OF THAT
APPROACH. YOU KNOW WE DON'T
SORT OF RAISING MAJOR ISSUES
WITH THAT BUT WE JUST WE DO
JUST WANT TO FLAG THAT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE'S CONSIDERATION- SO
THAT IT MAY CONSIDER TO WHAT
EXTENT IT AGREES WITH THAT
APPROACH FOR- IF IT WOULD WISH
TO SORT OF TARGET MORE FUNDING
OUGHT. TO USE ON PUBLIC
PROGRAMS SUCH AS I'M SUCH AS
MEDICAID I'LL- LASTLY GIVEN THE
ENORMITY OF THIS INITIATIVE AND
WE FIND THAT FLUSHING OUT THE
EVALUATION COMPONENT OF THE
INITIATIVE IS GOING TO BE
VITAL- TO SORT OF ENSURE THAT
DEMONSTRATED MEASURABLE
OUTCOMES ARE STILL STAR-
ACHIEVED AS A RESULT OF THESE
PROPOSALS- PARTICULARLY WHEN IT
COMES TO WORKFORCE INVESTMENTS-
THE ADMINISTRATION MENTIONS. IN
ITS INITIATIVE DOCUMENTS THAT
IT INTENDS TO COMMISSION AN
INDEPENDENT EVALUATOR TO
EVALUATE THE OVERALL A
COMPONENT OF THE INITIATIVE AND
WE UNDERSTAND THAT- THE
INITIATIVE WILL SORT OF HAVE
MORE FOCUSED. EVALUATION
COMPONENTS IN EACH OF THE
SPECIFIC DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE
PART OF THAT THE INITIATIVE-
BUT THAT'S REALLY ALL THE
DETAIL THAT WE'RE AWARE OF ON
ON THIS FRONT AND- SO WE JUST
SORT OF NOTE THAT- REALLY SORT
OF UNDERSTANDING CLEARLY WHAT.
EVALUATION FRAMEWORK IS GOING
TO BE IN PLACE JUST TO SORT OF
MAKE SURE THE STATE HAS AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IT'S
GETTING AS A RESULT OF THESE
INVESTMENTS IS GOING TO BE
REALLY REALLY CRITICAL- THOSE
ARE ALL OF OUR OFFICES OVER
ARCHING COMMENTS AT THIS TIME-
AGAIN THIS IS. BASED ON OUR
INITIAL REVIEW AND YOU KNOW
THERE MAY BE SOME ANSWERS TO
SOME OF THE SOME OF THE
CONSIDERATIONS THAT WE REYES-
IN THE FORTHCOMING TRAILER
BILL- THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
COMPLETES THIS PANEL I WILL NOW
BRING IT UP TO THE DíAS TO SEE
IF ANY MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS.
DOCTOR WHAT. FOLLOWED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO ALL THE
PANELISTS AND I'M JUST JUST
SOME QUESTIONS HERE AND I'LL
START WITH A COP COUPLE
COMMENTS ON EARLY ON I KNOW
DOCTOR GOLLY HAD HAD HAD OTHER
BUSINESS BUT REALLY ON- DR
GOLLY LINK TO- BEHAVIORAL. WITH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDER- IF
SOME OF THOSE CONDITIONS AREN'T
EARLY ADDRESSED EARLY I WOULD
ARGUE THAT THAT ALSO COULD THE
COMBINATION THOSE TO THINK
COULD LEAD TO HOMELESSNESS FOR
THIS POPULATION AS WELL- AND-
SO PART OF MY- QUESTION TO
PEOPLE OUT THERE- WHOEVER MIGHT
ADDRESSES. IS THAT- I GUESS IN
GENERAL WHAT KIND OF AN OVER
ARCHING THEME FOR ME AND I'LL
GO BACK TO WHAT I TALKED ABOUT
MONDAY MORNING AT EIGHT THIRTY-
WHEN THERE WASN'T ANYBODY HERE
EXCEPT FOR US- IN AND THAT IS-
JUST IN GENERAL THE OVER
ARCHING THEME- CONCERN THAT I
HAVE IS THAT. WHO WHO OR WHAT
GROUP OF PEOPLE IS ACTUALLY
PERFORMING THE OVERSIGHT OTHER
THAN THE LEGISLATURE. FOR THESE
KINDS OF PROGRAMS FOR EXAMPLE-
IS THERE SOMEONE WHO IS THE YOU
KNOW GOING TO BE IN LOOKING AT
ALL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROGRAMS
AND ALL OF THE OUTCOMES
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT TO SEE ARE
WE SPENDING THE MONEY AND
GETTING THE RESULTS WE WANT
THAT'S CALLED ACCOUNTABILITY-
IN OUR THAT IS OUR DATA
COLLECTION SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY TRACK PROGRAM
OUTCOMES. SO WHO IS THE ACT
WHEN I VISIT WHAT I'M
VISUALIZING HERE IS LIKE A BUSY
AIRPORT A LOT OF PLANES COMING
AND GOING BUT NO AIR TRAFFIC
CONTROLLER. IN THAT'S THAT
TROUBLES THAT TROUBLES ME WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PROGRAMS WITH FOR
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN PLEASE
DO NOT MISUNDERSTAND WE NEED TO
SPEND THESE RESOURCES WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO INVEST IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE FOR OLD PEOPLE AND
EVERYBODY IN BETWEEN IT'S A
HUGE HUGE ISSUE. BUT WHAT I
DON'T SEE. IS A COORDINATION OF
EFFORT AND WHEN I WORRY ABOUT.
IS THAT THE MONEY GOES INTO
SILOS. AND THE SILOS DON'T TALK
WITH ONE ANOTHER. AND THAT
THERE MIGHT BE DUPLICATION THEY
MIGHT BE OVERLAP AND WE MIGHT
NOT GET THE OUTCOMES THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR AND SO AS I MAKING
NOTES HERE LISTENING TO PEOPLE
I WANT TO. COMP THAT COMMENT
THAT- MISTER EWING BROUGHT UP.
SOME OF THESE THINGS. WE NEED
TO ESTABLISH GOALS. WE NEED TO
MEASURE AND MONITOR PROGRESS.
WE NEED REAL TIME INFORMATION
ACROSS HEALTHCARE IN GENERAL WE
DON'T HAVE IT. AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY. WE NEED TO USE
THAT INFORMATION AND BE NIMBLE
ENOUGH TO MAKE CHANGED COURSE
CHANGES. AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE DON'T WE DON'T OFTEN
DO- AND THEN WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO EVALUATE OUTCOMES TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
SPENDING THE MONEY ON IN THE
MOST APPROPRIATE WAY. SO CAN I
KNOW SOMEBODY FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION MIGHT BE ANSWER
WHO IS GOING TO BE THE
OVERSIGHT AND COORDINATION OF
ALL OF THESE EFFORTS. SO THERE
THERE IS A PERSON OR ENTITY
THAT WE CAN GO TO AND GET. REAL
TIME INFORMATION. HAZ I'D BE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO STEP IN
GIVEN THAT DR KELLY HAD TO STEP
AWAY FOR A MOMENT AND SO I
THINK ONE OF THE PIECES THAT
WAS MENTIONED IN HIS OVER YOU
WHAT'S REALLY THE BALL THAT
AGENCY WILL BE PLAYING IN
REGARDS TO THIS PROPOSAL AND
THEY WILL NOT ONLY BE LEADING A
CROSS DEPARTMENTAL COORDINATION
AS HE REFERENCED A BUT THEY
ALSO PLAN ON CONVENING AND
ENGAGING WITH STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING A YOUTH FOCUSED
ENGAGEMENT BURKE HOW TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL OF THE DECISIONS
ARE BEING PULLED ACROSS THESE
VARIOUS INVESTMENTS. ARE YOU
CAN SEE WITHIN THE PROPOSAL
THERE ARE KEY COMPONENTS THAT
ARE ONGOING THE BIRCH WALL THAT
DIRECT SERVICES THROUGH THE
VIRTUAL POPCORN THE ECON SALT
ON THE LINKAGE WITH SCHOOL-
SERVICES IN COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS BUT A LOT OF THE
INVESTMENTS IN THESE FIRST FEW
YEARS WILL BE REALLY BUILDING
THAT FOUNDATION FOR THOSE
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE FOCUSED ON
THOSE EARLY INTERVENTIONS AND
WHAT WORKING ACROSS- AS WELL AS
HOW THAT PLAYS INTO THE LONG
TERM KIND OF INVESTMENTS FOR
THAT PROGRAM AND SO. I THINK
THERE IS- MANY PLANS TO HAVE A
LARGE STAKEHOLDER GROUP THAT
WOULD BE INFORMING ON THAT WORK
WE WOULD HAVE THE- THE A
PROPOSAL FOR WHAT WE'RE CALLING
IT A BEHAVIOR HEALTH THINK TANK
WHICH WOULD HAVE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS ON THAT WOULD HELP
INFORM BEST PRACTICES LEAKAGES
HOW WE SHOULD BE BUILDING OFF
OF THESE THINGS TO BE AS
EFFECTIVE. AS POSSIBLE IN THE
FUTURE I'M IN TO REALLY DO IT
RIGHT AND THEN LASTLY A REALLY
DEVALUATION COMPONENTS STARTING
EARLY IT'S WHY EVEN- BRING ON
THE EVALUATORS IN YOUR WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE THINKING
ABOUT THE EVALUATION FROM THE
BEGINNING OF THIS PROGRAM WHAT
ARE WE TRYING TO ACHIEVE WHAT
ARE THE METRICS WE WOULD LIKE
TO YOU- TO TRACK INTO OVERSEE
AS WE BUILD THIS PROGRAM OVER
MANY MANY YEARS AND SO I THINK
THE COMBINATION OF THE MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS BEING LED BY AGENCY
THE STAKEHOLDER. GROUP THAT
WILL INFORM MUCH OF THIS
BEHAVIOR HEALTH THINK TANK AND
THE EVALUATION ON THAT THE
AGENCY WOULD BE PUTTING PARK
ARE ALL MANY COMPONENTS. THAT
WOULD ADDRESS ON WHAT YOU'RE
RAISING. IT AND THOSE AROUND.
BUT THERE WAS WORK ALL COME BUT
IS THERE SO IS HEARING AIR
TRAFFIC CONTROLLER. ABOUT THEIR
I MEAN IS THERE SOMEBODY
ULTIMATELY WHO'S GOING IS IT IS
IT IS IT DIRECTOR LIGHT BORN IS
IT I MEAN WHO WHO IS ULTIMATELY
GOING TO BE THE RESPONSIBLE
PARTY AND IS THAT IN IN NOT
JUST AN EMPLOYEE'S I'M RYING
TO BE KANNST CONSTRUCTIVE
BECAUSE I REALLY DO WANNA I
REALLY DO WANT TO GET TO THE
MEAT OF THE ISSUE HERE. IS THAT.
YOU KNOW CAN WE TAKE THAT. THAT
PERSON IS GOING TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL THESE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROGRAMS. AND
GET THEM WITH THE PERSON WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE WITH ALL THE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDER
ISSUES. AND GET THEM TOGETHER
WITH THE PERSON WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR HOMELESSNESS.
AND LINK THESE THINGS TOGETHER.
FROM THEIR INDIVIDUAL SILOS.
AND REALLY GET TO THE MEAT OF
THE ISSUE FOR SOME PEOPLE WHO
ARE HOMELESS NOW THERE'S OTHER
CAUSES FOR HOMELESSNESS AND
THERE ARE LOTS OF OTHER REASONS
HERE. BUT THE ACE OF
HOMELESSNESS THAT WE SEE AS WE
WALKED THE STREETS. I BEG TO
ARGUE THAT MUCH OF THAT IS
POTENTIALLY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDER
COMBINATIONS OF THAT. BUT YOU
KNOW. THESE ARE ALL COMPLICATED
THINGS AND YOU KNOW FEELS LIKE
YOU NEED TO HAVE THREE PEOPLE-
THREE GROUPS OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
ALL TALKING TO ONE ANOTHER TO
COORDINATE THESE EFFORTS. AND
THAT'S WHAT I DON'T SEE. I SEE
A LOT OF RESOURCES THAT I DO I
AGREE WE SHOULD SPEND BUT I
DON'T SEE THE COURT I DON'T SEE
ANY OVER ARCHING COORDINATION.
IT GIVES. THE GIVES US.
HOPEFULLY THE OUTCOMES THAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR. MAY DOCTOR
WHAT OLD WILL LIKE FOR PARK
WELL I THINK IT'S A IT'S A
FUNCTION THAT HAS TO BE
SOMEWHAT WITH AGENCY BECAUSE
YOU HAVE BOTH DAMAGE SEE ALL
WITH THE PRIVATE PLANS AND THEY
ARE ACCOUNTABLE FOR SOME
DELIVERY OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
YOU HAVE. ALSO THE H. CS WITH
MANAGED CARE PLANS. WELL AND-
LOCAL ARE RESPONSE. IS SOLD SO
DISORDER AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WE'RE ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL.
REPORTING ON THE PHONE THE ONLY
THING I TRUST I MADE UP-
DOLLARS AND EFFECTIVENESS SO I
THINK OF IT. YOU HAVE THESE
COUPLE OF DEPARTMENTS BUT
INITIATIVE OF THE SCALE ALL
CLEARLY THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
SECRETARY IS A CENTRAL AVENUE
TWICE. HE PRESENTED IT TO ME.
SO THAT WE SHOULD. REPORT WHERE
Q. EXILE ABOUT THIS ALL
MICHIGAN VERY COME TO IT- BUT
IT I THINK WE ALL THAT THERE
ARE. OF EACH CHAPTER ALL AND
THEN A LITTLE BIT AS A WHOLE-
OF THIS AND HIS ME STAFF. OR
WILL. BEAGLE STORES HELLO WORK
HITTING OUR TARGETS OF NOT. AND
IF I COULD JUST ADD ONE THING
YOU KNOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES IN OUR B.
C. P. IS ACTUALLY REQUESTING A
DEPUTY LEVEL INDIVIDUAL TO LEAD
THIS INITIATIVE BECAUSE OF THE
FACT THAT IT CROSSES OVER THE
MULTIPLE PAIRS AND BECAUSE OF
THE FACT THAT THE FUNCTION OF
THE BURKE WILL PLATFORM
ENVIRONMENT. WHICH INCLUDES THE
DIRECT SERVICES THE LINKAGES TO
THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT- DOCTOR WOULD AND
WOULD BE A FUNCTION THROUGH
THAT PLATFORM AND SO MAKING
SURE THAT THERE IS A HIGH LEVEL
TEAM ON THAT WOULD BE FOCUSED
ON CONNECTING THOSE TALKS
WORKING VERY CLOSELY YOU CAN
SEE WHO WOULD BE LEADING THE-
MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WAS
CLEAR ON. THAT WE ARE LOOKING
FOR SOME HIGHER LETTER
LEADERSHIP TO MAKE SURE THOSE
DOTS ARE BEING CONNECTED
NECKING TO ALL OF THOSE VOCAL
ON TEACHERS AS WELL AND THAT
IT'S NOT JUST LOST WITHIN OF
THE VARIOUS PROGRAMS BUT
THERE'S A CONCERTED TEAM TO
KIND OF LEAD THIS EFFORT IN THE
IN A VERY CLEAR WAY TO SPELL.
IT WOULD JUST NOTE YOU KNOW
WHEN WE USE THE TERM BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH IT IS ENCOMPASSED OF
BOTH MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER SERVICES
AND SO THE ENTIRE PROPOSAL IS.
INCLUSIVE OF BOTH OF US. WE
CAN'T PREDICT IT THAT WAY. THAT
WASN'T CLEAR TO ME BECAUSE I'LL
WHAT I WAS SEEING WAS. A LOT OF
MONEY GOING INTO A LOT OF
PROGRAMS AND I DIDN'T FEEL I
DON'T I DIDN'T FEEL
COORDINATION THERE'S OF NOT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A DEPUTY
LEVEL. PERSON WHO'S GOING TO BE
RESPONSIBLE THAT THAT'S HELPFUL
THAT'S HELPFUL TO ME TO
UNDERSTAND THAT. BECAUSE WITH
WITH WITH WITH SOMEBODY WE NEED
ACCOUNTABILITY WE NEED TO NOW
WE'RE GETTING THE RESULTS. HERE
AND NOT JUST. PUTTING MORE
MONEY IN SILOS THAT ARE WORKING
INDEPENDENTLY- AS WE SEE IN A
LOT OF PARTS A GOVERNMENT QUITE
FRANKLY AND- AND WE'VE WE'VE
HEARD WE'VE WE'VE HEARD THAT
FROM- WITH FOR THAT. ALL ALONG
ALL ALONG THE WAY HERE SO I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU. IF I
MAY MISTER SEVEN NUMBER- YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS YOU
MIGHT CONSIDER BECAUSE THIS
PROPOSAL AT TOUCHES BEYOND THE
BOUNDARIES I SHOULD SAY OF THAT
COMPANY SERVICES AGENCY WITH
EDUCATION IN PARTICULAR BUT AS
YOU POINTED OUT HOUSING. IS IT
ISN'T IT WILL BE VERY IMPORTANT
THAT THERE IS AN INTERNAL TEAM
THAT CAN PROVIDE THAT AS YOU
SAY AIR TRAFFIC CONTROLLER
GUIDANCE AT YOU KNOW ACROSS THE
VARIOUS BRANCHES OF THE
ADMINISTRATION- BUT IT'S ALSO
GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT THAT
THERE IS AN EFFORT TO BRINGIN
THE COUNTY TO BRING IN LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES THE LOCAL
PARTNERS ON WHOM WE DEPEND. FOR
THIS AFTER BE SUCCESSFUL AND I
WOULD ADD EVEN THE LEGISLATURE
SO THAT THERE IS THAT IT'S NOT
IT IT IS THE AIR TRAFFIC
CONTROLLER BUT IT'S ALSO THE
INFORMATION THAT EXTERNAL
PARTNERS NEED. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE MAKING THE KIND OF
PROGRESS THAT YOU EXPECT THAT
THE PUBLIC EXPECTS AND THAT WE
CAN REMOVE BARRIERS WHEN THEY
ARE ENCOUNTERED IN THE PROCESS
AND SO THAT THAT EMPHASIS ON
OUTCOMES AND GOALS WILL BE VERY
IMPORTANT TO CAN TO SUSTAIN THE
CONFIDENCE THAT OFTEN STARTS AT
THE BEGINNING OF A PROJECT.
THAT CAN WANE WHEN YOU CONFRONT
SOME CHALLENGES GIVEN THE
TECHNOLOGY PIECE YOU MENTIONED
HOUSING WE WOULD AGREE HOUSING
IS ESSENTIAL THAT YOU MAY ALSO
THINK ABOUT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
STRUCTURES SPECIFIC TO THIS
PROJECT THAT IS THAT IS NOT
LIMITED TO THE ADMINISTRATION
THAT INCLUDES ALL OF. THE
PARTNERS THAT ARE ESSENTIAL FOR
SUCCESS. THANK YOU AND I GESS
I BACK TO THE HOUSING BECAUSE-
I JUST I JUST FEEL YOU CAN'T
JUST. YOU CAN'T JUST THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE THAT JUST CAN'T
JUST BE TAKEN AND PUT AN INPUT
INTO HOUSING. AND EXPECT THAT
THAT YOU'VE SOLVED THE PROBLEM
FOR THEM THAT'S NOT REALISTIC
IT DOESN'T WORK IN THE REAL
WORLD YOU DON'T ADDRESS THESE
OTHER ISSUES. THAT HAVE LED TO
THEIR THEIR HOMELESSNESS-
YOU'RE JUST ET YOUR DATE YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND
IF YOU'RE HEARING FRUSTRATION
FROM ME IT'S BECAUSE-
EVERYWHERE I GO IN MY DISTRICT.
HOW HOMELESSNESS- BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ISSUES THAT THAT YOU
WITH THEIR MANIFESTED IN PEOPLE
ON THE STREET ARE THE NUMBER
ONE ISSUES AND WE'RE NOT DOING
A VERY GOOD JOB. AND I JUST
WANT TO BE SURE IF WE'RE GOING
TO PUT A TON OF MONEY AND ALL
THIS WE HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY. DO
WE HAVE DATA TO TRACK OUTCOMES
AND WE HAVE RESULTS AND
COORDINATED EFFORT A REALLY
COORDINATED EFFORT AND IT JUST
FEELS LIKE THE COORDINATION
PART IS WHAT'S MISSING. AND AND
I AND I HOPE THAT WE CAN GET
BEYOND THAT QUITE FRANKLY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
HEAR FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS
FOLLOWED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU TO
THE PRESENTERS. AND THANK YOU
FOR- BRINGING FORWARD- THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL.
HEALTH INITIATIVE I THINK IT'S
LONG OVERDUE THAT WE START TO
FOCUS ON. THE MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES THAT ARE NEEDED-
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR YOUTH.
POPULATION AND TALKING ABOUT
ARE HOMELESS YOUTH THAT ARE
OUT. OF THERE IN THE STREETS OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT WE
OWE IT TO OURSELVES TO. NOW
LOOK AT- BUILDING THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE THE RESOURCES
ARE THERE FOR THEM. WHEN I WAS
ON THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE ESTABLISH THE
HOMELESS. YOUTH TASK FORCE. AND
WE FOUND QUICKLY. THAT THERE IS
RESISTANCE TO DIFFERENT BEDS-
DIFFERENT. UNITS DIFFERENT
INSTRUCTION OF THOSE BEING DONE
THROUGHOUT DIFFERENT CITIES
YET. THE HOMELESSNESS ISSUE
BECAME IT WAS A NUMBER ONE
ISSUE FOR EACH ONE OF THOSE
CITIES. SO BEING ABLE TO SEE
NOW MOVING FORWARD. WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THOSE MOVING
FORWARD WITH THIS. PROPOSAL
SHOWS THAT NOW. WE COULD- START
TO FULLY ADDRESS THE
HOMELESSNESS. IN THE YOUTH AND
THE MENTAL HEALTH AND ALL THOSE
ISSUES. THAT WE NEED TO BUT
THERE HAS TO BE. AN AREA WHERE
ALL THIS INFORMATION IS COMING
INTO SO THAT WE CAN GET THAT
INFORMATION AND REALLY.
DECIPHER IT AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE SENDING RESOURCES TO
THOSE AREAS. AND THE PROGRAMS
THAT TRULY ARE BEING SUCCESSFUL
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE HOPES OF.
MOVING FORWARD WITH THE OFFICE
OF SUICIDE PREVENTION. THAT
WOULD BE THAT CATCH ALL OF ALL
THAT DATA. COMING THROUGH- AND
SO I JUST WANTED TO I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS MISTER CHAIR
ONE. IS WE'VE WE'VE HEARD ON
THE PRESENTATION. THAT THERE IS
GOING TO BE WORKING WITH- THE
LOCAL ALLEY AS IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT BOARD OF EDUCATION. ON
EQUIPPING TEACHERS ON HOW TO
IDENTIFY SOME OF THE DIFFERENT-
TRAITS THAT COULD BE COMING FOR
WITH MENTAL HEALTH ILLNESS. IN
AUTUMN AND ALL ALSO A SUICIDE
PREVENTION. BUT WE ALSO KNOW
THAT PARENTS PARENTS TODAY IN
THIS DAY AND AGE STILL NEED
THOSE RESOURCES ALSO. TO
IDENTIFY WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
THEIR OWN CHILDREN OR THE
GUARDIANS OF THE CHILDREN SO
THEY CAN BECOME THE FIRST LINE
OF DEFENSE. SO THOSE ARE ALSO-
TALK ABOUT INCLUDING THEM IN
THE WHOLE STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
OF INCLUDING THEM IN THAT
DISCUSSION. SO I'LL STEP IN AND
THEN A PUBLIC HEALTH CAN ALSO
ADD ANYTHING IN REGARDS TO THAT
THE CAMPAIGN THAT THEY WOULD
BE- COORDINATING ARE THERE VERY
MUCH IS GOING TO BE A FOCUS AND
ENSURE THAT THEIR YOUTH WITHIN
THE STAKEHOLDER GROUP THAT WILL
BE CONVENIENT- TO INFORM THIS
WORK AND I WOULD. ASSUME THAT
WOULD ALSO INCLUDE FAMILIES AND
OR- CARE GIVERS OF ABUSE I TO
ALSO INFORM THE WORK FROM THEIR
PERSPECTIVE. I'M SO I THINK THE
SHORT ANSWER IS YES- AND DON'T
KNOW IF THE IF ANY OF OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH COLLEAGUES WANT
TO ADDRESS ANY OF THE
ADDITIONAL- COMPONENTS OF THE
OVERALL KIND OF CAMPAIGN THAT
THEY WOULD BE. RUNNING THANK
YOU J. C. I CAN JUST ADD THAT
BESIDES THE EDUCATION SECTOR.
FAMILIES CAREGIVERS AND OTHER
INFLUENTIAL COMMUNITY LEADERS
AND ADULTS THAT PLAY AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN KIDS LIVES IS
A KEY PART OF THE CAMPAIGN FROM
FOSTER YOUTH TO TRANSITIONAL
AGE YOUTH TO OTHERS IT'S NOT
ALWAYS THE SCHOOL AND NOT
ALWAYS THE PARENTS LET ME
CREATE THE TOUCH POINTS SO
INTENTIONALLY. THE PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND CHANGE CAMPAIGN
WILL BE BROUGHT IN NATURE TO
TRY AND HELP ALL CALIFORNIANS
JUST LIKE WITH STROKE OR
SOMETHING ELSE TO BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY EARLY SIGNS TO
INTERVENE FOR ANY. YOU MAY NOT
HAVE IF YOU SEE OUR YOUTH THAT
THAT YOU HAVE THAT CONNECTION
WITH AND THAT THEY'RE IN
DISTRESS THAT YOU KNOW THOSE
SIGNS AND YOU KNOW HOW TO
SUPPORT THEM AND GETTING LINKED.
THANK YOU AND JUST EXPANDING
UPON THAT IS- UTILIZING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S ALREADY
BUILT WITH A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS- YOUTH TASTE
CENTERS THAT ARE OUT THERE. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THERE'S SOME
DIFFERENT YOUTH GROUPS THAT ARE
THERE T WAS BROUGHT UP EARLIER
WITH A PRISONER I BELIEVE THAT
TALKED ABOUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
CHILDREN HOSPITALS. THAT ARE
ALREADY IN MANY OF THE PARTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
BEING PART OF THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S THERE
THAT NOW WE'RE TRYING TO EQUIP
THEM TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THESE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES-
WITH ARE YOU. THERE ARE THEY
ALSO PART OF THE COMPONENT OF
HOW WE'RE REACHING OUT SO THAT
WE'RE NOT DUPLICATING OR TRYING
TO CREATE A WHOLE NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT PROBABLY
EXISTS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IF
THEY'RE DOING A GOOD JOB AT
ADDRESSING SOME OF THESE ISSUES
OR HAVE. THOSE THAT DRASTICALLY
WE NEED THE RESOURCES SO THAT
THEY COULD THEN GET THE
RESOURCES IN A TIMELY MANNER.
JUST OVERALL ALL COMMENTS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I MEAN I THINK.
IT'S DEFINITELY THE EXPLICIT
INTENTION. TO SORT OF. PULLING
TOGETHER ALL OF THE ALL. LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS PEOPLE WHO ALREADY
HAVE PRESENCE FOOTPRINT AND
IMPACT OF THE SPACE. THAT WE DO
BUILT ON WHAT EXISTS ALL THE-
HOSPITALS CLINICS SYSTEMS LIKE
THAT WELL PART OF THE SYSTEM
AND ULTIMATELY AS WE SORT OF
DEVELOPED PLATFORMS RENDON OUR
NEXT AGENDA. AREA WILL BILL
SOME ABOUT TWELVE TO POPULATION
HEALTH MANAGEMENT PLATFORMS
WELL ALL OF THESE ALL NEED TO
BE KEPT VERY EFFECTIVELY.
RANKED AND COMMUNICATED ACROSS.
THANK YOU ONE MORE QUESTION IF
I MAY MISTER CHAIR UNLESS
THERE'S SOMEONE WHO'S GOING TO
ANSWER FURTHER MORE ON THAT
QUESTION. JUST ONE MORE
QUESTION ON- YOU KNOW WORKING.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND WORKING
ON CRISIS STABILIZATION UNITS
FOR- OLDER. ADULT POPULATION IN
SEEN NOW THAT THE PROMISE OF
NOW FOCUSING ON YOUTH- AND- AND
CRISIS STABILIZATION
PSYCHIATRIC THOSE TYPES OF
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES FOR YOU
FOR NOW- BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT
THAT IT'S BEEN OVERLOOKED FOR
SO LONG. SO I'M EXCITED TO SEE
THAT THIS PROPOSALS COMING
FORWARD. BUT I ALSO WANTED TO-
A. B. AND BE ASSURED THAT THE
REQUEST IN THIS PROPOSAL IN THE
FUNDING. WOULD START TO GO
TOWARDS CREATING FOR ARE YOU
RIGHT ARE ARE K. THROUGH ALL
THE WAY UP TO THE- TWENTY FIVE
AGE I BELIEVE IT WAS. THAT A
PRESENTER SAID THEY WILL START
TO HAVE THOSE TYPES OF
STABILIZATION- UNITS. OR STE
THIS CRISIS CENTERS IN THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS THROUGHOUT HE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
INFRASTRUCTURAL NEEDS THAT ARE
THERE. WE'VE DONE SOME THINGS
FOR OUR OLDER POPULATION AS FAR
AS CRISIS STABILIZATION UNITS
AND NOW. WE'RE A BIG PROPONENT
OF CREATING LONG TERM AND IT IS
STABILIZATION UNITS FOR NINETY
DAYS PLUS. BUT YET WE'RE TAX
LEVY HERE AT THE OLDER AGES
WHAT AND IT'S GREAT TO SEE NOW
THAT WOULD BRING THE FOCUS TO
OUR YOUNGER AGES. WHAT THEY'RE
INGESTING NEED OF THE SAME
RESOURCES RIGHT AT EARLY AGE SO
WANTING TO ASK. IN THE FUNDING
SCHEME IS BEING PRESENTED WITH
THIS ALSO IDENTIFIED THE NEED.
FOR A CRISIS- STABILIZATION
SERVICES OR THINGS OF THAT
TYPE- TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO THAT MORE
COUNTIES MORE AREAS WOULD HAVE
THOSE RESOURCES READILY
AVAILABLE FOR USE. ESPECIALLY.
COMING OUT OF THE COVE IN
NINETEEN. THAT RESPOND. ALL THE
PROPOSAL ACTUALLY LINKS SHOULD
BE SO AS LINKED BOTH TO ALL
COVERS BUDGET JANUARY PROPOSAL
FOR THE INCENTIVE- BUILDING UP
CONNECTIONS BETWEEN- MANAGED
CARE PROGRAMS IN SCHOOLS BUT
ALSO LINKED TO THE OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE- INVESTMENT
STUFF ON OUR COULD BE DISCUSSED
IN OUR NEXT AGENDA ITEM WELL
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE DH CS
BUDGET BECAUSE OUR SPECIFIC
RESOURCES- DEDICATED THEIR TO
THE ALL WITH ALL SOCIAL CARE
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE ALL
OF ALL. YOUTH AND YOUNG ADULTS.
AND I WOULD ADD THAT- WITH THE
THIS BILL THERE'S TWO FIFTY
FIVE ON MILLION DOLLARS
SPECIFICALLY DEDICATED- ON TO
THE CHILDREN AND YOUTH
ADDITIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE
PIECES JUST MAKE SURE IT'S
SPECIFICALLY CARVED OUT- AS
WELL MENTIONED KIND OF BUILDING
OFF OF THAT PROPOSAL PREVIOUSLY
AND IT WOULD INCLUDE ANYWHERE
FROM ACUTE INPATIENT-
RESIDENTIAL FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH AS WELL AS- BUT- YOU
KNOW. TO CALLING BEHAVIOR
HEALTH URGENT CARE AS WELL AS
BEHAVIOR HEALTH WELLNESS
CENTRES THE FALL CONTINUE ON
FOR CHILDREN ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE- VARIOUS TOUCH POINTS
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THERE ARE
RETURNS WHERE- IN INPATIENT OR
RESIDENTIAL SETTING MAY BE
APPROPRIATE FOR A CHILD OR
YOUTH. I'M INDIVIDUAL BUT THERE
ALSO NEEDS TO BE FULL CONTINUUM
AND HOME LIKE SERVICES ON THAT
THEY CAN FEEL COMFORTABLE AND-
AND SO IT WOULD INCLUDE THE
FULL SPECTRUM OF SERVICES FOR-
THE CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND. I
HAVE ZERO TO TWENTY FIVE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR. BRING IN
THIS- THESE ISSUES FOR SO THAT
WE CAN ALL START TO- ADVOCATE.
FOR OUR YOUTH IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU NEXT WE WILL
HEAR FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND- ONE REALLY THANK
THE PANEL FOR THIS REALLY
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT THE. THE
IT HER. APPROACH TO HELPING
CHILDREN WITH THEIR MOLD MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES ONE OF THE THINGS
IT IS KIND OF CONCERNING TO ME
AS I SEE AN IMPLEMENTATION
COMPONENTS THIS YEAR'S OUT IN
SEVERAL OF THESE ITEMS. WHOM WE
TALK ABOUT THE IMPENDING. DIRE
NEED OF POST PANDEMIC THERE.
THE YEARS OUT DON'T DO US ANY
GOOD NOW. AND I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT WHEN WE LOOK AT. YOU
KNOW WE TALK ABOUT THE
DESPERATE NEED OF FOR CHILDREN
SO DO THEY'D WAIT FOR THE TWO
OR THREE YEARS THAT WE- AND
THEN THEY CAN HELP- THAT'S ONE
OF THE THINGS IS VERY
CONCERNING TO ME- THE OTHER IS.
I'VE NOT HEARD ANY MENTION OF
AN OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER WITH
PUBLIC SAFETY WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT CRISIS INTERVENTION OR
CRISIS RESPONSE RATHER THAN
HAVING THE PUBLIC SERVICE OR
PUBLIC SAFETY RESPOND WE'RE A
DISPATCHER WOULD HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DETERMINE IS IT A
PLEASE CALL RESERVE SHOULD THIS
MENTAL HEALTH CAPACITY BE SENT
INSTEAD. PROVIDING BETTER
OUTCOMES- LESS RISK ON BOTH
PARTIES OF INJURY OR OR WORSE
I'M SO I WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME
KIND OF CAPACITY WITH PUBLIC
SAFETY FIRST RESPONDERS TO BE
ABLE TO BE AN INTEGRATED IN
THIS. COMPONENT FOR. THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT GO OUT AND
THEN CAN ACTUALLY GET AND
DETERMINE WHERE THAT. PERSON
COULD GET CARE IMMEDIATELY
RATHER THAN GOING THROUGH A
PROCESS OF BEING ARRESTED AND
THEN DETERMINE IF THEY HAVE TO
GO TO THE LOCAL HOSPITAL GET
DETERMINED FIFTY ONE FIFTY.
IT'S REALLY WHAT I CONSIDER AN
IMPERATIVE FIRST INITIAL-
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP. AND I GIVE
THEM TO SOMEONE MISTER CHAIRMAN
SOME LIKE A BROKEN RECORD. I
DON'T HEAR ANY INTEGRATION WITH
THE REGIONAL CENTRES. NOT ONE
BIT. AND I WOULD HOPE THAT THE
PANEL HANDLES WHO. OUR
COMMITTEE WOULD LOOK AT THE
DOCUMENTARY A DANGEROUS SON.
WHERE FAMILIES HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THIS DUAL DIAGNOSIS
WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
MAYBE A MODERATE TO SEVERELY
AUTISTIC. OF CHILD THERE IS A
COMPLETE CONNECTION HERE WHERE
THIS HAS TO BE IMPLEMENTED WERE
THE REGIONAL CENTERS HAVE TO
HAVE AN INTIMATE RELATIONSHIP
WITH DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
THIS MENTAL HEALTH COMPONENT IS
ABSOLUTELY- NEEDS TO GO FORWARD.
THE OTHER IS THAT- YOU KNOW
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE SCHOOLS IT
IS PRESENT THAT'S THE PERFECT
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THE MOST
CONTACT WITH THESE CHILDREN IN
WHICH I ABSOLUTELY AGREE ONE
HOP WHOLEHEARTEDLY. BUT HOW
COME THE DEPARTMENT EDUCATION
WASN'T INCLUDED. HOW COME THEY
WEREN'T ASKED WHAT IT WOULD
TAKE IN THEIR THOUGHT PROCESS
AS THE EXPERTS WITH THESE
CHILDREN WHAT IT WOULD TAKE
COST WISE WERE EFFECTIVENESS TO
BE ABLE TO INTEGRATE THIS
PROGRAM. THEY'RE NOT HERE. AND
I NEED TO UNDERSTAND. AND A LOT
OF THIS IS GRANT INCENTIVIZED
SO IT'S IF THEY DON'T. WANT TO
GO OUT FOR THE GRANT THEY DON'T
HAVE TO. JUST PAY. WHEN YOU
LOOK THE SCHOOLS EL CAP THEY
HAVE TO ADDRESS THIS BY THEY
DON'T HAVE THIS CYCLE COULD
PASS THEN HAVE THE ANYMORE SOME
SCHOOLS HAVE EVEN OPTED OUT OF
THE S. OKAY SO. WHAT DOES IT
TAKE WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
CAPACITY OF GIVING INDIVIDUALS
INTO THESE SCHOOLS AND THE
SCHOOLS WOULD NOT. SO I WOULD
HOPE THAT THE DEPARTMENT.
PARTNERS WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ARE SUPERINTENDENT
HON TONY THURMOND TO DETERMINE
AND THEN. WHAT IS MR WHAT IS
SAID CONTABILIDADE. HAND HOW
COMES OR HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
BE DERIVED TO WHAT WE'RE
EXPECTING WITH THIS EXPENSIVE
MONEY- YOU KNOW I REALLY DO
THINK THAT THE PEER TO PEER
MENTIONED EARLIER IS IMPERATIVE
BECAUSE OF THE STIGMA THAT GOES
ALONG WITH THE MENTAL HEALTH-
UNFORTUNATE STIGMA ARE THEY
JUST WE REALLY DO NEED TO
ENGAGE OUR CHILDREN. FOR A PEER
TO PEER SO FOR SUPPORT AND I
THINK THAT'S WE'RE GONNA GET A
LOT OF THE- INITIAL RESULTS OF
SUCCESS- AND THEN ALSO WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW PARTNERING
WITH ORGANIZATIONS WHY HASN'T
HAD ME. BEEN INCLUDED IN THIS.
WE DON'T NEED TO RECREATE THE
WHEEL WITH THEM INVOLVED I MEAN
THEY'VE GOT IT THEY DO IT AND I
NATION WIDE. AND SO I'M HOPING.
THAT WE BROADEN OUR OUR OUTLOOK
ON. THE ITV POPULATION WITH DDS
THE REGIONAL CENTERS. ON THAT
WE PARTNER WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. TO FOR- A
PARTNERSHIP AS- WE LOOK FORWARD
TO. SERVICING THE CHILDREN ON A.
HOPEFUL OUTCOME HELPFUL IN AND
I THINK ONE OF THE LAST THINGS
ARE CLOSE ON HIS THAT. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I'VE SEEN. WITH
FAMILIES IS THE THIRD CHILD IS
GETTING HELP BUT THERE'S A CAP
ON THE ABOUT AMOUNT OF TIME THE
HELP CAN BE PROVIDED AND I'M
HOPING THAT WE ADDRESS THE I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S THROUGH
MEDICARE MEDICARE WHATEVER IT
IS BUT- IF IT'S FOR A PERIOD OF
TIME IN THAT CHILD IS NOT HELD.
THAT THAT CAN BE EXTENDED. THAT
pCHILD OR THAT INDIVIDUAL HAS
THE ABILITY TO BE THOROUGHLY
VETTED AND HELPED. FOR THAT
MISTER TERRA I THANK YOU FOR MY
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. I WAS
HOPING THE ADMINISTRATION TO
MAKE SOME COMMENTS TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND MEMBER FRAZIER'S
COMMENTS PARTICULARLY REGARDING
THE IDT POPULATION. SO WHAT I
WOULD JUST ADD THAT IN REGARDS
TO THE COMMENTS AT A FEW KEY
WORDS- I THINK THAT IT WILL BE
CRITICAL THAT ADVOCACY- IS
CONTINUE TO BE BUILTAND WE ARE
FINE TUNING THE POLICY THAT
WOULD BE DEFINITELY A KEEP IN
MIND THE NINE EIGHT H.
STRUCTURE THAT. MAY BE
IMPLEMENTED IN CALIFORNIA THAT
WE ARE JUST. I'M TO THE VARIOUS
CRISIS SERVICES AS WELL AS WITH
OUR- JUSTICE INVOLVED PARTNERS
ALONG THAT THAT BUILDS WE WILL
BE A CRITICAL COMPONENT THAT WE
WILL NEED TO MAKE SURE WORK
CONSIDERING AND AS WE DO THAT.
ADDITIONALLY A REGIONAL CENTERS
AND- THAT AND NOT IS GOING TO
BE A CRITICAL PARTNER AS WE
THINK THROUGH THE VIRTUAL
PLATFORM IN THE SERVICES THAT
THAT CAN BE AVAILABLE THROUGH
THAT PLATFORM. IN THE VARIOUS
POPULATIONS ARE THAT NEED TO BE
SERVED AND HOW WE DO THAT SO I
THINK WE WILL I'M DEFINITELY
ENSURE THAT WE ARE PARTNERING
ON THAT FRONT IN REGARDS THE
TYPES OF SERVICES I'M BACK TO
BE AVAILABLE THROUGH THROUGH
THIS VIRTUAL PLATFORM- AND THEN
AND THEN LASTLY AND DEFINITELY
NOT NOT LEAST IN REGARDS TO
PARTNERING WITH OUR EDUCATIONAL
PARTNERS I MEAN WE HAVE. WITHIN
A NUMBER INITIATIVES OUT BEFORE
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN
JANUARY AS OTHERS BEEN REALLY
PARTNERING I REALLY IN TAKING
AS CRITICAL STEPS TO FORGE
PARTNERSHIPS AND RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
EXPANDING THE AMOUNT OF
SERVICES AVAILABLE IN SCHOOL
THAT WE ARE LINKING TO TWO
SCHOOLS. ON TO ENSURE THAT THAT
CHILDREN CAN HAVE ACCESS TO THE
SERVICES- AND TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE PARTNER WITH
US IN REGARDS THAT POLICY
BUILD- AND GETTING ALL OF THEIR
FEEDBACK AND INPUT ALONG THE
WAY AS THEY HAVE BEEN CRITICAL
PARTNERS WITH US I'M FROM THE
BEGINNING IN THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH IN SCHOOLS A PROPOSAL-
THAT WE HAVE BEEN BETTING AS
WELL AS WILL BE CRITICAL
PARTNERS FOR THIS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. I'M TO ENSURE THAT
IT IS ROLLED OUT IN A
COMPREHENSIVE. WAY I WOULD ALSO
JUST HIGHLIGHT IN REGARDS TO
SOME OF THE GAPS THAT WERE
MENTIONED THAT SCHOOLS MAY
HAVE- WELL I AGREE WITH YOU-
GRANTS DO YOU HAVE TO BE.
APPLIED FOR BY THOSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS BUT OF THOSE. DOLLARS
FOR SCHOOLS WOULD ALLOW TO PAY
FOR. A THE INVESTMENT OR
INCENTIVIZE- THE HIRING OF. A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COUNSELORS AS
WELL AS THE PEER TO PEER-
ENVIRONMENTS IN BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH COACHES AND SO WE'RE
REALLY HOPING THAT SOME OF
THOSE INCENTIVES THEY- WOULD BE
ABLE TO FILL SOME OF THE- THE
GAPS. THAT HAVE EXISTED IN TO
BROKER SOME OF THOSE THOSE NEW
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THIS
PLATFORM. AS WELL. THANK YOU
WITHOUT A WILL BRING IT UP TO
THE CHAIR JUST FOR A COMMENT I
WANT TO START BY AGREEING WITH
TOBY EWING THAT THIS IS BOTH A
BROAD AND HISTORIC AND BEST.
THAT FOCUSES ON PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTIONS AS WELL AS
ON COMMUNITY EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH. I AM QUITE IMPRESSED%
WITH THIS PROPOSAL AND ITS
BREATH AND ABILITY TO HELP US
TO BUILD A BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
FOUNDATION THAT WE CAN ALL BE
PROUD OF. AND REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO BEING ABLE TO WORK
WITH THIS DEPARTMENTS TO BUILD
IN THE OUTCOMES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE. WILL NEED FOR THIS
SIZE OF INVESTMENT. THE REALLY
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT MANY OF THE
PROPOSALS- FROM THE VIRTUAL
PANEL TO THE DYADIC SERVICES TO
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
EXTENDING WITH. A BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH COACHES AND COUNSELORS
IS INCREDIBLE AND QUITE NEEDED.
I LOOK FORWARD TO US AS A STATE
MAKING SURE THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
RESOURCES TO THE CHILDREN WHO
HAVE THE GREATEST NEEDS AND-
REALLY AGAIN WANTS TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
WITHOUT ANY FURTHER COMMENTS WE
WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AND
MOVE ON TO PANEL THREE WHICH IS
ON THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION. MAY REVISE UPDATES
WE WILL HAVE FOR PRISONERS ON
THIS PANEL STARTING WITH TOBY
EWING THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE MHS OAC. FOLLOWED BY ILEANA
IT ALMOST AND SO NON BUT THEN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
FOLLOWED BY COREY HI SHEILA
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. MISTER EWING CAN YOU
PLEASE BEGIN. YOU'RE VERY MUCH
TO BE DOING ON BEHALF THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION I APPRECIATE THE
CHANCE TO AGAIN TALK WITH YOU
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE MEDICAL
STUDENT SERVICES ACT. YOU MAY
RECALL THAT IT THE COMMISSION
INITIALLY USE SOME OF OUR SB TO
TRIAGE FUNDS. TO INCENTIVIZE
COUNTIES TO WORK WITH SCHOOLS
TO BUILD OUT A ROBUST
PARTNERSHIP. TO MEET THAT NOW
HEALTH NEEDS OF STUDENTS AND WE
JUST HAD A TREMENDOUS RESPONSE
THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION FOLLOWED UP
ESTABLISHING A MEDICAL STUDENT
SERVICES ACT. M. WITH TEN
MILLION DOLLARS OF ON GOING.
AND MILLION OF TIME MONEY THAT
THAT ALLOCATED TO COMMISSION WE
ABLE. COBBLE TOGETHER SEVENTY
FIVE NINE DOLLARS OVER MULTIPLE
YEARS. TO SUPPORT MY ENDED UP
BEING EIGHTEEN COUNTY SCHOOL
PER. WE HAD A- TOTAL OF THIRTY
EIGHT COUNTY APPLICATIONS
COUNTY SCHOOL PARTNERSHIP
APPLICATIONS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE THE FUNDING WE HAD AND IT
AT THE TIME ONLY ALLOWED US TO
FIND EIGHTEEN OF THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS. THE R. TWENTY
GRANTS THAT WE WERE NOT ABLE TO
FIND- K. FROM SMALL COUNTIES
SIZED AND LAW COUNTY ALL THE
STATE AS WE DISTRIBUTED WE MADE
SURE THAT THESE FUNDS WERE
AVAILABLE BASED ON DIFFERENT
COUNTY SIZES FOR THE SMALL
COUNTIES WERE COMPETING AGAINST
THE LARGEST COUNTIES FOR
EXAMPLE. THESE PROGRAMS ARE
VERY IMPORTANT MORE IMPORTANT
TODAY THAN THEY WERE WHEN WE
SET THIS PROGRAM NOT BECAUSE WE
HAVE STARTED THIS INITIATIVE.
PRIOR TO COPE AND COUNTIES ARE
USING THESE FUNDS AB ACTUALLY
THE PARTNERSHIPS AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
PARTNERSHIPS INCLUDE ACCOUNTED
TO HEAR HEALTH DEPARTMENT ONE
OR MORE. LOCAL SCHOOLS OR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION. AND OR
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND AT THE
DIFFERENT PARTNERSHIPS THE
DESIGNATED DIFFERENT LEADS WE
GET THIS INTENTIONALLY. OUR OUR
PRIMARY MOTIVATION WAS TO-
INCENTIVIZE COUNTIES AND
SCHOOLS TO SIT DOWN AND WORK
TOGETHER AND FIGURE OUT HOW
THEY CAN LEVERAGE THE STRENGTHS
OF THE SCHOOLS BRING. AND THE
STRENGTHS THAT THE COUNTIES
BRING TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS AND IN MANY CASES
THEIR FAMILIES. ARE OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS ARE USING THESE FUNDS
TO DO SCREENING TO DO TRAININGS
TO DELIVER CARE. TO STUDENTS
THROUGH THE SCHOOLS ARE OFTEN
IN PARTNERSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THERE'S A
RANGE OF STRATEGIES THAT ARE
TAILORED. TO THE. LOCAL NEEDS
OF THOSE PARTNERS. THEY GRANT
RANGED IN SIZE TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION FOR SMALL COUNTIES FOUR
MILLION FOR MEDIUM SIZED
COUNTIES IN THE LARGEST GRANT
WAS LIMITED TO SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR A LARGE COUNTIES
WHICH AS YOU CAN IMAGINE THE
COUNTY LIKE LOS ANGELES IS
INADEQUATE- THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSES TO
INCREASE THE FUNDING BY TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO EXPAND.
THOSE GRANT OPPORTUNITIES TO IT
WHICH WOULD ALLOW US TO FIND AN
ADDITIONAL SIX COUNTIES THE MAY
REVISE ADDS AN ADDITIONAL
TWENTY FIVE MILLION TO THAT
AMOUNT WHICH WOULD ALLOW US TO
ACT IN AND ANOTHER SIX COUNTY
SO TOTAL TWELVE. TO MOVE LAST-
FROM THE EIGHTEEN TO THIRTY
COUNTIES. THE IT ALSO INCLUDES
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
AND EVALUATION AND ASSESSMENT
OF HOW WELL THAT PROGRAM IS
WORKING OVERTIME. SO WE ARE
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
OPPORTUNITY WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN
TALKING WITH OUR PARTNERS
APPLICANTS TO USING THE
LANGUAGE OF. OF AN EMERGENCY OR
CRISIS TO SORT OF PRE POSITION
THESE CONTRACTS WHAT WE'RE
ATTEMPTING TO DO CONSISTENT
WITH THE ALLOCATION THAT WE
BELIEVE IS COMING. IS TO BE
ABLE TO SIGN CONTRACTS THAT
WOULD BEEFFECTIVE JULY ONE.
AND THE GOAL THERE IS THAT WE
CAN. DO EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN
ON OUR SIDE. TO ALLOW OUR
SCHOOL COUNTY PARTNERS TO HAVE
SERVICES IN PLACE. AS STUDENTS
BEGIN TO RETURN TO CAMPUS IN
THE FALL. THAT MAY NOT MEAN
THAT OUR LOCAL PARTNERS CAN
REACT THAT QUICKLY BUT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT NOTHING IN
OUR BEHAVIOR AND ACTIONS ARE
EFFORTS IMPEDES THEIR ABILITY
TO BE AS RESPONSIVE TO THE
NEEDS. OF THEIR STUDENTS AND
COMMUNITIES AS THEY CAN BE- WE
SEE THIS AS VERY. IDEAS THE
TERM SHOVEL READY IN THE PAST-
BUT BASED ON SOME COMMENTS I
WOULD SAY CLASSROOM OR STUDENT
READY WE WANT TO BE A STUDENT
READY AS WE CAN. AND BELIEVE
THIS IS A PRIME OPPORTUNITY TO
BE RESPONSIVE TO THE IMMEDIATE.
NEEDS OF STUDENTS. UNDER THE
TO. WRECK THAT THAT YOU KNOW AS
YOU TALK ABOUT THE LAST COUPLE
OF HOURS THAT NEEDS ARE JUST-
INAPPROPRIATELY HIGH. HAVE BEEN
ANSWERING QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
ABOUT THE PROGRAM WITH PROPOSAL
IN FRONT OF YOU AND THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE CHANCE TO TALK.
THANK YOU NEXT WE WILL HEAR
FROM ILEANA RAMOS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M I WILL BE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND ALL
PATEL. AND WE WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE I'M INTERESTED IN
THE PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO THE COMMISSION FOR
THE MENTAL HEALTH STUDENT
SERVICE IN FACT. I'M IN
DETERMINING THE AMOUNT FOR THE
AUGMENTATION TO THE PARTNERSHIP
GRANT PROGRAM AND GIVEN THE
OASES HISTORICALLY BEING FUNDED
WITH THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FIND- WE REVIEW THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE FOR THE MENTAL
SERVICES FIND AT ME REVISION
AND DETERMINE THAT THE FINE
COULD SUPPORT AN ADDITIONAL
THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION. ADDITIONALLY THE
FUND HAS NOT BEEN RECONCILED AT
THIS TIME AND GIVEN THE
CHALLENGE WITH MULTIPLE
MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS SPENDING
OUT OF THIS FUND AS WELL AS A
NUMBER OF EXISTING
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITY AUGMENTATIONS WE THINK
THE CURRENT LEVEL OF RESOURCES
THAT ME REVISIONIST FISCALLY
PRUDENT- THANK YOU AND NO
FURTHER COMMENTS BUT WE ARE AT
MYSELF AND MY COLLEAGUE ILEANA
RAMOS ARE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM COREY HOW SHE GO
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. THANK YOU DOCTOR- WE
DON'T HAVE ANY SORT OF MAJOR
CONCERN SERVE TO RAISE ON THIS
PROPOSAL AND- WE DON'T SORT OF
HAVE ANY OBJECTIONS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES-
ASSESSMENT OF THE LEVEL OF.
AVAILABLE RESOURCE INDIA THE
STATE ADMINISTRATOR FUND. THANK
YOU WITH HIM WILL BRING IT BACK
UP TO THE DíAS FOR ANY MEMBER
QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE I'D LIKE
TO THANK TO BE EWING FOR
HELPING US TO IDENTIFY. PROJECT
THAT IS STUDENT READY SHOVEL
READY THAT WE CAN HELP TO GET
UP AND RUNNING BY JULY FIRST I
ALSO WANT TO THANK HIM FOR
WORKING AND HELPING TO PRE
POSITION SOME OF THE CONTRACTS.
AS I BELIEVE THIS IS ONE OF THE
BEST WAYS WE CAN HELP TO GET
OUR STUDENTS NEEDS ADDRESSED AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN. WITH THAT WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
PANEL PANEL FOR ON THE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY MAY REVISE UPDATES.
WE WILL HAVE SEVEN PRESENTERS
ON THIS PANEL INCLUDING DOCTOR
DAVE DUNCAN DIRECTOR. LOUIS
BRONCHI CHIEFDEPUTY DIRECTOR
RICK TRUSSELL CHIEF OF
ADMINISTRATION CRAIG JOHNSON
CHIEF DISASTER MEDICAL SERVICE
DIVISION WITHIN THE EMSA. HONG
**** AND STEVEN PAVLOV WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND SONYA
PADDOCK WITH THE L. A. M. LET'S
BEGIN WITH DIRECTOR DUNCAN. DR
DUNCAN EXCUSE ME. GOOD
AFTERNOON DOCTOR CHAIRMAN
ARAMBULA AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS-
I'M DOCTOR DAVE DUNCAN I'M
EMERGENCY POSITION AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY. I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT HERE TODAY- THIS
AFTERNOON OUR CHIEF OF
ADMINISTRATION MISTER RICHARD
TRUSSELL WILL BE PROVIDING A
SUMMARY OF OUR FOR PROPOSALS IN
ADDITION MYSELF OUR CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR LOUIS BRONCHI
AND OUR CHIEF OF DISASTER
MEDICAL SERVICES. BY CRAIG
JOHNSON WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS SO WITH THAT I'M
GONNA HAND THE FLOOR OVER TO
RICK TRUSSELL THANK YOU. I
THANK YOU DOCTOR DOKKEN AND
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. BUT
THE DEPARTMENT CURRENTLY HAS
FOR BUDGET PROPOSALS CONTAINED
IN THE MAY REVISION WHICH- IS
CURRENTLY UNDER CONSIDERATION
PROPOSAL NUMBER ONE. IS THE
INCREASE PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSE CAPABILITY- MS IS
REQUESTING EIGHT POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
FOURTEEN PERMANENT POSITIONS.
REDUCING THE ONE POINT SIX
MILLION OGOING BEGINNING IN
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. THESE
RESOURCES WILL MAINTAIN
CRITICAL EQUIPMENT AND MEDICAL
SUPPLIES ACQUIRED DURING THE
COLDER NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
PROVIDE LIFESAVING LIFESAVING
RESUSCITATIVE IN MEDICAL SEARCH
SEARCH SERVICES TO RELIEVE
SUFFERING FOR DISASTER VICTIMS
DURING PANDEMICS ANOTHER
CATASTROPHIC EMERGENCIES. SEVEN
OF THE REQUESTED POSITIONS
THREE POINT ONE MILLION FOR
WAREHOUSE SPACE IN TWO MILLION
FOR BIOMEDICAL MAINTENANCE ARE
FUNDED ON A THREE YEAR LIMITED
TERM BASIS. THESE LIMITED TERM
RESOURCES WILL PROVIDE MS A
SUFFICIENT TIME TO DETERMINE A
POST PANDEMIC STAFFING RESOURCE
NEEDS ARE SUFFICIENT TO MEET
INCREASED DISASTER MEDICAL
PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY OPERATIONS.
ADDITIONALLY FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING IS REQUESTED TO UPGRADE
MS AS DEPARTMENTAL OPERATIONS
CENTER INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
EMERGENCY RESPONSE CASH IS.
AVAILABLE WHICH CONTAIN MEDICAL
SUPPLIES AND EQUIPMENT FOR.
RESPONSE EFFORTS THE SPEED OF
MS ABILITY TO PROVIDE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL CARE TO DISASTER
VICTIMS CRITICAL IN ANY
DISASTER MAJOR EVENT WHILE MS A
CONTINUES TO STAND READY FOR
THREATS TO CALIFORNIA RECENT
PANDEMIC IN WILDFIRE RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES HAVES HAVE REVEALED
CRITICAL GAPS IN OUR RESPONSE
CAPABILITIES- MS IS REQUESTING
FUNDING AND RESOURCES TO FILL
THESE GAPS OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS THE TREND
DEMONSTRATES INCREASING NATURAL
AND MAN MADE DISASTERS AND I
NEED FRIENDS ARE TO
SIMULTANEOUSLY SUPPORT MULTIPLE
RESPONSE OPERATIONS. FOR
EXAMPLE AT ONE POINT DURING THE
CURRENT CULTURE NINETEEN
STATEWIDE WILDFIRE RESPONSES
AMSEL WAS SUPPORTING SEVENTEEN
DIFFERENT MISSIONS
SIMULTANEOUSLY THESE MEDICAL
MISSIONS INCLUDED FEDERAL
MEDICAL STATIONS ALTERNATE CARE
SITES LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES
WHICH INCLUDE- SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND ASSISTED LIVING
IN ADDITION AND THE CONTINUED
OPERATION SUPPORTING MULTIPLE
WAREHOUSES DEPARTMENTAL
OPERATIONS CENTER LOCAL
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER
LIAISON ROLES MEDICAL HEALTH
COORDINATION CENTER
RESPONSIBILITIES AND THE STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER AMSEL WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY UNDERSTAFFED AND
UNDER RESOURCE TO MEET THE
NEEDS AND RELIED ON OUTSIDE
SUPPORT TO SUSTAIN OPERATIONS
RESULTING IN NUMEROUS
SHORTFALLS IN CHALLENGES. THE
FOR EXAMPLE THE NUMBER OF MS A
STAFF TO SERVE IN LEADERSHIP AT
VARIOUS MEDICAL STATES WAS
LACKING IN EXPERIENCE MEDICAL
STAFF ASSIGNED TO FILL INCIDENT
COMMAND LEADERSHIP POSITIONS AT
ALTERNATE TREATMENT SITES.
NUMBER PERSONAL SUPPORT
RECEIVING PROCESSING STORAGE
AND DEPLOYMENT OF THE VAST
AMOUNT OF MEDICAL EQUIPMENT AND
SUPPLIES INCLUDING VENTILATORS
TO SUPPORT THE RESPONSE. THAT
LACKED THE NUMBER OF PERSONNEL
TO MANAGE MULTIPLE INTO
WAREHOUSES TO SUPPORT DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE. AND
AN INSUFFICIENT NUMBER PERSONAL
TO EFFECTIVELY RECRUIT ONBOARD
AND TRAIN THE THOUSANDS OF
CALUMET MEMBERS THAT WE BROUGHT
ON BOARD TO SUPPORT OUR
STATEWIDE MEDICAL NEEDS WHICH
INCLUDED ALTERNATE CARE SITES
LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES
HOSPITALS SURGICAL PROTESTING
IT CETERA- IN CONCLUSION THE
RESOURCES OUTLINED IN THIS
PROPOSAL REQUIP MS THAT TO
EFFECTIVELY MANAGE THE
INCREASED RESPONSIBILITIES AND
SUPPORT THE NECESSARY EXPANSION
TO PREPARE FOR AND RESPOND TO
FUTURE STATEWIDE DISASTERS THE
PROPOSAL SEEKS TO ADDRESS
SIGNIFICANT DEFICITS IN OUR
STATEWIDE MEDICAL HEALTH
RESPONSE CAPABILITY. AND AND
WE'RE GONNA BE BETTER PREPARED
TO MEET OUR NEW DEMANDS BY
PROVIDING ADEQUATE STAFFING
LEVELS BEING ABLE TO HIRE
PERSONNEL THAT WILL SYSTEM
RESPONSE OPERATIONS PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
LARGE SCALE RESPONSES TO
DISASTERS AND ALL CALIFORNIA
REGIONS ENSURING SMOOTH
RESPONSE TO EMERGING THREATS TO
CALIFORNIA'S CITIZENS SUCH AS
COVE IN NINETEEN HI ADDITIONAL
HIGHLY INFECTIOUS DISEASES
INFLUENZA PANDEMICS INDOOR
OUTSIDE THREATS- TO CALIFORNIA
ENHANCING CATASTROPHIC EVENT
PLANNING TRAINING EXERCISES AND
MEDICATION TO INCREASE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC HEALTH
MEDICAL PREPAREDNESS IN ADVANCE
A MAJOR DISASTERS. AND WE'RE
NOW OPEN TO ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT PROPOSAL
NUMBER. ONE THANK YOU SIR IF
YOU CAN RUN THROUGH ALL OF THE
PROPOSALS ALL FOUR OF THEM AND
THEN WE WILL MOVE ON TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOLLOWED
BY THE L. A. L. UNLESS THAT'S
THE CONCLUSION OF YOUR
TESTIMONY. I KNOW ALL STE I
WILL START WITH PROPOSAL NUMBER
TWO THANK YOU- THE PROPOSAL
NUMBER TWO MEDICAL SURGE
STAFFING PROGRAM THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY IS
REQUESTING SIX PERMANENT
POSITIONS ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION GENERAL FUND. AND-
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND ONE POINT THREE FIVE
MILLION ONGOING THE REQUESTED
RESOURCES WILL PROVIDE
INCREASED STAFFING OVERSIGHT
THE MEDICAL STAFFING SEARCH
PROGRAM CONSISTING OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CORE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSISTANCE
TEAMS AND THE DISASTER
HEALTHCARE VOLUNTEERS AND
MEDICAL RESERVE CORPS PROGRAMS.
THE FOCUS OF THESE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WILL BE ON STATEWIDE
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS ONBOARDING
PROGRAM MANAGEMENT EXERCISE AND
TRAINING AND DEPLOYMENT
MANAGEMENT OF THESE RESOURCES
BOTH PRIOR TO AND DURING
EMERGENCY RESPONSE ACTIVATIONS.
THE MOST RECENT COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC RESPONSE ACTIVITIES
HAVE ALSO REVEALED SERIOUS GAPS
IN OUR CURRENT PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSE. WITH THIS PROGRAM
INCLUDING THE FOLLOWING LACK OF
PERMANENT PERSONNEL WHICH
DIRECTLY AFFECTED AND HIS
ABILITY TO IMPLEMENT AND MANAGE
MEDICAL STAFFING SURGE
RESOURCES INABILITY TO
EFFECTIVELY MANAGE THE INCREASE
OF VOLUNTEERS UNDER CALUMET MRC
IN COUNTY THV PROGRAMS. REDUCE
SUPPORT TO THE COUNTY THV
ADMINISTRATORS OR MRC
COORDINATORS WE USED TO THE DHD
SYSTEM. AND THE COORDINATION OF
LOCAL VOLUNTEERS OR MAINTAIN
RECONCILE THE INCREASE OF ALLAH
TO REGISTRATION DATA AND THE
DHD SYSTEM DECREASED
INTEGRATION ENGAGEMENT OF
HEALTH CORPS MEMBERS AND
ADEQUATE RESOURCES TO COMPLETE
THE ETTING AND PROCESSING OF
THE INCREASED CAL MAP LOCATIONS
AND ONBOARDING FUNCTIONS. IN
ADEQUATE RESOURCES TO
EFFECTIVELY MANAGE THE
DEPLOYMENT OF THOUSANDS ACCOUNT
STAFF STATEWIDE. BLACK OF
COORDINATION AND TRACKING OF
OTHER EMERGENCY MEDICAL
PARTNERS INCLUDING CONTRACTED
MEDICAL STAFF DISASTER MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE TEAMS NATIONAL GUARD
STAFF IN CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS STAFF.
INSUFFICIENT STAFFING RESOURCES
TO AUTHORIZE AND MANAGE THE
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND OUT OF
STATE MEDICAL PERSONNEL WISHING
TO PROVIDES MEDICAL SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA DURING THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. LACK OF MS
OF PERSONNEL ALSO RESULTED IN
INADEQUATE RECRUITMENT EFFORTS-
INSUFFICIENT STAFFING SUPPORT
TO ON BOARD NEW CABINET MEMBERS
WHICH I THINK I MENTIONED
BEFORE. DURING THE CALL THE
NINETEEN RESPONSES BEEN A
SHORTAGE OF PERMANENT PERSONNEL
IMPLEMENT AND MANAGE THE
STAFFING PROGRAM AND ALSO
MASSACRES NUMBER OF CALUMET-
THE REQUESTED RESOURCES WILL
ADDRESS THIS GAP BY DIRECTLY
IMPLEMENTING AND MANAGING THE
NEW HEALTH CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE PROGRAM INCREASING
CALUMET AND MERCY DHD
VOLUNTEERS. NOW THE STATE
AUTHORIZATIONS TO INCLUDE
RECRUITMENT AND VETTING HIRING
IF APPLICABLE TRAINING
RETAINING DATA MANAGEMENT
RECONCILIATION DEPLOYMENT
COORDINATION AND VOLUNTEER
MANAGEMENT. CONDUCTING THE PLAN
JUST IN TIME TRAINING FOR THESE
VOTE FOR THESE RESOURCES TO
INCOMING MEDICAL PERSONNEL
ENSURING ONGOING PROGRAM
DEVELOPMENT INCLUDING POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES RESEARCHING AND
DEVELOPING METHODS TO
STREAMLINE DEPLOYMENT
PROCESSES. PLANNING AND
CONDUCTING TRAINING EXERCISES
FOR HEALTHCOR CAL MATT MRC DHT
IN OTHER MEDICAL PERSONAL
PARTNERS TO INSURE REYES OF
DEPLOYMENTS DURING DISASTERS
DIRECTLY SUPPORTING HEALTHCARE
PERSONAL PROCESSING DEPLOYMENT
AND VOLUNTEER MANAGEMENT DURING
EMERGENCY ACTIVATIONS.
SUPPORTING MEDICAL SEARCH
STAFFING PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT
AND MANAGEMENT OF THE
RECRUITMENT PROGRAM AND RECORD
KEEPING WITH THESE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES IN TERMS OF WILL BE
ABLE TO IMPROVE DISASTER
MEDICAL PREPAREDNESS AND
IMPLEMENT MANAGE RECRUIT.
VETERAN ON BOARD AND DEPLOY
THESE RESOURCES. THE PROPOSAL
THREE EXCUSE ME. HUMAN
RESOURCES WORKLOADS SUPPORT.
THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
REQUESTING. EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY
ONE THOUSAND GENERAL FUND AND
FIVE PERMANENT POSITIONS IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO REDUCING
THE FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND ONGOING
BEGINNING IN TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE. THESE REQUESTED RESOURCE
TO ADDRESS MISSION CRITICAL
WORKLOADS SO SHE WOULD INCREASE
HUMAN RESOURCE WORKLOAD MERCY
PREPAREDNESS PERSONAL SERVICES
AND TO ESTABLISH THE HUMAN
RESOURCES DIVISION WITHIN MS
ACT. THE REQUESTED RESOURCES
INCLUDE FIVE PERMANENT
POSITIONS WITH THREE OF THE
REQUESTED POSITIONS FUNDED ON A
THREE YEAR LIMITED TERM BASIS
OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS AMSEL
ANALYZE AND EVALUATE WHETHER
THESE HR STAFFING LEVELS IN THE
DISTRIBUTION OF STAFF OR
SUFFICIENT TO ADDRESS THE
INCREASED HR WORKLOAD AND
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS PERSONAL
HR ACTIVITIES. PROVIDING HR
SUPPORT FUNCTIONS IN ANY STATE
DEPARTMENT IS A HUGE
UNDERTAKING AN EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING WILLIAMS IS A SMALL
DEPARTMENT HR UNIT IS STILL
TASKED WITH PROVIDING THE SAME
STATE PROCESS PROGRAM AND LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS AS ANY OTHER STATE
AGENCY HR ANALYST ANOTHER
DEPARTMENTS MAY ONLY BE
RESPONSIBLE CLASSIFICATION PAY
EXAMINATIONS ARE TRAINING BUT
MS A SOLE HR- ANIMAL. IS
EXPECTED TO PROVIDE ALL OF THE
SERVICES IN ADDITION TO
PROVIDING SUPPORT AND SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTISE IN MANY OTHER
PROGRAM AREAS. THE PERSONAL
NEEDS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
INCREASED WITH PROGRAM
EXPANSIONS EXPANSIONS WHICH
INCLUDE NEW POSITIONS INCREASED
RESPONSIBILITIES POSITIONAL H.
R. STAFFING RESOURCES HAVE NOT
BEEN PROVIDED. A STARKLY MS AS
COMBINED ADMINISTRATIVE AND
HUMAN RESOURCE FUNCTIONS WITHIN
A SINGLE DIVISION ALL THIS
COMBINED RESPONSIBILITY MIGHT
BE MANAGEABLE FOR AN
ORGANIZATIONAL MORE STABLE AND
PREDICTABLE WORKLOADS. MS AS
UNIQUE IN THAT THE DEPARTMENT
MANAGES PROGRAMS ENCOMPASSING
ROUTINE ACTIVITIES WITH ANOTHER
DISASTER MEDICAL SERVICES WHOSE
DISASTER RESPONSE ACTIVITIES
MAY AT ANY TIME EXPAND RAPIDLY
WHICH CAN REQUIRE ENDS AT A
HIGHER LARGE NUMBERS OF
EMERGENCY STAFF. THIS CAN
RESULT IN OTHER DIVISIONS
PROGRAMS REDUCING OR SUSPENDING
ACTIVITIES. AND REDIRECTING
BOTH FRONT LINE AND MANAGEMENT
STAFF TO HR FUNCTIONS
CONCURRENT WITH THESE DRAMATIC
SHIFTS IN ANNE'S FOCUS. IS THE
NEED TO RECRUIT ONBOARD AND
MANAGE ADDITIONAL PERSONNEL IN
PREPARATION FOR FUTURE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE DEPLOYMENTS.
THE NUMBERS OF THESE EMERGENCY
HIRES IS UNPREDICTABLE BUT THE
TREND IN RECENT YEARS A SCENE
SHARP INCREASE DURING THE
PANDEMIC RESPONSE THE NUMBERS
HAVE BALLOONED EXPONENTIALLY.
UNDER THESE CIRCUMSTANCES MS
THAT MUST DELAY OR SIMPLY FORGO
CENTRAL HR FUNCTIONS. HAVING
INSUFFICIENT STAFFING RESOURCES
TO MEET AND AS HR NEEDS WILL
CONTINUE TO UNDERMINE STAFF
MORALE YOU CONTRIBUTE TO DELAYS
IN FULFILLING BOTH ROUTINE AND
DISASTER RELATED. DEPARTMENT
RESPONSIBILITIES. THE INCREASE
STAFF LEVELS ALLOW THE TO MEET
CRITICAL HR TO AND TIMELINES.
SPECIALLY MANDATED REQUIREMENTS
AND ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH FOR
YOU TO CREMINS IN THE CREATION
OF OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCIES
WITHIN THE HR DIVISION- THE
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS WILL ALLOW
THE HR DIVISION TO INCREASE
CUSTOMER SERVICE LEVELS TO
VARIOUS INTERNAL PROGRAMS WITH
MS- ELIMINATE DELAY IN RESPONSE
TIME TO EXECUTIVE STAFF
MANAGERS AND OTHER CONTROL
AGENCY REQUESTS. AND
REQUIREMENTS. PROPOSAL NUMBER
FOUR. IS THE CALIFORNIA EMS
DATA RESOURCE SYSTEM OR CEDARS
MS IS REQUESTING ONE TIME TEN
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO INTO POSITIONS
THIS REQUEST WILL GO TOWARDS
PROJECT PLANNING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES DATA RESOURCE SYSTEM
OR CEDARS UTILIZING THE STATE'S
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE
PROCESS AND TO CONNECT THE
REMAINING SEVENTEEN LOCAL EMS
AGENCIES TO AN EXISTING
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
NETWORK THE PROPOSED CEDARS IS
INTENDED TO CREATE A LINK.
RECENT DATA INTEROPERABLE IN
BETWEEN HOSPITAL'S EMS AGENCIES
AND OTHER HEALTHCARE
ORGANIZATIONS. INSURING
CONTINUITY OF CARE TO CURRENTLY
I'M COVERED AREAS OF THE STATE.
READING CONNECTIONS IN THESE
AREAS WILL ALSO ALLOW ACCESS TO
ONGOING FEDERAL FUNDING TO
MAINTAIN THESE NEW CONNECTIONS.
CURRENTLY ANSWER HAS TO DATA
SYSTEMS ARE NOT CAN CONNECTED
THAT COLLECT EMS DATA. THE
FIRST IS THE CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
INFORMATION SYSTEMS OR KIM SAYS
THE SECOND IS THE HIGH TENS
WHICH IS THE HEALTH INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY IN EMS SYSTEMS. I AM
SO PROPOSES CONNECTING THESE
TWO SYSTEMS TO ALLOW FOR BETTER
DATA QUALITY REAL TIME
REPORTING BY CREATING CEDARS
NOW LOCAL PLATFORM THAT WILL
INFORM AND IMPROVE THE
STATEWIDE AND LOCAL EMS
SYSTEMS. SEEDERS WILL BE
FURTHER USED TO PROVIDE A
CONNECTION TO C. H. HSA IS ALL
HAS OUR DASHBOARD BY CONNECTING
CEDARS TO THE DASHBOARD AND
WILL BE ABLE TO FEED REAL TIME
DATA. TO STATE DECISION MAKERS
DURING TIMES OF DISASTER HAVING
REAL TIME DATA ON PATIENT
COUNTS TYPES OF CALLS AND
LOCATIONS OF OUTBREAKS WILL
ALLOW THE STATE TO BETTER PLAN
RESPOND TO LEVELS OF DISASTER.
THE CHANCES SYSTEM COLLECTS
DATA RELATED TO THE PROVISION
OF EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
IN CALIFORNIA. INDIAN SHE'S IN
PRE HOSPITAL CARE REPORTING
SOFTWARE MANAGED BY THEIR
EMPLOYERS- EMS PROVIDER
AGENCIES IN TRAUMA CENTERS AS
REQUIRED BY TITLE TWENTY TO THE
CALIFORNIA CODE OF REGULATIONS.
IN MOST CASES THIS ENCOUNTER
LEVEL DATA IS TRANSFERRED BY
EMS PROVIDERS AND TRAUMA
CENTERS. TO ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
THIRTY THREE LOCAL EMS AGENCIES
WHICH ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
ADMINISTRATION OF UMASS. IN
ACCORDANCE WITH DIVISION TWO
POINT FIVE OF THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE. THE
DATA REFLECTS PATIENT TREATMENT
AND OUTCOMES THE M. S. TRAUMA
CASES BASED ON NATIONAL DATA
COLLECTION STANDARDS- WHILE
THIS DATA CAN BE USED TO PLAN
IMPROVE EMS TRAUMA BY LOCAL EMS
AGENCIES. IT DOES NOT PROVIDE
THE ABILITY TO COMPARE
BENCHMARK OR INTEGRATE WITH
LIKE PROVIDER AGENCIES OR THE
STATEWIDE SYSTEM FOR
PERFORMANCE IMPROVEMENT. IN
SHORT MS IT DOES NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO TIMELY STATEWIDE YOU
MUST PATIENT LEVEL DATA THAT
CAN BE USED TO PROACTIVELY
IMPROVE OUTCOMES. MS OUR
PROVIDES THE INLAND COUNTIES
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AGENCY WITH LOCAL ASSISTANCE
GRANT FUNDING TO COLLECT PRE
HOSPITAL TRAUMA DATA VIA
ISOMERS. CHANCES ARE FROM
THIRTY TWO OF THIRTY THREE
LENSES COVERING AN ESTIMATED
65% APPROXIMATELY SIX MILLION
EMS ENCOUNTERS PROVIDED IN
TWENTY TWENTY. SUBMISSION OF
DATA TO ISOMER FROM LOCAL EMS
AGENCIES IS DONE ON A LARGELY
VOLUNTEER BASIS. DOES NOT ALL
AND NOT ALWAYS IN REAL TIME.
WELL 65% UNKNOWN EMS ENCOUNTERS
ARE RECORDED AT ISOLA THE
QUALITY CONSISTENCY AND
RELIABILITY OF THAT DATA IT'S
NOT ALLOWED TO BE USED TO
INFORM SIGNIFICANT POLICY
MAKING. INSTEAD ARE. HI OR THE
HEALTH INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
MERCY MEDICAL SERVICES- IN
TODAY'S EMS US BECAUSE WE IN
TODAY'S EMS SYSTEM AMBULANCE
AND PARAMEDICS SERVICES HAVE NO
MEANS FOR PROVIDING ELECTRONIC
HERE DATED TO THE HOSPITAL'S
WE'RE RECEIVING THEIR PATIENTS
SAM NO INSIGHT INTO HOW THEIR
CARE MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE
AFFECTED ULTIMATE OUTCOMES
COMMUNICATIONS NECESSARY TO
TRANSPORTATION INFORMATION
RECEIVED TREATMENT HOURS
BETWEEN EMS PROVIDERS AND
HOSPITAL IS DONE VERBALLY TO
RADIO OR CELL PHONE. OFTEN
PAPER BASED PRE HOSPITAL CARE
RECORDS ARE LEFT AT THE
HOSPITAL AT THE CONCLUSION OF
THE TRANSPORT- ON JULY TWENTY
SIX TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE
OFF THE NATIONAL COORDINATOR
HEALTH INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY.
AWARDED MS- TWO YEAR GRANT TO
ADVANCE HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGE STATEWIDE DURING A
DISASTER AND REGIONALLY. AND
DALY MS ON A LIMITED PILOT
BASIS PILOT COUNTIES INCLUDING
SAN DIEGO ORANGE MATERIAL
SAMPOERNA DINO. FUNDING WAS
USED TO DEMONSTRATE TO HEALTH
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY USE
CASES. DURING THE TWO YEAR
GRANT CYCLE WHICH ENDED ON JULY
TWENTY SIXTH TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN- TOOLS ARE VITAL TO
IMPROVE PATIENT CARE DURING
EMERGENCIES AND DISASTERS. THE
FIRST USE CASE NAME PLUS YOU
KNOW MASS CREATED LOCAL IS PART
OF THE GRANT WAS DESIGNED FOR
DAY TO DAY IN US OPERATIONS IN
CONNECTED EMS PROVIDERS WITH
HOSPITALS TO SECURELY EXCHANGE
ELECTRONIC PATIENT HEALTH
INFORMATION. THE PLUS YOU MUST
USE CASE FOCUSED ON THE BI
DIRECTIONAL EXCHANGE OF
CLINICALLY RELEVANT PATIENT
INFORMATION WITH THE USE OF
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORDS BY
EMS PERSONNEL. THE TRANSMITTAL
PATIENT DATA IMPROVES A
TRANSITION OF KERR FROM THE PRE
HOSPITAL SETTING TO THE
HOSPITAL AMSEL WAS ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT H. I. YUNEEC THE MS
AND FOR CALIFORNIA COUNTIES. TO
ALLOW PARAMEDICS TO SEARCH FOR
PATIENT INFORMATION LEARN THE
HOSPITAL'S INCOMING PATIENTS
AND FATHER RECORD IN THE
HOSPITAL'S EHR AND CHAIN
OUTCOME INFORMATION. WHICH WAS
NOT PREVIOUSLY AVAILABLE. IN
THE SECOND CASE MS OF THE- OF
FIRST LOOKED TO HELP. TOOL TO
BE USED DURING EMERGENCIES AND
NATURAL DISASTERS IN THIS USE
CASE HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS
WORKING FASTER CAN SEARCH AND
RETRIEVE. PATIENT HEALTH
HISTORY ALLOWING THEM TO
IMPROVE CLINICAL DECISION
MAKING. CURRENTLY ONLY SIXTEEN
OF THE THIRTY THREE LENSES ARE
COVERED BY A CHINESE NEMS
SYSTEMS. THIS LEAVES SEVENTEEN
LIVES IN OUR POPULATIONS BEHIND
WITH REGARD TO QUICK ACCESS TO
PATIENT INFORMATION DURING
EMERGENCIES AND DISASTERS. MANY
OF THE UN COVERED LENSES ARE
ROLE OR HAVE LARGE UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS. AND THE SIX TO
CLOSE THIS GAP IN HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE. WITH THIS
FUNDING MS- ROLE WILL
REINVIGORATE THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM BY ASSISTING
LOCAL ENTITIES. TO CREATE DATA
PIPELINES THAT ALLOW FOR REAL
TIME HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGE HUB THAT ALLOWS LOCAL
EMS AGENCIES TO REVIEW AND
ANALYZE IT HE MUST DATA. AND
TECHNOLOGY TOOLS THAT CONTINUE
THE SKEWS ME THAT CAN
CONTRIBUTE TO A SINGLE SOURCE
INFORMATION TO IMPROVE CARE
DURING DISASTERS. THIS REQUIRES
CHANGES TO EXISTING AND
SYSTEMS. AND THEIR INTEGRATION.
INTO A- HUB. AND THAT IS THE
END OF THE TESTIMONY AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU SIR NEXT WE WILL
HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. BUT THE PROBLEM THE
FINANCE THAT WE HAVE NOTHING
FURTHER TO ADD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
SONYA PADDOCK WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU DR EMERSON YOU PICK
FROM THE L. A. WE ARE STILL IN
THE PROCESS OF REVIEWING THAT
THE DETAILED BUDGET PROPOSALS
FROM AND SO- THAT THAT JUST
CAME OUT YESTERDAY AT THIS
POINT WE DON'T- HAVE ANY SEEK
TO HAVE ANY MAJOR CONCERNS OR
SEE ANY BIG RED FLAGS BUT OF
COURSE WE'D REACH OUT TO YOU.
TO THE- BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
STAFF- IF THAT CHANGES AT ALL
AS WE CONTINUE TO REVIEW THE
PROPOSALS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WITH THAT I WILL
BRING IT UP TO THE DíAS FOR
ANY NUMBER OF QUESTIONS. DOCTOR
WHAT. YOUR QUESTION FOR MS- I-
WAS OBVIOUSLY LISTENING TO YOUR
PRESENTATION AT THE VERY END
YOU TALKED ABOUT. DATA TRANSFER
FROM PROVIDERS AND DURING
DURING EMERGENCIES SO- HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE WHICH GOT
GOT MY GOT MY ATTENTION- I'M
CURIOUS- YOU MENTIONED THAT
THAT THERE'S THERE THERE
CHALLENGES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AREAS- IN
AREAS WHERE THERE ISN'T RURAL
WHERE YOU HAVE LARGE
POPULATIONS DO YOU STILL HAVE
THOSE CHALLENGES- COMMUNICATING
ACROSS PROVIDERS AND FOR
EXAMPLE ARE YOU ARE THERE
CERTAIN PROVIDERS THAT ARE.
THAT YOU HAVE CHALLENGES WITH
OR DO YOU FOR ARE YOU FINDING
THE SYSTEMS TO BE WORKING WELL-
I'M GATHERING. THE ANSWER MAY
NOT BE COMPLETELY WELL BECAUSE
YOU'RE ACTUALLY CALLING FOR A
STATE WIDE HUB WHICH IS
INTERESTING BECAUSE THAT'S
SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
AS WELL SO I'M I'M CURIOUS. TO
HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT YOUR
EXPERIENCE IS- IN THE FIELDS
HOW YOU HOW YOU COMMUNICATE
ACROSS ALL PROVIDERS AND- JUST
JUST A LITTLE MORE INFORMATION.
HE DOCTOR WOULD DAVE DUNCAN
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
QUESTION AND- YOU CAUGHT MY
ATTENTION EARLIER- WITH YOUR
COMMENT ABOUT THE NEED FOR REAL
TIME HEALTHCARE DATA TO MAKE
REAL HEALTHCARE DECISIONS AND
YOU MADE THE POINT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THAT. THAT POINT WAS
SO STRONGLY MADE THROUGHOUT THE
LAST YEAR AND A HALF WITH
CODED- YOU KNOW REACHING OUT
FOR. MULTIPLE DATA POINTS ON A
DAILY BASIS LOOKING FOR THEM ON
AN HOURLY BASIS- MAYBE
OBTAINING THEM ON A TWENTY FOUR
HOUR BASIS BUT HAVING TO MAKE
REAL DECISIONS BASED ON. DATA
THAT- YOU KNOW JUST
UNFORTUNATELY- ISN'T THERE IT
WILL IT'S THERE IT'S JUST NOT
THERE AS TIMELY AS WE LIKE TO
HAVE IT. SO THAT'S SAID THIS IS
THE FIRST IN A NUMBER OF STEPS
TO START. MOVING OUR WAY
TOWARDS REAL TIME. UNIFIED DATA
WHERE WE HAVE AND AGAIN IN YOUR
WORDS SILOS TALKING TO EACH
OTHER SO WE HAVE PMS DATA WE
HAVE IT FROM RURAL WE HAVE IT
FROM BOURBON- WE JUST DON'T
HAVE IT IS TIMELY AS WE BLANK-
AND WE DON'T HAVE IT.
EVERYWHERE UNIFIED WITH
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS SO- THAT SAID
YOU KNOW IN IN ANSWERED YOUR
QUESTION- THE H. I EAT PEAS
I'VE I MEAN IN GENERAL TERMS
WORK WE'RE ABOUT HALFWAY THERE
WE LIKE TO GET ALL THE WAY
THERE- TO UNIFY THE EMS. DATA
WITH THE HOSPITAL DATA.
BUILDING THE SYSTEM AND
PLANNING AS WE'VE OUTLINED IN
OUR PROPOSAL NUMBER FOUR. WILL
CREATE THE PATHWAY TOWARDS REAL
TIME ACCESS TO THIS DATA. AND-
IT'LL ALL GIVE US WHAT I LIKE
TO CALL SORT OF THE VITAL SIGNS
WE NEED TO ASSESS. THE AND
MEDIA IT'S- A PERSPECTIVE OF
OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS. I MAY
BE AROUND THE BUSH A BIT THERE
ARE UP BUT THESE ARE THESE ARE
INITIAL STEPS THE BILL THAT IN
THE HIV ALLOWS US TO CONTINUE
ON A PATH. TOWARDS BETTER DATA
INTEGRATION AND THEN THE
PLANNING WILL PAVE THE WAY
TOWARDS- BETTER ACCESS
CURRENTLY A REGULATION AND-
PROVIDES AMSA WITH QUARTERLY
DATA. FROM ALL OF OUR EMS
SYSTEMS IN ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES ALL THIRTY THREE
LAUNCHERS AND WE'D LIKE TO
IMPROVE THEM. THANK YOU.
SHIPPED UP. THANK YOU WITHOUT
I'D LIKE TO THANK VERY MUCH
PANEL NUMBER FOUR WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON THE PANEL NUMBER FIVE
ON THE OFFICE OF STATEWIDE
HEALTH PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT
MAY REVISE UPDATES WE WILL HAVE
FOUR PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL
WE WILL BEGIN WITH DIRECTOR
LANCE BURKE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND
I'M PLEASED TO TURN IT OVER TO
KAREN RISE L. AUSTIN ITS WORK
FORCE DEPUTY DIRECTOR TO
PRESENT OUR TWO ITEMS TODAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON- THURSDAY'S
ISSUE EIGHT GERIATRIC CARE
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS. THIS IS A
REQUEST FOR FIVE MILLION ONE
TIME INCREASED AVAILABLE OVER
SIX YEARS TO PROVIDING
AUGMENTATION TO THE THREE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND.
POSTED THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
FOR GERIATRIC WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS. THE TOTAL AWARD
SPENDING REQUESTED ACROSS THIS
AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL WILL UTILIZE EXISTING
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS ADDING
ADDITIONAL CAREER EXPLORATION
PIPELINE SCHOLARSHIP AND LOAN
REPAYMENT AWARDS TO EXISTING
PROGRAMS TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF GERIATRIC CARE PROVIDERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. USING
EXISTING PROGRAMS WILL ENABLE
ASHFORD TO LEVERAGE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO INCREASE-
WARMS TO YOUR INTELLIGENCE AND
OTHER GERIATRIC CARE PROVIDERS
MORE QUICKLY THAN DEVELOPING A
NEW PROGRAM. CONSISTENT WITH
OTHER OUR STATE PROGRAMS
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGES REQUESTED
TO AUTHORIZE LOCAL ASSISTANCE
FUNDING TO BE AVAILABLE FOR
ENCUMBRANCE OR EXPENDITURE FOR
SIX YEARS TO PROVIDE A WAR TO
SAVE RECIPIENTS WITH A
REASONABLE TIME FRAME TO MEET.
AWARD REQUIREMENTS. I DON'T GO
ON TO NEXT TO ENSURE NIGHT.
ISSUE NINE AS AN AUGMENTATION
OF THE SOUND OVER HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE PROGRAM. THIS REQUEST
IS AN INCREASE OF FIFTY MILLION
ONE TIME AVAILABLE OVER SIX
YEARS FOR ADDITIONAL WARDS TO
FIND NEW PRIMARY CARE RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS THROUGH THE SONG BROWN
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE TRAINING
PROGRAM. THE FUNDING AND
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE REQUESTED
WOULD ALLOW FOR ADDITIONAL
BOARDS TO PROSECUTORS IN
CLINICS. TO SUPPORT NEW PRIMARY
CARE RESIDENCY TRAINING
PROGRAMS IN UNDERSERVED AREAS.
CONSISTENT WITH THE CURRENT
SONG BROWN FUNDING STANDING
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE WHAT
AUTHORIZES LOCAL ASSISTANCE
FUNDING COULD BE AVAILABLE FOR
A CONFERENCE OR EXPENDITURE FOR
SIX YEARS TO JUNE THIRTIETH.
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN. IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT THIS FUNDING
COULD SUPPORT UP TO TEN YOUR
PRIMARY CARE RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
ANNUALLY BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. I WAS
BILLS ARE NEW TO GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION CAN ALSO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF A HIGHER CAP ON
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT TO
LEVERAGE FEDERAL DOLLARS. IN
EXPANSION OF THE PRIMARY CARE
WORKFORCE IN CALIFORNIA. THAT
CONCLUDES MY PRESENTATION AND
WE ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU NEXT WILL
HOPE TO HEAR FROM COREY HOW
SHE'D- WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. THANK YOU DR
AMBULATORY ISSUED WITH THE L.
A. WE'RE STILL IN THE PROCESS
OF REVIEWING. THE TO ISSUE BCPS
THAT WERE DISCUSSED STAYING ON
WE DON'T HAVE ANY SORT OF MAJOR
CONCERNS YOU RAISE AT THIS TIME
BUT OF COURSE WILL FOLLOW UP
WITH- ANYTHING SEEMS AMISS STE.
THANK YOU WITHOUT A WILL BRING
IT UP TO THE DíAS FOR ANY
MEMBER QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE
I'LL BRING IT TO THE CHAIR
RIGHT I'D- LIKE TO ASK MISS
RESULT IF WE CAN. A GAP
ANALYSIS OR AN UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW WE CAME TO. FIFTY MILLION
AS THE CORRECT AMOUNT FOR SONG
BROWN. AND THEN SPECIFICALLY I
WAS HOPING YOU COULD COMMENT ON
THE ONE TIME NATURE OF THESE
FUNDS AS THESE RESIDENCY SLOTS
IF INITIATED. WILL REQUIRE ON
GOING FUNDING WAS HOPING YOU
COULD MAKE SOME COMMENTS. I'M
CERTAIN I CAN START- SO
RECOGNIZING THAT THESE ARE ONE
TIME FUNDS THAT WILL HELP US TO
REALLY ESTABLISH NEW PROGRAMS-
AND THEN TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPLEMENT THAT LONG TERM WITH
THE ON GOING SONG BROWN FUNDING
THAT WE HAVE TO SUPPORT. AND
SUSTAIN- EXISTING PROGRAMS SO
THIS AND INTENDED TO ALLOW US
TO ESTABLISH NEW PROGRAMS. AND
THEN BE ABLE TO SUPPORT SUSTAIN
LONG TERM WITH THE ONGOING
FUNDING. THE OTHER PIECE THAT I
WOULD ADD MISTER CHAIR IS THAT
WE HOPE TO THE WEEKEND WITH
THESE WE WITH THESE ONE TIME
FUNDS HEALTH PROGRAMS ESTABLISH
AND HELP THEM SECURE FEDERAL
FUNDING SO THAT THEY CAN.
OPERATE ON AN ONGOING BASIS. WE
FROM I'M HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP
OFFLINE BUT THE SECOND PART OF
THE QUESTION IS REALLY A GAP
ANALYSIS TO UNDERSTAND. HOW
MANY MEDICAL STUDENTS ARE
CURRENTLY LEAVING OUR STATE TO
ENTER INTO RESIDENCY PROGRAMS.
AND WHETHER OR NOT THIS
ALLOCATION WILL BE SUFFICIENT
TO. MEET THAT GAP AND SO HAPPY
TO FOLLOW UP WITH MORE
INFORMATION BUT THAT'S THE
NATURE OF WHAT THE QUESTION IS.
WHERE WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR STAFF WE
THINK THERE IS GREAT NEED AND
THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
INVESTMENT TOWARD THAT NEED. I
AGREE AND WOULD LIKE TO VERY
MUCH THANK THIS PANEL AS WE
MOVE NOW ON TWO PANELS SIX.
WHICH IS ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES WHO WILL
BE PRESENTING ISSUES TEN
THROUGH TWENY SIX. WE HAVE
THIRTEEN PRESENTERS ON THIS
PANEL BEGINNING WITH A DIRECTOR
LIKE BORN IN J. C. COOPER.
FOLLOWED BY LINDY HERRINGTON
AND RENEE MAILLOT KELLY FIVE
FOR. THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE CAN WE PLEASE BEGIN WITH
DIRECTOR LAKEPORT. THANK YOU
DOCTOR RANDALL ALL THE DH CS
ITEMS IN THE MAY REVISION COVER
A WIDE AREA. HOPEFULLY
COMMITTEE WILL BEAR WITH US AS
MISS COOPER AND I. WALK THROUGH
THE HIGHLIGHTS CLICK ON THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE QUESTIONS ON
THE AGENDA AND TORTURE ACTUALLY
A FEW OF THE NON PRESENTATION
ITEMS. ROUND OUT OUR PROGRAM
STRATEGY IN THE COMING YEAR
WORKS- GOOD CS MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL. OF A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE SUPPORT OF DHC
HAS PROGRAMS AND SERVICES. ONE
POINT TWO BILLION FONG STATE
OPERATIONS. THIS INCLUDES
ADDITIONAL PROPOSED EXPENDITURE
OF- OF EXTRA TRUCK ALREADY UP
NINE POINT FIVE NO DOLLAR POOL.
WORKING NUMBER IS JOURNAL FUND.
AND IT SUPPORTS A HUNDRED THREE
POSSESS. SO EIGHT. ON THE- TO
TWENTY FIVE LIMITED TERMS. ALL
WALDRON TWENTY EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS OF OUR BUDGET. ALL
PROPOSAL LOCAL ASSIST OVER THE
D. CS PROGRAM COST. I YOU KNOW
WE ARE THE PUBLIC HEALTH OF
WILL COME TO THE OF THIS. AND
THEIR POLITICAL. OF CONTINUOUS
ENROLLMENT PLUS NUMERAL IS
ESTIMATED TO INCREASE THE TOTAL
PROGRAM TO APPROXIMATELY
FOURTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
PEOPLE. IN BUDGET YEAR.
ADDITIONALLY IN JULY WE WILL
BEGIN ACCELERATED AND ROLLING
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA TERMS
FOR ADULTS AGED. NINETEEN TO
CHILDREN. AVERAGE WILL BEGIN AT
APPLICATION WELL IN COMMON
OTHER VERIFICATION IS BEING
PROCESSED THIS WILL HELP MAKE
THE PROGRAM MORE ACCESSIBLE
NUMBER BUDGET INCLUDES COSTS
OF. FOURTEEN POINT THREE
MILLION TOTAL FONG SEVEN POINT
TWO MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR
THE SIDE. AFTER DECEMBER BASED
ON CURRENT FEDERAL GUIDANCE WE
WILL BEGIN REDETERMINATION
SPUTTERED BEEN SUSPENDED AS
PART OF THE HEALTH EMERGENCY-
COUNTY WELFARE DEPARTMENTS WILL
THEREFORE HAVE TO BE CATCHING
UP. ON THREE TO FOUR MILLION
DEFERRED CASES IN ADDITION TO
THEIR REGULAR CYCLES. AND TAKE
AGREED TO TERMINATIONS AND SO
AFTER CONSULTATION WITH C. W.
K. WE HAVE BUDGET AT SEVENTY
THREE MILLION. FOR THE
INCREASED WORKLOAD GOT POP
ABOUT HIS GENERAL FUND AND
HAPPENS THAT'LL- THERE ARE TWO
FOR COVERAGE CHANGE I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT. ALL THE FIRST
EXPANSION OF POSTPARTUM
COVERAGE FROM.
SIXTY DAYS TO
TWELVE MONTHS. THIS IS NOT.
BIRTH REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. THIS WILL BE EFFECTIVE
APRIL ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO. IT
IT INCLUDES NINETY POINT FIVE
MILLION WHICH ONE FIVE POINT
THREE MILLION GENERAL FUND BUT
THE ADDITIONAL BENEFITS. THE
IS THE EXTENSION OF FULL SCOPE
MEDICAL COVERAGE TO
UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS SIXTY AND
OLDER. WE ANTICIPATE
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND PEOPLE COMING FROM
EITHER RESTRICTED SCOPE
COVERAGE FOR PEOPLE WHO WORK.
ON A WORLD CAR. ARE IMPLEMENTED
TARGET IS MAY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BUT THIS IS
CONTINGENT ON SUCCESSFUL
AUTOMATION SYSTEM READY. AS YOU
KNOW THE STATE WIDE ORDER
NEEDED WELFARE SYSTEM IS IN THE
PROCESS OF MIGRATING FROM THREE
TO ONE SYSTEM. RESOURCES TO ONE
SYSTEM AND THIS NECESSITATES
CALIBRATING PROGRAM CHANGES
WITH THE CULT OVER WINDOWS
NORMALLY WE WAIT TO THE BULK
DETAIL PROGRAM INSTRUCTIONS
UNTIL FINAL BUDGET ADOPTION BUT
IN THIS CASE WE CONSIDER IT SO
IMPORTANT WE ARE MOVING AHEAD
EVEN AS WE SPEAK THE GRAPH OF
THE STORY REGULATORY CHANGES TO
GET THE INSTRUCTIONS BY THE
AUTOMATION SYSTEMS. AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE RESPECTABILITY TARGET
FOR BUDGET YEAR WE ARE
ESTIMATING SIXTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLAR TOTAL QUALMS FIFTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND AFTER
OFFSETTING COSTS COST SAVINGS
OR CURRENT. LIMITED SCOPE
MEDICAL BENEFITS. NEEDLESS TO
SAY WORLD VERY TO PRO OF EXTRA
HELD HER COPE TO POPULAR. AND
ALONG WITH OF ALL UP TO AGE
TWENTY SIX AND FEELS LIKE REAL
PROGRESS TO THE ULTIMATE GOAL
OF UNIVERSAL CALL. EVEN AGENDA
DOESN'T CHOIR ABOUT DIFFERENCES
IN COST ESTIMATES BETWEEN DH CS
IN THE L. A. O. AND I WOULD
JUST OBSERVE THAT AMONG THE
FACTORS THAT PLAY. IS THE
DIFFERENCE IN THE AGE BANDS
THAT IS THE L. O. L. A. ALWAYS
LOOKING AT PEOPLE SIXTY FIVE
OP. WELL THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSAL SIXTY BOOKS HOWEVER WE
WILL TAKE THIS BACK FOR REVIEW
WITH THE CHANGED COHORT- AND
RECONCILE NUMBERS. WELL SHOULD
NOTE THAT THE- INCREASED
ALREADY H. S. S. CALLS
RESULTING FROM THE EXPANSION.
IS NOT BEING SCORED IN TO
BUDGET YOUR PLUS ONE AND THAT
OF COURSE WILL BE IN THE DSS
BUDGET. IN OTHER AREAS WE ARE
REFLECTING COSTS A BUDGET YEAR
WE'RE CONTINUING ENHANCED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES WITH
A FOSTER YOUTH WHO RETURNED
FROM OUT OF STATE PLACEMENTS. I
WANT TO COMMEND MY COLLEAGUES
WITH DSS RECALL PUSHING THIS
NEXT STAGE. IN OUR FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM REFORM. FINALLY FOR MY
PART AS NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA
OUR BUDGET PROPOSAL ELIMINATES
DENTAL MANAGED CARE SACRAMENTO
LOS ANGELES AFFECTED DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST. THE TREND SEEN IN
PRIOR YEARS OF LOWER
UTILIZATION HOMES IN THIS MODE
DESPITE HIGHER COST WAS
CONTINUED IN TWENTY TWENTY THE
PANDEMIC EUROPE IN WHICH PEOPLE
SERVICE DENTAL CARE SOUL OF
THREE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FOUR PROXIMITY VISITS
PER HUNDRED THOUSAND
BENEFICIARIES. VERSUS JUST TWO
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO OR BENEFIT. FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND GONNA
FISHERIES MANAGED CARE. GOING
FORWARD WE WILL HAVE AN
ENTIRELY FOR SERVICE
ENVIRONMENT ALLOWING DHS TO
IMPLEMENT MORE EFFECTIVE AND
UNIFORM PROVIDER PLAN BENEFITS
RESULT REACHING STATEWIDE BASIS.
THE BUDGET INCLUDES NET SAVINGS
OF TWENTY MILLION HELLO EIGHT
MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR THIS
CHANGE. WHAT THAT WILL PASS
ALONG THE SCOOP BURKE AND WE
WILL BOTH BE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS FOLLOWING
HER PRESENTATION. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR MISS COOPER. AT AND
I'LL GO THROUGH THE REMAINDER
OF THE DEPARTMENTS- BUDGET
PROPOSALS- SO AS MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY ARE IN THE MEETING
TODAY THERE IS SOME SIGNIFICANT
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS ON THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUUM
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM SO IN
ADDITION TO THE SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION PROPOSED TO
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ON THERE
NOW IS A TOTAL OF TWO POINT
FOUR FIVE FIVE BILLION A TOTAL
FUNDS OR THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CONTINUUM INFRASTRUCTURE THE
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE MILLION
DEDICATED TO CHILDREN AND YOUTH
MITCHELL PREVIOUSLY TODAY AS
WELL AS- AN ADDITIONAL TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS WHO ARE DEEMED
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL AND
THEN LASTLY ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS TO ADD TO THE
ADDITIONAL CONTINUING
INFRASTRUCTURE DOLLARS TO FUNDS
OR THE ABILITY FOR US TO
CONSTRUCT ACQUIRE A REBEL
REHABILITATE A REAL ESTATE
ASSETS TO EXPAND THE CONTINUE
OF BEHAVIOR HEALTH. SERVICES
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ADDITION OF THE DEPARTMENT IS
PROPOSING A TO ADD A DO LET
BENEFITS TO MEDICARE ALL THE
BUDGET INCLUDES FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWO THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR DOLLARS TOTAL
FUNDS. IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO FOR THE DO A
BENEFIT TO IMPLEMENT JANUARY
ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THE
ACS PROPOSES TO ADD THE DEALER
BENEFIT AS A PREVENTATIVE OF
BENEFIT IN MEDIC CAL. THE
SERVICES INCLUDE PERSONAL
SUPPORT TO PREGNANT INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES THROUGHOUT
PREGNANCY LABOR AND POSTPARTUM
PERIOD. REACHER STRONGLY
SUGGEST THE DO THE BENEFIT CAN
RESULT OFF I'M SETTING SAVINGS
DUE TO AVOIDANCE OF PRETERM
BIRTHS. AND CESAREAN DELIVERIES
THE MAIN REVISED DOES NOT
ASSUME COST SAVINGS HOWEVER
SUCH A SAVINGS- COULD ACCRUE AS
REDUCTIONS IN THE BASE
EXPENDITURES. AS WE MATERIALIZE
OVER TIME. ADDITIONALLY I'M CAL
IS. ON TO OUR COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS AS A BENEFIT THE BUDGET
INCLUDES COST OF SIXTEEN POINT
THREE MILLION TOTAL FUND- IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO YOU. WITH THAT GROWING AND
EXPANDING OVER MANY YEARS AND
WE HAVE A MULTI YEAR WE CAN
SHARE WITH THOSE WHO ARE
INTERESTED. I'M IT IS PROPOSED
TO BEGIN JANUARY ONE OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. ADDITIONALLY ARE
REALLY JUST LOOKING FORWARD TO
ENGAGING WITH PEOPLE IN REGARDS
TO THE ROLE OF THE COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKER- BENEFIT IN
MEDICARE. FOR A LONG TIME WE
HAVE PROVIDED THESE SERVICES
THROUGH VARIOUS PILOTS OR
PLANES HAVE PROVIDED AND PAID
FOR COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS
SERVICES HOWEVER MAKING IT A
MEDIC HEALTH BENEFIT. PLANS
WILL BE REQUIRED TO HAVE A FULL
NETWORK OF COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS REALLY HELPING TO
BROKER THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
PROVIDERS AND FAMILIES TO GO IN
AND PROVIDE NOT ONLY. AN
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES FOR
FAMILIES BUT REALLY TO BROKER
RELATIONSHIPS. AND BREAK DOWN
SOME OF THE CULTURAL AND OR
LANGUAGE BURIAL SIT IN OFTEN
EXIST FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS BY
HELPING THEM NAVIGATE THE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEIR
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER ASSIST THEM
IN ACCESSING HEALTHCARE
SERVICES. AS WELL AS PROVIDER
HEALTH EDUCATION MINNESOTA
PORTENT OF. FOR THEM TO IMPROVE
THEIR HEALTH OUTCOMES. THERE
ARE SEVENTY AND- WITHIN CALLIN
IN THE PROPOSAL UNKNOWNS
NOTABLE THE MEDICARE POPULATION
HEALTH MANAGEMENT SERVICE SO
THE BUDGET DOES INCLUDE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION TOTAL FUND.
THREE HUNDRED MILLION GENERAL
FUND FOR LOCAL LISTINGS FUNDING
IN FIFTEEN MILLION TOTAL FUNDS
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL
FUND FOR STATE OPERATIONS. THE
DEPARTMENT HAS PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE AS WELL- WITH
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL- WE
ARE LOOKING TO PROCURE A
BUSINESS SOLUTION THAT WOULD
UTILIZE BOTH ADMINISTRATIVE AND
CLINICAL DATA. AND INFORM THE
DEPARTMENT. OF MANAGED CARE
PLANS COUNTIES PROVIDERS
BENEFICIARIES AND OTHER
DEPARTMENT PARTNERS- IN THE USE
OF SUPPORTING THE DELIVERY
SYSTEM FOR MEDIC CAL DELIVERY
ARE BENEFICIARIES. WERE REALLY
WANTING TO USE THIS POPULATION
HEALTH MANAGEMENT- SERVICE YOU.
POLL DATA ACROSS ALL OF THE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS OF MEDIC
TO ALLOW IT TO BE A VERY
HOLISTIC APPROACH FOR
DELIVERING MEDICAL SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS WOULD INCLUDE
MANY OF THE KEY COMPONENTS OF
OUR LARGER CALLIN POPULATION
HEALTH MANAGEMENT STRATEGY
INCLUDING THE STANDARDIZED
STATEWIDE RISK ASSESSMENT- AS
WELL AS THE STRATIFICATION AND
RISK TEARING. THAT WOULD BE
DONE IN CALLING WOULD BE
AVAILABLE THROUGH THIS
PLATFORM. ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD
BE LOOKING AT IDENTIFYING GAP
CLOSURE WITHIN THIS PLATFORM SO
ENSURING THAT BENEFICIARIES FOR
EXAMPLE KNOW WHETHER THEY'RE
PREVENTIVE SERVICES THEY HAVE
RECEIVED OR HAVE NOT RECEIVED.
WE WOULD BE LOOKING AT DISEASE
MANAGEMENT CLOSING CLINICAL-
GAPS AND MAKING SURE THAT NOT
ONLY PROVIDERS AND
BENEFICIARIES ARE WHERE THOSE
SERVICES BUT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES BUT ALSO
BE ABLE TO USE THAT AS AN
ANALYTICAL BACKLOG- ANALYTICAL.
BACKBONE I SHOULD SAY NOT
BACKLOG. OF UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT SERVICES ARE NEEDED FOR
BENEFICIARIES TO IMPROVE OUR
DELIVERY SYSTEM TRANSFORMATION.
WE ALSO WOULD BE USING THIS TO
IDENTIFIED GAPS IN BENEFITS
YOUR REFERRALS FOR EXAMPLE IF
WE HAVE A PREGNANT WOMAN WHO IS
NOT ON BREAK. SO PULLING IN NOT
ONLY BE A JUST YESTERDAY BUT
DATA BUT SO DATA TO REALLY
INFORM AND DRY FROM. APART SHE
AND- AS WELL AS EIGHT REALLY
IMPORTANT TOOL FOR CASE
MANAGERS AND CARE COORDINATION
GIVEN THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
MEDICARE SYSTEM. SO WOULD BE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY. FOR THE CASE
MANAGER WHERE THOSE GAPS MAY
EXIST TO MAKE SURE THOSE
REFERRALS ARE HAPPENING AND TO
CLOSE THE LOOP FOR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES. WE ALSO WANT TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE INCLUDING
MEDICARE DATA INTO THE PLATFORM
ONE OF THE CRITICAL PIECES
AROUND OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH CMS
IN GETTING MEDICARE DATA. IT
WOULD BE INCLUDED IN THIS
PLATFORM CARD TO A
BENEFICIARIES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE NOT ONLY
MEETING FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS OF
SHARING THAT DATA BUT ALSO TO
ENSURE THAT OUR INDIVIDUALS ARE
DO NDIVIDUALS ARE GETTING
BETTER COORDINATED CARE. ANY OF
THESE STANDARDIZED ASSESSMENTS
THAT WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED AND
ROLLED OUT THROUGH MEDICARE
WOULD ALSO BE AVAILABLE FOR
THAT BENEFICIARY REALLY TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF REPEAT
ASSESSMENTS THAT CAN OFTEN
HAPPEN. FOR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES I'M IN THE
PORTAGE STREAMLINING NOT BASED
ON SIGNIFICANT FEEDBACK THAT WE
HAVE RECEIVED THROUGH
BENEFICIARY FOCUS GROUPS AND
OTHERS IN REGARDS TO WHAT THEY
CALL ASSESSMENT FOR. PETIQ IN
THE MEDICARE PROGRAM. WE ALSO
WOULD BE LOOKING TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
CONNECTING INDIVIDUALS TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND REALLY ALLOWING US TO DRIVE
DELIVERY SYSTEM TRANSFORMATION
THROUGH A PLATFORM THAT WOULD
BE AVAILABLE. TO NOT ONLY DH CS
BUT THE PLANS PROVIDERS AND
BENEFICIARIES. ADDITIONALLY
WITHIN THE AD BUDGET WE HAVE
SOME FUNDS FOR PROVIDING ACCESS
IN TRANSFORMING HEALTH OF
WHAT'S KNOWN AS PASSED. THE
BUDGET INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED
MILLION TOTAL FUNDS ARE ONE
HUNDRED MILLION GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT A MULTI YEAR EFFORT TO
SHIFT THE DELIVERY SYSTEM IN
ADVANCE THE COORDINATION OF
SERVICES THROUGH THE JUSTICE
PROPOSALS WITHIN THE CALTRAIN.
AND PROPOSAL BEFORE THAT-
LEGISLATURES WHILE THESE FUNDS
WOULD BE SPECIFIC TO JUSTICE
REALLY LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN
FIND THE SUPPORT AROUND I'M NOT
ONLY THE- ENROLLMENT OF
INDIVIDUALS INTO MEDICARE ALL
BUT THE THIRTY DAY IN REACH OF
SERVICES. AS WELL AS THE COURT
NEEDED RE ENTRY OF INDIVIDUALS
INTO THE COMMUNITY SO THAT THEY
CAN HAVE ACCESS TO YOUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES UPON
RELEASE AS WELL AS CONNECTING
THEM TO ENHANCE CARE MANAGEMENT
WHEN APPROPRIATE. AS WELL AS
VARIOUS IN LIEU OF SERVICES
INCLUDING THOSE HOUSING
SUPPORTS WHICH COULD BE SO
CRITICAL FOR THEIR RE ENTRY
INTO THE COMMUNITY. SO THERE'S
A DEDICATED AMOUNT OF FUNDS FOR
THAT JUSTICE PACKAGE WITHIN
PASSED- BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES
ANY IN ADDITION TO THE
MEDICALLY TAILORED MEALS PILOT
PROGRAM. THE BUDGET INCLUDES
ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION GENERAL
FUND IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND TEN POINT SIX
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. FOR THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO THIS REFLECTS
THE DEPARTMENT RECEIVING AN
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME BUDGET.
ALLOCATION OF NINE POINT THREE
MILLION. I'M THIS IS TO ADD ON
TO THE MEDICALLY TO OTHERS NO
PROP- PILOT THAT HAS BEEN. IN
PLACE FOR QUITE SOME TIME
THERE'S AN ADDITION OF.
ADDITIONAL COUNTIES INCLUDING
FRESNO KINGS MADERA SANTA CRUZ
TULARE AND CONTRA COSTA IN
REGARDS TO THAT THAT PROGRAM-
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
ON THAT OKAY I WOULD ALSO NOTE
THAT IT INCLUDES ADDITIONAL
DIAGNOSES FOR THOSE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS. IN THE MEDICALLY
TAILORED MEALS PILOT REALLY AS
A BRIDGE BETWEEN WHAT WE ARE
OFFERING AND CALLIE UNDER THE
IN LIEU OF SERVICES- BUT REALLY
EXPANDING WHERE WE CAN'T GO
SERVICES. A PRIOR. TO THE IN
THE SERVICES BEING AVAILABLE-
THE NEIGHBOR OF THE ALSO
PROVIDE. TO PERMANENTLY REMOVE
ALL SUSPENSIONS OF PROPERTY SIX
PAYMENTS AN OPTIONAL BENEFITS
CURRENTLY IN LAW. I'M IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THAT WE ALSO
PROPOSED ELIMINATING THE AB
NINETY SEVEN RATE FREEZE OR I.
C. F. T. D. R. AS WELL AS FREE
STANDING PEDIATRIC SUB ACUTE
FACILITIES. AND ESSENTIALLY THE
DEPARTMENT IS PROPOSING. AND
THAT WE WOULD SEE THROUGH THIS
INCREASE AN AVERAGE OF 3% PER
DIEM RATE INCREASE ABOUT WHAT
WAS INCLUDED IN THE JANUARY
BUDGET PRICE YET TNCS. IN
PEDIATRIC SUB ACUTE FACILITIES-
WITH THE RATE CHANGE BEING
EFFECTIVE WITHIN THE RATE YEAR
BEGINNING AUGUST FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO THAT'S
WHEN THE NEW RATE WOULD WHAT
BEGAN. IT ALSO JUST- OUT THAT
THE PROPOSAL WOULD UNFREEZE THE
RATE ON AN ONGOING BASIS AND
WOULD RESULT IN THE RATE BEING
UPDATED ON AN ANNUAL BASIS TO
REFLECT THE UPDATED COST
RECORDED. SUBMITTED BY THE
FACILITIES ALLOWING FOR ONGOING
INCREASES IN THE FUTURE. THE
RATE METHODOLOGY WOULD
INCORPORATE UPDATED COST REPORT
DATA TRENDED FORWARD TO THE
RATE YEAR ALONG WITH ADD ONS TO
ACCOUNT FOR COSTS TO COMPLY
WITH FEDERAL. OR STATE MANDATES
THAT WOULD BE ACCOUNTED FOR IN
THE COST REPORTS. THE PROPOSAL
INCLUDES THE PROPERTY SIX
FUNDED SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS AS
A PART OF THE CALCULATION FOR
THE TOTAL UNFROZEN RATE. IN
ESSENCE THE PROPERTY SIX FUNNY
BECAUSE A PART OF THE- PERSON
RATE ANY ADDITIONAL IS FUNDED
THROUGH GENERAL FUND- AS THESE
ARE AT SERVING NEARLY A 100% OF
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES IN THESE
FACILITIES THE REVENUE FROM
MEDIC HOW IT'S CRITICAL. TO
THEIR PHYSICAL CONDITION WHICH
IS WHY WE BELIEVE IT IS
IMPORTANT TO UNFREEZE THE RIGHT
METHODOLOGY ON GOING TO ENSURE
THAT THE REIMBURSEMENT LEVELS
ARE ABLE TO REFLECT THE COST OF
PROVIDING SERVICES GOING
FORWARD. IN THIS PROPOSAL.
ADDITIONALLY YOUR YOU WILL SEE
YOU IN- ARE BUDGET THERE ARE
NUMBER OF. IMPACTS MOST NOTABLY
AS AS- DIRECTOR LIKE BORN
ALREADY HIGHLIGHTED. ON THERE
IS A REDUCTION. IN THE
ESTIMATED CASELOAD IMPACT FOR
THE DEPARTMENT- WE CURRENTLY.
I'M. HELLO THERE WE ARE- WE
CURRENTLY ARE ESTIMATING-
WITHIN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TIME CARRIED AN AVERAGE OF
THIRTEEN POINT SIX MILLION
BENEFICIARIES WITHIN THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM AND AS
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY I'M IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
INCREASING THAT TO AN AVERAGE
OF FOURTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
BENEFICIARIES WITHIN THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM THIS WAS
REALLY- UPDATED BASED OFF OF
HAVING A MORE TIME TO ANALYZE
REAL ENROLLMENT DATA THROUGH
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES
AS WELL AS TRENDS WITH THAT
DATA AND UPDATED TO REFLECT
MORE DATA THAN WE HAD I'M
DURING THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
RELEASED IN JANUARY. YOU ALSO
SEE SOME UPDATES IN REGARDS TO
COST FOR TESTING PER CODE
NINETEEN IN SCHOOLS AS WELL AS
UPDATING THE VACCINE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS REFLECT
1100% FEDERAL FUNDS FOR CERTAIN
PORTIONS OF THE OF THE YEAR- AS
PROVIDED THROUGH THE- RESCUE
PLAN ACT ADDITIONALLY YOU'LL
SEE THE FUNDING MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY FOR COUNTY
REDETERMINATION AS WELL AS
OTHER CODE NINETEEN IMPACTS
INCLUDING THE AN ENHANCED R. F.
MAP THAT IS STILL AVAILABLE.
THROUGH THE END OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. ADDITIONALLY
THERE A REQUEST FOR THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
DESIGNATED A PUBLIC HOSPITAL
SYSTEMS. ARE AS THEY HAVE BEEN
A AN INTERNAL PARTNER IN
REGARDS TO ADDRESSING THE CODE
NINE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY.
I'M IN REGARDS TO NOT ONLY
TESTING I'M A PROVIDING
SERVICES BUT ALSO REALLY AROUND
SOME OF THE SERVICES PROVIDED
FOR THE MEDICARE FEE FOR
SERVICE BENEFICIARIES WHERE
THEY DO SELF FUND THOSE
SERVICES. AND REALLY HELPING TO
CLOSE THE GAPS IN REGARDS TO
YOUR VACCINATIONS BURKE NOT
ONLY LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS BUT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IT REALLY
HAVE BEEN A LEADER IN REGARDS
TO CLOSING THE EQUITY GAP FOR
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION. AND SO WE
ARE REQUESTING THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OF AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN FUNDS TO BE
DIRECTED TO PUBLIC HOSPITALS
SUPPORT THEIR HEALTHCARE
EXPENDITURES. THE ALSO SEE AN
UPDATE IN REGARDS TO THE
TELEHEALTH PROPOSAL- WITHIN
THAT BUDGET I WE'RE ARE
PROPOSING TO SET THE AUDIO ONLY
TELEHEALTH. REIMBURSEMENT RATE
AT 65% OF THE MEDICARE RATE FOR
NON ACCURACY PROVIDERS SO FOR
EXAMPLE FOR PHYSICIANS. AND
OTHERS WHO ARE ABLE TO BILL ON
THOSE IDEA ONLY TELEHEALTH
SERVICES AND THEN WE WILL BE
PREPARING. TO PROPOSE A
COMPARABLE ALTERNATIVE TO THE
PPS RATE COURT S. U. H. C.
CLINICS- TO BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN
THOSE ARE YOUR ONLY SERVICES. I
WOULD KNOW AS PREVIOUSLY ARE
PRESENTED AND THAT THIS WOULD
REQUIRE A WAIVER OF THE GPS AND
COMMITMENT FROM THE FTC'S IF
THEY ARE OKAY WITH THE WAIVER
OF PPS PRESTON FORWARD AND GET
THAT APPROVAL. FROM CMS. IT
WOULD REQUIRE FEDERAL APPROVAL.
WE ALSO WOULD KNOW THAT THE-
PROPOSAL UPDATES YOU ENSURE
THAT ONLY PROVIDERS LOCATED IN
CALIFORNIA OR BORDER
COMMUNITIES SIMILAR TO THE
MEDIC HOW- ENROLLMENT
REQUIREMENTS TODAY AND
MEDICARE. AND ARE ABLE TO
PROVIDE IN PERSON SERVICES BUT
THEY MUST BE ABLE TO PROVIDE IN
PERSON SERVICES TO EACH
CLIENT'S SERVED IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE SYNCHRONOUS AN
AUDIO ONLY TELEHEALTH SERVICES
WITHIN THE PROGRAM. WE ALSO
WILL BE- WORKING TO ENGAGE WITH
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS- TO
ESTABLISH UTILIZATION
MANAGEMENT PROTOCOLS FOR
TELEHEALTH SERVICES PRIOR TO
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE POST
PANDEMIC TELEHEALTH SERVICES.
REALLY AROUND WHAT IS THE RIGHT
BALANCE BETWEEN IN PERSON ARE
YOU ONLY IN OTHER TELEHEALTH
MODALITIES I'M AS WE CONTINUE
TO BUILD OUR OUR TELEHEALTH
PROGRAM HERE- THAT THE
DEPARTMENT. THERE ALSO IS A- I
REQUEST FOR TWELVE MILLION.
DOLLARS TOTAL FUND FOR
MEDICATION THERAPY MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM REALLY HERE LOOKING TO
IMPLEMENT THIS PROGRAM FOR
SPECIALTY PHARMACY SERVICES
THIS WOULD BE EFFECTIVE JULY
ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IN
REALLY FOCUSED ON PATIENTS WITH
COMPLEX MEDICATION THERAPIES
HIGH PRESCRIPTION COSTS OR
HAVING OTHER RISKS THAT MAY
RESULT IN IMPEDIMENTS OF THE
BENEFICIARIES COMPLIANCE OR
ADHERENCE WITH THOSE DRUGS-
THAT'S ALSO IN THERE. AND
LASTLY BUT DEFINITELY NOT LEAST
OF FUNDS FOR THE SAN MATTEO
DENTAL INTEGRATION PILOT
PROGRAM SO THE ESTIMATE DOES
INCLUDE SIX HUNDRED AND NINETY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS TOTAL
FUNDS TO IMPLEMENT ANY DENTAL
IMPLANTS AND INTEGRATION PILOT
WITH HEALTH PLAN OF SAN MATTEO
PURSUANT TO U. S. B. EIGHTEEN
FORTY. EIGHT FORTY NINE OF THE
FISCAL IMPACT REFLECTS
DIFFERENCES IN THE TIMING OF
PAYMENTS BETWEEN PEOPLE SERVICE
TO MANAGED CARE I'M NOT
DIFFERENCES IN COST BETWEEN THE
TWO DELIVERY SYSTEMS. AND THIS
WHICH INCLUDE THE COMMENTS A
LINDSAY RENEE AND KELLY WILL BE
pAVAILABLE FOR- QUESTIONS A
LATER IF NECESSARY A BIT ARE
NOT PRESENTING ANY ADDITIONAL.
ITEMS ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT. THEY YOU MAX WE
WILL HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THE PARTS
DEPARTMENT YEAH I'M SORRY TIGER
WOODS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD AT THIS
TIME. NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
COREY HOW SHE DEALT WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU DR ARAMBULA I'M COREY
WITH THE L. A. L. HAN I'LL JUST
BE SPEAKING ON A COUPLE OF THE
ISSUES DISCUSSED ON ON THIS
PANEL- MY COLLEAGUE BEN JOHNSON
WILL WILL HANDLE THE REST AFTER
ME- IN IN. FOR FIRST OFF- JUST
TO COMMENT ON THE- THE MODIFY
TELEHEALTH PROPOSAL FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION- OUR OFFICE
RELEASED YOU KNOW RECENTLY AN
ANALYSIS OF YOU KNOW THE
GOVERNOR'S ORIGINAL JANUARY
PROPOSAL FOR. TO ESTABLISH A
PERMANENT MEDICARE TELEHEALTH
POLICY AND I'M GENERALLY IN OUR
ANALYSIS WE FOUND THAT YOU KNOW
MUCH ABOUT THE CLINICAL AND
COST EFFECTIVENESS OF
TELEHEALTH AND- IT'S SORT OF
ASSOCIATED FISCAL IMPACT IS NOT
WELL UNDERSTOOD. AND SO YOU
KNOW THE CONCLUSION THAT WE
CAME TO WAS SORT OF THAT- IT
WAS PREMATURE TO SORT OF
ESTABLISH A PERMANENT MEDICARE
TELEHEALTH POLICY AT THIS TIME
GIVEN THAT THERE IS A LOT WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT- TELEHEALTH
AND HOW IT'S- EFFECTS ARE ARE
IN SORT OF THE HEALTH DELIVERY
SYSTEM- YOU KNOW IN ADDITION
YEARLY RAISES. A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS REGARDING-
DISPARITIES IN ACCESS TO CARE
BETWEEN MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES-
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT ACCESS
CARE AT HEALTH CENTRES VERSUS
THOSE THAT DON'T- IN GENERAL
ARE OUR REACTION TO THE TO ME
REVISION PROPOSAL IS THAT- YOU
KNOW WE FIND THAT IT EXPANDS
UPON THE JANUARY PROPOSAL. YOU
KNOW IT REFLECTS AN IMPROVEMENT
IN THE SENSE THAT IT- YOU KNOW
PROVIDES FURTHER DETAIL ON YOU
KNOW WHAT I MEAN PERCENT RATES
WILL BE FOR AUDIO ONLY
SERVICES- YOU KNOW- IT. THERE
IS SORT OF A ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION PUT FORWARD
EIGHT- PROPOSAL TO SORT OF-
EXTEND AUDIO ONLY COVERAGE TO
HEALTH CENTRES ALTHOUGH WE
WOULD NOTE THAT- FEDERAL
APPROVAL FOR THAT PROVISION IS
UNCERTAIN AT THIS TIME- BUT WE
STILL SORT OF HAD OUTSTANDING
QUESTIONS ABOUT SORT OF THE
CLINICAL EFFECTIVENESS OF
TELEHEALTH AND SORT OF ITS
FISCAL IMPACT AND- WE STILL
SORT OF FIND THAT IT'S
PREMATURE TO SORT OF SET A-
PERMANENT MEDICARE POLICY AT
THIS TIME I- YOU KNOW WE STILL.
OF HOUS ISSUE- TO RAISE
REGARDING NEED. AND IN CONVERT
PARTICULARLY BETWEEN YOU KNOW
THOSE AT HEALTH CENTERS IN
THOSE IF NOT- ESPECIALLY WHEN
IT COMES TO THE REMOTE PATIENT
MONITORING BENEFIT WHICH- IS
STILL SORT OF NOW CLOSE TO BE
EXTENDED TO. TO HEALTH CENTERS-
YOU KNOW AND SO WE WOULD
SUGGEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER THAT AS AN OPTION- AS
FAR AS EXTENDING THAT BENEFIT
OUT TO THE HEALTH CENTERS- ONE-
ONE OPTION THAT THE LEGISLATURE
MAY HABIT IT'S ADDED SOME.
DISPOSAL IS TO PERHAPS CONSIDER
SETTING A SUNSET DATE TO ALLOW
FOR SORT OF EVALUATION AND- YOU
KNOW- FURTHER SORT OF
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT MEDICARE
TELEHEALTH POLICY SHOULD BE ON
A PERMANENT BASIS YOU KNOW-
PUTTING THIS SORT OF SUNSET.
DATE IN WHICH SORT OF ALLOW FOR
A REASSESSMENT OF- YOU KNOW
THAT THE TELEHEALTH SITUATION
BASED ON SORT OF UPDATED
INFORMATION AND SO THAT IS SORT
OF ONE. ONE OF ONE OPTION HAT
WE WOULD- PRESENT ON THAT
FRONT- THE NEXT ISSUE WILL BE
SPEAKING ON IS- THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONTINUUM PROPOSAL- YOU
KNOW- WE WROTE THIS UP IN IN
JANUARY RELEASED AN ANALYSIS OF
THE CONTINUE PROPOSAL- YOU
KNOW. IN GENERAL LIKE WE DON'T
HAVE SORT OF BEEN MAJOR
CONCERNS AT THIS TIME YOU KNOW
THERE WAS A SPRING FINANCE
LETTER TO- RE DIRECT RESOURCES
TOWARDS PROVIDING MORE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
COUNTIES- WHEN IT COMES TO REAL
ESTATE ACQUISITION THAT WAS
SORT OF. ONE OF THE BIG.
CONCERNS THAT WE RAISED IN OUR
ANALYSIS IN JANUARY- ONE THING
THAT WE WOULD. RAISE IS THAT-
GIVEN YOU KNOW SORT OF THE
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF FUNDING
ADDED TO THIS PROPOSAL- WE SORT
OF WITH A FLAG ARE ARE
OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS ABOUT-
THE CAPACITY FOR LOCAL ENTITIES
TO SORT OF SUSTAIN THE ONGOING.
SERVICES THAT- WOULD RESULT
HAZARD- IF THEY WERE TO APPLY
FOR THESE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS- WE SORT OF HAD
OUTSTANDING. QUESTIONS ON THAT
ON THAT COMPONENT OF IT IS WELL-
THE OTHER THING THAT I WOULD
FLAG IS THAT THERE IS. I
PROPOSAL IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS TO- FOR THE
DEPARTMENTS THE HOSPITALS TO
SORT OF STOP. ACCEPTING LANCER
MINIATURE SHORT CONSERVE
PATIENTS FROM COUNTIES AND SORT
OF EVENTUALLY PHASE OUT THOSE
BEDS FROM THE STATE HOSPITAL-
IF THAT. WERE TO BE IMPLEMENTED
YOU KNOW WE FIND THAT THERE IS
A- POSSIBILITY THAT SOME OF
THIS FUNDING FOR BEHAVIOR
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE- COULD
SORT OF BE NEEDED TO ABSORB
THAT. THAT POPULATION AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL AND SO ON WE JUST
SORT OF WANTED TO FLAG THAT FOR
LEGISLATIVE AND- CONSIDERATION-
THOSE ARE ALL THE COMMENTS THAT
I HAD. AT THIS TIME I THINK
I'LL PASS IT ALONG TO MAKE MY
COLLEAGUES JOHNSONAP. THANK YOU
NOT WE WILL HEAR FROM BEN
JOHNSON WITH THE L. L. HI
DOCTOR AND GO INTO THE MEMBERS
I JUST LIKE TO COMMENT BRIEFLY
ON A FEW OF THE ITEMS DISCUSSED
HERE- UNDER THE DTS PORTION THE
AGENDA- STARTING WITH THE MEDIC
CAL CASELOAD THAT ITEM TWELVE-
JUST SORT OF YOU KNOW CONFIRMED
THAT- THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
REVISED DOWNWARD. ITS ESTIMATES
THAT RATHER SIGNIFICANTLY IN
THE IN THE MAY REVISION AND NOT
ONLY THAT IT'S ALSO RUDE IRVINE
IT'S CHANGED SOME ASSUMPTIONS
RELATED TO SORT OF WHICH MEDIC
CAL IN ROWLEY POPULATIONS WITH
GROW AT FASTER OR SLOWER RATES.
NAMELY RECOGNIZING THE TRENDS
IN ACTUAL CASELOAD GROWTH THAT
SHOW SLOWER GROWTH AMONG SOME
HIGH COST POPULATIONS SUCH AS
SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES AND FASTER GROWTH
AMONG. LESS COSTLY POPULATIONS
SUCH AS THE ACA OPTIONAL
EXPANSION THIS CHANGE IN THE
ASSUMPTION AS A RESULT AS IN
ADDITION TO LOWERING THE
OVERALL CASELOAD GROWTH
ASSUMPTIONS REALLY CONTRIBUTE
TO THE DECLINE- THAT THE
DOWNWARD REVISION IN ESTIMATED
COSTS. OVER THE FULL FOUR FULL
BUDGET THAT- WINDOW HERE.
OVERALL THE ADMINISTRATION'S
CASE ARREST MEN'S AND THE
RELATED COST PROJECTIONS
GENERALLY ALIGNED WITH THE L.
A. O.'S EXPECTATIONS AND-WHILE
WE NOTE THAT THERE IS SOME RISK
THAT COST COULD COME IN
SOMEWHAT HIGHER THAN THE
ADMINISTRATION PROJECTS- WE DO
NOT RECOMMEND ANY CASE THAT ARE
RELATED TO JUST MEANS TO THE
MAY REVISION. BUDGET AT THIS
TIME. SO I JUST TURN TO I
NUMBER. ON THE I'M- OLDER
ADULTS EXPANSION AND JUST A
SECOND THE ADMINISTRATION'S
COMMENTS THAT- THE ESTIMATES OF
THE ADMINISTRATION AND- OUR
OFFICE ARE NOT DIRECTLY
COMPARABLE- ACTUALLY FOR A
COUPLE OF REASONS ONE THE MAIN
ONE BEING THAT WE USE DIFFERENT
SORT OF AGE GROUPS THAN HAS
ACTUALLY BEEN PROPOSED AND SO-
THERE'D HAVE TO BE SOME
MODIFICATIONS THERE. AND THEN
THE SECOND IS THAT IT SPECIALLY
FOR THE ONGOING COST ESTIMATE
WHICH IS EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL. THAT
TAKES INTO ACCOUNT THAT SEVERAL
EXTRA YEARS OF COST GROWTH
WHEREAS OUR ESTIMATE- REALLY
REFLECTED COSTS AS WE EXPECTED
THEM TO BE ASSUMING FULL
IMPLEMENTATION IN IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO- WE ARE CURRENTLY
REVIEWING THE ADDITIONAL
DISCREPANCIES BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATIONS AND OUR
ESTIMATE- BUT ARE WAITING BACK
UP TO. REALLY BE ABLE TO DIVE
INTO WHICH IS SOME GINS MAY
DIFFER FROM WHAT WE DO NOW WE
DO THINK THAT- DIFFERENCES IN
CASELOAD ARE EXCUSE ME AND COST
GROWTH COULD BE- COULD BE
CONTRIBUTING AS WELL AS
DIFFERENCES AROUND- I HSS
COSTS. AND ULTIMATELY BOTH OF
THESE ARE SUBJECT TO A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY BUT WE WILL LOOK
INTO THIS- LOOK INTO THIS
FURTHER- NEXT I'LL JUST TURN TO
THAT MEDIC CAL POPULATION
HEALTH MANAGEMENT SERVICE. AND
OVERALL WE DO FIND THAT THIS
PROPOSAL COULD IMPROVE MEDIC
CAL PERFORMANCE MODERATE
MONITORING AND CARE DELIVERY-
IN ANALYSIS WE RELEASED EARLIER
THIS YEAR RELATED TO IT.
CALLING EQUITY CONSIDERATIONS
WE RAISE THE QUESTION OF HOW
CALLIE AND ENHANCEMENTS TO
REALLY MANAGEMENT MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS POPULATION
HEALTH MANAGEMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE WOULD TRANSLATE
INTO IMPROVED STATEWIDE
MONITORING OF HEALTH EQUITY IN
QUALITY OUTCOMES- IN MEDIC CAL
STATE CHANNELS THROUGH. PUBLIC
REPORTING AND DASHBOARDS AND
TRACKING REALLY AT A SORT OF
META CAL WIDE LEVEL AND IN
CONCEPT. THE PROPOSED- PROPOSED
SERVICE. HAS COME OUT AT THE
MAY REVISION COULD- THIS
IMPROVE STATEWIDE PERFORMANCE
MONITORING BY SERVING AS THE
CENTRAL SORT OF REPOSITORY OF
ADMINISTRATIVE AND CLINICAL
DATA ACROSS MEDICAL DELIVERY
SYSTEMS- WE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF
OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS ABOUT
THIS PROPOSAL- THESE INCLUDE- A
FUNDAMENTAL ONE RELATED TO
WHETHER OR NOT THIS REPRESENTS
AN- INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
PROJECT THAT- WOULD BE SUBJECT
TO THE STATE'S. I. T. PROJECT
OVERSIGHT RULES ANOTHER IS WHAT
IS THE FULL INTENDED SCOPE OF
FUNCTIONALITY FOR EXAMPLE HOW
COULD IT. POTENTIALLY INTERFACE
WITH OTHER- HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGE EFFORTS OR HOW. OR
WHAT SORT OF DATA LINKAGES
WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
RETURN PROGRAMS BEYOND HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES PROGRAMS
SUCH AS IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM OR STATE AND LOCAL
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS. ANOTHER
QUESTION OUTSTANDING QUESTION
WE HAVE IS AROUND THE
ANTICIPATED TIMELINE ABOUT
AROUND WHEN SERVICES ARE THE
SERVICE WOULD BE OPERATIONAL
AND THEN WHAT IS THE ON GOING
COST OF MAINTAINING THE
SERVICE. WE FIND THE GATHERING
SUCH INFORMATION PRIOR TO
TAKING ACTION ON THE PROPOSAL-
WOULD ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE
DEBATE BETTER EVALUATE THE
PROPOSALS MERIT. NEXT DOWNTURN
TO PASS AND- AGAIN THAT WHICH
IS THE PROPOSAL TO SORT OF
BUILD UP- CAPACITY AT- IN A
LOCAL CRIMINAL JUSTICE AGENCIES
TO ASSIST WITH ENROLLING
INMATES SAT IN MEDIC COW IN
COORDINATING INITIATING
HEALTHCARE SERVICES BEFORE
THEY'RE RELEASED- AND JUST NOTE
THAT THAT WHILE WE- WE DON'T
KNOW THE FULL EXTENT OF
EXISTING AGENCY CAPACITY.
ASSISTING THESE AGENCIES IN IN
THEIR CAPACITY TO MEET THE NEW
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT THEY
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO UNDER
CALAMP LIKELY IS WARRANTED. AS
WITH THE- POPULATION HEALTH
MANAGEMENT SERVICE PROPOSAL
HOWEVER FUNDAMENTAL DETAILS
RELATED TO THAT PATH PROPOSAL
ARE MISSING AVAILABLE BUDGET
DOCUMENTS THAT DO NOT INDICATE
OUT WHICH WHICH KINDS OF AND
AGENCIES WOULD BE ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE THE FUNDING. HOW THE
FUNDING WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED
WHAT CAPACITY BUILDING
ACTIVITIES WITH WOULD ACTUALLY
BE FUNDING AND WHAT IS THE
RATIONALE FOR THE PROPOSED
FUNDING AMOUNT OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS MOREOVER IT
DOES SEEM THAT FEDERAL
FINANCIAL PARTICIPATION COULD
BE- UNCERTAIN WHICH- IF TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS DOES
REFLECT THE FULL FUNDING NEEDS
OF THESE CAPACITY BUILDING
EFFORTS. EFFORTS COULD REST GOT
COULD BRING SOME RISK ON SOME
AND ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND
BEING NEEDED SO AS WITH THE
POPULATION HEALTH MANAGEMENT
SERVICE WE JUST- RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE GATHER. SUCH
INFORMATION PRIOR TO TAKING
ACTION- TO MAKE AT A FULLER
EVALUATION OF THE PROPOSALS
MERIT. AND THEN LASTLY- JUST
NEW BOB BRIEFLY ON THE- PUBLIC
HOSPITAL FUNDING- WITH- WOULD
BE SORT OF MORE INTEREST IN AND
LEARNING MORE ABOUT SOME OF THE
RATIONALE OF THE RELIEF FUNDING
OUT FOR THESE HOSPITALS WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO UNDERSTAND A
LITTLE BETTER- THIS THE FISCAL
IMPACT OF COVERT NINETEEN ON
VARIOUS HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS.
AND AND. AND WONDER WHAT SORT
OF DATA INFORMATION THE STATE
ADMINISTRATION USE TO POINT TO-
OF PUBLIC HOSTAGE DESIGNATED
PUBLIC HOSPITALS FIND IT FISCAL
POSITION AS A RESULT OF COVER
NINETEEN AND HOW THAT INFORMED
OUR PROPOSAL SO- THAT'S ALL MY
COMMENTS BUT HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WITH THE CONCLUSION OF THE
PANEL I WILL BRING IT UP TO THE
DíAS FOR ANY NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS. SEEING NINE I WILL
BRING IT TO THE CHAIR UP FIRST
AS I BEGAN MY COMMENTS TODAY I
BEGAN WITH GRATITUDE AND
APPRECIATION AGAIN WANT TO ECHO
THAT TO THE ADMINISTRATION
PARTICULARLY. FOR HOW THEY HAVE
EXTENDED ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
FOR UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS. I
LOOK FORWARD TO AN OPPORTUNITY
TO REVIEW SOME OF THE
DISCREPANCIES AS WELL AS
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS WITH BEN
JOHNSON ON THE L. L. SO THAT WE
CAN HOPEFULLY AGREE WITH. THE
FINANCE NUMBERS AND FIGURE OUT
HOW TO EXTEND COVERAGE TO AS
MANY UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS AS WE
CAN. I DO WANT TO ASK A
QUESTION AND FOLLOW UP WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION IF I CAN ON
THEIR ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN
REGARDING POPULATION HEALTH.
I'D LIKE TO ECHO THE QUESTION
OF THE L. A. REGARDING WHETHER-THIS IS AN I. T. PROJECT AND
HOW IT INTERFACES WITH OTHER
EIGHT CHINESE. THIRTY HAVING TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION SO. WE ARE
NOT CONSIDERING IT AND I. T.
PROJECT AT THIS TIME IT'S
REALLY WHERE WE WILL BE I'M
DOING A PROCUREMENT- TO PROCURE
A SERVICE THAT IS PROVIDED BY
MANY- COMMERCIAL PLANS AS WELL
AS- OTHER ENTITIES ACROSS. THE
US TODAY IN REGARD TO
POPULATION HEALTH MANAGEMENT
PORTALS AND ANALYTICS SYSTEMS
THAT CAN KIND OF HELP. ON THE
DRIVING OF HOW TO INFORM THE
DELIVERY SYSTEM FOR BOTH
MANAGED CARE PLANS. FOR
PROVIDERS FOR COUNTIES AND FOR
BENEFICIARIES AND SO HAS A
MULTIPLE SERVICE OPTIONS WITHIN
IT WOULD BE INCLUDING BOTH.
CLINICAL AND ADMINISTRATIVE
DATA AVAILABLE THROUGH BOTH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AS WELL AS OTHER
DEPARTMENTS- INCLUDING YOU KNOW
SOCIAL SERVICES- DDS AT PUBLIC
HEALTH EXCEPT ROTH. I'M TO
REALLY GATHER ALL OF THE
VARIOUS DATA POINTS FROM ACROSS
THE RIVER IT'S MEDICAL DELIVERY
SYSTEMS IN INTO ONE-
COMPREHENSIVE SINGLE KIND OF
CORAL INJURY. I'M TO HAVE THAT
AVAILABLE FOR INDIVIDUALS IT
REALLY WOULD BE I'M CALLING THE
DATA INTO THAT SYSTEM FOR
ANALYTICS ABILITY AND
IDENTIFYING THOSE GAP CLOSURE
PIECES ETCETERA. SEPARATENESS
CARBON THAT WE WOULD BE
ENSURING THAT WE CAN WORK WITH
ARE INCORRECT HE COUNTERPARTS
FOR INTER OPERABILITY AND HOW
WE CAN MAKE THOSE LINKAGES FOR
THOSE DATA SYSTEMS TO GET THAT
INFORMATION- IN TO ENSURE THAT
IT IS A PORTABLE. TO OTHER
SYSTEMS- AS WE EVOLVE FEET
POPULATION HEALTH MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM AND GATHER ALL OF THAT
INFORMATION AND ONE. LOCATION
IT'S A HOPEFULLY THAT HELP
ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS IN
REGARDS TO HOW WE'RE THINKING
ABOUT THE SYSTEM AND THE
SERVICE THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE
FOR A LARGE NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
WHO ARE SOMEONE WHO SPENT TIME-DOING INFORMATICS WHILE I WAS
IN THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
IT'S EXCITING FOR ME TO THINK
ABOUT. WHAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
DO AS A STATE WHEN WE ARE ABLE
O. COLLECT THIS POPULATION
DATA AND- I REALLY LOOK FORWARD
AND THINK AGAIN THE- DEPARTMENT
FOR THIS PROPOSAL. I'D LIKE. TO
ASK ON ISSUE NUMBER SEVENTEEN
TO THE ADMIN. REGARDING RATE
FREEZE- YOU WERE PLEASE COMMIT
TO MEETING WITH THE STATE. ON
THIS ISSUE AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
I'VE HEARD FROM MANY OF THEM
AND BELIEVE THERE'S FURTHER
COMMUNICATIONS NECESSARY SO
THAT WE CAN. AGREE ON A LANDING
POINT AND JUST WANTED TO HEAR
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION IF YOU
ARE AMENABLE TO THAT. OF COURSE
WE ARE MORE THAN HAPPY TO WE
HAVE ALREADY DONE OUT REGION
WILL CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH
THEM REGARDING THE PROPOSED
RATE INCREASE. I'M WITHOUT I
WILL UP WITH THREE OTHER
PROPOSALS THAT DH CS IS MADE
REGARDING THE TOOL OF BENEFIT
THE PROMOTE TAUGHT US AS WELL
AS THE PAST. I BELIEVE ALL
THREE WILL HELP US TO
SIGNIFICANTLY ADDRESS EQUITY
AND FOCUS ON TO.THOSE WHO HAVE
NEEDS AND AGAIN WANT TO THANK
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR LEADING
ON THIS ISSUE WITH THAT I DO
HOPE TO SEE FUNDAMENTAL DETAILS
ON PATH SHORTLY SO THAT WE CAN
BETTER ANALYZE THIS PROGRAM
AND- FIGURE OUT HOW IT TIES
INTO THE OTHER CALLIN
PROPOSALS. CAN REALLY DO WANT
pCAN. WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD
PANEL WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
PANEL SEVEN. ON THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH THANK VERY
MUCH PANEL SIX. THANK YOU. FOR
PANEL SEVEN WE WILL HAVE EIGHT
PRESENTERS WE WILL BEGIN WITH
DOCTOR ERAGON FOLLOWED BY A
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FINALE. MONICA
MORALIS ADRIAN BERASA FOLLOWED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND L. A. L. IF WE CAN BEGIN
WITH DIRECTOR ERTEGUN. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M I'M ACTUALLY
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND- THE OLD
ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN WITH REGARD
TO OUR PURPOSES SINCE PROGRAM
TRAILER BILL. I MAJOR IN
BROWSERS THAT DEPUTY DIRECTOR
WITH THE CENTER FOR INFECTIOUS
DISEASES AND THEN I WILL. GO
AHEAD AND PASS IT ON TO MY
COLLEAGUES TO COVER THE
REMAINDER OF THE ITEMS. I'M SO
THE DEPARTMENT IS PROCESS-
PROPOSING A TECHNICAL AMENDMENT
TO HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE TO
ALLOW THE PROPER ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. BAKER SPECIALIZED
ANCILLARY SERVICES- FOR A
PERSON WHO IS. DISPENSED OR
FURNISHED OPERA PURSUANT TO
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE.
EXISTING OUTLAW CODIFIED IN
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE DOES
SPECIFY THAT IN ORDER FOR THE
OFFICE OF BATES TO SUBSIDIZE
COSTS THE PROPER PATH. I'M
PERSON MUST. POSSESS OR OBTAIN
A PRESCRIPTION- SENATE BILL
FIFTY NINE AND NINETY. MODIFIED
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE-
ESSENTIALLY AUTHORIZING A
PHARMACIST TO DISPENSE OR
FURNISH PREP AND PAP- PERSONS
WITHOUT A POSITION PRESCRIPTION.
AND IT'S ENTERED INTO THE
CURRENTLY CREATED A CONFLICT
BETWEEN A BIT AND BIT OF
PROFESSIONS CODE AND HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE. AS PRESCRIPTION IS
DEFINED VERY DISTINCTLY FROM
FURNISHED OR DISPENSE MEETING
THAT ESSENTIALLY THE PURPOSE
THAT THIS PROGRAM FOR
TECHNICALLY NOT BE FOLLOWING A
LOCKET PAPERWORK I'M SPECIFIED-
ANCILLARY SERVICES FOR A PERSON
THAT WAS PROVIDED CRAP. OR PAT.
JOINT S. B. ONE THIRTY NINE AND
SO WHAT WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE
REALLY SPEAKING TO JUST
HARMONIZE INTACT. BEHIND BOTH
OF THE STATUTE TO ALTERNATELY
EXPAND ACCESS TO PREP AND PAP.
AND THAT THAT DOES CONCLUDE THE
END OF MY TESTIMONY HAPPY TIGER
ANSWER QUESTIONS OR PASS IT ON
TO- BY COLLEGE. LET'S CONTINUE
WITH THE- PROPOSALS FOR CAN.
SURE JACK'S WELCOME TO FINANCE
ARE SPEAKING TO- ISSUE TWENTY
EIGHT- THIS PROPOSAL AS IT
RELATES. TO IMPLEMENTATION OF
VARIOUS- DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH PROCEDURES AND
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT I'VE
RECEIVED SOME OPPOSITION FROM
VARIOUS END USER GROUPS. THESE
THESE THESE RESOURCES WILL.
SUPPORT EFFORTS TO RESOLVE-
THAT OPPOSITION AND- MOVE THE
DEPARTMENT FORWARD. THANK YOU
CERTAINLY HEAR A PRESENTATION
ON- ITEM NUMBER. TWENTY NINE.
GOOD EVENING THIS IS MONICA
WHEREAS WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH I WILL BE
DISCUSSING OUR I'LL SAME
VERSION- REVISIONS OF THE MAY
REVISION SO THIS IS A ONE TIME
INCREASE OF SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FIND
IN EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- WE WOULD
USE FIVE MILLION OF THE PUBLIC-
FIVE MILLION FOR THE PUBLIC
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN IN TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION FOR THE STANDARDS
OF KERR MODEL. AS THE FRIENDLY
REMINDER THIS OR RELATES TO
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S- TASK FORCE
ON L. SUMMERS DISEASE AND
PREVENTION AND SO SOME OF THE
EFFORTS FOR EXAMPLE FOR THE
STATE WHAT STANDARD OF CARE
MODEL WOULD SUPPORT.
IMPROVEMENTS TO EARLY DETECTION
AND DIAGNOSIS TREATMENT AND-
DECISION MAKING IN TERMS OF
CARE FOR FOLKS AFFECTED BY
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE. THE A
PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN WHICH
FOCUSED ON EDUCATING THE PUBLIC
ON THE SIGNS AND SYMPTOMS OF
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE AS WELL AS
DRIVING THEM TO- YOU KNOW
RESOURCES ON EITHER WEBSITES OR
OTHER UP PLATFORMS FOR FOLKS TO
LEARN MORE. ABOUT DEMENTIA AND
ITS IMPACT TO DADS IN SUMMARY-
THE CHANGES IN THE MAY REVISE.
FOR OUTSIDERS. THANK YOU NEXT
WE WILL HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. CHECK
SEASON GENTLE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE NO ADDITIONAL DETAILS
AT THIS TIME HAPPEN ANSWER
QUESTIONS AT THE WHICH IN OUR
PRESENTATION STRUCTURE. FINALLY
WE WILL HEAR FROM SONYA PADDOCK
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. I THANK YOU SENATE
HEADACHE FROM THE ILIO- IN
REGARDS TO THE PREP AND PEP-
LANGUAGE THIS- STRENGTHENS REAL
GAINS- JUST CLEAN UP OF. A
STATUTE WE DON'T SEE CONCERNS
WITH THAT- AND ON WE DON'T
HAVE- CONCERNS WITH THE- THE
CODE RED- EXPENSE AND IN TERMS
OF THE ALZHEIMER'S PROPOSAL
AND- THIS ONE IS JUST REALLY WE
DON'T HAVE A TON OF DETAIL
ABOUT HOW THE FUNDS WOULD BE
SPENT- NOR WHY THEY WERE
NECESSARILY SOMEBODY AMOUNTS
WERE NECESSARILY INCREASED FROM
JANUARY SO. I THINK IT JUST
COMES DOWN TO YOU KNOW DECIDING
HOW MUCH THE- THE STATE WANTS
TO. TO SPEND ON THOSE- EFFORTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WITH THE
CONCLUSION OF THIS PANEL OF
BRING IT UP TO THE DíAS TO SEE
IF ANY MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE I DO WANT TO
THROUGH THE CHAIR UP LEFT ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY NINE AND THE
INVESTMENT INTO ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE AWARENESS. AS WELL AS
THE OUTREACH AND EDUCATION AS
IT'S SO NECESSARY. WITHOUT IT
WILL THANK VERY MUCH PANEL
NUMBER SEVEN WILL NOW MOVE ON
THE PANEL NUMBER EIGHT ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS.
MAY REVISE UPDATES WE HAVE
ELEVEN PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL
AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH DIRECTOR
CLINTON. GOOD EVENING STEPHANIE
CONDON AND DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
AND I'M GOING TO COVER ITEMS
THIRTY THIRTY ONE AND THIRTY
FIVE. AND THEN I WILL TAKE THE
HANDED OVER TO DEPUTY DIRECTOR
HI CHRIS EDENS AND DEBBIE
DIRECTOR BRETT HAUSER TO COVER
THE REMAINING OF THE
PROPOSAL'S. REMAINDER OF OUR
DEPARTMENT- REPRESENTATIVES
WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
AT THE END. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- AND THIS IS REGARDING
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY CONTENT-
COMMUNITY CARE DEMONSTRATION
PROJECT FOR FELONY I. S. TEASE
IN THE BUDGET AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDED A
PROPOSAL FOR D. S. H. TO
ESTABLISH THIS DEMONSTRATION
PROJECT. UNDER THIS PROPOSAL D.
S. H. WOULD HAVE CONTRACTED
WITH A SMALL NUMBER OF COUNTIES
TO ASSUME RESPONSIBILITY FOR
INDIVIDUALS FOUND INCOMPETENT
TO STAND TRIAL ON FELONY
CHARGES AND PROVIDE A CONTINUUM
OF SERVICES IN THE COUNTY TO
PROVIDE RESTORATION OF
COMPETENCY SERVICES FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS. BASED ON THE
FEEDBACK WE RECEIVED FROM
STAKEHOLDERS THAT MAY REVISION
THIS PROPOSAL IS BEING
WITHDRAWN. ALTERNATIVELY IT
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS INTO NEW
AND EXISTING STRATEGIES ARE.
PROPOSED TO EXPAND LOCAL
CAPACITY FOR THE TREATMENT OF
DEFENDANTS FOUND INCOMPETENT
TEASED INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL ON FELONY CHARGES. AB
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY ONE THIS IS
THE LAND TERMAN TREACHEROUS
SHORT POPULATION AND PERSONAL
SERVICES AN ADJUSTMENT. WITH
THIS ITEM THE DEPARTMENT IS
PROPOSING TO DISCONTINUE THE
STATE HOSPITALS AS A TREATMENT
OPTION FOR LANCMAN PATRICK
SHORT LP WHERE LPS PATIENTS WHO
ARE CIVILLY COMMITTED PATIENTS
OVER A THREE YEAR PERIOD
PROVIDE TREATMENT FOR THESE
PATIENTS AT THE COUNTY LEVEL
AND AS EXISTING LPS PATIENTS
TRANSITION FROM THE STATE
HOSPITALS TO THE COUNTY.
UTILIZE THE BEDS FOR
RESTORATION OF COMPETENCY
TREATMENT FOR I. S. T. UNDER
EXISTING LAW COUNTIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE TREATMENT
OF LPS PATIENTS AND D. S. H. IS
ONE OF THE TREATMENT OPTIONS
THAT IS AVAILABLE TO THE
COUNTIES WHEN IT COUNTY REFERS
AND LPS PATIENT TO D. S. H. FOR
TREATMENT THEY REIMBURSE THE
DEPARTMENT FOR THE USE OF THE
STATE HOSPITAL BED. WITH THIS
PROPOSAL THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING GENERAL FUND TO BACK
FILL FOR THE LOSS IN
REIMBURSEMENTS THAT OTHERWISE
WOULD HAVE BEEN RECEIVED FROM
COUNTIES FOR THE L. CATS
PATIENTS THAT WE TREAT. SO THAT
THE DEPARTMENT MAY CONTINUE TO
UTILIZE THESE BEDS FOR AYE IS
TRICKY I S. T. TREATMENT. DO
YOU H. REQUEST LIMON TERM. TO
MANAGE THE WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED
WITH THE TRANSITION. AND
SIXTEEN POINT SIX MILLION IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
EIGHTY EIGHT POINT ONE MILLION
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
A HUNDRED FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE
MILLION IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR TO PROVIDE THE FUNDING TO
SURVEYS TO PATIENTS. IN THOSE
BEDS. YES AGE ALSO REQUESTS A
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO ADJUST
ITS EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY AS
NEEDED SHOULD THE LPS CASELOAD
BE REDUCED QUICKER THAN
PROJECTED IN THIS PROPOSAL.
DEPARTMENT PLANS TO ENGAGE WITH
THE COMPANY BEHAVIOR HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION THE
CAIFORNIA MENTALHEALTH
SERVICES AUTHORITY IN COUNTIES
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
TRANSITION PLAN TO THE SOUTH
FACILITATE THE TRANSITION OF
OPS PATIENTS TO COUNTY
TREATMENT OPTIONS WITHIN THE
THREE YEARS. AT THE DEPARTMENT
ALSO PROPOSES TO STOP ADMITTING
NEW LPS PATIENTS BEGINNING JULY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND THEN
STARTING JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TO BEGIN REDUCING
THE OUTCAST POPULATION FROM THE
CURRENT CENSUS WITH THE
TARGETED REDUCTION OF ONE THIRD
OF THE LPS CENSUS EACH YEAR.
THIS ACTION IS NECESSARY TO
ENABLE THE DEPARTMENT TO
DEDICATE ITS FULL BY CAPACITY
TO FORENSIC PATIENTS AND TO
REFLECT THE DEPARTMENT
STATUTORY AND CONSTITUTIONAL
OBLIGATIONS FOR THE TREATMENT
OF THOSE FRIENDS OF PATIENTS.
WHILE ALSO BEING RESPONSIVE TO
THE WEIGHTLESS ONGOING
REFERRALS AND LEGAL PRESSURE
SURROUNDING INDIVIDUALS FOUND
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL. ON
FELONY CHARGES AND REFERRED TO
THE DEPARTMENT FOR RESTORATION
OF COMPETENCY TREATMENT. I'M
FOR THIS ITEM THERE WERE TWO
AGENDA HAVE QUESTIONS THE FIRST
BEING DOES THE DEPARTMENT DSHS
BELIEVE THAT COUNTIES EITHER
HAVE OR WILL HAVE GIVEN OTHER
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES IN THE
BUDGET SUFFICIENT CAPACITY TO
TREAT THIS POPULATION. AS
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY THIS
PROPOSAL IS STRUCTURED TO
ACCOMPLISH THE TRANSITION OF
LPS PATIENTS OVER THREE YEARS
WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT SOME
INDIVIDUALS WILL BE EASIER TO
TRANSITION TO TREATMENT OPTIONS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND OTHERS
DUE TO THEIR SPECIFIC NEEDS MAY
TAKE ADDITIONAL TIME TO
IDENTIFY OR DEVELOP PLACEMENT
OPTIONS. WE PLAN TO WORK WITH
THE COUNTIES TO DEVELOP
TRANSITION PLANS WHICH WOULD
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THOSE
CHALLENGES PHASE TRANSITION OF
UP YES PATIENTS ACCORDINGLY
ACROSS THE THREE YEARS BUT
STILL ACCOMPLISH THE GOALS OF
THE PROPOSAL BY THE END OF THE
THREE YEAR PERIOD. WHERE
COUNTIES DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
ADEQUATE RESOURCES THE PUBLIC
PROPOSAL PREVIOUSLY PRESENTED
BY OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THAT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONSORTIUM INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAM. MAY BE AN OPTION TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
ASSIST COUNTIES AND MEETING THE
NEEDS OF THE OUTCAST POPULATION
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. AND THE
SECOND QUESTION IS WHERE DID IT
D. S. H. BE OPEN TO CONSIDERING
A LONGER TRANSITION TIME FOR
THIS POPULATION IN ORDER TO
GIVE COUNTIES AMPLE TIME TO
ESTABLISH APPROPRIATE TREATMENT
FACILITIES. WE ARE OPEN TO
CONSIDERING ANY FEEDBACK FROM
THE COUNTIES OUT OF RELATES AS
IT RELATES TO THE LPS PROPOSAL
ON TIMING. BUT IT IS IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THERE IS A
DELICATE BALANCE BETWEEN LPS
PROPOSAL IN THE IMPACT ON AYE
AS TEENS. AND THE
DISCONTINUATION OF LPS
TREATMENT AT THE STATE
HOSPITALS IS PROPOSED AS A
SOLUTION TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
CAPACITY FOR THE TREATMENT OF I
SPS. THE WAIT LIST FOR AYE IS
TO USE HAS BEEN EXACERBATED BY
THE PANDEMIC GOING FROM OVER
EIGHT HUNDRED. PRE PANDEMIC TO
OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED TODAY. I'M
D. S. H. FACES SIGNIFICANT
LEGAL PRESSURES REGARDING
PROVIDING TIMELY ACCESS TO
TREATMENT CRISES. SO AS WE
CONSIDER ANY FEEDBACK OR
REQUEST REGARDING THIS PROPOSAL
WILL NEED TO CONSIDER ITS
IMPACT ABOUT THE OUTCAST
POPULATION. AND I. S. T.
POPULATIONS. I THEN MOVING ON
TO SOMETHING HAD A LITTLE BIT
ON TO NUMBER THIRTY FIVE ANON
RESTORE A BALL I S. T. T. BL.
I'M THIS D. S. H. PROPOSES
TRAILER BILL LEGISLATION TO
REQUIRE THAT NON RESTORE BOWL
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
DEFENDANTS FOR WHOM THE
DEPARTMENT HAS FILED A REPORT
TO THE COURT. THAT THERE IS NO
SUBSTANTIAL LIKELIHOOD THAT
THAT INDIVIDUAL READ WILL
REGAIN COMPETENCY OR WHO HAVE
REACHED THEIR MAXIMUM I S. T.
TERM OF COMMITMENT TO D. S. H.
BE RETURNED TO THE CUSTODY OF
THE COUNTY WITHIN TEN DAYS. AND
IF THE PATIENT IS NOT RETURNED
TO THE CUSTODY OF THE COUNTY
WITHIN TEN DAYS AUTHORIZED THE
DEPARTMENT TO CHARGE THE
COUNTY. DAILY BED RATE AS IS
CURRENTLY AUTHORIZED TO DO SO
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
RESTORED TO COMPETENCY BUT
REMAIN AND D. S. H. BAD AFTER
TEN DAYS. THE STATUE CURRENTLY
REQUIRES THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE NO SUBSTANTIAL LIKELIHOOD
ARE TO BE RETURNED TO COURT
WITHIN TEN DAYS. HOWEVER THERE
IS NOT AUTHORITY FOR D. S. H.
TO CHARGE THE BILL DALY BAD
RIGHT IF THEY REMAIN OVER TEN
DAYS AS CURRENTLY EXISTING
STATUTE FOR THAT REASON
INDIVIDUALS RESTORED TO
COMPETENCY. ADDITIONALLY SOME
COURTS INTERPRET THAT AFTER
BEING RETURNED TO COURT THE
INDIVIDUAL CAN BE RETURNED TO
D. S. H. R. REMAIN AT D. S. H.
PENDING THEIR CONSERVATORSHIP
INVESTIGATION. THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE DEEMED
UNLIKELY TO REGAIN COMPETENCY
THAT REMAIN IN A D. S. H. BAD
LONGER THAN TEN DAYS HAS GROWN
BY 12100% FROM TWENTY FOUR IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN. TO THREE
HUNDRED THIRTEEN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY. ONE AND NON
RESORBABLE ISSUE REMAINS IN A
STATE HOSPITAL BED IT PREVENTS
THE S. H. FROM A MANY NEW I SEE
PATIENTS WHO ARE AWAITING
TREATMENT. THE STATUTORY
CHANGES NECESSARY TO ENSURE D.
S. H. MAXIMIZES UTILIZATION
UTILIZATION OF ITS BED CAPACITY
FOR ICY TREATMENT. TO ADDRESS
THE ONGOING WEIGHTLESS FOR ICE
TEAS. I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND
TURN IT OVER TO THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AT CHRISTINE'S FOR
ITEMS THIRTY TWO. THIRTY THREE.
REMAINING. ITEMS THIRTY TO
THREE THIRTY SIX. HELLO CNN'S
DIRECTOR FOR FORENSIC SERVICES-
ITEM THIRTY TWO THIS IS AN
UPDATE TO THE JAIL BASED
COMPETENCY TREATMENT- UP OR AS
WE CALL IT G. B. C. T. PROGRAMS
ARE THE DEPARTMENT CONTINUES TO
PARTNER WITH COUNTY SHERIFF'S
TO EXPAND G. B. C. T. BED
CAPACITY ACROSS THE STATE AS
ONE OF THE SOLUTIONS WERE
SEEKING TO ADDRESS THE HIGHEST
HE WAIT LIST AND THE MAY
REVISION OF THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING AN INCREASE OF
THIRTEEN POINT THREE MILLION IN
THE BUDGET YEAR AND TWENTY TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION ONGOING AS
COMPARED TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. TO SUPPORT THE COST
INCREASES ENCOURAGE INCURRED BY
EXISTING COUNTY PROGRAMS AS
WELL AS TO EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
NEW PROGRAMS IN ADDITION THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING TO
ESTABLISH SEVEN POSITIONS TO
SUPPORT THE OVERSIGHT AND
MANAGEMENT OF THIS GROWING
PROGRAM. COUPLED WITH THE
ADJUSTMENTS PRESENTED AT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE
DEPARTMENT PLANS TO ACTIVATE
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
NEW J. B. C. T. BEDS ACROSS
ELEVEN COUNTIES. UPON
ACTIVATION OF THESE NEW BEDS
THERE WILL BE A TOTAL OF. SIX
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY B. C. T.
BEDS ACROSS THIRTY TWO COUNCILS.
IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT THE
SEVEN POSITIONS REQUESTED WILL
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO CREATE
A FORMAL PROGRAM STRUCTURE TO
MANAGE THESE G. C. T. PROGRAMS.
DEPARTMENT HAS NOT RECEIVED
DEDICATED STAFFING RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT THE SIGNIFICANT GROWTH
IN THIS NEW PROGRAM- AS WELL AS
EFFORTS. TO SUPPORT THE ONGOING
OVERSIGHT OF THESE EXISTING
PROGRAMS I THE CURRENT VOLUME
OF WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
EACH EXISTING AND NEW GBC T.
SITE EXCEEDS DSHS CAPACITY TO
PROVIDE DEQUATE CLINICAL
OVERSIGHT AND CONDUCT QUALITY
ASSURANCE REVIEWS OF THESE
ESSENTIAL PROGRAMS. THAT'S THE
END OF MY TESTIMONY AND G. B.
C. T. MOVING ON. ME NEXT ITEM
ITEM THIRTY THREE IS AN UPDATE
ON THE COMMUNITY BASED
RESTORATION PROGRAM- OR I'M MAY
REFER TO IT AS CPR WE ARE
REQUESTING TO SUBSTANTIALLY
EXPAND THIS PROGRAM IS AGAIN
ONE OF THE SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS
I S. T. WAIT LIST. AS OF THE
MAY REVISION THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
POINT THREE MILLION IN BUDGET
YEAR AND FIFTY FOUR POINT NINE
MILLION ON GOING TO SUPPORT AN
INCREASE OF THREE HUNDRED AND
TWO ADDITIONAL CPR BEDS TO BE
ACTIVATED OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD. AND FOUR AND A HALF
POSITIONS ABOUT THE REQUEST
PRESENTED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. THE FUNDING REQUESTED
FOR THE CBR BEDS WOULD SUPPORT
HOUSING AS WELL AS CORE
TREATMENT SERVICES- PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION IN START UP
FUNDS FOR THESE NEW PROGRAMS. A
CLINICAL PROGRAM MANAGEMENT AND
NAVIGATION SERVICES SO THIS
WOULD BE THE JAIL IN REACH TO
HELP IDENTIFY AS WELL AS TO-
STABILIZE PERSPECTIVE CLIENTS
WHILE THEY'RE STILL IN JAIL IN
ORDER TO EASE THAT TRANSITION
TO THE COMMUNITY. AND THEN- PRE
TRIAL PROBATION SERVICES THIS
HAPPENS TO BE- A BEST PRACTICE
AND LESSONS LEARNED FROM OUR
DIVERSION PROGRAM. BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WE PROPOSED FUNDING TO
SUPPORT OUR CURRENT YEAR
ACTIVATION OF TWO HUNDRED
BALLOTS IN L. A. COUNTY AS WELL
AS A BUDGET YOU'RE EXPANSION OF
FIFTY ADDITIONAL BEDS. THROUGH
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OTHER
COUNTIES. IT SHOULD BE NOTED
THAT THE ON GOING FUNDING FOR
MORE MAJORITY OF THESE BEDS
THAT WERE IDENTIFIED IN IT IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WAS
ACTUALLY INCLUDED AS PART OF
THE C. C. G. P. PROPOSAL- AND
THIS WAS REALLY TO ALLOW FOR
THE POSSIBILITY. FOR LA'S
PARTICIPATION IN THAT PROGRAM.
AND SO NOW WITH THE WITHDRAWAL
OF THE CCP PROPOSAL THE ONGOING
FUNDING FOR THOSE CB ARE BAD
AND THE POSITIONS REQUIRED TO
MANAGE THIS PROGRAM ARE NOW
REFLECTED. IN THIS UPDATED MAY
REVISE REQUEST. WITH THE
ADJUSTMENTS PRESENTED HERE THE
TOTAL REQUEST FOR THE C. B. R.
PROGRAM IS THIRTY TWO POINT
EIGHT MILLION IN THE BUDGET
YEAR AND FIFTY NINE POINT EIGHT
MILLION BY YEAR THREE. THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD SUPPORT AN
EXPANSION A TOTAL EXPANSION OF
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO NEW
COMMUNITY BASED RESTORATION
BEDS OVER THE COURSE OF A THREE
YEAR PERIOD. THAT WOULD BE
THREE HUNDRED FOR LA TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO FOR UP TO
SEVENTEEN OTHER COUNTIES. AND A
TOTAL OF FIVE POINT FIVE
POSITIONS AS WELL AS OPERATING
EXPENSE FUNDING TO SUPPORT
COUNTY TRAINING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES. THIS
INVESTMENT BUILDS UPON THE
GOALS ORIGINALLY OUTLINED IN
THE C. C. T. P. WHERE THESE NEW
PROGRAMS CAN WORK IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE
ESTABLISHED A VERSION. G. B. C.
T. AS WELL AS OUR CONRAD
PROGRAMS TO BUILD OUT A GREATER
CONTINUANCE CARE IN THE
COMMUNITY FOR THE FELONY I S.
T. POPULATION. CONCLUDES MY
TESTIMONY ON THAT ITEM. ON.
NEXT STOP IS ITEM THIRTY FOUR
THIS IS THE RE EVALUATION
SERVICES FOR THE FELONY I S. T.
THE DEPARTMENT REQUEST TWELVE
POINT SEVEN MILLION. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE TEN POINT TWO
MILLION IN THE OUT YEARS AS
WELL AS FIFTEEN POINT FIVE
POSITIONS TO ESTABLISH
REEVALUATION SERVICES FOR
FELONY I S. T. PROGRAM ON A
FOUR YEAR LIMITED TERM BASIS. I
APPROVAL OF THIS REQUEST WILL
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT BEGINNING
JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
PARTNER WITH COUNTY JAILS
ACROSS THE STATE TO RE EVALUATE
INDIVIDUALS DEEMED INCOMPETENT
TO STAND TRIAL ON A FELONY
CHARGE. WHO BEEN WAITING IN
JAIL FOR SIXTY DAYS OR MORE
PENDING TRANSFER TO A D. S. H.
TREATMENT PROGRAM. THIS REQUEST
BUILDS OFF OF THE DEPARTMENTS
EXPERIENCE OVER THE LAST YEAR
DURING THE PANDEMIC WHERE-
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO CONDUCT
REMOTE FRIENDS ABOUT UA ATION
VIA TELEHEALTH INTERVIEWS- AND
THAT IS IN BOTH THE JAILS AS
WELL AS- PRISONS. THE WORKLOAD
AND COST FOR THIS PROPOSAL FALL
INTO THREE MAIN CATEGORIES- WE
PROPOSED TO CONTRACT WITH A
PANEL OF INDEPENDENT FORENSIC
EVALUATORS- TO- IT WOULD
SUPPORT STATE STAFF TO PROVIDE
THAT CLINICAL ADMINISTRATIVE
AND CASE MANAGEMENT SUPPORT TO
COORDINATE THE SERVICES. AS
WELL AS REIMBURSEMENT TO THE
COUNTY JAILS TO ASSIST WITH THE
SANITATION OF THE TELEVISED
RATIONS. ONE THIS WOULD INCLUDE
A ONE TIME FLAT RATE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR TECHNOLOGY
SUPPORT SUCH AS LAPTOPS OR
SOFTWARE LICENSES WE WOULD
PROPOSE FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER COUNTY- AS WELL AS A FLAT
RATE REIMBURSEMENT OF FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR. EACH I. S.
T. CENDANT THAT'S OF VALUE
WAITED AND THIS PAYMENT IS
INTENDED TO COVER THE JAIL
STAFF TIME INVOLVED WITH
ESCORTING I S. T. DEPENDENCE
FROM THEIR CELL- TO THE
DESIGNATED AREA TO PARTICIPATE
IN A TELEHEALTH INTERVIEW- AND
ORDER FOR TRANSMITTING UPDATED.
INMATE RECORDS TSCH- THE CAR
FRIENDS EVALUATE WILL
ESSENTIALLY ASSESS. WELL IN THE
JAIL AND ASSESS IF THAT
INDIVIDUAL HAS RESTORED WHILE
THEY'VE BEEN WAITING IN JAIL OR
IS PERHAPS- NON RESTORE BOWL ON
THE EVALUATORS WILL FILE A
REPORT TO THE COURT ON THE
STATUS OF THE PATIENT SO
EFFECTIVELY WE BE ABLE TO
COMPLY WITH THE STATUTORY
REQUIREMENT OF- PROVIDING AN
UPDATE TO THE COURT- WITHIN
NINETY DAYS OF COMMITMENT. IF
THE PATIENT IS. DEEMS TO BE
RESTORED I S. T. FORENSIC
EVALUATOR WILL FILE THAT
CERTIFICATE OF RESTORATION
PASSED THE PENAL CODE THIRTEEN
SEVENTY TWO. REPORT ON IT IN
ADDITION THE EVALUATOR WILL
ASSESS WHETHER THE INDIVIDUAL
MAY BE A GOOD CANDIDATE FOR
DOING VERSION OR SOME OTHER
TYPE OF OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
PROGRAM. AND IF THAT'S THE CASE
THAT EVALUATOR WILL THEN INFORM
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND
PUBLIC DEFENDER ON AS WELL AS
CONTACT ANY AVAILABLE TO
VERSION OR OTHER COMMUNITY
BASED RESTORATION PROGRAM- IF
THAT IS AVAILABLE IN THE COUNTY.
JUST TO CONNECT THOSE- THOSE-
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE POTENTIAL
FOR SERVICE- AND THEN THE
DESIGN OF THIS PROGRAM IS
CONSISTENT WITH HOW D. S. H.
MANAGES ITS RESPONSIBILITY FOR
PRE COMMITMENT FORENSIC
EVALUATIONS UNDER THE-
OFFENDERS WITH MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDER AS WELL AS SEXUALLY
VIOLENT PREDATOR STATUTES. I'M
AND THEN LASTLY AFTER THE THIRD
YEAR OF PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION
DEPARTMENT WILL ASSESS THE NEED
TO EXTEND ALL OR A PORTION OF
THESE RESOURCES ON ON GOING
BASIS- AND IF NECESSARY SUBMIT
ANY BUDGET REQUEST. FOR FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX
BUDGET CYCLE. CONCLUDES MY
TESTIMONY ON THAT ITEM. AND
LAST BUT NOT LEAST ITEM THIRTY
SIX THIS IS AN UPDATE ON THE
DIVERSION I S. T. DIVERSION
PROGRAM- JUST BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND IT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
WE REQUESTED ONE TIME FUNDING
OF FORTY SEVEN POINT SIX
MILLION IN THE BUDGET YEAR TO
EXPAND DCH DIVERSION PROGRAM.
THAT'S UNDER WELFARE AND
INSTITUTIONS CODE FORTY THREE
SIXTY ONE- WE WERE REQUESTING
TO EXPAND TO ALL OTHER COUNTIES
IN THE STATE- THREE YEAR PERIOD
BEGINNING FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO THROUGH FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX.
CURRENTLY DSHS FUNDED TWENTY
FOUR COUNTIES. TO IMPLEMENT
MENTAL HEALTH DIVERSION
PROGRAMS AIMED AT SERVING- THE
I. S. T. OR LIKELY TO BE FOUND
I S. T. ON A FELONY CHARGE-
TWENTY OF THOSE TWENTY FOUR
COUNTIES HAVE ACTIVATED THEIR
PROGRAMS. AS OF THE MAY
REVISION THERE'S ACTUALLY NO
CHANGE IN FUNDING COMPARED TO
WHAT WE PROPOSED IN IN HE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- AS PROPOSED
THAT EXPANSION WILL AND ADD
ENOUGH CAPACITY TO TREAT AN
ADDITIONAL THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY SEVEN. I S. T.
DEFENDANTS OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS. IF ALL COUNTIES
PARTICIPATE. HOWEVER I THE
DEPARTMENT IS PROPOSING- O
IMPLEMENT TRAILER BILL
LEGISLATION TO AMEND PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS OUTLINED IN
WELFARE AND INSTITUTIONS CODE
FORTY THREE SIXTY ONE. WHICH
WILL APPLY ONLY TO THE
EXPANSION OF EXISTING COUNTY
DIVERSION PROGRAMS FUNDED BY D.
S. C. H. THOSE. AMENDMENTS ARE
THOSE CHANGES ARE AS FOLLOWS
ONE THE EXPANSION MUST SERVE
THE FELONY AS HE POPULATION
TRYING TO TARGET AGAIN- A
SOLUTION TO HELP US REDUCE THAT
WEIGHT LAST- THE SECOND
AMENDMENT WOULD BE THAT WE
WOULD WAIVE THE REQUIREMENT
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE IN OUR
PROGRAM WHERE- INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE ONE OF THREE DIAGNOSES
COULD QUALIFY SO WE WOULD WANT
TO. UNDER THIS NEW CHANGE WE
WOULD- ALLOW ANY MENTAL HEALTH
DIAGNOSIS THAT IS AUTHORIZED
UNDER PENAL CODE ONE THOUSAND
ONE TWENTY THREE SIX TO QUALIFY.
FOR DS EACH DIVERSION PROGRAM.
AND THEN ANY HOW EXISTING
COUNTY PROGRAM THAT'S EXPANDED
WE WOULD- WAIVES THE MATCHING
FUND REQUIREMENTS- TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM. ANY
NEW COUNTY PROGRAM FUNDED BY
THE DEPARTMENT WOULD STILL BE
SUBJECT TO THE ORIGINAL
REQUIREMENTS OF- WELFARE AND
INSTITUTIONS CODE FORTY THREE
SIXTY ONE. AND THAT CONCLUDES
MY TESTIMONY ON THOSE FOUR
ITEMS SO I WILL. TURN IT OVER
TO. MY HOUSE- DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING BRETT
HAUSER DEPARTMENT STATE
HOSPITAL SPEAKING TO ISSUE
THIRTY SEVEN ON THE AGENDA- THE
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS
REQUEST SIXTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND FOURTEEN TO SIXTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
ANNUALLY THROUGH TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE AND SEVEN POINT-
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS TO
ADDRESS WORKERS COMPENSATION
COSTS. AND CLAIMS RELATED TO
KOBE NINETEEN ENABLE D. S. H.
TO MEET TIME CONSTRAINTS AND
PROCESSING EVALUATING WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIMS. THIS
BUDGET REQUEST ALSO INCLUDES
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE FOR
ADDITIONAL WORKERS COMPENSATION
EXPENDITURES IF NECESSARY OR TO
REFER UNSPENT FUNDS AT THE
CLOSE OF THE FISCAL YEAR. AT
THE READ HE DOES NOT RESOURCES
ARE REQUIRED DUE TO AN
INCREASED NUMBER AND THE NUMBER
OF D. SHS WORKERS COMPENSATION
CLAIMS PRIMARILY DRIVEN BY
COPING NINETEEN. FOR EXAMPLE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THERE
WERE A TOTAL OF ONE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY NINE TOTAL
NEW CLAIMS AS COMPARED TO AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS OF THE END
OF FEBRUARY. THE DEPARTMENT HAS
RECEIVED TWO THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE NEW
CLAIMS OF WHICH SIXTY POINT
SIXTY THREE POINT 1% ARE DUE
PRIMARILY- ARE DO TO COPE IN
NINETEEN. IN ADDITION TO THE
INCREASE CLAIMS AS A RESULT OF
COVERT NINETEEN WHICH IS THE
PRIMARY DRIVER OF THIS REQUEST.
THEY ARE REQUIRED TIME FRAMES
TO RESPOND TO THE CLAIMS AND
THE WORKLOAD FALLS ON DSHS
STAFF. TO GATHER THE
APPROPRIATE INFORMATION
DOCUMENTATION AND EVIDENCE TO
INFORM THE STATE COMPENSATION
INSURANCE FUND DECISION. TO
ACCEPT OR DENY A KOBE NINETEEN
CLAIM. A WORKERS COMPENSATION
BENEFITS MAY INCLUDE BUT NOT BE
LIMITED TO FULL HSPITAL
SURGICAL MEDICAL TREATMENT.
DISABILITY INDEMNITY DEATH
BENEFITS AND DISCOVERY
DISPOSITION COSTS. THIS
INFORMATION CONCLUDES AN
OVERVIEW OF ISSUE THIRTY SEVEN
AND AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
BY THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU NEXT WE
WILL HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. JESSICA THANK IS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD AT
THIS TIME- THANK MY COLLEAGUES
VERY MUCH FOR THEIR TESTIMONY
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU FINALLY WE WILL HEAR
FROM COREY HOW SHE DEALT WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. THANK YOU DR ARAMBULA-
JUST HAD ONE SORT OF
OUTSTANDING QUESTION ON- FROM
OUR OFFICE ON ISSUE THIRTY ONE
DISCONTINUING LPS- PATIENT
CONTRACTS WITH COUNTIES- SORT
OF NOT NOT SORT OF CLEAR TO US-
IT NEEDS TO SORT OF THREE UPS
THE HOSPITAL BEDS IN- FAVOR OF.
PERHAPS FURTHER INVESTMENTS IN-
SORT OF COUNTY- TREATMENT
OPTIONS SUCH AS LIKE THE G. B.
C. T. PROGRAM THAT. IN CONCEPT
ARE ARE SORT OF CHEAPER OR-
COST LESS TO PROVIDE TREATMENT
TO PATIENTS WHO BUT- AND THOSE
ARE OUR WATER QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU WITH THAT I WILL BRING IT
UP THE DIET TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. IF
NOT I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU DIRECTOR
AS WE FIGURE OUT HOW TO SOLVE
THIS VEXING PROBLEM REGARDING
OUR- I. S. T. POPULATIONS. I
WILL THANK VERY MUCH THIS PANEL
AND WE WILL MOVE ON TO OUR
FINAL PANEL NUMBER NINE. WHICH
IS ON COVERED CALIFORNIA MAY
REVISE UPDATES WE HAVE TWO
PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL
INCLUDING THE DIRECTOR. OF
COVERED CALIFORNIA POLICY
ELIGIBILITY AND RESEARCH
DIVISION KATIE RAPHEL AND BEN
JOHNSON WITH THE ALLOW YOU. TO
ME PLEASE BEGIN WITH DIRECTOR
OF L. THANK YOU GOOD EVENING
I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE THREE COVER
CALIFORNIA BUDGET ISSUES AND
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE- BEFORE INTEREST TO
SPECIFIC ITEMS- JUST START BY
NOTING THAT COVER CALIFORNIA IS
PROUD TO PARTNER WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION TO IMPLEMENT OUR
THREE YEAR STATE SUBSIDY
PROGRAM. WHICH WE BELIEVE WAS A
SUCCESSFUL PROOF OF CONCEPT FOR
THE EXPANSION OF HEALTH
INSURANCE PREMIUM SUBSIDIES
WHICH WE NOW SEE IN THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN. IN THE
FIRST TWO BUDGET ITEMS ARE
RELATED TO THE IMPACT OF THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ON OUR
STATE SUBSIDY PROGRAM- SO WITH
THAT I'LL TURN TO ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT ON YOUR AGENDA. THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN INCLUDED
SEVERAL PROVISIONS TO MAKE
HEALTH INSURANCE COVERAGE
THROUGH EXCHANGES LIKE COVERED
CALIFORNIA MORE AFFORDABLE FOR
PLAN YEARS TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED THE
PREMIUM SUPPORT FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH INCOME BELOW THE FEDERAL-
4100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL. INCLUDING ELIMINATING
PREMIUMS CONTRIBUTIONS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH INCOME BELOW
110050% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL. IT ALSO ELIMINATED THE
CAP ON FEDERAL SUBSIDIES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH INCOME ABOVE
THE FOUR HUNDRED- ABOUT 40% OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. SO
THAT NO INDIVIDUAL HAS TO PAY
MORE THAN EIGHT POINT 5% OF
THEIR INCOME FOR A BENCHMARK
PLAN COVER CALIFORNIA. THE
PREMIUM SUBSIDIES UNDER THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ARE MORE
GENEROUS THAN STATE SUBSIDIES.
SO THEY EFFECTIVELY ZERO OUT
THE CONSUMER STATE PREMIUM
SUBSIDY. ARE COVERED CALIFORNIA
IMPLEMENTED THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN PREMIUM SUBSIDY
ENHANCEMENTS FOR COVERAGE
BEGINNING MAY FIRST- FOR NEW
AND EXISTING MEMBERS. FOR THIS
REASON THE TWENTY TWENTY STATE
PREMIUM SUBSIDY EXPENDITURES
WILL BE LIMITED TO THE PERIOD
JANUARY THROUGH APRIL. HI FOR
COVERAGE FROM MAY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THROUGH THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO PLAN YOUR
CONSUMERS WILL RECEIVE FEDERAL
PREMIUM SUBSIDIES. THROUGH THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT IN THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN. THE MAY
REVISION REFLECTS REDUCTION OF
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES FORTY
FOR BOTH CURRENT YEAR IN BUDGET
YEAR TERRACE LIKE THIS YEAR
OWING OUT OF THE STATE PREMIUM
SUBSIDY PROGRAM TO THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN- THAT CONCLUDES MY
OVERVIEW ON- ITEMS THIRTY EIGHT
ALMOST TEN THIRTY NINE HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY RESERVE FUND.
AS I NOTED LAST ITEM THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE THE
INVESTMENT IN FEDERAL PREMIUM
SUPPORT FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
HEALTH INSURANCE MARKET THROUGH
MARKETPLACES LIKE COVERED
CALIFORNIA. OR THE ENHANCED AND
EXPANDED PREMIUM SUPPORT UNDER
THE AMERICAN RISKY PLANS
TEMPORARY PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
AMERICAN FAMILIES PLAN PROPOSAL
WOULD MAKE THOSE SUBSIDIES
PERMANENT. OTHER FEDERAL POLICY
PROPOSALS WOULD FURTHER ENHANCE
AFFORDABILITY EITHER THROUGH
ADDITIONAL PREMIUM SUPPORT FOR
THROUGH ENHANCED AND EXPANDED
CARSHARING SUPPORT LOWER
DEDUCTIBLES OUT OF POCKET
COSTS. WHILE THESE FEDERAL
POLICY DISCUSSIONS PROCEED
COVER CALIFORNIA IS COMMITTED
TO MAXIMIZING THE BENEFITS THAT
WE HAVE TODAY UNDER THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN FOR
CALIFORNIANS. WE DID WORK
QUICKLY TO IMPLEMENT THE NEW
AND EXPANDED PREMIUM SUBSIDIES
IN APRIL WE ANNOUNCED A SPECIAL
ENROLLMENT PERIOD THAT WILL RUN
THROUGH THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO ALLOW
CALIFORNIANS TO BENEFIT FROM.
THESE LOWER PREMIUMS AND HIGHER
SUBSIDIES. COVER CALIFORNIA'S
ALSO EMPHASIZING EARLY SIGN UPS
BY INVESTING UP TO THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS- IN MARKETING
IN OUTREACH BETWEEN APRIL AND
JUNE TO RAISE AWARENESS AND
WILL CONTINUE OUR OUTREACH
EFFORTS THROUGH THIS YEAR
INCLUDING DURING OUR
TRADITIONAL OPEN ENROLLMENT
PERIOD WHICH STARTS IN NOVEMBER.
A WHILE WE WORK THROUGH THE OF
TWENTY TO MAXIMIZE MOMENT UNDER
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN. I
KNOW WHAT THE OUTCOME OF
POTENTIAL ADDITIONAL CHANGES AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL WE BELIEVE
IT'S PRUDENT TO ESTABLISH A
RESERVE FUND THAT COULD BE USED
TO PARTIALLY BACKFILLED THE
LOSS OF THE MORE GENEROUS
FEDERAL SUBSIDIES IF THEY'RE
NOT EXTENDED. OR TO POTENTIALLY
SUPPORT OTHER STATE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY INVESTMENTS THAT
COULD BE EXPLORED IN THE
FUTURE. TO THAT END THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES TO ESTABLISH
A HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY
RESERVE FUND. IN TO PROVIDE
AUTHORITY FOR A ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TRANSFER OF
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE MILLION INTO THE
NEW FUND. THE GENERAL FUND
TRANSFER AMOUNT IS EQUAL TO THE
PROJECTED. AT REVENUE- FOR
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO- FOR
THE SHARED. AT INDIVIDUAL
SHARED RESPONSIBILITY PENALTY
REVENUE- THAT IS LESS TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH- WE
PROPOSED TO COVER THE ONE
DOLLAR PREMIUM SUBSIDY PROGRAM
WHICH IS THE NEXT ITEM- THE
FUND WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND WOULD BE
UTILIZED TO IMPROVE
AFFORDABILITY. OF HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE FOR COVERED CALIFORNIA
ENROLLEES. THAT CONCLUDES MY
OVERVIEW OF THIS ITEM. HOW
MOVED TO ISSUE A ITEM FOR-
FORTY. ONE DOLLAR PREMIUM
SUBSIDY PROGRAM. UNDER THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT FEDERAL
PREMIUM TAX CREDITS CANNOT BE
USED TO FUND THE PREMIUM AMOUNT
FOR CERTAIN PORTIONS SERVICES.
BY THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT ALSO
REQUIRES A QUALIFIED HEALTH
PLANS OFFERED TO MARKET PLACES
LIKE COVER CALIFORNIA MUST
SEPARATELY ESTIMATE THE PREMIUM
COST OF THESE ABORTION SERVICES
AND THAT COST CANNOT BE LESS
THAN ONE DOLLAR PER MEMBER PER
MONTH. FOR THIS REASON MANY
COVERED CALIFORNIA ENROLLEES
HAVE HISTORICALLY HAD TO PAY A
ONE DOLLAR MONTHLY PREMIUM EVEN
THOUGH THE PREMIUM TAX CREDITS-
WOULD MAKE THEM- OTHERWISE
ELIGIBLE FOR FREE COVERAGE. AS
I MENTIONED THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN ELIMINATES PREMIUM
CONTRIBUTIONS FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH INCOME BELOW 110050% OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. WHO
RUN BENCHMARK COVERAGE SO THIS
MEANS THAT MORE COVERED
CALIFORNIA ENROLLEES THAN EVER
BEFORE COULD HAVE ACCESS. TO
ZERO PREMIUM PLANS BUT FOR THIS
ONE DOLLAR MONTHLY CHARGE FOR
ABORTION SERVICES. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT RECENT RESEARCH ON MARKET
PLACE ENROLLMENT SUGGESTS THAT
THERE IS A ZERO PRICE EFFECT
WHERE ENROLLMENT SPIKES WHEN
PREMIUMS ARE FREE AS OPPOSED TO
JUST VERY LOW. THE PROPOSAL
BUILDS ON THAT RESEARCH AND
WOULD ALLOW COVER CALIFORNIA TO
OFFER TRUE IT'S ZERO PREMIUM
PLANS. AND WE BELIEVE THIS-
PROPOSAL WOULD BE AN IMPORTANT
PROGRAM ENHANCEMENT TO
ENCOURAGE LOWER INCOME
INDIVIDUALS TO SIGN UP FOR
COVERAGE- SO SPECIFICALLY UNDER
THIS BUDGET ITEM COVER
CALIFORNIA'S REQUESTING
AUTHORITY TO ESTABLISH A
PERMANENT PROGRAM TO PAY THE
ONE DOLLAR PER MEMBER PER MONTH
CHARGE FOR ABORTION SERVICES.
FOR WHICH FEDERAL FUNDING IS
PROHIBITED. AND WE'RE ALSO
REQUESTING EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE PROGRAM FOR
BUDGET YEAR. AT TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. IF APPROVED COVER
CALIFORNIA WOULD PAY THE ONE
DOLLAR PER MEMBER PER MONTH
PREMIUM CHARGE- TO OUR HEALTH
PLANS ON BEHALF OF ALL OF OUR
MEMBERS BEGINNING WITH COVERAGE
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THAT
CONCLUDES MY OVERVIEW OF THAT
ITEM AND I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. THANK
YOU DIRECTOR NEXT WE WILL HEAR.
FROM BEN JOHNSON WITH THE L. A.
L. I HELLO AGAIN DOCTOR
GLENDALE- I WOULD JUST WE WERE
JUST BRIEFLY NOTE THAT WE DO
NOT HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WE DO FIND
THAT IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ONE
DOLLAR PREMIUM SUBSIDIES. COULD
BE A COST EFFECTIVE APPROACH TO
GAINING NEW ENROLLMENT IN
COVERED CALIFORNIA AND THEREBY
REDUCING THE UNINSURED RATE IN
THE STATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THAT CONCLUDES THIS PANEL I
WILL NOW BRING IT UP TO THE
DENTIST TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
MEMBERS QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE
I WILL SIMPLY COMMENTED THAT
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY NINE APPEARS
TO PLACE THE- PENALTY REVENUE
FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
INTO THE NEW. HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY RESERVE FUND BUT
IT DOES NOT COMMENT WHAT OCCURS
TO THOSE PENALTY REVENUES AFTER
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO FUTURE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION. ON
WHERE THAT PENALTY REVENUE WILL
GO. WITH THAT WITH THE EXCUSE
ME DOCTOR WHAT YEAH I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO ECHO THAT COMMENT
I THINK WE NEED TO START
CONSIDERING OTHER OPTIONS-
LIKE. COST SHARING ASSISTANCE
GOING FORWARD HERE- I JUST HOPE
WE CAN CONTINUE THESE
DISCUSSIONS. I DON'T THINK THE
PENALTY REVENUE IS GOING TO BE
ENOUGH. TO HELP US- THROUGH.
SOME OF THE SOME OF SIGNIFICANT
NEED WE HAVE. WITHOUT I WILL
THANK VERY MUCH ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS WE WILL NOW IF THERE
IS NO ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. WE WILL
NOW BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT AS A
REMINDER WE WELCOME PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ANY ISSUE ON THE
AGENDA INCLUDING OUR NON
PRESENTATION ISSUES. WE HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND THEREFORE I
WANT TO URGE YOU TO KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS. BRIEF SO THAT WE CAN
HEAR FROM EVERYONE. WE WILL NOW
GO TO THE PHONE LINE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT AND AS A REMINDER THE
PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND
SHOULD BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU
ARE WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET.
THE NUMBER IS TOLL FREE.
1-877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR. TWO ZERO TWO. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CALL THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2090 NINE
AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST
YOU. OPERATOR WE ARE READY TO
BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT. IN LATE
ZERO ONE IF YOU WISH TO ASK A
QUESTION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE.
YOU MAY REMOVE YOURSELF FROM
QUEUE AT ANY TIME BY PRESSING
ONE ZERO AGAIN. IF USING A
SPEAKERPHONE PLEASE PICK UP THE
HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING NUMBERS
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU HAVE A
QUESTION. PLEASE PRESS ONE MIN
ZERO. WE'LL BEGIN WITH LINE
NUMBER TWO FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF AN AFRICAN CANNOT
BURST ON THE HOPPNER FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SOMETHING AND
WOULDN'T STAKEHOLDERS PROPOSAL
TO PROVIDE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
ONGOING FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND APPEAL TO
SUPPORT THE EXPANSION OF TWELVE
MONTHS COAST PARDON MEDICAL
COVERAGE. THEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS WE STAND STRONG
SUPPORT ABBAS HAD FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR AUGMENTATION THE SONG
BROWN RESIDENCY TRAINING
PROGRAM THAT ARE EXTREMELY
APPRECIATED MISTER CHAIR
CONTENT UNDERSTANDING FUNDING
FOR THIS CRITICAL PROGRAM.
EXPERIENCING A SHORTAGE. OF
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS. I
PROPOSAL PARKING MEDICINE. EACH
FAMILY MEDICINE ALL PROVIDE
TRAIN AND HEALTH SERVICES IN
THE- RIGHT HOLDEN QUESTION
THOSE. AND WE BELIEVE THAT
INTEGRATING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
THREE FAMILY PRACTICE IS A WAY
TO REACH PATIENTS OF ALL AGES
HONG BROWN IS UNLIKE ANY OTHER
NEWER GRADUATE MEDICAL PROGRAM
THAT DOES NOT FOCUS ON PRIMARY
CARE AND DOES NOT HAVE A
DEDICATED FUNDING STREAM IN
THOSE WAYS THIS FIFTEEN MILLION
IS CRITICAL IN ESTABLISHING
LONG TERM PROGRAMS DIRECTOR
LANCE BURKE MENTIONED HE
BELIEVES THIS IS A GREAT WAY TO
BRING DOWN COSTS AND. IMPROVE
HEALTH EQUITY THANK YOU. THANK
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO IT
ONLINE TWO SEVENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING I'M
TELLING BURKE I WILL BE
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF SEVERAL
CLIENTS ON SEVERAL ISSUES ON
ISSUE NUMBER ONE ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE VENTURA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
THE INCREASE COUNTY WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADOPT TWO
HUNDRED MILLION AN ONGOING
FUNDING FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE CAN DO BOTH INVEST IN PUBLIC
HEALTH AND DO A STUDY OF
PROPOSED A REVISION IT DOES NOT
HAVE TO BE ONE OR THE OTHER AND
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
FOR CAMPING THIS ISSUE. SECOND
ON BEHALF OFTHE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
THE VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE SUPPORT THAT
THREE HUNDRED MILLION PROVIDED
THE PUBLIC HOSPITALS FOR THEIR
INCREASED MEDICAL COSTS RELATED
SERVING COVERED PATIENTS.
PUBLIC HOSPITALS PROVIDED
CRITICAL CARE TO THE POPULATION
AND THE FUNDING WILL HELP US
ADDRESS OUR COSTS RELATED TO
KOBE YOU WANT TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR INVESTING IN
OUR FACILITIES. I'M A
TELEHEALTH ISSUE I'M TESTIFYING
ON BEHALF OF C. A. T. H. AND
URBAN COUNTIES CAUCUS THE
ADMINISTRATION TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE DOES NOT INCLUDE A
TRANSITION PERIOD FOR TELEPHONE
VISIT FOR FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTERS WHICH PUBLIC
HOSPITALS OPERATE. WE HAVE A
LOT MORE TO LEARN ABOUT THE NEW
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT METHODOLOGY
METHODOLOGY STRUCTURE WE HOPE
THE STATE ENGAGES US WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO USE EIGHTY
THIRTY TWO OF THE MODELS TO FOR
THE TRAILER BILL. NEXT URBAN
COUNTIES APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S UNPRECEDENTED
INVESTMENT IN CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS
WORKFORCE INVESTMENTS ARE
CRITICAL TO GROWING CAPACITY IN
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
INVESTMENT IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR
WORKFORCE- ESPECIALLY CRITICAL
FINALLY ON ISSUE THIRTY ONE
URBAN COUNTIES DON'T THINK THE
PROPOSAL TO STOP AND TAKE ND
RELIEF PLAN FOR MEN PETROUS
SHORT CONSERVATORSHIP FROM
STATE HOSPITALS IS FEASIBLE TO
BE IMPLEMENTED AS PROPOSED IN
THE MAY REVISION. WE DON'T HAVE
THE TIME A CAPACITY TO DEVELOP
RESPONSIBLE RESOLUTION AND JUST
A FEW WEEKS WE ARE TO THE SUB
COMMITTEE TO REJECT THE
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
TO ADELINE. SIX EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU ARAMBULA AND
YOUR DS ON BEHALF OF YEAH YOU
TELL COULD CALM ON THE HEALTH
PUBLIC HOSPITAL AND BE ABLE
HELP MAY BE NICE AM. FIRST WE
ARE UTTERLY DISAPPOINTED THAT
THE MAYBE LIFE WOULD NOT
INCLUDE ANY PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT THAT COULD BE USED
TO STAFF UP OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT THAT JUNE AND JULY
ONE THIS YEAR IN ORDER TO MEET
THE NON COLD IT YET POOR PUBLIC
HEALTH ACTIVITIES THAT WE HAVE
TO THAT ONE I THANK YOU IN THE
LAST YEAR AND A HALF. WE
SUPPORT THE ASSESSMENT OF OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM BUT THE
STATE CAN DO BOTH CONDUCTED
AFFECT MEN AND AT THE SAME TIME
FIND OUR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS NOW WE REQUESTED
TIME INCLUDE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ONGOING IN YOUR
PROPOSED BUDGET AND WE THINK
OUT THE DOCTOR WOULD FOR YOUR
LEAGUE LEADERSHIP AND IF. THAT
CAN'T WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
THREE HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME
FUNDING TO HELP OUR PUBLIC
HOSPITAL SYSTEM IN ORDER FOR
THEM TO OFFSET THE COST OF
TREATING COOLEY NINETEEN
PATIENTS WHO NEED IT I SEE YOU
AND HOSPITAL SERVICES. AND WHO
MOST OF WHICH WERE UNINSURED
AND ARE UNDOCUMENTED AND DID
NOT HAVE HEALTH COVERAGE AT
THAT TIME. LASTLY WE APPRECIATE
IT THE MEXICAN INVESTMENT TO
IMPROVE YOU ACCESS TO BE HEALTH
SERVICES AND A LONGER TERM
THINKING AND HOW TO BUILD UP
ACTUAL BEHAVIOR HEALTH
WORKFORCE. BOTH IN A DATA
PLATFORM BUT ALSO ACTUAL
WORKFORCE PROGRAM BUT WE HAVE A
LOT OF QUESTIONS REGARDING THE
PROPOSED CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE
AND WORK FORCE PROGRAM
EXPANSION. IN BOTH INITIATIVES
WE ARE DISMAYED THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL DID
NOT INCLUDE ANY EXPLICIT
RECOGNITION OR ACTUAL
INVESTMENT IN OUR EXISTING
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORK
WORK WHO HAD BEEN RESOURCE
CHALLENGE TIME AND TIME AGAIN
WE ARE ALSO ALARMED BY HOW MUCH
OF THE PROPOSED FUNDING IS
CONTEMPLATED TO BE USED OUTSIDE
OF EXISTING PUBLIC SECTOR
PROGRAMS. AND POTENTIALLY.
CRIME CONTRACTED OUT- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING YOU ON THE
TRIP. I THINK HAVE. A MOMENTOUS
ENTRANCE FROM- TO READ THAT
PART BECAUSE HEALTH CARE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM A PLEASE.
NEXT WE GO TO LINE TWO EIGHT
FOUR PLEASE GO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER MEGAN SUPER
HALF CALIFORNIA'S PLAN ADVOCATE
THERE ARE MANY- REALLY
IMPORTANT INVESTMENT DISCUSS
TODAY ONLY COMMENT ON A COUPLE
HERE ON ISSUE NUMBER NINE WE
WANT. WE SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE THE ADDITIONAL FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
INVESTMENT AND THE SONG BROWN
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE PROGRAM
FOR NEW PRIMARY CARE RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS THIS PROGRAM IS TO
HAVE A SUCCESSFUL TRACK RECORD
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE. AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE THESE
NEW REPORTS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
FOR RESIDENCY PROGRAM ACT
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS AND
ALSO MAINTAINING THIS
INVESTMENT LONG TERM TO HELP
MARKET PHYSICIAN SHORTAGE. WE
FULLY SUPPORT ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTEEN HEALTH FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS OVER SIXTY AND
SUPPORT THE LEGISLATURE PUSH TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO QUALITY HEALTH
REGARDLESS O IMMIGRATION
STATUS. AND IN REGARDS TO
TELEHEALTH IN ISSUE NUMBER
FOURTEEN WE APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR SHOWING THE
POSITIVE MOVEMENT HERE AND
THERE REVISED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WHEN IT COMES TO
PROVIDING AUDIO ONLY ACCESS
THAT A SEVEN POINT FOUR MILLION
PEOPLE WHO GET THEIR HAVE THEIR
CARE T A HEALTH CENTER. WE
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT THIS
NEW PROPOSED LANGUAGE WOULD
MEAN FOR THESE PATIENTS BETWEEN
THE TIME THE FEDERAL PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY ENDS AND WHEN
THE H. YES WOULD BE ABLE TO
OBTAIN FEDERAL APPROVAL FOR AN
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT. WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO ABOUT THE
PROVISIONS OF AB THIRTY TWO
WHICH ACKNOWLEDGES THE
POTENTIAL GAP IN CARE AND
PROVIDES AN APPROPRIATE BRIDGE
PERIOD AND ALSO INCLUDES AN
EVALUATION. REQUIREMENTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND NEXT TO
ALIGN TO EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PLANETS ARE BOTH ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACTOR
CALIFORNIA SPEAKING ON THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFIT
EXCHANGE ITEMS THIRTY EIGHT TO
FORTY. CALIFORNIA'S EMERGED AS
A NATIONWIDE LEADER IN OFFERING
AFFORDABILITY ASSISTANCE IN
COVERED CALIFORNIA. BUT MOST
PEOPLE COVERED CALIFORNIA PLANS
DON'T HAVE DEDUCTIBLES OF FOUR
OR EVEN SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND THEY MIGHT HAVE TO SIXTY
FIVE DOLLARS FOR REGULAR
DOCTORS. THAT THEY ARE EVEN
EIGHTY TO SEE A SPECIALIST.
PEOPLE MAKING FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR DON'T HAVE THE
SAVINGS NECESSARY TO COVER THE
HIGH DEDUCTIBLES. CALIFORNIA
COMMITTED TO AFFORDABILITY
ASSESSMENT SEVERAL YEARS AGO
BECAUSE WE KNOW THE NATIONAL
STATUS QUO WON'T SUFFICE ARE
HIGH COST OF LIVING STATE. WE
MUST PRESERVE THE OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ALREADY
ALLOCATED ONE PORTABILITY
ASSISTANCE TO CONTINUE TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS BY REDUCING COST
SHARING. WELL INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE PENALTY REVENUE SHOULD
GO TOWARDS GREATER
AFFORDABILITY ASSISTANCE THE
RESERVE SHOULD NOT BE FUNDED
FROM THIS REVENUE ALONE IF THE
FEDERAL SUBSIDIES EXPIRE AFTER
TWO YEARS OF HEALTHY REVENUE IS
NOT ENOUGH TO KEEP GIVING
CALIFORNIA THE STATE SUBSIDIES
THEY'VE COME TO RELY UPON
ALREADY. IF SUCH CHANGES ARE
NOT USABLE FOR TWENTY TWENTY
TWO NOW WE DO ASK THAT ALREADY
ALLOCATED STATE SUBSIDIES BE
PUT INTO THEIR THEIR AND THAT
COVER CALIFORNIA BE DIRECTED TO
RECONFIGURE AND IMPLEMENT.
REDUCED DEDUCTIBLES AND COST
SHARING FOR TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. PEOPLE NEED FURTHER HELP
CALIFORNIA CAN LEAD THE WAY
AGAIN WITH LOWER PREMIUMS LOWER
COPAYS AND BUY OR DEDUCTIBLES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM. IN
JUST THE- WE HAVE ROUGHLY
SEVENTY COLORS IN Q. JUST WANT
TO KEEP. YOU UPDATED. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT YEAR LINE
TO NINE PLEASE GO. I THANK YOU
pCOMMITTEE AT JEDDAH HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S THAT THE IS NOW
PLAN I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT
TODAY HOW WE WOULD LIKE TO
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS OUR COMIC
YOU TO RAISE YOUR CHILDREN YOU
PEDRO HELP INITIATE. HEALTH
PLANS ARE TO BE AWARE OF THE
TOLD THE COMPANY P. PANDEMIC IT
HAD ON THE MENTAL HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
BUT THIS PARTICULARLY TRUE FOR
CHILDREN. I WE ARE INTERESTED
IN SEEING THE DETAILS OF THE
PROPOSAL AND HAVE A PARTICULAR
INTEREST IN THE FORTHCOMING
DMACC TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
REQUIRING NOT HE MIGHT HEALTH
PLAN TO REIMBURSE PAYER HEALTH
SERVICES PROVIDED GOAL SETTING
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER A
PROVIDER IS A PART OF THE PLANE
CONTRACTED PROVIDER NETWORK.
AND WE ARE CURIOUS TO SEE HOW
THE PROPOSAL ADDRESSES THE VERY
THING AND MAKE USING ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AND HOW WE ALL
WORK TOGETHER TO ENSURE THAT
CLEAR PRACTICAL DELIVERABLES
ARE OUTLINED TO EFFECTIVELY
DELIVER BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES. I NEED A
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR QUESTIONS
THAT WE ASKED EARLIER THIS YEAR
IN REGARDS TO THE INTRODUCTION
OF PINNACLE FIVE AWAIT I WOULD
PUT IT NUMBER SIMILARLY
REQUIRED HELP MAINSTREAM FIRST
PAPER HEALTH SERVICES PROVIDED
IN SCHOOL SETTINGS I AGAIN
CAPITOL TOUR TO SEEM TO BE
HELD. AT THE PROPOSED BEING P.
I. D. MAKES THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND BEFORE TO WORKING
WITH YOU ALL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
YEAH YOU'RE GOING TO FIX EIGHT
GO AHEAD. CHAIR MEMBERS KATHY
MUSTARD ON BEHALF OF CLIENTS
NOT ITEM SEVENTEEN THE ENTRY A
MEDIC REACHED. STANDALONE PETE
BASILIDES WANT TO THANK
COMMITTEE AND STAFF WELL THE
MEMBER STAFF THE WORK AND
PARTNERS IT'S ONE OF THE AND
THANK FOR THE CHAIR
HIGHLIGHTING THIS ISSUE I
ENCOURAGING DEPARTMENT MEET
WITH THAT TO DISCUSS THAT WAY
IN THE NOT. OF THE BELT SERVICE
NETWORK I A WHOLE OFTEN
SERVICES FOR WITH INTO TO
DISABILITIES THESE INDIVIDUALS
HAVE SPECIAL HEALTHCARE NEED TO
APPLY NURSING. IN A BILL TO.
FREESTANDING SUB ACUTE. THE
FILM DEPICTS ME HELP FRAGILE
CHILDREN STILL ALIVE AND BE AS
HEALTHY AS THEY CAN IF THEY
LIVE WITH VERY DIFFICULT
MEDICAL CONDITION WELL THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE FINALLY
ELIMINATES THE RATE FREEZE
WHICH IS LONG OVERDUE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED IT ALSO WOULD
ELIMINATED URGENT COVER
NINETEEN LATER JUST MEANT AS OF
MID YEAR FISCAL YEAR DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THE LITTLE NET IMPACT OF
REMOVAL OF DEBRIS TREES AND THE
MANY REVISED MEDICARE WE JUST
WANT TO VOTE ICS AND PEDIATRIC
SUB ACUTE CARE PROVIDERS THE
QUAKE ALTERNATELY TO A FLAT
FUNDING FOR HOME TO THE FIRST
SIX MONTHS OF THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR. WITH A
CONTINUATION OF THE COVERT
SACRAMENTO WOULD LEAVE US WITH
A RATE CUT MADE FISCAL YEAR
THIS WOULD TAKE THESE PROVIDERS
TO THE BRINK OF FINANCIAL
DISASTER ALL OF THISPOST A
TWELVE YEAR BREAK FREE. BOTH OF
THESE PROVIDERS ARE 1100%
RELIANT. MEDICAL WASTE AND HAVE
BEEN BARELY ABLE TO CONTINUE
SERVICES BECAUSE OF THE RATE
FREEZE IN PLACE FOR OVER A
DECADE KOPET OF COURSE WORKING
TO OUR CIRCUMSTANCE
DRAMATICALLY BOTH THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES NETWORK
IN PEDIATRIC SUB ACUTE
FACILITIES URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO PROVIDE A SIX MONTH
EXTENSION OF THE TOBY NINETEEN
BRADY JOHNSON THROUGH JUNE
THIRTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THIS WILL OUR HOMES AND
DISABILITIES TO STAND EQUAL
FOOTING FINANCIALLY AND WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT MOVING
FORWARD ON RIGHT SIZING OUR
RATES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THIS EVENING. THANK YOU MA'AM.
COLOR MEXICO TWO NINE ONE GO A-
HI THIS IS BERG THE HELP
OFFICERS JESSE ACCOUNT. CALLING
BECAUSE INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR NAY REAL ANY INVEST
AND WILL PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WE THE THREE NINE
DOLLARS FOR US BUT WE NEED TO
INVEST NOW. LET'S NOT WAIT FOR
A STUDY DON'T NEED THAT TO KNOW
THAT THIS INVESTMENT OF FIVE
DOLLARS PER PERSON IS NOT AS
MUCH AS WE NEED SO LET'S NOT
WAIT LET'S INVEST FIVE DOLLARS
PER PERSON AS A DOWN PAYMENT
NOW. AND THEN DO THE STUDY SO
PLEASE ON THE TWO HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLAR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE REQUEST THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANKS TO THE
LINE TO FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING I'M MISTER
CHAIR AND SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS
JENNIFER SCIENCE- I'M
TESTIFYING ON HAPPENED TO
CLIENTS TODAY THE COMPANY
SUFFICIENT HELP FACILITIES FOR
DHS ITEMS SEVENTEEN AND FOR
ACCESS DENTAL FORWARD-
DEPARTMENTS- ITEM TWENTY FOUR.
I'M SO HAPPY CALIFORNIA'S
DECISION HOPELESSLY GREATLY
APPRECIATES THAT DHS HAS
ADDRESSED A LONG STANDING ISSUE
ACROSS THE MEDICARE RATES FOR
OUR INTERMEDIATE CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED AND
ALSO OUR PEDIATRIC SUB ACUTE
FACILITIES OUTLINED AS OUTLINED
IN ITEM SEVENTEEN. HOWEVER IS-
CAPPY MUST WORK ALSO- NOTED IN
A COUPLE MINUTES AGO THESE
RATES HAVE BEEN FROZEN SINCE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WHICH IS
THIRTEEN YEARS- SO IT WILL TAKE
TIME FOR THE FACILITIES TO
ADJUST THEIR COST OF PROVIDING
CARE WITH THE MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENT THAT REFLECT THAT
COST. AND IN ADDITION YOU KNOW
IN THE UPCOMING BUDGET YEAR THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT PROPOSING
ANY SOLUTION TO THE CURRENT
UNDERSTANDING OF THE STABILITY
SO TO DRESS THAT ISSUE CATHOLIC
ASKING FOR AN EXTENSION OF THE
10% MEDICARE RATE ADJUSTMENT
FOR THE PANDEMIC. FOR THE SIX
MONTHS BETWEEN JUNE AND
DECEMBER OF NEXT YEAR AND THIS
WILL ENSURE THAT FACILITIES WHO
ARE YOU KNOW 100% MEDICAL
FUNDED CAN MAINTAIN EXISTING
STAFF AND WAGES WHY THEY START
TO ADJUST. TO THE UNFREEZING OF
THEIR RATES WHICH WOULD BE
EFFECTIVE. AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. AND I'M HAPPY. THEN
THEY'RE OPPOSED TO THE IN A-
PROPOSAL- IN THE HELP SERVICE
EITHER TWENTY FOUR. WHICH
PROPOSES TO LIMIT MEDICAL
DENTAL MANAGED CARE IN
SACRAMENTO AND LOS ANGELES
AFFECTED JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. ACCESS BATTLES ONE
OF THE THREE DENTAL MANAGED
CARE PLANS AND BEAT YOU COUNTY.
THE ELIMINATION OF THE DENTAL
MANAGED CARE PROGRAM WILL BE
DEEPLY DESTRUCTIVE TO EXISTING
DENTAL CARE FOR. THE MEDICAL
MORE LEASE THAT ARE IN THOSE
PROGRAMS AND WE BELIEVE WILL
NOT RESULT IN GREATER ACCESS TO
QUALITY DENTAL CARE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO THE LINE TO
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWO NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THREE OH NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I DO THE THIS IS CLEARLY THE
ASSIST I WORK WITH MINUS WE
JUST WANT OF THE THREE FIVE
YOU'RE GOING TO BE BY THE
PROGRAMS UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
THEY DO THINK FORTY PROJECT. I
AM CALLING IN SUPPORT FOR THE
OF SIXTY THREE POINT ONE
MILLION TIME FUNDING FROM THE
SURPLUS OF THE CAN TREND. THIS
IS SEEN THIS YEAR D. B. OR
COLLEGE REDUCE TO SUPPORT ITS
BUDGET OR FOR ADDITIONAL YOU.
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF THEM YOU
MAY TOWARD IN. SAYING AND HAVE
A GOOD EVENING THANK YOU THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALL PLEASE. AND
NEXT TO THE LINE. OH NO. PLEASE
GO AHEAD SORRY LINE TO EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE AHEAD. MAKING NAME
IS LAW WHEN SHE NINE BE PROUD
TO COORDINATE FOR THE AND FROM
PROGRAM TO ONE OF THE THIRTY
FIVE ONE. TO SOME PART PROJECTS
THAT THE FOR THE ON COME. UNDER
CALIFORNIA REDUCE THERE'S BY.
I'M CALLING INTO OF THE
PROPOSED SIXTY THREE NINE AND
ONE COMING THAT WITH YOU BE THE
EXTRA DEEPLY. NOT BECAUSE I AM
PART OF THE PROGRAM BUT BECAUSE
I AM PART OF THE PROCESS
ISLANDER. THAT WE SEARCH A
TECHNICAL THAT SAVE COMMUNITY
AND THAT IS WHAT OUR PROGRAMS
ARE DOING BY ADVOCATING FOR
THOSE WHO ARE DEEPLY. POWERS
ARE TIME THANK YOU FOR THIS.
OPPORTUNITY AND HAVE A GREAT
DAY. THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. YES YOU ARE
GOING TO THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MODERATOR HELLO MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS SERRA
WITH DATING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES SPEAKING ON SEVERAL
ISSUES TONIGHT ON ISSUE ONE THE
PANDEMIC RESPONSE I ECHO OTHER
SPEAKERS ABOUT THE NECESSITY
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CAN'T WAIT
COALITIONS ASK FOR TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ONGOING FROM
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. WHICH IS
SEPARATE FROM THE MEDICAL AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OTHER
PROPOSED- A GOOD HEALTH
POLICIES IN THE MAY REVISION WE
APPRECIATE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD SUPPORT ON THIS PROPOSAL
AND URGE THE ASSEMBLY TO ADOPT
THIS FOR THEIR BUDGET THAT IT
SENT TO THE GOVERNOR. ON THE
ISSUE TO THE CHILD AND YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE
WERE STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS INITIATIVE AND VERY
EXCITING- BUT WE. ALSO DO ECHO
DR WOULD. IT'S REGARDING THE
AIR TRAFFIC. ISSUE AND HOW THE
FUNDING WILL WORK AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL HOW WILL- ADDED TO
EXISTING PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
AND HOW WHO WILL KEEP TRACK OF
IT AND HOW WE KNOW HOW WILL THE
TAXPAYERS KNOW. THAT THE
FUNDING IS BEING SPENT WELL
WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT IT HAS
THE POSSIBILITY TO TRANSFORM.
WE HAVE A WHOLE FOR YOU FROM
THE STATE THAT WERE STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF IT LOOKING FOR TO
WORKING OUT THOSE DETAILS. OUT
ISSUE FIFTEEN THE BEHAVIORAL
CONTINUAL DIFFERENCE OCHRE
PROPOSAL AGAIN STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS OFFICE IS
LONG OVERDUE AND WE JUST CAN'T.
EVEN BELIEVE IT WE'RE SO
THANKFUL FOR THE GOVERNOR SOME
OF THE FOR THE LEGISLATURE FOR
DOUBLING FROM THE JANUARY
BUDGET PROPOSAL. BUT AGAIN WANT
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT I
SAID ABOUT THE YOUTH INITIATIVE
WHICH IS WE NEED AN AIR TRAFFIC
CONTROLLER AT A LOCAL LEVEL. ON
ISSUE TWENTY TRUE ON THE
CALLING PAST JAIL TRANSITION
MONEY STRONGLY SUPPORT THAT
FUNDING AS WELL. ONE ISSUE
TWENTY SIX THE PUBLIC HOSPITALS
AND A ONE TIME AUGMENTATION TO
HELP THEM CLOSE THE GAP FOR
CARING FOR. MEDICAL PEOPLE
SERVICE AN UNINSURED FOLKS
DURING THE CALL THE CARPETS
WERE VERY THANKFUL FOR THE
INCLUSION OF THAT AND THE MAY
REVISION. OF ISSUE THIRTY ONE-
THE DEPARTMENT THE HOSPITAL THE
DISCONTINUATION OF TAKING LPS.
PATIENTS FROM COUNTY. LET ME
NOTE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HOSPITAL IN THE MOST. ARE FOR.
AND COUNTIES ONLY- WHERE THEY
WHO TAKE FIND A PLACEMENT. ELSE
TO DEPARTMENT TAKEOFF. AND
THERE'S NO INCENTIVE FOR A TO
KEEP SOMETHING FOR THERE- AND
WE HAVE GREAT CONCERN. ABOUT
CAPACITY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL-
THE THEY ARE STOP. PICKING UP
HERE PAGE AND WE ARE. KNOW THAT
A- AND- CONCERNED ABOUT THE- ON.
LASTLY OBVIOUS YOU THIRTY FIVE
THE INCOME. TO STAND TRIAL-
ISSUES OF THE IS SOMEWHAT
RELATED AGAIN AS THE PARTY
HOSPITAL'S MENTIONS THE LPS
ISSUEMAKING CAPACITY- AS-
ALWAYS WE ARE WILLING TO WORK
WITH THE DEPARTURE HOSPITALS
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
FIGURE OUT A SOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM. BUT HAVE A SERIOUS
CONCERNS WITHOUT THE I. N. C.
AND THE LPS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK. YOU
MA'AM. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
TO ADELINE THREE FIFTEEN PLEASE
AHEAD. THANK I'M CALLING ON
SUPPORT OF THE R. D. P. OF
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU NEXT CALL. TO GO TO
LINE THREE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI HELLO CHAIR OF THE
LAND MEMBERS I WOULD BE ABLE TO
REGISTER FIFTY WE COOPER WANTED
THAT YOU FROM THEIR HOME
PERSONAL GIVEN IN THE
COMMITMENT BE LEVEL. FORWARD TO
REMOTE BUT TRIAL OF THE LINE
AND IT BECOMES AVAIL WE ARE
GENERALLY SUPPORTIVE OF
MULTINATIONAL BOND I AM IN THE
CHELTENHAM BECAUSE HELP
INCLUDING STRONG SUPPORT FROM
THE VEHICLE HOW CONTENTION
ALONE. AGUIAR-CURRY COULD BE ON
THE- FOCUSED ON CHILDREN THE
JUNGLE CONTINUE. AND THE-
INFRASTRUCTURE. OKAY ON HOW TO
POPULATION. WE ALSO SAW.
FOLLOWING. OKAY WITH THE PART
TIME INTERVIEW HAVE UP
WORKFORCE AND I PERSONALLY
WENT. TO REVIEW THE BUDGET
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WE URGE
OF THE INVESTMENTS INCLUDE HERE
INCLUDE THE TEARS START UP
FUNDS FOR THE CALIFORNIA. WORKS
BEST CERTIFICATION PROGRAM
CHAMPIONED BY CAROLINE BALAT
THIS INVESTMENT WILL ENSURE
THAT CARE PROFESSIONALS ARE
ABLE TO BRING IN MILLIONS AND
FEDERAL FUNDS AS MEDICARE
BILLABLE PROVIDERS WE SUPPORT
THE EXPANSION OF MEDICARE
COVERAGE. INCLUDING BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES TRY DOCUMENT IN
OLDER ADULTS WE SUPPORT THE
AUGMENTATION OF THE MEDICAL
STUDENT SUSPECTED ACT. THANK
REPORTER CATALANES ABOUT. COULD
PROGRAM FINAL WE SUPPORT THE
FOR THE C. R. D. P. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO THE LINE TO
SIXTY FIFTH GO AHEAD. BEHALF OF
THE CHILDREN PROJECT. SHE THERE
AND TWENTY. YOU CAN CHILDREN
YOU HELP. AND WE'RE HAVING A
HARD TIME HEARING HER TEST IS
THERE ANY YOU CAN SPEAK UP FOR-
CHANGE THE MEDIUM. SURE IS THIS
BETTER YES MA'AM THANK YOU.
OKAY YEP NICOLE ORNAMENT ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP COMMENTING ON
ISSUES THIRTEEN AND TWENTY
THREE. ON ISSUE TO THE CHILDREN
AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE EXPANDING EARLY
CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH AND
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
INVESTMENTS IT'S CRITICAL WE
BELIEVE IN ADDITION TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED INVESTMENTS
MADE IN EXPANDING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD WORKFORCE THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA INCLUSION AND
BEHAVIOR. BEHAVIOR CONSULTATION
NETWORK AND INCREASED
INVESTMENTS IN DYADIC CARE AND
FAMILY THERAPY BENEFITS THERE
MUST BE MORE SPECIFIC
INVESTMENTS MADE IN RECORDING
THE FIFTH YOU KNOW EMOTIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND TRAUMA
RESILIENT FOR YOUNG CHILDREN
BEFORE THEY DISPLAY CONCERNING
BEHAVIORS OR ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES. INCLUDING THE
PARENTS PANDEMIC ACCUMULATE
UNADDRESSED TO COALESCE INTO
LONG TERM TOXIC STRESS.
INEFFECTIVE TO THE PANDEMIC
MUST INVOLVE A WHOLE CHILD
WHOLE FAMILY WELLNESS APPROACH
THAT INCLUDES A FOCUS ON EARLY
CHILDHOOD CENTER MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO EVALUATE THE
POTENTIAL FOR MENTAL HEALTH
DIAGNOSES OR CRISES LATER IN
LIFE. AND SYSTEMATIC ATTENTION
TO THE PREPARATION AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT OF OUR
EARLY CHILDHOOD WORKFORCE TO
RESPOND INCLUDING HOME VISITORS
AND OTHER FAMILY SERVICE
PROVIDERS. WE ARE ASKING THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE A ONE
HUNDRED TWELVE MILLION EXPLICIT
INVESTMENT IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
MENTAL HEALTH STRATEGIES. AND
NON CLINICAL SETTINGS TO ENSURE
SERVICES LIKE EARLY CHILDHOOD
MENTAL HEALTH COMPLICATIONS AND
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE TRAINING
FOR SERVICE PROVIDERS REACHES
OUR YOUNGEST CALIFORNIA. ON
ISSUE TWENTY THREE A MEDIC CAL
ELIGIBILITY EXTENSION FOR
POSTPARTUM INDIVIDUAL WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
THIS PROPOSAL AND IN ADDITION
REQUEST THE INCLUSION OF
CONTINUOUS COVERAGE FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN. UP TO AGE FIVE IN THE
FINAL BUDGET WE WOULD ALSO
RECOMMEND AMENDING THE
EFFECTIVE DATE FROM APRIL
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO OR THE END OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
CONTINUOUS COVERAGE. FINALLY ON
THE ISSUE THIRTEEN WE SUPPORT
EXPANDING MEDICAID HEALTH KERN
DOCUMENTED OLDER ADULTS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO THE LINE. THREE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M TRACY
WERE TRACED FROM THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH EQUITY FUND WHICH IS A
CRITICAL PART OF THE SOLUTION
TO ACHIEVING HEALTH JUSTICE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR LGBTQ CLASS AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES. WE KNOW
THAT FEDERAL FUNDS TO THE FLOOD
CALIFORNIA ARE VITAL IN
ADDRESSING THE FALLOUT KOPET
NINETEEN WE ALSO KNOW THAT IT'S
VERY HARD FOR THESE FUNDS TO
GET TO SMALL ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE THE FABRIC OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES. THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH EQUITY FUND WILL PROVIDE
SUPPORT THESE ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING NONPROFITS CLINICS
TRIBAL ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND AREAS
THAT HAVE BEEN HARD. HARDEST
HIT BY THE PANDEMIC. FUNDING
LOW TO. OF COMMUNITY PRIORITIES
AND STRATEGIES TO MEET THEM
WHAT DISTINGUISHES THIS
REQUEST. FUNDED ORGANIZATIONS
WILL WORK TOGETHER TO IDENTIFY
THE MOST PRESSING INEQUITIES IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND DESIGN
STRATEGIES TO MEET THEM. ROBUST
METRICS AND EVALUATION WILL
ENSURE THAT FUNDS ADDRESS
COMMUNITY NEEDS WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
EQUITY FUND THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
GO TO LINE THREE FORTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING CHAIR
ARAMBULA MEMBERS HOWEVER RANDY
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTED THE
PREPARATION BE MUCH RESPECT FOR
YA- EXPRESSED OPPOSITION TO
ITEM THIRTY ONE COULD GET THE
CONTINUE ALBEIT PENSION
CONTRACT WITH COUNTY UNDER THE
PROPOSAL THE STATE INTENDS TO
RETURN SEVEN HUNDRED SEVENTY
EIGHT OUT YEAH CONSERVATIVE.
THE COUNTY OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS IN ORDER TO ACCEPT WAR
IRAQ HM THE POPULATION IS
HIGHLY VULNERABLE AND IN SOME
CASES THE THIRD METRIC AND
THREAT TO PUBLIC SAFETY A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
POPULATION ARE MURKY
CONSERVATIVE COURSE. RISK TO
PUBLIC SAFETY BASED ON THE
NATURE OF THE CRIME THAT THEY
COMMITTED- IT WHICH INCLUDES
MURDER RAPE AND BODILY HARM-
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES REQUEST PLEASE STAND
AT THE- STATE HOSPITAL ONLY
WHEN THERE ARE NO VIABLE
TREATMENT OPTIONS LOCALLY WE
THAT IS UNCONSCIONABLE TO ITS
SUBJECT BY WITHIN A MATTER OF
TWO WEEKS WE GET OUT THE STATE.
PULLED TOGETHER A PLAN TO SEE
IF WE TRANSITION OF POPULATION
TO ABLE TO THE LOCAL LEVEL IT'S
NOW I'M STARKLY CONTRASTS WITH
THE COLLABORATIVE THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH THE CLOSER AFFECTS THE
DEVELOPMENTAL STANDARDS WE
STAND READY TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO PARTNER ON HOW
TO ADDRESS THE AYE HE CRISIS.
BUT CANNOT SUPPORT AND
AFTERWARDS YOU OP HE PUT THE
STATE HOSPITAL ABOUT THE
REMAINING ON LPS I'M
CONSERVANCY POPULATION. IN THAT
SHORT OF A TIME FRAME. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MEXICO LINE THREE FOUR
EIGHT GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
CHAIR MEMBERS MACHEL GIVEN THAT
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVE THE
TECHNICIAN OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT I'M ALSO AN ECHO OUR
DISAPPOINTMENT WITH THE LACK OF
INVESTMENT AND PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE-
THAT GIVEN IT WAS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
AND WHILE WE SUPPORT THE
PANDEMIC RESPONSE REVIEW WE
WANT TO ECHO THE SENTIMENT
EXPRESSED BY OTHERS WHICH IS
THE CALIFORNIA CAN'T WAIT AND
THAT WE NEED TEN BACK AND
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE
INFRASTRUCTURE NOW. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHEN I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE I ASK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AT THE PORT BY
INVESTING TWO HUNDRED MILLION
ONGOING INTO LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE THERE'S A
NUMBER OF CRITICAL ISSUES THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS NEED
TO ADDRESS NOW THE WRITING
RIGHT THE NEXT HE NEEDS THE
UNDETECTED TUBERCULOSIS CASES-
AND THE CHRONIC DISEASE
CHALLENGES THAT HAVE. LED TO
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT FOR
KOBE WE NEED FUNDING TO DO THAT
NOW- WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
AND AFTER THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
PARTNER WITH AN OFFER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO THE LINE.
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI
THIS IS CHRIS JEPSEN- BEHALF OF-
I'M A PARTICIPATION BEHALF OF-
INSTANCE AMANDA ONE OF THE
THIRTY FIVE I. P. P. UNDER IS
BASED CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT I DO
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED SIXTY
THREE POINT ONE MILLION IN ONE
TIME FUNDING FROM THAT SURPLUS
OF THE GENERAL FUND. THIS ONE
TIME FUNDING WOULD SUSTAIN C.
R. D. P. FOR FOUR ADDITIONAL
YEARS. I AM A CURRENT- CURTIS
INTENT OF MANA AND THIS MEANS A
LOT TO ME AND- THIS PROGRAM HAS
IMPACTED QUITE A BIT SO FAR
BEING IN THIS PROGRAM AS A
SINGLE FATHER- I WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW ABOUT THAT IT. HAS AN
EFFECT ON MANY OTHER FAMILIES.
AS WELL- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO THE LINE THREE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU TERM MEMBER SERVERS
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
WE WANT TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION AND CHAIR OF THE
BOARD OF THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR AUGMENTATION TO THE SONG
BROWN HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
pCHEN DOCUMENTED OLDER ADULTS. I
WOULD OUT A COUPLE OF COMMENTS
ON THE DHS TELEHEALTH PROPOSAL
WE APPRECIATE THEM THE REVISION
INCLUDED ADDITIONAL DETAILS ON
THE BEEF CATTLE IT'S 65%
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR AUDIO
ONLY TELEHEALTH DOES NOT GO FAR
ENOUGH. IT'S CRITICAL THAT ALL
FORMS OF ASYNCHRONOUS CARE BUT
ESPECIALLY AUDIO ONLY CARE BE
REIMBURSED AT PARITY TO ENSURE
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES WITH THE
CARE ACT THAT'S THIRTY SERVICES
COMPARABLE TO THEIR
COMMERCIALLY INSURED
COUNTERPARTS WELL WE APPRECIATE
THE ADMINISTRATION'S
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH
ACTUALLY SHE'S IN AREN'T YOU.
I'M FEDERAL WAIVER TO PROVIDE
THESE SERVICES THERE IS NO
GUARANTEE FOR AUDIO ONLY CARE
WE KNOW THE NEED IS IMMEDIATE
AND ONGOING NUMBER
INCREDULOUSLY HERE TO ADOPT THE
LANGUAGE AND YOU'D BE THIRTY
TWO IN LIEU OF THE DTS PROPOSAL
WE LOOK FORWARD TO ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS ENDING TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
FOR YOUR WORKING AREA. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO THE LINE
THREE FOR. P. SAT PLEASE AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CAPITA MAKE WITH THE COUNTY
WILL DIRECTORS AT THAT. WE
APPRECIATE TODAY SESSION ON
ISSUE THAT RELATE TO THE
PROGRAMS ARE MEMBERS DELIVER ON
THE STATE PASSED THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES SIGNIFICANT
AND IN MANY AREAS OF PRECEDENT
INVESTMENTS WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE PROVISION OF
FUNDS FOR COUNTIES. TO RESTART
MEDICAL KEEP REACHING SO OUT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH OF OUR AS
WELL. TO MEDICINE AREAS FOR
WORK SHOULD NEVER ENSURING BILL
FOR THE JUSTICE RELATED BUT-
REFLECT THE NEW FOR BETTER DATA
AND COORDINATE ACROSS EASTERN.
ENSURING ACCOUNT TRAILER BILL
IN COURT THE COW OVER LINE TO
HAVE PUT FOR AND FINALLY
WORKING FOR ANY. TIME
UNDERNEATH QUESTION ON THE
MAJOR- ELIGIBILITY IF OF THE
INTERNET. I'D LIKE AGREED TO
FORWARD WITH WE GENERALLY
SUPPORT FROM PER. WITH THAT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CAN.
OUR GAY.
SONOMA SUPPORTED BY THE FACT
THAT THE AVERAGE LIFE
EXPECTANCY OF THOSE WHO FEED
THE STATE FARM MARKER IS ONLY
FORTY NINE YEAR HOW CAN THAT
MAKE AN EXISTING INEQUALITY
HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED TO COME ALL
AND- THE CHAIR AND MUCH.
LEADERSHIP ON THIS REGARDING
ISSUE TO FOUR THE LIMON OF MAN
CARE ARE USED TO ON THE- BUT
WITH WANT TO ENSURE THE-
PLANNING CALL. OF CARE. WHICH
THAT ON THE SERVER DID MANAGE
CARE BUT NOT BY OUR THE
ADEQUATE PROVIDER COMCAST AND
HIGH WILL INTO. BENEFITS
NOTICES THAT HAVE BEEN BY
STAKEHOLDERS AND THEN. THE
PROPOSAL TO DO. A QUESTION IT
SUFFICIENT FUNDING IS INCLUDED
FOR PRO SIX. IN ADDITION WITH
THE POKE BOWLS ARE ISSUE. TO
FOR CALIFORNIA JAPANESE BUT
RECOMMEND RATHER THAN REPORT
THE AND THAT. STATE SUBSIDIES
TO THE GENERAL FUND THE STATE
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN HEALTH
COVERAGE AFFORDABILITY SHOULD
THE FEDERAL SUBSIDIES EXPIRE.
WE SUPPORT. THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES EFFORT TO
IMPLEMENT XCELERATED
INVOLVEMENT CORDELL ISSUE FIFTY
ONE WHICH WILL PREVENT DELAYS
IN CARE WHILE INCOME OR AFTER
VERIFICATION IS BEING SORTED
OUT. AND FINALLY WE REQUEST THE
ELIMINATION OF THE MEDICAID
ACID TEST THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT TO THE LINE TO NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
DR ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS I'M
STACY HAREM MOTOR THE DIRECTOR
OF RAM COAL THE RACIAL AND
ETHNIC MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES COALITION. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT TODAY BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT THERE WERE
IMPORTANT ITEMS LEFT OUT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S NEWLY REVISED AMONG
THEM IN PARTICULAR AND IN
PARTICULAR THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT OR
THE C. R. D. P. THE C. R. D. P.
IS ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND ALTHOUGH THERE HAS BEEN A
LOT OF TALK TODAY ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH DISPARITIES IN SERVING
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY IN THE LIGHT OF THE
DEVASTATION THAT THE COVERT
PANDEMIC HAS BROUGHT UPON. OUR
COMMUNITIES IT IS AMAZING HOW
THE SUSTAINABILITY AND
EXPANSION OF THE SECURITY P.
WAS NOT IN THE MAY REVISE WE
WOULD LIKE TO COMMEND THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK FOR ANALYZING THE NEW
ITEMS IN THE MAY REVISE AND
POINTING OUT THE LACK OF NEW
INITIATIVES. RELATED TO EQUITY
WE ASK THAT THIS COMMITTEE
PRIORITIZE AN ADVOCATE SO THAT
THIS PROJECT IS FUNDED THROUGH
THE BUDGET AT THE LEVEL WE
ALONG WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
AND DOZENS OF OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE REQUESTED.
THE INDIVIDUAL IN THE C. R. D.
P. R. CURRENTLY PROVIDING
VALUABLE SERVICES IN RESPONSE
TO COPE IT AS WELL AS PROVIDING
EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICES TO
ADDRESS THE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
OF RACIAL ETHNIC AND LGBTQ
COMMUNITIES ALL OVER THE STATE.
MOREOVER THESE PARTICULAR
PROJECTS WILL SERVE AS A MODEL
FOR SIMILAR PROJECTS THAT COULD
BE SET UP EFFECTIVELY AND SERVE
UNDER SERVED COMMUNITIES IN
EVERY COUNTY OF THE STATE WE
FRANKLY BELIEVE THAT IS MORE
EFFECTIVE TO CONTINUE THIS
VALUABLE PROJECT AND UTILIZE
THE EVALUATION DATA THAT WILL
BE GAINED. THEN STARTING A LOT
OF NEW PROJECTS THANK YOU
DOCTOR ARE REGULAR FOR
SPONSORING OUR BUDGET PROPOSAL
AND WE HOPE THAT IT REMAINS. IN
THE FINAL BUDGET NEGOTIATED.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALL
PLEASE. MEXICO ONE TWO FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR RIGHT STANDS ON
BEHALF OF A FEW CLIENTS FIRST
ON BEHALF OF TRIPLE P. AMERICA
SHE WILL BE COMMENDED GOVERNORS
CONTINUED WORK IN SUPPORTING
CHILDREN'S BEHAVIOR HEALTH AND
IN PARTICULAR HIS PROPOSED TO
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIOR
HEALTH INITIATIVE ISSUE NUMBER
TWO WHAT WAS TO WAIT FOR MORE
DETAILS IN THE TRAILER BILL
SHOULD BE DOES HOPE THAT
CONSIDERATION IS GIVEN TO THE
WORLD THAT. PLAY IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH OF THE CHILDREN TRIPLE
P. WOULD ASK THAT THE
INITIATIVE INCLUDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PARENTS TO
RECEIVE EVIDENCE BASED POSITIVE
PARENTING PROGRAM AND SO THEY
MAY STRENGTHEN THE PARENTING
SKILLS TO MANAGE OUR CHILDREN'S
BEHAVIOR AND PREVENT PROBLEMS
FROM DEVELOPING A FUTURE SECOND
I'LL BE HAPPY THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBGYN IS JUST NINE
WE'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE AND
SUPPORTIVE OF ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY THREE REGARDING THE
TWELVE MONTH EXTENSIVE MEDICAL.
ELIGIBILITY FOR POSTPARTUM
INDIVIDUALS HOWEVER WE ARE
STILL VERY INTERESTING CONTINUE
DIALOGUE TO ENSURE AL PREGNANT
WOMEN REGARDLESS OF STATUS ARE
ELIGIBLE THE OPERATING
INDIVIDUALS REMAIN COVERED
BETWEEN THE- PROPOSED IN A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY AND
ABLE TWENTY SECOND THE START OF
THE EXTENSION FINALLY ON BEHALF
OF- CHEN WITH REGARD TO ISSUE
NUMBER FOURTEEN REGARDING
TELEHEALTH WELL WE APPRECIATE
THE EXTENT INFLEXIBILITY IS FOR
CERTAIN HEALTH SERVICES- JIM
HAS DEEP CONCERNS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL. TO
HAVE A SEPARATE REDUCED FEE
SCHEDULE AUDIO ONLY SERVICES WE
BELIEVE HEALTH SERVICES SHOULD
BE REIMBURSED AT PARITY
REGARDLESS OF MODALITY AND
ENCOURAGE THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
TO LOOK TOWARD AB THIRTY TWO AS
A MODEL THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER. NEXT
GOT A LINE THREE SIXTEEN PLEASE
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS ADRIAN
SHELTON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES. WE WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT ON ISSUE NUMBER TWO
REGARDING THE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVES WE APPLAUD THAT
THESE INVESTMENTS IN CHILDREN'S
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WHICH
ACKNOWLEDGE THE BURDEN THAT HAS
FALLEN ON ARGUED DURING THE
PANDEMIC. PARTICULARLY LEADS
LIVING IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND YOUTH OF COLOR
WHO HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED WE
WANT TO REITERATE THE URGENT
NEEDS OF OUR KIDS RIGHT NOW AND
THE TIMING OF THIS INITIATIVE.
ISSUES AROUND WORKFORCE SOME OF
WHICH HAVE BEEN RAISED TODAY
ARE REALLY ESSENTIAL TO ADDRESS
WE HAVE A BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROVIDER SHORTAGE ACROSS ALL OF
OUR CATEGORIES OF STOCK BOTH
LICENSED AND UNLICENSED. A
WORKFORCE IS ESSENTIAL TO
ENSURING THAT THIS INCREDIBLE
INITIATIVE IF SUCCESSFUL AND
THIS IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES IN THE FIELD RIGHT
NOW WE LOOK FOR DEPARTING WITH
ADMINISTRATION. WE ARE ALSO
SUPPORTERS OF THE WORK THAT THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
CONNECTION HAS BEEN DOING WHAT
THEY'RE STUDENTS MENTAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE ISSUE NUMBER THREE.
THIS IS A KEY INVESTMENT SCHOOL
MENTAL HEALTH AND WE ARE PART
OF A COALITION TO REQUEST AN
INCREASE THE FUNDING EIGHTY
POINT FIVE MILLION TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL GRANTS FOR
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN SCHOOLS
AND COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM. AND LASTLY WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF CONTINUED FUNDING
FOR THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO THE LINE THREE.
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING IN THE HILLARY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION THE DEPTH
AND BREADTH OF THE ISSUE
COVERED BY THE HEARING I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO COMMENT ON A FEW
PRIORITIES THAT CMA BUT LIKE
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER AT
THAT REVIEWS THE GOVERNOR MAY
REPRESENT A CALLED BALL WHAT
THE INMATES STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THE IMPACT AND PULLED
APPARENTLY WE ARE DEEPLY
CONCERNED THAT WITHOUT
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES DIRECTED
TO PROVIDERS. A LOT OF LOCAL
TALENT WILL BE IMPOSSIBLE TO
REACH FRONTLINE PROVIDERS
PARTICIPATING IN TALENT NEEDS
SUPPORT DIRECTLY BOTH ONE TIME
START UP RESOURCES AN ONGOING
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE HIGHER WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH THE ENHANCED
CARE MANAGEMENT PURPOSES
ASSUMING THAT FUNDING DIRECTED
AT HEALTH PLANS WILL COME HOW
TRICKLE DOWN TO PROVIDE- IT'S
UNREALISTIC AND WHAT BECAUSE
THIS IMPORTANT NEW PROGRAMS TO
FAIL. CMAT WE APPRECIATE THE
INFUSION OF FUNDING FOR START
AND INITIALLY SUPPORT NEW
RESIDENCY PROGRAM IN AREAS THAT
DO NOT CURRENTLY HAVE ONE
AVAILABLE HOWEVER THE IMPACT OF
THE ONE TIME FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT WILL BE
REDUCED IF THOSE FUNDS ARE
ADMINISTERED STRICTLY THROUGH
THE FONG BROWN PROGRAM
STRUCTURE THERE ARE MANY
SPECIAL FEATURES THAT ARE
NEEDED AND THAT COULD MEET GAPS
IN CARE PARTICULARLY IN RURAL
AND UNDERSERVED REGIONS OF
CALIFORNIA. LIMITING THE
ALLOCATION OF THE NEW
PRESIDENCY PROGRAM FUNDS ONLY
TO PRIMARY CARE PROGRAM WHAT
UNNECESSARILY LIMIT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PUMP NINE
PM I WOULD LIKE TO BE ENGAGED
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION IN FINDING THE
RIGHT BALANCE FOR THIS
IMPORTANT WORKFORCE FUNDING.
AND BRIEFLY SINCE SEVERAL OTHER
CALLERS HAVE ALREADY SPOKEN TO
THE ISSUE CNN ALSO CONTINUES TO
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADOPT THE
CONTENT EIGHTY THIRTY Q. BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AS
AN ALTERNATIVE TO THE
ADMINISTRATION HOW HELP
PROPOSAL AUDIO ONLY POWERHOUSE
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO
MAINTAIN ACCESS TO CARE AND
EQUITY IN THE MEDIC HELP WITH
THEM. FINALLY YEAH MY WOULD
LIKE TO WIN THE SUPPORT TO THE
REQUEST BY PUBLIC HELP YOU
INVEST IN PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND P. C. H. I'D
REQUEST FOR FUNDING. THE
NAVIGATOR PROGRAM FOR TO A
COLLEGE THANK YOU MUCH. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
TO ALIGN THREE NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL I CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF HIS CAR AGAIN EACH RECORD
STEINBERG AND KICKING I'D LIKE
TO OUR STRONG THE CORPORATE
ISSUE ME ONCE FIRST ISSUE TO
THE CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE
FOR CRITICAL REALLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE INVESTMENT
EXPANDING OUR WORK FIRST AND
CREATING VIRTUAL PLATFORM. WERE
ALSO SUPPORTIVE OF ISSUE
FIFTEEN THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL
APPRECIATE THE SATISFIED IN
PARTICULARLY APPRECIATE THE
ABILITY TO FIND CRISIS
STABILIZATION QUITE RESIDENTIAL
AND MOBILE CRISIS TEAMS TO THE
TO THE PARKLAND. OF THE STATE
WORKS INCOME AT NINE EIGHT
EIGHT IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE
LEVERAGE ONE TIME INVESTMENTS
ARE POSSIBLE TO SUPPLEMENT
FEDERAL INVESTMENTS AND REVENUE
FROM AMONG EIGHT EIGHT FIFTY
PAPA ABOUT A COMPREHENSIVE.
HEALTH CRISIS RESPONSE SYSTEM
INFRASTRUCTURE FINALLY ISSUED
SIXTEEN APPRECIATE THE ON GOING
GLOBAL IN CHECK FORM. AND CHECK
OUT. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT ALIGN THREE
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT THE
GERMAN OR UNDER IN THIS MEMBER
GOOD EVENING. I'M ROWLAND MORE.
OF PHD SENIOR RESEARCH AND SO%
DIRECTOR OF THE PREVENTION
RESEARCH CENTER IN BERKELEY AND
I'M PART OF THE NATIVE AMERICAN
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDER
TEEN IN THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT. I WANTED
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT EACH OF THE
THIRTY FIVE ZERO DP GRANTEES
SUBJECT IN THEIR COMMUNITY TO
FIND EVIDENCE PRACTICES TO
RIGOROUS EVALUATION. ALONG WITH
THE STATEWIDE EVALUATOR AND
WHAT THIS YEAR DPU GRANTEES ARE
LEARNING ABOUT CULTURALLY BASED
PREVENTION ANDTREATMENT
PROGRAMS IS A VALUE NOT ONLY TO
THE UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS
THEY REPRESENT BUT A DIVERSE
OTHER COMMUNITIES AS WELL. I
DON'T WANT TO GIVE YOU THE- OF.
YOUR GP GRANTEES IN THE NATIVE
AMERICAN HOPE. WHO HAVE
RECENTLY PUBLISHED THREE
INFLUENTIAL REVIEWED NATIONAL
JOURNAL ARTICLES AND NEWS
ARTICLES REPRESENT BOTH
QUANTITATIVE AND QUALITATIVE
ANALYSES OF THE CULTURAL
FOUNDATIONS OF THEIR
INTERVENTIONS BASED ON SURVEYS
INTERVIEWS WHAT PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS I'M MORE SUCH
PUBLICATIONS WILL FURTHER
INFLUENCE SOLID AND CULTURALLY
NUANCED COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
EFFORTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THE HEALTH EQUITY INVESTMENT OF
SIXTY THREE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS WOULD SUSTAIN THE
SECURITY PEOPLE FOR YEARS FOR
ADDITIONAL YEARS OF PUBLIC
HEALTH POSITIVE IMPACTS ON
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES BUT I
THINK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
JUST AS THE CHECK WE HAVE ABOUT
FIFTY PEOPLE STILL IN Q.
OPERATOR CAN GO TO THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ACTUALLY THE
LINE THREE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CRACKED OPEN FOR ON
BEHALF OF A P. L. A. HEALTH AND
NOT ANGELES I FIRST JUST ONE
ACTOR THE COMMENTS FROM
CALIFORNIA HELPLESS ADVOCATES
REGARDING THE ADMINISTRATION
TELL HELP PROPOSAL AND HELP FOR
ALL. WE ALSO SUPPORT ISSUE
TWENTY SEVEN FROM PDPA
TRIGGERED IN THE STATE'S
CORPORATE SYSTEMS PROGRAM I
ALSO WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
MY PUBLIC HEALTH COLLEAGUES
ABOUT THE NEED TO INVEST NOW
THIS YEAR TO SUPPORT THE STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
AND ADDRESS THE GROWING
PANDEMIC OF HIV STI. VIRAL
HEPATITIS AND OVERDOSE THESE
ACADEMICS WERE ALREADY RAGING
OUT OF CONTROL BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC AND THEY HAVE NOW
GROWN EVEN WORSE AS PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE RIGHTLY
BEEN FOCUSED ON THE CODE
RESPOND. AND COMMUNITIES THAT
HAD LIMITED ACCESS TO SERVICES
WE SIMPLY CANNOT WAIT UNTIL
NEXT YEAR TO MAKE INVESTMENT
THAT WE KNOW ARE NEEDED NOW TO
GET A HANDLE ON THE GROWING
CRISES. I ALSO JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT WHILE WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR QUESTION
SHE ASKED AND OTHERS BACK
FUNDING WOULD PRIMARILY BE USED
TO SUPPORT WORKFORCE INVESTMENT
AND WE MUST REMEMBER THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
REMAIN A CRITICAL COMPONENT OF
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE.
THEY ARE OFTEN THE FIRST LINE
OF DEFENSE IN THE MOST TRUSTED
PARTNERS FOR VULNERABLE AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES SO I
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO SUPPORT THE STRATEGIC
INVESTMENTS FROM EVERY EFFORT
THAT MEXICO ELECTION TO ENSURE
THAT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED. TO PROVIDE
LIFESAVING SERVICES TO PEOPLE
AFFECTED BY HIV STI AND
HEPATITIS. AN OVERDOSE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE.
NEXT TO THE LINE FOUR FIVE
PLEASE GO. THIS IS NEAR MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND LIKE THAT THE CURSOR DURING
ITEM TO CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BEHAVIOR HEALTH INITIATIVE.
LEAVE THAT THE SIZE OF THE
INVESTMENT ADMINISTRATION. TO
MAKE NATIONAL GRID PANEL HELP
AND THIS INITIATIVE WILL GO A
LONG WAY TO BUILD OUT THE
CONTINUUM OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AVAILABLE FOR CHILDREN
ADOLESCENTS. AND MAKE IT EASIER
FOR CHILDREN FAMILIES CONNECT
WITH THE STATE MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM AND ACCESS AVAILABLE
SERVICES IN THE COMING YEARS.
WE SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSAL WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
THEY WILL NOT BE ABLE TO STAND
UP SOME OF THESE AFRICAN TIME
TO ADDRESS THE GROWING CRISIS
AT HAND. MANY CHILDREN ARE
STRUGGLING TODAY AS A DIRECT
RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC AND THE
SHORTCOMINGS OF OUR EXISTING
SYSTEM AND CANNOT AFFORD TO
WAIT FOR THE LARGER MORE
SYSTEM. SYSTEMIC PROGRAMS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE COMPLETED.
WE FIND OURSELVES IN A UNIQUE
MOMENT WHERE THE STATE HAS THE
MEANS TO MAKE BOTH SHORT TERM
AND LONG TERM INVESTMENTS IN
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH AND
WELL BEING AND WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO THINK ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION TIMELINE FOR ALL
THE PROPOSAL'S IT'S REVIEWING.
WHEN WHERE AND HOW MUCH TO
INVEST. WE HAVE RECENTLY
INCREASED OUR OWN REQUEST FOR
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
HELP CHILDREN HOSPITALS
IMMEDIATELY INCREASE ACCESS TO
A RANGE OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN THE REGION. I HOPE
THE LEGISLATURE WILL CONSIDER
ARTS AND OTHER PROPOSALS THAT
HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO ADDRESS
THIS URGENT NEED. ITEM THREE
IS. TO REQUEST- FROM THE MHS
OHC ARE PROPOSED INVESTMENT IN
SHOVEL READY SCHOOL COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL PARTNERSHIP WHO
SUPPORT THAT INITIATIVE. AS
WELL. WE ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR I
INTEND WITHDRAWAL OF
SUSPENSION. FOR PROPERTY SIX UP
ON A PAYMENT. ITEM NINETEEN-
THE NEW TO LET BENEFIT AND ITEM
TWENTY THREE EXPANSION OF
COURSE PART OF MEDICAL COVERAGE
FOR TWELVE MONTHS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NECK WE GOT A LINE.
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THANK YOU CLAIRE RAMSEY ON
BEHALF OF JUSTICE IN AGING I
WANT TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENTS TO
pADULTS- AND REALLY SHOULD HAVE
THE DOWN PAYMENT ON OUR MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING WHICH IS A TEN
YEAR PLAN. I SPECIFICALLY WANT
TO SAY THAT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
ITEM THIRTEEN THE EXPANSION OF
MEDICARE TO OLDER ADULTS SIXTY
IN ABOUT AND WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE CHAIR FOR
THEIR LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
AND THINK WE CAN CONTINUE TO
MOVE THE AGE DOWN EVEN FURTHER
TO HELP. MORE OLDER ADULTS-
HAVE ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
HEALTHCARE ALSO WANNA- SHORT
SUPPORT FOR ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY
INVESTING IN THE GERIATRIC
WORKFORCE WHICH IS VITALLY
IMPORTANT OTHER STATE AGENCIES
I'M THERE ARE SEVERAL OTHER
PROPOSALS THAT THAT WE THINK
INVEST IN OLDER ADULTS WE
APPRECIATE THAT AND WE ALSO
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
ELIMINATE THE MEDIC HOW ASSET
TEST. THAT WILL FURTHER PARITY
AND EQUITY IN THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM AND INCREASE STABILITY
AND SIMPLICITY FOR OLDER ADULTS
WHO ARE NOT A CAL BENEFICIARIES
OR LOOKING TO BECOME ACCOUNT
BENEFICIARY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
YEAH SHOULD ALIGN THREE EIGHTY
FOR. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING AFTER TEARING MEMBERS
RONALD KOEMAN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC CAL.
YOU CAN SUPPORTS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND MEDICARE TO
UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS AGE SIXTY
PLUS WE THINK THE GOVERNOR AND
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD WORK
TOGETHER TO GO FURTHER AND
EXPAND COVERAGE TO ALL
UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS REGARDLESS
OF STATUS. WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS TO LIVE INCOME TOWARDS
AT AMERICA BENEFIT. THIS WILL
GO A LONG WAY IN SUPPORTING
COMMUNITY NEEDS AND PROVIDE
STEPS TOWARDS HEALTH EQUITY BY
ENSURING COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO
GET THE SERVICES. IN LANGUAGE
AND THAT ARE CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE WE NEED MORE
RESOURCES COULD BE ADDED HERE.
WE ALSO SUPPORT ENDING THE
PROPERTY SIX EXTENSION
CONNECTED WITH DENNIS CAL WE
WHILE WE SUPPORT THE CREATION
OF THE RESERVE FOR COVER
CALIFORNIA PORTABILITY FUNDS WE
WANT TO PRESERVE THE OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION ALREADY
ALLOCATED FOR AFFORDABILITY AND
TO CONTINUE TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS BY REDUCING COST
SHARING- THIS YEAR. HOWEVER WE
SHOULD POINT OUT THAT WE WERE
EXTREMELY DISAPPOINTED AT A
TIME WHERE HEALTH DISPARITIES
BY RACE HAVE BEEN MAGNIFIED THE
NEW SEVEN MINISTRATION FAILED
TO INVEST IN YOUR RESOURCES AND
RACIAL EQUITY WITHIN OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM OR FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH. WE SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA CAMPOLI PURPLE LOOK
BECAUSE OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE IS
IMPORTANT BUT WE ALSO URGE
LEGISLATORS TO FUND COMMUNITY
BASED PARTNERSHIPS THAT WILL
SPECIFICALLY FOCUS ON RACIAL
EQUITY. IN THE PARTNERSHIP WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
TO START TREATING RACISM AS A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS SO THAT
ALL COMMUNITIES CAN THRIVE WE
NEED TO FUND FOR RACIAL JUSTICE
INNOVATION THAT BROADLY TACKLE
HEALTHCARE DISPARITIES WE'VE
SEEN THE SUCCESS FROM SMALLER
INNOVATIVE PROJECTS
SPECIFICALLY BUT THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT
WHICH ALSO WASN'T FUNDED IN THE
REVISION. WE URGE THE ASSEMBLY
POINT AT SIXTY THREE MILLION TO
KEEP C. R. T. P. GOING FOR FOUR
MORE YEARS TO CONTINUE TO REAP
THE BENEFITS OF THE COMMUNITY
TO FIND EVIDENCE PRACTICES AND
REDUCING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES WE NOW STRONGLY
URGE THE ASSEMBLY TO FIND
RACIAL JUSTICE INNOVATION THAT
SEEKS TO USE THE COMMUNITY TO
FIND EVIDENCE PRACTICES TO
TACKLE RACISM. AND HEALTH CARE
BROADLY AND ALSO FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE EQUITY
FUND TO ENSURE OUR OUR LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
CAN PARTNER TO FOCUS ON
WIDESPREAD DISPARITIES TO
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO THE LINE
THREE SEVENTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING DOCTOR INLAND
NUMBERS TWENTY RENTAL TO
CALIFORNIA'S VISORS ON BEHALF
OF PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATE
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE ONE
ON TODAY'S AGENDA REGARDING THE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET REQUES. FOR ONGOING
FUNDING FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE
COBIT NINETEEN LAID BARE HOUSE
FAILING TO INVEST IN PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE PUTS LIVES AT
RISK. AND WORSENS HEALTH
DISPARITIES CALIFORNIA CAN'T
WAIT UNTIL THE NEXT CRISIS
STRIKES IMPACT IN PUBLIC HEALTH
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BUDGET YEAR THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MEXICO
LINE THREE FIFTY EIGHT I'M
SORRY. YES LINE THREE FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS REGINA BRENT AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF THE BLIND. I AM
TALKING ON BEHALF OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE BLIND AND HAVE LOW VISION.
THERE THE FIRST ONE IS STATE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THE INCREASE
FUNDING FOR OLDER ADULTS
HOWEVER UNDER- THE CURRENT
SYSTEM ONLY 3% OF OLDER ADULTS
WHO ARE BLIND OR HAVE LOW
VISION AND NEED REHABILITATIVE
SERVICES AFTER THEY LOSE THEIR
SITE OR WITH THEIR SITE
WORSENS. ARE GETTING THE HELP
THEY NEED AND THIS IS AN
EXTREMELY CONCERNED AS KELLY
MAKES BANDS. AND MEDIC COUNT
AND THERE ARE HOME BASED. THE
HEALTH SERVICES AVAILABLE WE
WOULD LIKE AN EXPLICIT-
RECTIFICATION THAT THE NEEDS OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE BLIND OR HAVE
LOW VISION WOULD BE MET UNDER
CAL AIMED ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE RECENTLY LOST THEIR
SITE AND CANNOT GO TO WORK
UNDER THOSE CONDITIONS UNTIL
THEY RECEIVED THREE. PATIENTS
ALSO. THE TELEHEALTH OPTION
UNDER AB THIRTY TWO WE ARE
ASKING THAT THAT BE FUNDED. AS
IT MIGHT BE OBVIOUS MANY PEOPLE
WHO ARE BLIND OR HAVE LOW
VISION WOULD RELY ON AN AUDIO
ONLY SYSTEM OF CARE. AND UNDER
FUNDING IT WOULD MEAN. THAT
THIS WOULD BE HARD TO OBTAIN.
SIMILARLY WITH DENTAL SERVICES
AND THEY END OF MANAGED CARE
THERE IT'S ALREADY HARD TO FIND
A DENTIST IT. THERE ARE
BARRIERS FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE
BLIND OR HAVE LOW VISION TO
EVEN. NAVIGATE THAT SYSTEM AND
DOING AWAY WITH THE MANAGED
CARE WE NORMALLY HURT OUR
COMMUNITIES AS WELL. THANK YOU%
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. YES TO ALIGN THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE ARE THAT
A CO SPONSOR AND THAT BUDGET
REQUEST FOR THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT
AND STRONGLY SUPPORT TO SIXTY
THREE POINT ONE BILLION FOR
THIS VERY- SUCCESSFUL
INNOVATIVE PROJECT THAT HELPS-
WITH MENTAL HEALTH DISPARITIES
IN OUR RACIAL ETHNIC AND LGBTQ
COMMUNITIES. IT IS- SORELY
NEEDED AND THIS IS A GREAT
PROJECT AND WE CANNOT LET IT
LAPSE I'M AT NEXT I WOULD LIKE
TO ALSO SUPPORT THE HEALTH CARE
FOR ALL UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS
AND AS OTHERS HAVE STATED- WE
WOULD LIKE THAT STILL FURTHER
TO ALL- I DOCUMENTED THAT DEL-
ALSO WANT TO ASSOCIATE MY
COMMENTS WOODLAND AWAY ON
COVERED CALIFORNIA TO PRESERVE
THE OVER SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION
ALREADY ALLOCATED FOR
AFFORDABILITY ASSISTANCE TO
CONTINUE TO HELP CALIFORNIANS.
BY REDUCING COST SHARING AND
PUTTING THAT IN A RESERVE IF IT
IS NOT FEASIBLE- I ALSO WANT TO
COMMENT ON THAT- UNDER OSP HAD
THE PROPOSAL FOR SCHOOL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COACHES AND
COUNSELORS- WHILE I DON'T
REALLY KNOW ALL THE DETAILS OF
THE PROPOSAL AND WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN GOING FURTHER I
DO WANT TO REMIND. THE
COMMITTEE THAT ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES NOW ARE CREDENTIALED
STAFF BETTER WORKING WITH
STUDENTS SUCH AS SCHOOL SOCIAL
WORKER SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS AND
SCHOOL COUNSELORS AND WE- BEAR
BEAR CAN HELP AND DO A LOT OF
THAT- IN BAGHDAD ITEMS THAT
WERE OUTLINED IN THIS NEW
PROPOSAL AND WE NEED TO FIND A
FULL STUDENT SUPPORT TEAM ON
CAMPUS. I ALSO WANT TO- I AGREE
WITH THE PEOPLE WHO TALK ABOUT
AUDIO ON ONLY SERVICES HAVING
PARITY AND REIMBURSEMENT IN
LINE WITH AB THIRTY TWO- AND I
THINK THAT'S IT FOR TONIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK. YOU MA'AM.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MEXICO I
THREE EIGHTEEN PLEASE AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS JUSTIN ROUTE ON BEHALF
OF THE FIRST FIVE LOCATION
WHICH REPRESENTS THE FIRST FIVE
COUNTY COMMISSIONS IN ALL FIFTY
COUNTY. WORKING ON THE ISSUE TO
REGARDING THE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIOR HEALTH
INITIATIVE. HOLISTIC AND ROBUST
INVESTMENT IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
IS VERY MUCH NEEDED AND WORKING
ALONGSIDE OTHER EARLY CHILDHOOD
MENTAL HEALTH PARTNERS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ONE
HUNDRED AND TWELVE MILLION OVER
THREE YEARS. TO EXPAND DIRECT
ACCESS TO EARLY CHILDHOOD
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS AND NON
CLINICAL SETTINGS INCLUDING
CHILD CARE HOMES AND COMMUNITY.
PRECIADO AFTER DAILY COMMENTS
EARLIER THIS AFTERNOON ABOUT
HAVING A MORE DETAILED
COMPUTATIONAL FIRST FIVE. ON
HOW THIS CRITICAL INITIATIVE
CAN SUPPORT. A METAL UP
APPEARANCE PEOPLE AND ADULTS IN
THEIR LIVES. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING ON THE DETAILS OF YOU
YOUR STAFF AND HHS ON THE
ISSUE. TWO INVESTMENT IN
HOLISTIC MULTI LAYERED ZERO TO
FIVE INVESTMENT. ADDITIONALLY
WE THINK THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
COMMITMENT. TO THE CREATION OF
THE DYADIC CARE AND DO A
BENEFIT AND TO ADVANCE. TWELVE
MONTHS OF CONTINUOUS POSTPARTUM
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE AND WE'RE
QUITE THE CHILDREN UP TO AGE
FIVE HAVE THE SAME CONTINUOUS
COVERAGE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT GO TO LINE THREE FORTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR- HAVE YOU
WOULD THINK MY COMMENTS
TONIGHT- MY NAME'S GOALBOUND
MIND THAT YOU'RE DIRECTOR FOR
GENDER SPECTRUM WHICH IS ONE OF
THE THIRTY FIVE AMAZING
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE PART OF
THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT- PUTS ON
WANT TO THANK DAHLE PERSONALLY
DOING PEOPLE BET THAT THIS IS A
LONG AND LABORIOUS PROCESS- AND
BACK I ALSO WANT TO ECHO. THE
CALL QUEUE- BOND- THE C. R. D.
P. PROJECT ONE MORE YEARS THE
ALLOCATION OF FIFTY THREE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS- IN ORDER
TO HELP YOU UNDERSTAND WHY THIS
PROJECT MATTER SO MUCH I WANT
TO TELL YOU VERY QUICKLY THE
STORY OF A YOUNG PERSON NAMED
ELLIOTT. A SENIOR AT A HIGH
SCHOOL IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
L. IT HAPPENS TO BE A
TRANSGENDER MAN MEANING HE WAS
APPLYING THE FACTS OF A YOU
KNOW ONE IS BORN BUT IT'S NOT
UP TO BE A GROWN WOMAN ALL OF
YOUR LIFE- THIS IS AN AMAZINGLY
CHARISMATIC YOUNG MAN WHO MOST
LIKELY BE JOINING SOME OF YOU
IN THE YEARS TO COME.
UNFORTUNATE PARK RALLY IT
THOUGH IS THAT HE GROWING UP IN
A HOUSEHOLD THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
NOT A BURNING OF HIS AUTHENTIC
GENDER AND THAT DATA IS VERY
CLEAR WHAT THE MENTAL HEALTH
OUTCOMES ARE LIKELY TO BE FOR
ALEX. AND YET HE IS CONQUERING
ALL OF THAT DATA THE REASON AN
INCREDIBLY SUPPORTIVE SCHOOL
COMMUNITY THAT HE HAVE ALL A
CART OF A PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT SESSION WE LET
SPOKE TO THE IMPACT THAT THE
EDUCATORS WHO ARE SUPPORTING
HIM HAVE HAD ENCOUNTERING THE
NEGATIVE HOME LIFE- THAT YOU'VE
EXPERIENCED STATE. JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF THE THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THIS INCREDIBLE
UNPRECEDENTED PROJECT THAT IS
DEALING WITH. THE MENTAL HEALTH
UTILIZING COMMUNITY BASED
SOLUTIONS WE ARE ALSO
EVALUATING THE IMPACT OF THAT
WORK AND DEMONSTRATING THAT IN
FACT WE ARE MAKING. A HUGE
DIFFERENCE I'M SAD AB THAT THE
GOVERNOR. NOT TO. I'M ANY UP
FOR. NEW WIL TO EVERYBODY- AND
THESE THE- BUT I TO STRONGLY.
YOU PLEASE. SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED SIXTY THREE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING FOR
THE NEXT FOUR YEARS ONE TIME
FUNDING AND FINALLY I WANT TO
THANK DR ARAMBULA. FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN THIS CRITICAL
PROJECT THANK YOU AND HAVE A
GREAT NIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. MEXICO LINE
THREE EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS ERICA JOHN SENIOR RESEARCHER
WITH SPECIAL SERVICE FOR GROUPS
AND LOS ANGELES. I AM PART OF
THE ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDER
TEAM FOR THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT
WITH YOUR D. P. I'M OFFERING
COMMENTS SUPPORTED THE PROPOSAL
FOR SIXTY THREE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING TO SUSTAIN AND EXPAND.
FOR FOUR MORE YEARS. THIRTY UP
LESS UNSERVED. COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN NEGATIVELY IMPACTED
IN MULTIPLE WAYS BY THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THE THIRTY
P. NETWORK A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION THIRTY FIVE ME
CONNECTED AND COMMUTERS BY
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS FOCUSED
ON PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION ACROSS FIVE
DIVERSE POPULATION. HAS BEEN
WORKING NONSTOP DURING THE
PANDEMIC HAS ROUGHLY
COMMUNITIES BARRIERS AND MEET
THEIR NEEDS. BUT CONTINUED
INVESTMENT NECESSARY TO SUPPORT
THE COMMUNITY. HE WAS LEFT OUT
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE AND
SO WE ARE SO CLOSELY THE
LEGISLATURE TO INSURANCE
REQUESTED IN THE FINAL BUDGET.
SO THAT THE COMMUNITIES WE
SERVE PUBLIC SERVICES THEY NEED.
TO TRULY ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A
PLAN TO CREATE A HEALTHIER
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL. IS
IMPERATIVE TO FUND THE PURITY
FOR FOUGHT. FOR FOUR MORE YEARS
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
MA'AM. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
MEXICO LINE THREE SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BEGINNING THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION I WILL
BE SENDING LETTERS AND I THINK
MAYBE THERE COULD NOT BE PART
IN SPECIFIC RELATIONSHIP THE
NAY REVISED AS WELL AS WHERE
WITH THE ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO INVEST IN
ALZHEIMER'S SPECIFIC PROGRAMS
WHICH ARE REFLECTED IN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NIGERIAN ALZHEIMER'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL BUT WE ARE SO
APPRECIATIVE AND SUPPORTIVE OF
THE ADMINISTRATION
UNPRECEDENTED PACKAGE OF
ALZHEIMER'S SPECIFIC PROPOSALS
THE DATE MARKING IN SUPPORT OF
THE FOLLOWING ITEM. ITEM EIGHT
GERIATRIC CARE WORKFORCE
PROGRAM ITEM THIRTEEN EXPANDING
MEDICAID HEALTH PLAN DOCUMENT
ADULTS AGED SIXTY AND OVER AN
ITEM TWENTY NINE EXPANDING THE
FUNDING FOR ALZHEIMER'S PUBLIC
HEALTH PROGRAMMATIC MANDATE
TAKEN TOGETHER THESE HELP
ADVANCE THE IMPORTANT WORK THAT
HAD BEEN DONE BACK HERE IN THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING- ARE
EXTREMELY VALUABLE TODAY COMING
UP FOR THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT
FOR THESE PROPOSALS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT TO THE LINE THREE TWO SO.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO WELL- MY
NAME IS MARATHON UNION WITHIN
ONE EQUITY PARTNERSHIP ALSO
PART OF THE HEALTH FOR ALL
COALITION AND I WANTED TO I
THANK THE GOVERNOR AND THE
CHAIR. ASSEMBLY AND IS A MEMBER
ARAMBULA SENATOR ALSO TO
CONTINUE PUSHING HELP FOR ALL
AND I WANTED TO CONTINUE
PUSHING TO MAKE SURE THAT IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND INDEPENDENT.
THAT WE DO INCLUDE HEALTHCARE
ALL ELDERS WE FEEL THAT WE'RE
ALL CALIFORNIANS AND IF WE SAY
THERE WERE CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
NO MATTER IMMIGRATION OR CLASS
OF REACH THE THINK THAT
EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE HEALTH
CARE AND COVER NINETEEN REALLY
SHOWED US THAT THE SENSE OF
URGENCY THAT WE NEED TO HAVE A
STRONG. HEALTHCARE
INFRASTRUCTURE- IT REALLY
EXASPERATED CANNOT IN EQUITY
AND WE ARE LIVING IN A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS- AND SO IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT IN THE MIDST OF.
IT IS THAT ACADEMIC. OUR MOST
VULNERABLE ARE WITH SO IN DA.
SENIORS ATTEMPT THAT YOU KNOW
AS THE PUSH FOR IMMIGRATION
REFORM WE'RE ALWAYS GONNA SHE
SAID. DIFFERENT YOU KNOW
CLASSES OF PEOPLE AND SO IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT IF WE'RE GOING%
TO BE. AT CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
NOT EVERYBODY GETS HEALTHCARE
AND FOR US YOU KNOW THERE ARE A
WAY NOT SURE WHEN HE DOES IT'S
A FAIR AMOUNT OF TIME TO. GET
YOUR OF THEM AS WELL. PAGE NOT
DAVID ACCENTUATED TO THE
ECONOMY. THREE POINT SEVEN
BILLION IN STATE AND LOCAL
TAXES. SEVEN BILLION IN FEDERAL
TAXES. SO THERE CONTRIBUTE TO
OUR SOCIETY TO OUR COMMUNITY.
AND NOT ONLY DO WE WANT INVEST
SOME HELP ALL ELDERS. YOU KNOW
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT ARE
ALSO. LEADERSHIP BUT IT WAS THE
BEST I STAND WITH A FAMILY
MEMBER ARAMBULA. THAT WE COULD
CHANGE THE JOB ON HEALTH FOR
ALL SO INCLUDE OLDER ADULTS- SO
PLEASE- LET'S CONTINUE DOING
THIS WORK. AND MOST INCLUDES
HELP FOR OUR ELDERS AND THEN
HOW FOR ALL. ADULTS AS WELL IN
THE BUDGET AND THE AND LONG
TERM INVESTMENTS WE WANT TO SEE
NOT JUST NE TIME. BUDGET ITEMS
THANKS SO MUCH. THANK YOU
MA'AM. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NATIONAL THREE EIGHTY. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU I EVENING I
FELT AFTER WORKING AT A THE
LAST THAT MEMBERS I THINK IT'S
A LEAST GET BANK IN I'M PROGRAM
COORDINATOR WITH COMMITTED
HEALTH. A CONSORTIUM OF TEN
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTERS AND COMMUNITY CLINICS
IN SANTA CLARA AND SAN MATEO
COUNTY I AM SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER EVAN LOW
MEDI MEDI NAVIGATOR BUDGET
REQUEST TO A FIFTY LOW INCOME
SENIORS ACCESS HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. EACH DAY AS I SPEAK
WITH COMMUNITY MEMBERS OFTEN
COMMITMENTS PRIMARILY SPANISH
SPEAKERS ARE SENIORS THAT FINE
INVOLVING AND MEDICARE MEDI CAL
OR OTHER HEALTH COVERAGE
PROGRAMS ARE NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE.
MOST OF THEM REQUIRE ONE ON ONE
ASSISTANCE DUE TO LANGUAGE
BARRIER IMMIGRATIONSTATUS
POVERTY LACK OF TRANSPORTATION
OR A LACK OF TRUST IN OUR
GOVERNMENT WHICH MAKE IT
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
APPLY. THOSE SELECTED STRUGGLE
ALONE DON'T COMPLETE THEIR
APPLICATIONS AND EVENTUALLY GET
THAT BY FINDING THE MEDI MEDI
NAVIGATOR BUDGET PROPOSAL
CALIFORNIA'S INVESTMENT WILL BE
RETURNED MANY TIMES OVER BY
ENSURING THAT ARE VULNERABLE
SENIORS GET ENROLLED IN HEALTH
PLANS TO KEEP THEM FROM ENDING
UP IN THE EMERGENCY ROOM.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOS PROPOSAL
MAKES SENSE I THINK EARLY IN
FINANCIALLY THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR TIME THIS EVENING. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT WE GET A LINE THREE EIGHTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING CARE ACT MANY MEN MY IS
FOR THE TESTING WITH THIS ACT
HEALTH- AND WE SUPPORT CAL
HEALTH AND THE PROPOSE AROUND
AUDIO HOW THE HELL AND WE FEEL
IT WOULD EXPAND ACCESS TO
SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE SERVICES WE ALSO BUNDLE OF
COMMENTS ABOUT THE NEED TO
STRENGTHEN OUR STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ADDRESS OUR OTHER PRESSING
PUBLIC HEALTH NEEDS TO HAVE
BEEN DEFERRED AND WILL CONTINUE
TO GET WORSE AND ARE COMPOUNDED
BY COALBED. THE CHRONIC
UNDERFUNDING OF PUBLIC HEALTH
IS BEST ILLUSTRATED BY THE
RAPID RISE OF SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS THAT
WERE ALREADY SKYROCKETING IT
COULD CRISIS LEVEL PRIOR TO
COLD ED IN APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS WERE LIVING WITH
DIFFERENCE CHLAMYDIA OR
GONORRHEA INFECTIONS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AND IT'S ESTIMATED AT
THE CURRENT NUMBERS. ARE MUCH
HIGHER BUT THE CONSTANT ACTION
IS FAR TOO GREAT TO CONTINUE
IGNORING AND ALTHOUGH IT SEEMS
ALL COMMITTEES ACROSS THE STATE
ARE AFFECTED BY THIS CRISIS
IT'S THE PARTICULARLY
CALIFORNIA YOU- BLACK
INDIGENOUS AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND LGBT COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED.
THIS IS A SOCIAL JUSTICE PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUE THAT MUST BE
ADDRESSED IMMEDIATELY AND NOT
WAIT UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO
WE ARE THE LEGISLATURE TO KEEP
THIS IN MIND WHILE AFFECTING
THE STATE BUDGET WE APPRECIATE
ALL OF YOUR WORK TODAY AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH YOU ALL THANK YOU.
THANK. YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND NEXT TO THE LINE
THREE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU NINETEEN AS
THE LINE NAY- I AM PART OF A P.
R. D. P. AND SHE CAN'T BE MY
ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE. AND
NAME OUR PROGRAM IS THEY TRIED
PROGRAM JENNY INTO BILLION
SUPPORT THE PANICKING AND I'M
SUPPORTING A ONE TIME-
EXTENSION OF THE I. D. E. N. I
WANT TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR THAT
WITHOUT THIS EXTENSION MORE
THAN. EIGHTY DOWN PAYMENT- A
YOUNG MAN AND YET ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR OUR SERVICES WILL NOT BE
DETAILS IT HAS BEEN L. A.
COUNTY AND THAT IS TRUE FOR TWO
REASONS FIRST OF ALL THE L. A.
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL
HEALTH IS NOT CONTRACT.
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE OURS THAT
ARE NOT ABLE TO BILL MEDICAID
AND THAT DON'T PROVIDE- A
COMPLETE ARRAY OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IS DEPOSED AGAINST
PREVENTION AND INTERVENTION AND
THE SECOND REASON IS THAT A
GOOD AGENCIES THAT DO GET THEIR
FUNDING DO NOT HAVE CULTURALLY
COMPETENT. WHICH IS FINDING L.
A. COUNTY AS MORE- AMANDA OF
THE LINGUISTICS AND DON'T HAVE
CULTURAL COMPETENCE PAYER P. SO
WHAT WE HAVE INTRODUCED IS HELD
I FELT IN HIP HOP HE'LL- GET
POPULAR THERE'S A. TRAUMA
PROGRAM. I THANK YOU THE SONG.
AND MUSIC PRODUCTION FEEL
ADDRESS HEALING. AND HAVE A
COMMON- PARTNER WITH A BRAND
NEW YEAR OF WAR WINNING-
PRODUCE. TO- PRODUCE SONG THAT
TALKS THE TRAUMA OF YOUNG
PEOPLE AND THEN PUT THEM ON. NO
THANKS CAL PLEASED PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN OPPORTUNITY IN THE SAME
SPACE. TO LOOK AT THEIR- YEAH
APPEALING THEIR EMOTIONS YOUR
FUTURE AND THE WAY IN WHICH
THEY THINK. AND WE ARE NOW AT
THE CONCLUSION OF OUR EVIDENCE
BASED EVALUATION ABOUT THE
QUANTITATIVE AND THE
QUALITATIVE DATA SHOW THAT
THERE IS. SHOW THAT OUR PROGRAM
IS EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL WE HAVE
HAD HUNDREDS OF YOUNG PEOPLE TO
COME TO OUR PROGRAM WE FIND IT
ALMOST HALF SHOWS SIGNS OF
CLINICAL DEPRESSION. MORE THAN
A THIRD SHOW SIGNS OF P. G. CAL.
SYMPTOMS OF PTSD. YES WITH THE
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT WE ON GOING
TO SEE- HEALTH SERVICES BEYOND
PROBATION OR THE OF INTO NOT
ONLY IS EIGHTY THOUSAND L. BUT
THE AUGUST YOUTH WOULD YOU
HUNDRED OF THAT OF PEOPLE IN L.
A. COUNTY THIS IS A MENTAL
HEALTH INTERVENTION DAN IS
GOING TO BE ABLE TO CHANGE THE
LIVES OF PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT
GOING TO SIT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO ANY KIND OF
TRADITIONAL- HE- THE YOUNG
PEOPLE TO COME TO OUR PROGRAM
SAY THEY ARE NOW CRITICAL
THINKER IF THEY CAN MANAGE
THEIR EMOTIONS THAT THEY KNOW
HOW. TO HANDLE SITUATIONS
DIFFERENTLY. SO THERE'S A LOT
TOP OF BLACK LIVES. AND
ADDRESSING STRUCTURAL RACISM.
IF THIS IS EXTENDED. AND
STRUCTURAL RACISM WILL BE- WILL
WILL BE ADDRESSED BECAUSE IT'S
NOT ADDRESS TO OUR COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM AND IT'S
NOT GOING TO BE A GUEST ELECT
COUNTY HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM. AND IT DID EXTENDED.
AND THE BELIEFS OF OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT THEIR LIVES DO NOT
MATTER BECAUSE BLACK LIVES DO
NOT MATTER WILL BE A FIRM. AND
WE ASK THAT YOU DO NOT AT THE
END OF THE BALLOT TO GET THEIR
LIVES DON'T MATTER. BECAUSE TO
A STATE MATTER VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ACTUALLY THREE
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS DR GERE
JONG I'M AN AUTHOR OF A BOOK
ABOUT THE REFUGEE EXPERIENCE IN
AMERICA AND ALSO THE DIRECTOR
OF A MENTAL HEALTH AGENCY THAT
PROVIDES CULTURALLY LINGUISTIC
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO
UNDERSERVED. CANNOT COMMUNITY
IN TRAINSPOTTING GO BY COACH
MAY HELP CLINICIANS FOR THE
LAST TEN YEARS I WANT TO SAY
BECAUSE OF THIS CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DESPAIR PROJECT WE A
PRESENT A LABEL TO CREATE A
COMMUNITY FIND EVIDENCE
PRACTICE CALLED THE MOST
HELPFUL HINTS THAT HAVE SAVED A
HUNDRED FOURTEEN SONGS. THIS IS
JUST ONE- CRT P. IN CALIFORNIA
AND THERE ARE THIRTY FIVE
OTHERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE
ARE OFTEN TOLD ME IN BAKER
ANALYSIS WATER SO. INVADE ARE
JUST BUDGET HAS GAME SUPPORT
FROM THE MHS WELL EIGHTY HAS
WALL HAD THE ALL- HE ADVISED
REMEMBER MANY OTHERS DROP THIS.
SUPPLEMENT DESK WE BY PRESSURE
FAIRNESS AND PRONE. TO HELP THE
POOR THE UNDERSERVED YOU CAN
ALSO IN THIS BEAUTIFUL STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I CALL UPON EACH OF
YOU TO HELP US TO JOIN THEY SAY
ME MORSELS AND I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS ONE TIME SIXTY
THREE MILLION THIRTY P. ON TO
THE GOVERNOR'S REVISED BUDGET.
THANK YOU AND HAVE A WONDERFUL
EVENING. THANK YOU SR JUST AS
A REMINDER WERE ROUGHLY WERE
OVER AN HOUR AND A PUBLIC
COMMENT AND WE HAVE FORTY
PEOPLE STILL IN QUEUE TO MAKE
COMMENT. OPERATOR NEXT CALL
PLEASE. NEXT CALL COME ARE
COMING COUNTRY ONE THREE C.
PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD EVENING AND
THANK YOU OF. DR ABDULLAH AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
DANIEL TOLERANCE AND I
CURRENTLY SERVE AS THE- PROJECT
DIRECTOR FOR THE LGBT Q.
TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- FUNDED THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT I WON A FIRM IN THE
KNOWLEDGE OF THE MANY PARTNERS-
THAT. STOOD UP AND SUPPORTED
THE R. D. P. ONE TIME AFTER
SIXTY THREE POINT ONE MILLION
IN WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT IT
STATE. ON THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
THEN. THANK YOU AGAIN A DOCTOR
ARAMBULA CHAMPIONING CAUSE AND
WE HOPE THAT THEY DON'T GO TO
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET. PROCESS
THANKS AGAIN THANK YOU SIR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. MEXICO LINE
THREE SIXTY TWO GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING ALL THANK YOU CHAIR DR
ARAMBULA FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
AND LEADERSHIP MOST ESPECIALLY
AS IT PERTAINS TO COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR AND ADDRESSING THEIR
EXACERBATED HEALTH INEQUITIES
AS A RESULT OF MULTIPLE
PANDEMICS OVER THE LAST YEAR.
AND DEEP APPRECIATION TO DR
RADHAKRISHNAN OF THE DIRECTOR
OF THE OFFICE OF HEALTH EUITY
AT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH FOR YOUR OPENING
REMARKS IT'LL TO SPECIALLY THAT
CALIFORNIANS OF ALL AGES HAVE
EQUAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR HEALTH
AND WELL BEING WITH A SPECIFIC
RACIAL EQUITY LINE AS WELL AS
THE DEEP VALUING OF PREVENTION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION AND- I
AM DOCTOR NINA. MARINO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT I AM ONE OF. THIRTY
FIVE LOCAL EVALUATORS WITH THE
PROJECT AND SPECIFIC I AM THE
LOCAL YOU DIAL YOUR WAITER OF
THE STATE'S POWER OF COACH
MODEL. AND THEY ARE WHY OF ACT
AMERICAN AND- PRO. I HAD BEEN
DOING HEALTH THE VALUE OF WERE
FOR APPROX TWO FIVE YEARS. NOT
ONLY UP CAL AND NEW YORK
LEGISLATIVE LEVEL BUT ALSO AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND I CAN SAY
THAT I HAVE NEVER. WORKED WITH
A MORE ROBUST BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
MODEL THAN THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT I
WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
SOME OF THE FORMER PUBLIC
SPEAKERS. I WAS DISAPPOINTED TO
LEARN THAT THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE DID NOT INCLUDE ANY NEW
INVESTMENTS WERE RACIAL EQUITY
WORK FOR OUR STRUGGLING PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEM. ONE WAY TO
RECTIFY THIS IS TO LEVERAGE THE
CURRENT INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CAPACITY OF THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT
ADMINISTERED THROUGH THE OFFICE
OF HEALTH EQUITY AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. I INCLUDING SIXTY THREE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME FUNDING FROM THE
SURPLUS OF THE GENERAL FUND OR
ANY OTHER STATE BUDGET FOR THIS
YEAR IN CALIFORNIA FINAL.
SCHOOL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET I STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO ADVOCATE FOR THE
AND VOTE FOR THIS THE STATE
MUST MAKE A COMMITMENT TO
SUPPORT COMMUNITY TO FIND
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES TO
REDUCE DISPARITIES.
INTERGENERATIONAL MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES WILL REMAIN
INTRACTABLE WITHOUT A SUSTAINED
AND AGGRESSIVE LEVEL OF STATE
INVESTMENT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT SHOULD GO
BEYOND PHASE TWO FUNDING OF THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT IT MUST ADDRESS THE NEW
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS RESULTING
FROM COLD AT NINETEEN. WE WILL
NOT REDUCE DISPARITIES AS WE
CONTINUE TO FUND THE SAME
STRATEGIES WE MUST DO THINGS
DIFFERENTLY IF WE WANT TO
PRODUCE DIFFERENT RESULTS.
THANK YOU THANK. YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. TO GO TO LINE
TWO FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS AKASH OTHER
CUNNINGHAM ACADIA AFTER TENNIS
AS WELL AS A DENTAL
ANESTHESIOLOGIST OPERATIVE
DENTAL OFFICE IN SACRAMENTO
THAT'S THEIR THEIR PROXIMITY
15220% OF THE MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES IN THE AREA GREAT
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE SPECIAL
NEEDS CHILDREN. AND ADULTS OUR
OFFICE EMPLOYS FIFTEEN DENTISTS
AND DENTAL SPECIALISTS AT
SEVENTEEN EMPLOYEES I AM IF NOT
THE ONLY OFFICE AMONG VERY FEW
THE OFFICES IN THE AREA THAT
HAD THIS MANY TALENTED DENTISTS
AND DENTAL SPECIALISTS AT THE
SAME LOCATION. WE ALSO SPEAK
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES FLUENTLY AND
HAVE MANY IMMIGRANTS MEDICAID
REQUESTING OUR OFFICE THROUGH
THE INSURANCE COMPANY LIBERTY
DENTAL. TRANSITION THIS
MEDICARE POPULATION INTO
DEMOCRAT FEE FOR SERVICE IS A
MASSIVE MISTAKE. I'VE BEEN A
KID WHO'S NEVER BEEN A PROGRAM
THAT CAN DELIVER AND HAS HAD
THE SAME ISSUES WITH LIMITED
ACCESS TO PEDIATRIC AND GENERAL
DENTAL CARE FOR EVER AND IN
EXCHANGE. IS FULL OF FRAUD
WASTE AND ABUSE. NOT TO MENTION
THE PROGRAM PERCENT ON POOR
MANAGEMENT OF CLIENTS THAT NEED
TO BE PAID. I KNOW FOR A FACT
THAT YOU WOULD NOT SAVE MONEY
FOR THE STATE INDONESIA YOU
SAID YOU WOULD HARM OUR
PATIENTS IF YOU ELIMINATE THIS
PROGRAM. I'M SAD BUT DETERMINED
TO TELL THAT IF MY TEAM. AND I
WILL CLOSE OUR OPERATION IN
SACRAMENTO IF THE GNC PROGRAM
IS ELIMINATED. AS WE WILL NOT
AND CANNOT FUNCTION IN THE FEE
FOR SERVICE ENVIRONMENT. AS I
MENTIONED MY OFFICE HAD JUST
15220% OF THIS POPULATION. THIS
WILL MAKE THE UNDERSUPPLY
POSITION BACK IN PROPER CARE
AND ACCESS TO SERVICE. YOUR
CONSIDERATION IN THIS MATTER IS
VERY IMPORTANT. AND CRUCIAL TO
MY TEAM AND I. I AS WELL AS
THIS POPULATION WITH THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PROPER DECISIONS BY
NOT ADMITTING. GMC PROGRAM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THAT'S A LITTLE
LINE FIFTY FIVE GO AHEAD. OKAY
GOOD EVENING. THANK YOU SHARE
AND MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO YOU. I'M PHILIP
CLARK AND I'M THE FOUNDER AND
CEO OF THE HEALTHY HERITAGE
MOVEMENT BASED IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE WE'RE ONE OF THIRTY FIVE
CULTURALLY RELEVANT PROGRAMS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT WHICH IS
VERY VERY SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE
THE AIR CULTURALLY RELEVANT. I
PROGRAM ADDRESSES MENTAL HEALTH
AWARENESS ISSUES BASED IN THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN FAITH BASED
COMMUNITY IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
AND OUR FAITH BASED PROGRAM HAS
EDUCATED OVER TWO HUNDRED BLACK
WOMEN ABOUT THE NEEDS FOR
MENTAL HEALTH AWARENESS TO
REDUCE STIGMA. SO THAT. ARE
CALLED TO. STILL COMFORTABLE
GOING TO SEEK HELP. WE SUPPORT.
UNPRECEDENTED HISTORIC ACROSS
THE POPULATION PROGRAM AND
PERFECT AND WE WANT TO ASK THAT
YEAH SUPPORT THIS SIXTY THREE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME FUNDING FOR THE
SURPLUS. FROM THE GENERAL. AND
WE'RE ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO ALIGN
THREE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING THIS IS A
TIME WHEN TRUMP PLATINUM
ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF LIBERTY
DENTAL PLAN ONE OF THE STATE'S
CONTRACTED PLANS IN SACRAMENTO
AND LOS ANGELES COUNTIES. AND
WE'RE CALLING TO OPPOSE THE
PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE DENTAL
MANAGED CARE- ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR JUST A FEW QUICK
OBSERVATIONS ABOUT THE PROPOSAL
ONE IS WE NOTE THAT THE DATA
APPEARS TO BE FLAWED- COMPARING
UTILIZATION ACROSS THE FOR
SERVICE IN DMC IS NOT COMPARING
LIKE DATASETS. AND CONSEQUENTLY
MAKING COMPARISONS USING
DISSIMILAR ENCOUNTER DATA
MISREPRESENTS THE DATA AND
LEADS TO FLAWED CONCLUSIONS.
SECONDLY WE KNOW THAT IF THE
DENTAL MANAGED CARE ELIMINATED
IN SACRAMENTO BENEFICIARIES
WILL SUFFER. WE'LL SEE PROGRAMS
LIKE THE EARLY SMILE SACRAMENTO
PROGRAM THAT HAS GENERATED
SIXTY THOUSAND SCHOOL BASE
VISITS. AND FIFTY THOUSAND
VARNISHES AND NAVIGATION GOES
AWAY AS DO OTHER CRITICAL
PROGRAMS IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
LIBERTY DENTAL IS PREPARED TO
PARTICIPATE MCALENN PROCESS BUT
CAN'T. FOR ELIMINATED MUST
ONLINE FIFTEEN YEARS OF DENTAL
MANAGED CARE ACTIVITY. LASTLY
WILL NOTE WE APPRECIATE THE
ANALYSIS POINTING OUT THAT ONE
OPTION MOVING FORWARD WOULD BE
FOR DH CS TO RE PROCURE THE
CONTRACT IN SACRAMENTO LOS
ANGELES- THAT'S THE PATH WE
THOUGHT WE WERE HEADED DOWN THE
DEPARTMENT AS RECENTLY AS ONE
OF ROUGHLY NINETY DAYS AGO-
SAID THEY'D BE RE PROCURING THE
CONTRACTS IN OUR OF P. WOULD BE
RELEASED THIS SUMMER- AND WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO
PARTICIPATING IN THAT PROCESS.
FOR THESE REASONS WERE OPPOSED
TO THE PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE
THE MANAGED CARE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT HEADLINE THREE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
SHARON MEMBERS OF ROB BLAME AT
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES THAT MAYBE THIS AND
BRINGS EXCITING POSSIBILITIES
FOR BEHAVIOR HEALTH AND WE
APPRECIATE THE SPIRIT OF THE
PROPOSALS RELATED TO EARLY
DETECTION OF COMMA WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT EXPEDIENT HAPPENS
THE R. T. P. INVESTMENT AND HOW
MUCH THAT THE SCHOOL
PARTNERSHIPS. ARE PROVIDERS
LOOK FORWARD TO REVEALING THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE BUT ARE
GENERALLY SUPPORT OF ALL OF
THESE ITEMS LASTLY WE SUPPORT
COMMENTS MADE BY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS EARLIER ABOUT REQUIRING
BETTER OVERSIGHT FOR BEHAVIOR
HEALTH PROGRAMS AND REALIGNING
THE DOLLARS CLOSER TOWARDS
COMMUNITY PROGRAMMING. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. SIX THE LINE THREE
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
JACQUELINE TRAN AND I AM- KEY
MEMBER OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDER TEAM OF CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT I
WANT TO BE BRIEF BECAUSE
THERE'S A LONG QUEUE AND JUST
ACKNOWLEDGE ALL OF THE
COMMENTS- AND SENTIMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN SHARED BY MY-
COLLEAGUES AND COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. AND ECHO OUR SUPPORT
OF THE PROPOSED SIXTY THREE
POINT ONE MILLION IN ONE TIME
FUNDING FROM THE SURPLUS OF THE
GENERAL FUND THIS ONE TIME
FUNDING WHICH EXTENDS HERE TO
PEOPLE FOR ADDITIONAL YEARS I
HOPE THAT THE CHAIRMAN AND THE
FAMILY MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE WILL CONSIDER THAT-
RECOMMENDATION AND APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME AND OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THIS
EVENING THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
TO GO TO LINE. EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS LUCY QUESTION NOW-
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF MATERNAL
AND CHILD HEALTH ACCIDENTS- WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN EXTENDING
MEDICAID OKAY THEN DOCUMENTED
TO OLDER ADULTS. MANY OF THE UP
WELL AS A NUMBER AT LEAST THOSE
WHO ARE AT THE FAMILIES THAT WE
SERVE THEIR CHARACTER GIVERS-
THIS WILL BE A GREAT BENEFIT TO
FAMILIES- WE ALSO STRONGLY
SUPPORT AYE NUMBER TWENTY THREE
WHICH EXTENDS POST PART IN
MEDICAL COVERAGE- FOR TWELVE
MONTHS THIS WILL BE A
TREMENDOUS ASSISTANCE TO THE
THOUSANDS OF WOMEN AND IN TIPS
THAT WE SERVE EVERY YEAR.
INCLUDING THROUGH OUR HOME
VISITATION PROGRAM- BUT WE
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO CALL THE
COMMITTEE'S ATTENTION TO THE
FACT THAT STARTING POSSIBLY AS
EARLY AS JANUARY ONE- PEOPLE
COULD START LOSING THEIR
MEDICARE ONE THE STATE STARTS
TO REVIEW CASES AFTER THE END
OF THE PANDEMIC. AND IT WOULD
BE TRAGIC REALLY EATS HER POST
PART INDIVIDUALS IN THAT SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME- TO LOSE THEIR
COVERAGE SO WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT- WITHIN THE
MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY IS ALLOWED
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES. THAT
POSTCARD IMAGES OF CONTINUE
THEIR MEDIC CAL- WE ALSO ASK
THAT THE CHILDREN UNDER AGE
FIVE BE ABLE TO CONTINUE DURING
THIS PERIOD AFTER THE
MORATORIUM ON DISCONTINUANCE
IS- FRESNO MODESTO NEWSPAPERS
RECENTLY SECRETARY POWERFUL
ARGUMENTS ABOUT THIS. IT'S AN
ISSUE THAT'S IMPORTANT STATE
WHY DID SUCH IMPORTANT AGE FOR
DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENINGS
IMMUNIZATIONS THE RECENT AUDIT
SHOWS THAT OUR MEDICAL PROGRAM
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S DOING A VERY
POOR JOB WITH PREVENTIVE CARE.
THESE YOUNG CHILDREN IN BREAKS
IN COVERAGE AT THIS EARLY AGE.
INTERFERE WITH THE SALUTE TO
IT'S TO OUR RATE OF TO THE
PRINTER CARE. LASTLY LEADING
FALL OFF COME. WILL BE IN. MAX
UNDER. THE MEN IMPORT. TO IN
THE ACES- THAT WERE PRESENTED
EARLIER THIS EVENING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR ATTENTION.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO ALIGN THREE
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
JERRY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
NOT AVAILABLE AT THE LATINO
COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA I WILL BE COMMENTING
ON SEVERAL CRITICAL HEALTH
EQUITY ITEMS FIRST THANK YOU
DOCTOR ADAM LOCKYER INCREDIBLE
LEADERSHIP TO HELP ACCESS AND
HEALTH EQUITY I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT TO EXPAND
MEDICARE FOR ALL ADULTS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS- NEXT WE WANT TO VOICE
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO FIND RACIAL
JUSTICE AND HEALTH EQUITY
PROPOSAL. SUCH AS THE RACIAL
JUSTICE INNOVATION FUND AND THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH EQUITY FUND
THAT WILL FUND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION AS WELL AS LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO ADDRESS
THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH TO CRITICALLY IMPROVE
THE HEALTH OUTCOMES OF CREATIVE
COLORS. AND LASTLY OF EACH YEAR
THE PROPS ONE PAIR OF THE UCLA
I NG BUDGET REQUEST AND AGAIN
WANT TO THANK DR ARAMBULA FOR
CAMPING AT THE POINTS PROGRAM
THE I. N. G. TAP INTO EXISTING
RESOURCES RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND WHAT'S ALL THE
POSITION WORKFORCE SHORTAGE AS
WELL AS INCREASE THE CAPACITY
TO PROVIDE CARE IN LANGUAGE AND
IN CULTURE. FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS SPECIFICALLY FOR
MONOLINGUAL SPANISH SPEAKING
POPULATIONS- WE RECOGNIZE THAT
ACCIDENTS UP TO BUT RAISING THE
INTEREST OF ONE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AT THAT ADDRESSES THE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE OF
HEALTHCARE AND HOPE MEMBER CAN
SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM WHEN
APPROPRIATE TO INCREASE HEALTH
EQUITY THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK.
YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
YES THE LINE THREE NINE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME'S OFFICERS LAW
TIME THE GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
SENIOR MANAGER FOR THE LATINO
COALITION FOR A HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
A CALIFORNIA HEALTH EQUITY FUND
TO THROUGH THE PASSED THE
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN THIRTY EIGHT.
IT'S TIME OUR STATE TAKES A
PROACTIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING HEALTH DISPARITIES
FOR HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES WE ALSO CALL FOR
THE ALLOCATION OF THREE POINT
TWO POINT SEVEN TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE INTERNATIONAL
MEDICAL GRADUATE PROGRAM AT
UCLA. YOU QUICKLY RE CERTIFIED
MEDICAL PERSONNEL FROM FOREIGN
COUNTRIES IN OUR STATE AND THE
MATERIALS OF QUITE HIGH NEED.
THERE ARE TOO MANY AREAS THAT
ARE NOT CULTURALLY ADAPTABLE TO
POPULATIONS THAT LIVE IN THEM
AND WE- ARE GOING TO TAKE A
PROACTIVE APPROACH TO
HEALTHCARE WE NEED TO DO THAT
BY PROVIDING THE RIGHT PERSON
NOW. THANK YOU ABOUT PERSONAL
THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AUDIBLE UPPER CHAMPIONING THE
FACT. HAVE AGREEMENT. THANK YOU
SIR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MEXICO
LINE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. EVERYONE ON BECAUSE OF
BAD DUCT WORK ON THE PART HI
I'M GOOD PROJECTED BOTH
TECHNICALLY TO CREATE I AM- I
WANT TO SPEAK ON ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR TO FORTY- DID
MANAGE CARE AND LOCAL AND
REGIONAL SO HOW MANAGED CARE
MEDICAL MANAGEMENT. I HAVE
BOUGHT WHAT COULD BE AMENDED TO
CANCEL MORE THAN A DECADE AND I
FEEL THAT MANAGEMENT HAS MADE
ME TO PROVIDE GOOD QUALITY OF
CARE TO MY PATIENTS. MANAGED
CARE HI BE SURE TO PROVIDE
THIS. DOES NOT PROVIDERS TO
PROVIDE COMPLETE HEALTHCARE.
PATIENT. ALL CREATORS OCT TWO
GREAT CONDITION AND THE
DESCRIPTION OF THE VICTIM
WITHOUT EXTENSIVE.
INVESTIGATION ALL RECORDS. IT
ALSO BILL PATIENT PROVIDE
RELEASED AND HOW QUALITY OF
CARE- MANAGED HER GOAL TO THE
POLLS FISHING. HE OPENED SAME
VOTE FOR AND CUTTING OFF ON
THEIR OWN COME- MIGHT ONE COULD
BE TO GET. THE FULL BUDGET BUT
NOT K. SO MUCH. MISSION I HAD
THE TOTAL IT THAT MANAGE KIDS
TO GET- TO GET TEACHING RIGHT
TO RECALL EXAMPLES THE REGION
THAT MIGHT BE CANCER. AN HE
MORE ABLE TO GET THEM. WE A FEW
DAYS THIS IS A BIG HELP TO
PEACE. WHO DON'T TO DEAL WITH
THE HALF OF COURSE AROUND
LOOKING SPECIALIST OFFICE. IN
THE TIME MANNER I KNOW THAT
NINE CARE HAS. AGREED HAS TO
ATTENTION POPULATION. THANK YOU
FOR SO MUCH FOR THE OFFICE.
THANK MA'AM NOT CALLER PLEASE
ENTER AS A REMINDER OF HAVE
ROUGHLY PEOPLE LEFT IN Q. NEXT
TO ADELINE FOUR OH ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS BRETT KNOW
WHERE AND I REPRESENT THE
GOLDEN WEST CHAPTER OF THE ALS
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE URGING
SUPPORT FOR CONTINUED FUNDING
FOR THE A. L. S. WRAPAROUND
MODEL OF CARE INITIALLY FUNDED
AT NINE MILLION DOLLARS THREE
YEARS AGO. YOU WILL RECALL OUR
GOOD FRIEND AND MENTAL HEALTH
ADVOCATE RUSTY CEILINGS. WHO
HAVE BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH LOU
GEHRIG'S DISEASE AT THAT TIME
PROVIDED COMPELLING TESTIMONY
BEFORE SUBCOMMITTEE ONE FOR THE
INITIAL PROPOSAL IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. HE DIED FROM ALS A
YEAR LATER. THE WRAPAROUND
MODEL PROVIDES CRITICAL
RESOURCES TO ALS TREATMENT
CENTERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE AS
WELL A ASSISTANCE TO PATIENTS
AND FAMILIES AT HOME AND IN
THEIR COMMUNITY OUR CURRENT
PROPOSAL IS TO CONTINUE TO
FUNDING AT THE SAME LEVEL AT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR.
BUT WE ARE ASKING TO BE DONE
WITH ONE TIME DOLLARS OVER FIVE
YEARS. FOR A TOTAL OF FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS WE SIMPLY ASKED
TO BE ABLE TO KEEP DOING WHAT
WE HAVE BEEN DOING. FOR THE
GROWING POPULATION OF
CALIFORNIANS LIVING WITH ALS.
THANK YOU TO DR RAM DEALER IN
PARTICULAR FOR SPONSORSHIP.
MEMBERS AND STAFF OF
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE THE L.
A. O. AND THE ADMINISTRATION
CRUCIATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR NEXT ON PLEASE. MEXICO LINE
THREE NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ARAMBULA AND COMMUTING
COMMUNITY- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
DECADES OF DATA DEMONSTRATE
THAT TRADITIONAL MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES DO NOT MEET OUR NEEDS.
THE STATE THAT SIXTY THREE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLAR
REQUESTED SUSTAIN THE C. R. D.
P. WILL LEVERAGE EXISTING
TRUSTED COMMUNITY BASED
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN LATINO ACT ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER NATIVE
AMERICANS AND LGBTQ KEEPS YOU
CLASS COMMUNITY. WE HAVE
EXPANDED AND STRETCH TO ADDRESS
THE DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
OUR COMMUNITY DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
FUNDS NOW WE ARE ADVOCATING FOR
THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO INVEST IN WHAT
HAS ALREADY BEEN BUILT AND IN
THE SOLUTIONS. THAT WORK FOR
OUR COMMUNITIES. ABBAS OF THESE.
THESE SOLUTIONS ARE AT THE
CENTER OF NO LESS THAN THIRTY
SIX INVALIDATION WE CAN SCALE
NOW WHILE SEVERAL OF THE
PROPOSED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INTERVENTIONS. WILL BE AND-
PLANNING PHASE AS BEST THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE C. R. D.
G. WE ARE EXPANDING THE
RESEARCH BASE OF WHAT WORK TO
ADDRESS THE UNCONSCIONABLE
ETHNIC RACIAL LGBTQ CLASS
MENTAL HEALTH TO SHARE USED. IN
OUR STATE WE ALSO KNOW THAT WE
ARE THE MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS AND WE ARE SO FAR
PATH HIGHLIGHTING. CULTURE IS
AT THE CENTER OF WHAT WORKS AND
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE CANNOT BE DIVERSIFIED
WITHOUT US. I REALLY WANT TO
THANK DR ARAMBULA FOR ALL OF
YOUR SUPPORT IN CHAMPIONING AT
THE R. T. P. THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR LISTENING
AND PLEASE FIGHT FOR US MY NAME
IS FOCUSING ON WHAT OTHER MEN
I'M THE FEEL SAFE PASSAGES WE
ARE ONE OF THE THIRTY FIVE
IMPLEMENTATION PILOT PROGRAM.
AND WE ARE- ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TO HELP FIFTEEN THAT'S
VERY CRITICAL AND URGENT WORK
THAT THAT THAT REALLY
REPRESENTS. THE STRONGEST
POSSIBILITY FOR CALIFORNIA
FINALLY ADDRESS THE SYSTEMIC
DISPARITIES THAT HAVE EXISTED
FOR GENERATIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALL
PLEASE. NEXT TO THE LINE FOUR
OH NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK HI MY NAME WITH THE CAN
ATTACK ALONE AND I AM A PACIFIC
ISLANDER DESCENT TO BE SPECIFIC
I AM THE MOMENT IN THE MIDDLE
OF MOTHER EARTH THREE. I AM
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
ESSENCE OF MINE A PROGRAM UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT I SUPPORT
THE PROPOSED SIXTY THREE POINT
ONE MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDING
THAT WOULD SUSTAIN THE C. R. D.
P. THANK. AND HAVE A GREAT
EVENING. THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MEXICO TO ONE FOR IT
WILL FOR ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I CAN START WITH CARRY FROM
RIVERSIDE COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
AND ABOUT THE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH EXECUTIVES
LOCATION CAN HELP ADVOCATE OF
THE VISION OF CALIFORNIA ARTS
YEAH. OKAY NINETEEN LAID BARE
HOW FAILING TO INVEST IN OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE PUT LIVES AT
RISK AND BURDENS HEALTH
DISPARITIES CALIFORNIA CAN'T
WAIT UNTIL THE NEXT CRISIS
TRIED TO INVEST IN PUBLIC
HEALTH. I THINK IT'S PRECISELY
WHY KOBE NINETEEN BUT SO
DEVASTATING AND FELONY COURT
CALIFORNIA MUST INVEST YOU
UNDER MILLION IN ONGOING
FUNDING TO REBUILD LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND
WORKFORCE NOW LIVES DEPEND ON
IT. AND I'D LIKE TO JUST GIVE A
SPECIAL THANK YOU TO DR- DOCTOR
WENT FOR YOUR POWERFUL REMARKS
IN SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL
AND- PLEASE SUPPORT. CALIFORNIA
CAN'T WAIT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM MEXICO PLEASE. ACTUALLY
GOT A LINE TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD EVENING DOCTOR
ARE AROUND US BUT COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND- I ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA HEPATITIS
ALLIANCE. BURKE BUT LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT STRONG SUPPORT
ABOUT IN THIRTEEN EXPANDING
MEDICARE TO OLDER ADULTS
REGARDLESS THEM GRATION STATUS
AND AS MANY OF THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THE BIG FAN TO TALK ALL
ADULT. I 14% EXTENSION OF MEDIC
HELP TELL SERVICES ITEM TO.
EXPANSION A COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS AND ITEM TWENTY SEVEN
EXPANSION OF THE CRAP. GRAHAM
LIKE- MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES WE
SHARE THE DISAPPOINTMENT AT THE
LACK OF FUNDING FOR THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND
BLUECORE AND WHILE WE SUPPORT
THE ASSESSMENT AS MANY OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AS MANY HAVE
SAID- THE MONEY IS NEEDED NOW.
I'M ALSO HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE AND THE EPIDEMIC BUDGET
REQUEST WILL ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA IS NOT MOVING
FURTHER BROWN AND ADDRESSING
HIV VIRAL HEPATITIS STI AND
OVERDOSE. AS WE CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS THE CODE NINETEEN
CRISIS. WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE MENTION ON THE EVENING OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF ADDRESSING
INTERRELATED EPIDEMICS WERE
CRISES PRIOR TO BECAUSE THATIS
THE ONLY GOTTEN WORSE BECAUSE
WE'VE NOT BEEN ABLE TO IMPORT
TO REDUCE. PREVENTION TESTING.
KAREN TREATMENT TWO DURING CO
THAT I ALSO TO THANK YOU SO
MEMBER WHILE IN I'LL BE T.
POCKET PORTER THE COURT OF THIS.
REQUEST THIS REQUEST WAS WELL-
PUT TOGETHER WITHIN LENS
BECAUSE THEY RECOGNIZE THE
BLACK INDIGENOUS PEOPLE CALL.
OF THE G. P. Q. QUEST COMMUNITY
AS WELL AS OTHER VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
THE EPIDEMIC. AND ALSO BY
COLETTE. SO WE URGE YOUR- NOW-
SO THAT AS QUICK QUITE FOR MY
CALL. NOTED THE- REBATES ORDER.
THAT PROVIDED. AND CHAIRED MOST
VULNERABLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
WILL HAVE THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED TO MAINTAIN A CRITICAL
SERVICE FOR THE COMMUNITY.
EPIDEMIC AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
ENSURE THE FUNDING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCHFOR A CHANCE. TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALL PLEASE. NEXT WOULD ALLOW
THREE SAID THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING CHAIR AND
MEMBER JOSE COURT ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH ACTIVE CALIFORNIA THE
STATEWIDE HEALTHCARE CONSUMER
ADVOCACY COALITION. I AM
CALLING ABOUT ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTEEN THE EXPANSION OF
MEDICARE FOR AND DOCUMENTED
PEOPLE OVER THE AGE OF FIFTY WE
SUPPORT THAT THAT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WE BELIEVE
THAT OUR HEALTH SYSTEM IN
BETTER WHEN EVERYONE HAS ACCESS
TO COVERAGE. BUT WHAT THE
RECENTLY ANNOUNCED BUDGET
SURPLUS AND ONGOING AND THEN
MAKE IT EVEN MORE URGENT TO
COVER ALL UNDOCUMENTED DAHLE.
THESE HAVE BEEN PEOPLE WHO WERE
ESSENTIAL WORKER AND EXPOSED
DUE TO THE WORK THEY ARE STILL
IN NEED OF POWER COVERAGE AND
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE NOT NO
LONGER EXCLUDE UNDOCUMENTED
PEOPLE CALL MEDIGAP. THIS IS A
STEP FORWARD AND URGE THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
TO CONTINUE THE WORK TO TAKE
FURTHER STEPS TO REACH A TRUE
HEALTH FOR ALL. IT WAS ALSO NOT
INCLUDED BUT WE ALSO SUPPORT
THE REMOVAL OF THE MEDIC HOW
ASSETS YOUR SENIORS. AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES- AND FINALLY
I WOULD ALSO ACT RIDERSHIP
SUPPORT FOR THE HEALTH FOR ALL
MAY REVISED PROPOSAL ON BEHALF
OF AT THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU AND- THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND NEXT
MOVED TO THREE FORTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THE
SURPLUS SHARPLY THAT'S WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION ON ISSUE EIGHTEEN
C. PH I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR KNOWLEDGE IN
THE NEED TO PROVIDE MEDICATION
THERAPY MANAGEMENT AS COVERED
BENEFIT FROM. RECIPIENTS THE
RATE OF CHRONIC ILLNESS
CONTINUES TO RISE MTM WILL
PROVIDE PATIENTS THE NECESSARY
CARE TO HELP MANAGE THEIR
ILLNESSES AND PREVENT EXPENSIVE
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND OFTEN
ENCOURAGE YOUR RESULT THERE'S
STRONG EVIDENCE THAT THE USE OF
MGM BY FARMS IS AFFECTED IT'S
ESPECIALLY EFFECTIVE FOR
PATIENTS WITH MULTIPLE CHRONIC
CONDITIONS. COMPLEX MEDICATION
THERAPY AND MULTIPLE
PRESCRIBERS EPHA ABOUT PHONE
SUPPORT- ON ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN
WE APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S DESIRE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE CONTINUING TO
REMOVE ANY BARRIERS TO CHIU
INDIVIDUAL TO RECEIVE PACKED
AND PREPPED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND NEXT TO THE LINE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING-
MISTER CHAIR AND STAFF MEMBERS
THIS IS MICHELLE GAYLE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER. I AM CALLING
REGARDING ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN
MEDI CAL EXPANSION TO ALL
UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS. OUR LOW
INCOME UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS ARE LOCKED OUT OF
ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE AND ARE
DYING FROM TREATABLE CONDITIONS
NO ONE SHOULD TROUBLED BY DIE
DUE TO LACK OF HEALTHCARE
SIMPLY BECAUSE OF WHERE THEY
WERE BORN. WE REALLY APPRECIATE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL OF HEALTH
FOR ALL ADULTS SIXTY AND OLDER
BUT WITH SUCH SURPLUS NOW IS
THE TIME TO PRIORITIZE ALL
UNDOCUMENTED COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THAT HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED FROM
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE AND OTHER
PANDEMIC ASSISTANCE- WE URGE
THE GOVERNOR AND LEADERSHIP TO
SUPPORT HEALTH FOR ALL. AND
TAKE YOUR FAMILY MEMBER FOR
BEING A CHAMPION FOR HEALTHCARE
EXPANSION TO ALL REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALL
PLEASE. IF YOU MOVE ON THE LINE
FOUR HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH HAVE A GOOD EVENING DOCTOR
ARAMBULA ON OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT TO BETTER
HEALTH FOR CALIFORNIA. MY NAME
IS SONYA YOUNGER DON I'M CEO OF
CALIFORNIA BLACK WOULD HELP
PROJECT FOR OUR MISSION OF
BETTER HEALTH AND WELLNESS FOR.
CALIFORNIANS BLACK WOMEN AND
GIRLS. MENTAL HEALTH OUTCOME TO
THIRTY FOR THE STATE'S MOST
VULNERABLE RACIAL AND ETHNIC
POPULATIONS RESUSCITATED THE
INVESTMENT IN THE SECURITY TEAM.
ON AN EARLIER PANEL TODAY DR
RADHAKRISHNAN FROM THE OFFICE
OF HEALTH EQUITY HIGHLIGHTED
THE KEY STRENGTHS OF THE THEORY
IS A CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE
MENTAL HEALTH INITIATIVE TO
ELIMINATE STIGMA. THANK YOU
SHOULD BE TO REDUCTIONS IN THE
SEVERITY OF MNTAL ILLNESS FOR
RACIAL ETHNIC AND LGBTQ
POPULATION. IT WAS UNFORTUNATE
TO SEE THAT THE SUSTAINABILITY
OF THE THIRTY P. SIXTY THREE
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
EXTENSION WITH MISSING FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE. PROGRAMS
UNDER OPERATING UNDER THE
THEORY HE FOR THE LAST YEAR. IN
PARTICULAR HAVE WORK TO ADDRESS
THE ONSLAUGHT OF KOBE RELATED
IMPACTS ON THE MENTAL HEALTH OF
THE COMMUNITIES SERVED BY THE
THIRTY FIVE PILOT POPULATION. I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE
NUMEROUS PANELISTS TODAY.
INCLUDING THE HEADS OF SEVERAL
DEPARTMENTS UP LIFTED BUT
BEHAVIORAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF CHILDREN USE TEAM I
HEARD SENIOR IMMIGRANT
POPULATION. ETHNIC NON ENGLISH
SPEAKERS AND LOW INCOME AND
OTHER UNDERSERVED AND
MARGINALIZED POPULATION. THE C.
R. D. T. HAS BEEN AND CONTINUES
TO PROVIDE PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND SUPPORT TO THESE
POPULATION TARGET ANYMORE YET
MANY OF THE PANELISTS DID NOT
MENTION THE IMPORTANCE. OF
EXTENDING THE POWERFUL ALREADY
EXISTING EFFECTIVELY
IMPLEMENTED COMMUNITY TO FIND
EVIDENCE PRACTICES UNDER THIS
PROGRAM. MHSAA THEIR CURRENT
INVESTMENT IN THE THREE RD PEAK
OF CALIFORNIA AHEAD OF THE
NATION AND RECOGNIZING THE NEED
FOR INTENTIONALLY ADDRESS
DISPARITIES. CALIFORNIA.
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT.
THE FOREIGN OF AGAIN THE CLASS
TIME IS AN ON. HISTORIC CROSS
POPULATION POLLUTION BUT IT'S
NEVER BEEN DONE BEFORE IT IS
NOT HAPPENED AT THE STATE LEVEL
NATIONALLY OR EVEN
INTERNATIONALLY THIS PROJECT
HAS TREMENDOUS VALUE. VALUE TO
THE POPULATION THAT IS DESIGNED
TO SERVE MANY OF THOSE THAT ARE
CONSISTENTLY CALLED OUT AYE
PANELIST YES THEY DON'T ADDRESS
THE RACIAL ETHNIC LGBT. STATUS
OF THESE POPULATION. HE IS A
CRITICALLY NECESSARY MENTAL
HEALTH INTERVENTION.
INTERVENTION THAT IS WORTHY OF
FURTHER INVESTMENT
SUSTAINABILITY IS WARRANTED AND
IT'S NECESSARY AND FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COLLECTIVE WOMEN'S
HEALTH PROJECT AND THOSE THAT
WE SERVE TO OUR PROJECTS
OCCASIONALLY MOBILIZED THE
BLACK WOMEN BLACK FAMILIES AND
BLACK COMMUNITIES THAT WE SERVE
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
FOUR KEY REGIONS NEED THIS
PROGRAM TO CONTINUE. AND
DESERVE TO HAVE THIS PROGRAM
CONTINUE BECAUSE IT IS A PLACE
WHERE THEY GO FOR THE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS WHEN THEY DON'T
FEEL IS THAT THOSE SERVICES CAN
BE PROVIDED BY THE TRADITIONAL
SYSTEMS THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I
THOUGHT THE OTHER PROGRAMS AND
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SPOKE ON BEHALF
OF THE PROJECT AND I ALSO LIKE
TO ADD OUR SUPPORT. FOR THE
HEALTH AND RACIAL EQUITY
JUSTICE FUND AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TRANSFORM
COMMUNITIES CONTESTANT
INSTITUTIONAL GOVERNMENT SYSTEM
PROMOTE HEALTH EQUITY AND
RACIAL JUSTICE THIS IS A ONCE
IN A LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY TO
BEGIN DISMANTLING STRUCTURAL
RACISM AND BECOME THE NATION'S
LEADER IN ADVANCING EQUITY
OPERATIONS AT THAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND HAVE A GOOD EVENING
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
AND CLEANING THE WHOLE DAY. AND
TO LISTEN TO ALL OF US THANK
YOU THANK. YOU MA'AM. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. A LINE FOR
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THIS IS MARIANNA I'M THE
PROGRAM MANAGER AT LEAST NOT
SACRAMENTO PROGRAM. IS NOT
SACRAMENTO IT'S A UNIQUE SCHOOL
PLEASE PROGRAM THAT SERVES BOTH
LOCAL CHILDREN AND SACRAMENTO
COUNTY WHERE THE ONLY PROGRAM
THAT PROVIDES PREVENTATIVE
DENTAL SERVICES IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY THE SERVICES WE PROVIDE
OUR ORAL HEALTH EDUCATION
DENTAL SCREENINGS FLUORIDE
VARNISH TREATMENTS AND
NAVIGATION TO DENTAL CARE. THE
WORK WAS SCHOOL NURSES TEACHERS
UNTIL THE POOR STAFF TO PROVIDE
OUR SERVICES TO STUDENTS AGED
ZERO TO TWENTY YEARS OLD WERE
FUNDED AND SUPPORTED BY THREE
TNC TRANS LIBERTY DENTAL ACCESS
DENTAL AND HEALTH NET OF
CALIFORNIA WHAT MAKES OUR
PROGRAM UNIQUE IS THE
NAVIGATION TO DENTAL CARE WE
WORK. WITH THREE TMC DENTAL
PLANS. TO FIND AND CARE CLOSE
TO HEALTH AND ALSO PER TRANCE.
AND SANTA IF NEEDED. YEAH AFTER
SCHOOL YEAR WE PER SIR. TO
TWENTY THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE CHILDREN CHINKO THAT
SHUT DOWN WE PROVIDE IT TO MORE
HEALTH EDUCATION AND TRY TO
PREVENT OF PENNSYLVANIA SAYS HE
TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN
CHILDREN. OUR PROGRAM IS AN
ESSENTIAL PROGRAM FOR SCHOOLS
AND STUDENTS IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY. THE TEACHER DMG PLANS
ARE THE MAJOR PARTNER FOR ANY
SMALL SACRAMENTO PROGRAM THE
ELIMINATION OF PNC PLANS WOULD
JEOPARDIZE THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF OVER TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND CHILDREN WE SEARCHED.
I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
OPPOSED IN THE NATION FTNT PLAN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND OPPORTUNITY
ME COMIC DECEITFUL. THANK YOU
MA'AM. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
TO LITTLE FOR A PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD EVENING
EVERYBODY MY NAME IS YVONNE BUT
I DON I AM WITH THE HELP BROAD
COALITION- WE WERE SUPPORTING
ITEM THIRTEEN EXPANDING MATIC
HOW UNDOCUMENTED TEEN YEARS BUT
WITH A POSITIVE NEWS ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET ENTERPRISE WE
SUPPORT TAKING EVEN BIGGER
THEFT TREMENDOUS EXCLUSION AND
INCLUDED MANY UNDOCUMENTED.
PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE IN THAT
ACCOUNT. THIS CALL THE NINE
ARGENTINE THEIR SENATORS IMPAIR.
THAT WE NO LONGER EXCLUDE
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE WHO
HAPPENED SHE DID SO MUCH TO
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES AND
ECONOMY. THEY WERE ESSENTIAL
WORKER THE AND EXPOSE DUE TO
THEIR WORK AND ARE STILL IN
NEED OF COVERAGE CALIFORNIA HAS
UP PONDERED ABOUT GETTING AND A
SURPLUS- THERE IS JUST NO
EXCUSE NOT. TO INVEST IN THE
DOCUMENT COMMUNITY- BORE THE
BRUNT OF CALL NIGHTS. ON A
COUPLE ABOUT LEADERSHIP
CALIFORNIA LED THE WAY BY
PACKING HELP FROM KEATON TWENTY
FIFTEEN. AND HELPFUL YOUNG
ADULT IN TWENTY NINETEEN. TO
BUY COVERING- THE REST OF THE
POPULATION AT TWENTY SIX PLUS.
I WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SET
A NEW PATH FOR OTHER STATES TO
FOLLOW AND THAT CALIFORNIA ON
THE PATH. TO UNIVERSAL COVERAGE
THANK YOU SO MUCH DOCTOR AND
LAPEER CONTINUE. LEADERSHIP ON
THAT- I DON'T. THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. SHOULD
ALIGN FOR NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIRTY CAT ON
BEHALF OF THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
COMMENTING ON SEVERAL PROPOSAL
I DON'T ONE IN ADDITION TO THE
THREE MILLION FOUR VIEW OF
PUBLIC HEALTH PANDEMIC RESPONSE
REAL COUNTY- THE LEGISLATURE
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL TWENTY
PAST TWO HUNDRED MILLION I'M
GOING TO START REBUILDING LOCAL-PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. I DON'T NUMBER
FOURTEEN WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER PARITY
FOR TELEHEALTH AUDIO ONLY
SERVICES ASK CONTAINED WITHIN
EIGHTY THIRTY TWO ARE YOU ONLY
THIRDS OF HAVING CRITICAL AND
WILL COMMUNITY WILL OFTEN HAVE
AN ADEQUATE ACCESS TO BROADBAND-INFRASTRUCTURE. LASTLY WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH ITEM
THIRTY ONE THE DISCONTINUATION
OF LPS PATIENT CONTRACT WITH
COUNTY AND CURRENT TIMELINES
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS PROPOSAL
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATIONS AND
PLANNING ARE NEEDED WITH
COUNTIES ESPECIALLY AROUND
LOCAL CAPACITY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT LITTLE TO THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD
EVENING TERRY MEMBERS
ALEXANDRIA MEDICAL LEADING EDGE
CALIFORNIA LEADING OUT LEADING
EDGE CALIFORNIA HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF PARTICIPATING IN A
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AND IS
PLEASED TO SEE. MANY OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDED IN MAY
REVISED. HE OF THE MASTER
RECOMMENDATIONS AND SEARCH
TELAVI CALIFORNIA SENIORS AND
BOTH TIMES OF CRISIS AND CALM
AND PUT THE STATE. ON FIRM
FOOTING TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
EIGHT OF THE AGING STATE. WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
PRIORITIZE THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING SPECIFICALLY ONE EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT FOR THAT FOLLOWING
ITEMS DISCUSSED TODAY. ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT GERIATRIC CARE
WORK FORCE PROGRAM AS DISCUSSED
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR AND THE
PANDEMIC- INVESTING IN OUR
GERIATRIC WORKFORCES IS CRUCIAL
TO AGING ADULT. ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN EXPANDING MEDICALS AND
DOCUMENTED OLDER ADULTS- ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN MCCAULEY-
CONTINUED WORK EXPECTING
CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR THE
CHARACTER OF THE CAL A
PROPOSAL. AND ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY NINE- SUPPORT FOR
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE RESEARCH
AND TRAINING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM A MASTER
PLAN. FOR AGING BECOME
CALIFORNIA'S REALITY. THANK YOU
MA'AM. JUST AS OR ROUGHLY TWO
HOURS IN THE PUBLIC COMMENT AND
WE HAVE TWENTY PEOPLE STILL IN
Q. OPERATOR CAN BE OF THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ZERO NINE FOUR
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD EVENING ANDREA SAN
MIGUEL FROM PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES CALIFORNIA I'M
CALLING THE SHARED CONCERN
ABOUT ISSUE FOURTEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION TELEHEALTH
PROPOSAL AFTER YOU'RE A CURRENT
FLEXIBILITY IS A PROPOSAL TO
REIMBURSE AUDIO ONLY AT 65%
MACCALLUM MOUNT SIMPLY BECAUSE
THE PATIENT MAY NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO VIDEO IS JUST PARAMOUNT TO A
RATE CUT FOR CD THAT WRITERS-
ALL THOUGHT THERE BUT A LINE MY
COMMENTS- WHICH THAT WAS MADE
BY THE CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION TO ADOPT PROVISIONS
IN AB THIRTY TWO. I ALSO JUST
WANT TO URGE BUDGET LEADERS TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH ASSEMBLY
WOMAN ACTUALLY NORTH ITS
REQUEST TO STOP HARMFUL 80% OF
MEDICARE CAP- IT CURRENTLY
IMPOSED ON MEDICARE ALLOWED
SERVICES INCLUDING STI TESTS
AND- THE PROPOSAL WOULD ALSO
INCLUDE A ONE TIME FORTY
MILLION APPROPRIATION OF
MEDICAID EVERYBODY TO CALL
BACK- HERE TO HELP UNDER THE
LOAN PROVIDE ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION. STI TEST OF THE YEAR
HE'S CALL BACKS ARE
UNSUSTAINABLE COST MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT ARE NEEDED FOR
PATIENT CARE WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION ON NOT THANK YOU.
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER. SIXTY I
APOLOGIZE MEXICO LINE FOR
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS JENNA HE
WOULD ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
HARM REDUCTION COALITION- EVEN
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA
WAS EXPERIENCING A MAJOR CRISIS
OF HIV HEPATITIS FTI THE
OVERDOSE ON BLACK INDIGENOUS
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE EPIDEMIC- WE KNOW THAT
OVERDOSE CONTINUES TO BE THE
LEADING CAUSE OF ACCIDENTAL
DEATH HERE IN CALIFORNIA. IN
THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
MADE THESE EPIDEMIC EVEN WORSE
FURTHER EXPOSING DECADES OF
HEALTH AND EQUITIES DRIVEN BY
CHRONIC UNDERFUNDING AND
SYSTEMIC RACISM WE SEE THIS
CLEARLY IN THE OVERDOSE DEATH
RATES THAT ARE HIGHEST AMONG
NATIVE IN BLACK CALIFORNIA. IN
ORDER TO PREVENT A DRAMATIC
INCREASE IN BOTH DISEASE BURDEN
AND COST WE MUST INVEST NOW TO
ENSURE THAT LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO MAINTAIN
CRITICAL SERVICES OUR COMMUNITY
THANKS STRONGLY SUPPORT THE AND
THE EPIDEMIC BUDGET REQUEST. TO
ENSURE THAT THE STATE DOES NOT
LOSE FURTHER GROUND AND
ADDRESSING THESE EPIDEMICS WELL
ADDRESSING THE COVER THAT CAN
CRISIS THANK YOU. THANK. YOU
MA'AM. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
ALIGN FOR A SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- ELENA MARIA WHAT'S
NEXT IN CALIFORNIA CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE COUPLE ITEMS
FIRST- AS IT RELATES TO COVER
CALIFORNIA WE KNOW THAT THERE
ARE FOLKS A COVER CALIFORNIA
WHO STILL HAD TO VOTE
DEDUCTIBLES OF FORTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS WE WANT TO
PRESERVE THE OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION ALREADY ALLOCATED FOR
AFFORDABILITY ASSISTANCE. TO
CONTINUE TO HELP COURT
CALIFORNIANS BY REDUCING COST
SHARING AS WELL WOULD LIKE TO
APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR FOR THE
BEST TO THE UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY HOWEVER MORE IS
NEEDED AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP DR ARAMBULA ON THIS
FRONT. AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST
AS IT RELATES TO EQUITY AND AT
THE STATE GOLD TO THE DRESSING
SYSTEMIC RACISM- THE STATE
SHOULD FOLLOW THE LEAD OF
COMMUNITY AND FUNDED THE-
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT IS ESSENTIAL IN TERMS
OF THE SERVICES THAT THEY
PROVIDE IN THE EFFICACY AT
WHICH THEY DO IT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT LITTLE LINE
FOR THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.%
LINE FOR THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON THE
LINE FOR SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING KAREN
MEMBERS WHEN ACCIDENTS AT THE
LOCAL HEALTH PLAN CALIFORNIA
THE COMMENDED THE MINISTRATIONS
FOR MANY OF THE PROPOSAL
PERTAINING TO MEDIC HAL AND THE
REVISION PHYSICALLY THE
PROPOSAL THAT WILL EXPAND
MEDICAID ELIGIBILITY TO
UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS OVER THE
AGE OF SIXTEEN. THANKS AN
ELIGIBILITY FOR POST PARTUM
INDIVIDUAL THEIR OPEN SUPPORT
ADDING COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS
AS A MEDICAL PROVIDER TYPE.
LOCAL PLANTS HAVE A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT TO THE PROPOSAL
INCLUDING THE YOUTH AND HERA
HEALTH INITIATIVE AND THE
CALLING POPULATION HEALTH
MANAGEMENT GLOBAL. REGARDING
THE USE AND THEY HAVE A HEALTH
INITIATIVE LOCAL PLAN THE
BODY'S EDUCATION FOCUSED ON
HERE A HEALTH AND WELLNESS FOR
CHILDREN. HOWEVER AS STATED BY
OTHERS TODAY WE BELIEVE MORE
DETAILS ARE NEEDED INCLUDING
HOW ALL THE PROPOSAL PUT
TOGETHER AND THE ROLE THAT
CONDITION FOR MEDICARE MANAGED
CARE PLAN. FOR THE COUNTY AND
POPULATION HEALTH MANAGEMENT
PROPOSAL WE ABSOLUTELY LOVE THE
QUESTIONS RAISED BY THE ALLEY
OUT TODAY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
LEARNING MORE ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDING HOW IT WILL
BE IMPLEMENTED WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF THE BROADER
POPULATION HEALTH MANAGEMENT
LEVEL AND TALENT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MA'AM NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. YES WE GO TO LINES FOR.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I COULD EVEN
DOCTOR AND MEMBER HE LOOKS CITY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA RECALL IN
INCLUDES IN SUPPORT OF SEVERAL
ITEMS UNDER THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES THAT ARE
ALIGNED WITH OUR MISSION TO
EXTEND COVERAGE ALL
CALIFORNIANS. I KNOW THAT
CERTAINLY APPLIES TO ITEM
THIRTEEN EXPANSION FULL SCOPE
MEDI CAL FOR UNDOCUMENTED OLDER
ADULTS SIXTEEN ABOUT. ON ITEM
TWENTY THREE THE EXTENSION OF
FOR POSTPARTUM COVERAGE FROM
SIX TO TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT TO
TWELVE MONTHS. WE WANT TO SAY
THAT NOT ONLY IS THIS LONG
OVERDUE BUT THAT WE ARE ONE OF
MANY ORGANIZATIONS ARE HOPEFUL
FOR AND SUPPORTING ITS
PERMANENT STATEMENT AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL YEAH BEYOND THE
FIVE YEARS CURRENTLY ALLOTTED.
UNDER THE AMERICAN WEST YOU
PLAN. I FOR THEIR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIOR HEALTH NEEDS- WE
ARE EX. BY THE ADDITIONAL. FOR
COULD. AND INFRASTRUCTURE
BUILDING FOR. HEALTH PLANS- CAN
HEALTH PLAN C. B. AND SCHOOL
SPORTS SERVICE. I WE COMMENTED-
MEETING OF THIS UP TO. IN
SUPPORT OF THE ORIGINAL ON A
BILL AND A COVERS. BY BASED ON
OUR EXPERIENCE WITH A SIMILAR
MISCHIEF NEWSLETTER CLICK
TWENTY SCHOOL THE COST TO. AND
WE THINK THERE'S ADDITIONAL. OF
FOREIGN NO. WELL OBVIOUSLY TO
EVEN FOR IN EUGENE MORE
STUDENTS IN THE- THANK. YOU
THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALL PLEASE.
YES GO TO ONE FORTY SO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING DOCTOR
REGULAR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS WHAT THE FAVOR AND
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF LIFE
AS A PROUD SYRINGE SERVICES
PROGRAM OPERATOR IN COMMUNITY
HEALTH CLUB IN SAN FRANCISCO'S
TENDERLOIN NEIGHBORHOOD. GLIDED
IMPLEMENTED HARM REDUCTION
STRATEGIES SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF THE AIDS EPIDEMIC TO CURTAIL
THE SPREAD OF DISEASE REDUCE
STIGMA. PRIOR TO THE CALL THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA
WAS ALREADY FACED WITH
PERSISTENT CHALLENGES POSED BY
DRUG OVERDOSE HIV. STI AND
HEPATITIS C. ABJECTLY THE
SITUATION IS WORSENED AND THE
NEED FOR ASSOCIATED SERVICES
AND AMPLIFIED. OUR MOST
VULNERABLE NEIGHBORS AND LOVED
ONES PARTICULARLY BLACK
INDIGENOUS AND PEOPLE OF COLOR.
AND THOSE ARE AT THE
INTERSECTION OF HOMELESSNESS
AND DRUG USE EXPERIENCING THE
BRUNT OF THESE CONSEQUENCES CAN
MEET THE NEEDS. GLIDE STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE END ACADEMICS
COALITION BUDGET REQUESTS. THE
SCIENCE BEHIND A HARM REDUCTION
INTERVENTIONS IT IN FACT AND
THEY'RE EXTREMELY COST
EFFECTIVE. NOW IS THE TIME TO
SUPPORT THESE EVIDENCE BASED
APPROACHES TO CALIFORNIA'S
INTERSECTING PUBLIC HEALTH
CORRECT. WE HAVE TO THE STATE
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN A STRONG
COMMITMENT TO AND INVEST
FURTHER IN THE NECESSARY
SERVICES OUR COMMUNITY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO THE LINE FOR
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE FOUR FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND FOR FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DR ARAMBULA
CONNIE DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
DISTRICT HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP
FORM HERE- TODAY AT ON ITEM
THIRTEEN IN SUPPORT OF THAT
EXPANSION FOR THE MACALLAN
DOCUMENTED OLDER ADULTS AND
ITEM FOURTEEN WITH RESPECT TO
TELEHEALTH WE SUPPORT THE
PROVISIONS OF AB THIRTY TWO IN
THE URGENT ADOPTION OF THAT
LANGUAGE AS AN ALTERNATIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MA'AM. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
TO GO TO LINE FOR FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
CHAIR ERIC PAYNE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE- AND CAN YOU-
WE REPRESENT LOW INCOME
FAMILIES- ACROSS THE CENTRAL
VALLEY- AND WE'RE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
LEADERSHIP ROUND TABLE-
SPECIFIC ITEM THIRTEEN- DICK
VAN MEDICARE OUT THAT
UNDOCUMENTED OLDER ADULTS OVER
THE AGE OF SIXTY- WE ALSO
BELIEVE HEADS DOWN THAT'S ON
THE BOARD OF ADDING. THAT
PROMISE TOWARDS AND MORE
RESOURCES- THAT COULD BE ADDED-
THE TYPICALLY IN THE AREA- TO
MITIGATE THOSE ISSUES- AND WE
CANNOT. STRONG SUPPORT OF OUR
COLLEAGUES. I WHO CALLED HER-
THE TELE PAN AM HELP- I WANT TO
DO COULD NOT IT BRIEF- TO THE
POOR BATALLA EQUITY FINE- AND
THE HEALTH. AND PICKING A LOOK
AT THE NEW OF LOCAL FAMILY
ACROSS OUR STATE THANK YOU
GREAT. THANK YOU SIR. SIX
CALLER PLEASE. IN MEXICO FOR
FIFTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU- MY NAME IS WILSON AT THE
TIME THAT THAT KIND OF DIRECTOR
OF KNOCKED UP WHICH IS A
WELCOME AMERICA I DO SUCH A
THING FOUNDATION- WE ARE ONE OF
THE THIRTY FIVE. BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT THAT ARE TO TRY.
REDUCING THE- PROJECT- MATH UP.
DIFFICULT SIXTY THREE POINT ONE
MILLION. ONE TIME FROM COME NOT-OF THE JET FUND- DECLINE
FINDING WHAT THE GAME IS VERY
DIFFICULT CORPS I'D NAY HI
BECAUSE MOCKED UP PROVIDE- A
CULTURALLY WITH THE PEER PEER
THE FIRST. MY TRAINING SIXTY
TWO YOU LET. TO BECOME CLEAR
SEXUAL AND WILL TRYING YOUR
TWENTY FIVE AND ALL THAT. OF
THIS YEAR- AFFECT SERVICES
ARTICLE FACT. HE RESTAURANT
ACCOUNT. DURING THE TIME THAT
MIGHT MATH OF THE ONLY THREE
FUNDS NON NON PROP UP THIRTY
FEET ON THE NONPROFIT. TO CRIED
AND PEER TO PEER. EDUCATION AND
FIVE LANGUAGES SELECTIVELY AND
IMMIGRANTS- THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT BECAUSE SACRAMENTO
WHILE IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN I
DIVERSITY IT IS NOT HAS BECOME
ONE OF THE MANY MORE REFUGEES.
ARE RESETTLED BY THE- FROM UP
ON A FARM. IN IRAQ IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT THE TDP IT'S
SOMETHING UNFORTUNATELY- WHAT'S
LEFT OUT OF THE MAYBE BY AND SO
I DON MOFFATT AND SUPPORT OF
THE- ONE TIME FIFTY POINT ONE
MILLION ONE TIME FUNDING A
CONDITION OF THEIR GENERAL.
THANK YOU FOR THE LONGEST THE
TIME AND UP- PUBLIC THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND ACTUALLY LINES FREE
FOUR PLEASE GO. HELLO THURMOND
THANK. THANK YOU FOR THE- MY
NAME IS BOTH GOT YOU ALL AND
WITH THOSE GOOGLE CENTER OF THE
L. EMPIRE. WE ARE CALLING I'M
CALLING IN. OF I NUMBER THIRTY.
AT THE PAR OF HEALTH BROUGHT A
FOCUSING ON PLUS SENIOR
VETERANS- WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS SITUATION AT
THIS BILL AND WE'RE ASKING FOR-
PLEASE CONTINUE. SUPPORTING OUR
UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS A LOT AT
THE- UNITY MEMBERS WE ORGANIZE
OUR FARMWORKERS THAT HAVE GIVEN
THEIR LIVES HERE. TO HARVEST
OUR CROPS HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NOW IT'S OUR TURN TO
SUPPORT THEM IN THEIR ELDER H.
THANK YOU SENATE ASSEMBLY. AND
SENATORS. THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WE GOT A LINE
FOR FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES MA'AM
HELLO. HELLO ALL DOCTOR
ARAMBULA THANK YOU SO MUCH YOUR
GRACIOUSNESS AND LEADERSHIP ARE
SO GREATLY APPRECIATED-
GLENBURN ON WITH ON TRACK
PROGRAM RESOURCES AND I AM SO
VERY PROUD AND HONORED TO BE-
WITH THE TECHNICAL SERVICE
PROVIDER TO THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN. P. I. P. GRANT YOU
MANY OF WHOM YOU MET ALREADY
THIS EVENING- I AM GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF THE THIRTY P. I
AM GRATEFUL FOR MY- COLLEAGUES
FROM OUR- FROM THE THIRTY P.
AND ALLIES WHO HAVE ALREADY
SPOKEN THIS EVENING OF COURSE I
DIDN'T CATCH HIS NAME BUT THAT.
BRILLIANT BROTHER COMPLETE PLAN
I CAN'T WAIT TO HEAR THE
RECORDING ON THE DEFENSE THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND OUR BRAND NEW
VISIONARY DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY DR
RADHA KRISHNA- AND I WILL TRY
NOT TO DUPLICATE WHAT HAS.
ALREADY BEEN SENT SO. PERFECTLY
I'M- TO BRING UP COLD CHEN
OPENING REMARKS- ABOUT THREE
BASIC. THE ABILITY UNDER THE
BLUE OF THE EQUITY AND PROJECT.
THE MOST DIVERSE STATE. IN THIS
COUNTRY WITH JAW DROPPING
DISPARITIES ALL OVER THE PLACE
WE CAN WE CAN SPEND HOURS
TALKING ABOUT THE DATA THE
STEPS THAT TALK ABOUT
DISPARITIES HOW WAS THIS
POSSIBLE IN A GOOD YEAR HOW WAS
THIS POSSIBLE BUT IN THE WAKE
OF CORPORATE IN THE WAKE OF
GEORGE FORD IN THE WAKE OF
WHAT'S BEEN HAPPENING TO THE
API COMMUNITIES HOW DID THIS.
HAPPEN IT'S- THERE WAS A
REDUCTION SHOULD BE A PRIORITY
AND REQUIREMENTS ACROSS EVERY.
OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH-
CATEGORIES WE'VE HEARD THIS
EVENING. AT THE END INCLUDING
AND MAYBE EVEN ESPECIALLY THE
CHILD AND YOUTH BEHAVIOR HEALTH
INITIATIVES WHEN I THINK. OF
THE CHILDREN OF COLOR
ESPECIALLY BLACK CHIP GREAT.
WHO HAVE BEEN SEALED BY THE
SCHOOL SYSTEM. WHO HAVE BEEN SO
MANY CASES IN THE RECEIVING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INTERVENTIONS
DIVERSION TYPE PROGRAMS I'VE
BEEN PUNISHED I'VE BEEN TO
SPEND HAVE BEEN FATAL NEGLECTED.
AND THAT THIS I DIDN'T HEAR
ANYTHING AND EITHER THE
PRESENTATION OR THE PANEL ABOUT
HOW THIS FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
FUND WITHIN ANYWAY. BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT THAT THE DIVERSE CHILDREN
WOULD BE WOULD BE APPENDED TO
AND I AND I AND I HOPE THAT
WILL BE LIMITED AND THE STATE
WILL I THINK FOR THE POINT OF
COURSE WE CAN FOR THE CENSUS
RESULTS BUT I THINK WE'RE AND
SOMEONE WELL OVER SIXTY
PERCENT. RIGHT STUDENTS OF
COLOR HOW HOW COULD YOU BE
TALKING ABOUT THE CHILDREN AND
YOU CAN NOT AND NOT BRING UP
THE DIVERSITY WITH AN
APPROXIMATE POPULATION AND HAVE
NETWORKS TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
BUT ANYWAY AND OF COURSE I'M
I'M JUST VERY SAD THAT THE SUIT
BECAUSE WAS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN CUT I WILL REPEAT
THAT BECAUSE IT IS WORTH
REPEATING THE C. R. D. P. STAGE
TWO IS ON ON- ACCIDENT AND IN A
RESTAURANT ON MENTAL HEALTH
SOLUTION ORIENTED THE VALUATION
DRIVEN COMMUNITY BASED PROJECTS
INCLUDING THIRTY FIVE GRANTEES
ACROSS FIVE POPULATIONS THE
LIKES OF WHICH HAS NOT BALK.
HAPPENED. ANYWHERE AT THE- IT
SHOULD BE- A LEVERAGE IN EVERY
HOUSE WAY NOT EVEN. SO IF THIS
REQUEST IS NOT GRANTED. C. R.
THE P. WILL END. EIGHT OF
TWENTY TWO. IN ELEVEN SURE
MONTHS FROM NOW INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT HAS BEEN BUILT WITH WITH
GREAT RIGOR AND DIG A GREAT
SACRIFICE. IF THAT IS ALLOWED
TO END IT WOULD TAKE YEARS TO
REBUILD. OKAY AT ANOTHER POINT
IS ONE POINT IT HAS NOT BEEN
MADE IT'S NOT THAT WE ONLY WANT
FOUR MORE YEARS JUST TO EXPAND
THE PROJECT TO KICK THE CAN
DOWN THE ROAD AND WE KNOW WE
WANT TO USE THIS TIME. TO CLAIM
HOW TO BRING THESE PROJECTS TO
SCALE TO BE PARTNERING WITH
COUNTIES TO BE PARTNERING WITH
STATE AGENCIES ABOUT HOW WE CAN
BE BUILDING THE KIND OF COOLEY
SUSTAINABLE. FUNDING AND NOT
JUST ONE BUT IMPLEMENTATION
PLATFORMS FOR THESE FOR THESE
ACCIDENTS. PUBLIC OPINION IS A
PROJECT THAT I HAVE BEEN A
SOLUTION THAT THAT IS NEEDED
AND COUNTIES I CAN'T REALLY
EXIST CALIFORNIA ALL OVER SO- I
JUST WANT TO END BY SAYING YOU
KNOW PLEASE YOU KNOW FUND US
AND THEN YOU ACCESS. YOU KNOW
THIS STATE AGENCIES AND LOCAL
NEWS PARTNER WITH US WE JUST
WANT TO WORK WITH YOU WE WANT
TO BRING SOLUTIONS THAT WE WANT
TO BRING COMMUNITY- TO THE- TO
THE SOLUTIONS ON THE CALL-
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS AND
SIGNED FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
PLEASE SUPPORT THE REQUEST THIS
CALL ONE TIME EXTENSION. OF THE
ASEAN TT THANK YOU AGAIN SO
MUCH TALKED ARAMBULA THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. YEAH TO GO TO LINE
FIFTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANKS
MY NAME IS MEANWHILE THE WHOLE
WITH A CAL. AND APPRECIATE THE
YOUR PATIENCE AND THE TIME.
TAKEN WITHOUT WELL PAST EIGHT
O'CLOCK. I A. R. P. IF YOU'RE
TO BE GONNA FEW OF OUR BY
PRIORITIES ATTENDED TODAY'S
AGENDA. AND IS ON BEHALF OUR
TRIP THREE NON AND ALL OVER CAL.
FIRST OF ALL WE ARE VERY. FOR
THE NAME OF THE OF BUDGET. NEXT
MAKE SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH AND HOW
FUTURE AND IN SUPPORTING ALL
TELL. SO THEY CAN REMAIN ON THE
HOME AND THEN IT IS. WHERE THEY
WANT TO BE THERE WAS SO MUCH
CELEBRATE IN THE- HOW CLOSER TO
TWO DAYS CONVERSATION WE WERE
VERY TO SEE THE END OF THE
THIRD. ON THE MEDICAL MEDIC
OPTIONAL BENNETT THAT SOMETHING
THAT I'M- YOUR OPINION OR AND
THEN CROSS THE PRESS ON FOR
ONE. I DO TO RAISE UP IN VIA
PROGRAM I HAVE A HEARD FROM
MUCH OF. AND THAT IS OUR CARE
RESOURCE CENTER. THEY ARE
PRETTY STRONG SUPPORT. FIFTY
YARDS HE I WOULD FOR THE EXTENT
OF. ONE OF YOUR- AFTER CURRENT
TEN MILLION ON. AND FOR YOUR
FUTURE. UNTIL ALONG WITH THE
MILLION DOLLAR ARM AUGMENT. SO
PROMINENT WORST. CUT TO THE
PROBE IN THE PROCESS YEARS.
WELL WHAT ABOUT IF YOU THING TO
OFFER A FULL TO PUT FREE AND
VERY LOW COST CARE GIVING
SERVICES ARE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND IT'S A SPECIAL
IMPORTANT EUROPEAN NUMBER MANY
OF WHOM CANNOT CALL AS OTHER
PRO. SO I WILL- I WILL END HERE
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR. TO
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT CALL
PLEASE. MEXICO LINE FOR SIXTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS JESSICA
MORAN OF THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION WE WOULD LIKE TO
GET COMMENT ON ISSUE TWENTY
FOUR AT THE REGISTER THAT ONE
NATION OF DENTAL MANAGED CARE.
PDA APPLAUDS GOVERNOR NEEDS
NUMBER ENSURING THAT SACRAMENTO
AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY
RESIDENTS WILL HAVE THE SAME
ACCESS AS THE REST OF THE STATE
YOU WILL BE ABLE TO FULLY
BENEFIT BENEFIT FROM THE
EXTENSIVE IN INVESTMENT BUDGET
MAKE THEM MEDICAL DENTAL. THE
MANAGED CARE. BUT THE GENTLEMAN
CARE CLAN BUILT THE LEVER ON
MANY OF THE CLEAN SIDES IN THE
ANALYSIS AND IN FACT THE
UNDERPERFORM YOU FOR SERVICE
ANY COURT AND EVERYTHING-
QUANTIFIABLE METRICS USED BY
THE STATE. WE ALSO HAVE LINK IT
DOES NOT COMMENT ON VARIOUS
OTHER ISSUES BUT I WILL SEND
THOSE VIA EMAIL FOR THE SECOND
TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH HAVE A
GOOD NIGHT. THANK YOU MA'AM.
NEXT CALL PLEASE. NEXT TO THE
LINE FOR SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES MA'AM. PLEASE CONTINUE.
OKAY YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
STUCK AROUND A LOT AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR
DEDICATION AND YOUR PATIENT IF
YOU TAKE A MY NAME IS AND PROP
AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD IS MEDICINE
COALITION AND I'M CALLING ABOUT
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE WHICH IS
A MEDICALLY TAILORED MEALS
EXPANSION PROGRAM. AND FIRST OF
ALL I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND THE GOVERNOR FOR
SUPPORTING THESE PROGRAMS
PROGRAM- I'M ALSO MAINLY
CALLING TO SAY THAT CALIFORNIA
COULD NOT IF THE COALITION
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE MEDICALLY
TAILORED MEALS EXPANSION ONE
TIME OF FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM. AND THE PROGRAM IS
VITAL TO ADDRESS CRUCIAL
NUTRITION NEEDS A HIGHLY
VULNERABLE MEDICALLY FRAGILE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE CHRONIC
AND ACUTE ILLNESSES. AND THE
PEOPLE. WHO WILL BENEFIT FROM
THIS PROGRAM. OUR OUR LAW FOR
UNDERSTOOD COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED BY COPING NINETEEN.
AND BY OTHER DISEASES-
CHRISTIAN INSECURITY PROBLEM
HAS BEEN CLEARLY RECOGNIZED AS
A MAJOR ISSUES DURING COVER
NINETEEN AND BEYOND. SO THIS
MEDICALLY TAILORED MEAL PROGRAM
WILL BE VERY IMPORTANT TO
DELIVER HEALTHY MEALS TO PEOPLE
WHO NEED THESE TAILORED MALES.
AT THIS PARTICULAR TIME AND TO
ADDRESS THEIR ILLNESSES. ALSO
FORTUNATELY THIS PROGRAM DOES
UPHOLD HEALTHEQUITY A RACIAL
EQUITY- AND IS REALLY- YOU KNOW
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT OTHER PEOPLE
HAVE TALKED ABOUT IN TERMS OF
THE HEALTH DISPARITIES IN OUR
SOCIETY. SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
COLLABORATING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES
IN- WORKING OUT THE DETAILS AND
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PROGRAM THANK YOU AGAIN. THANK
YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
MEXICO CAROLINA FOR SEVENTY
FOUR. HELLO GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS JULIETT LEA AND I SERVE
ON THE NATIVE AMERICAN
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDER
TEAM FOR THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROGRAM I
ASKED YOU TO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED SIXTY THREE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR THE SECURITY KEY
FROM THE SURPLUS OF THE GENERAL
FUND. THE FUNDING WOULD STAY IN
A THIRTY P. FOR FOUR MORE YEARS
I ECHO MY COLLEAGUES EARLIER
COMMENTS AND I WANT TO COMENT
ADDITIONALLY ON THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE FUNDING TO CALIFORNIA'S
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE THE SEVEN
NATIVE AMERICAN GRINSTEIN'S
UNSERE DPR PROVIDING CRITICALLY
NEEDED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO THEIR OWN
INDIGENOUS COMMUNITIES. IN
CALIFORNIA'S MAJOR METROPOLITAN
AREAS AND ON BROUGH
RESERVATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
AND SEVERAL SPEAKERS HAVE NOTED
INTRODUCTION YOU THESE HAVE
BEEN SEVERELY IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC OF OPIATE OVERDOSE
SILVA NINETEEN AND ENTRENCHED
STRUCTURAL. AND EVERYDAY RACISM.
SEVEN YOU KEEP GRANT. PROGRAM
ARE DEEPLY ROOTED SHOULD WELL
CHARACTER. THAT HAVE BEEN
TESTED OVER. OF COMMUNITY LIFE
BUT MAY NOT YET ACKNOWLEDGED TO
BE EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE. THE
HERE YOU CAN SUPPORT THESE
TRIBAL SERVING STUDIOS AND
THEIR EVALUATORS ESTABLISHING
THAT THE EVIDENCE BASED. THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERING. A
CONTINUES FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM. THANK YOU MA'AM. NOT
CALLER PLEASE. MEXICO LINE OF
FOUR SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS REGINA
MASON AND I'M CALLING FROM
MONTEREY COUNTY CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT ON
HERE TO REQUEST THAT YOU.
SUPPORT THE SIXTY THREE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLAR. DOLLARS-
DOLLARS TO SUSTAIN OUR AND
EXTEND OUR THREE RD P. PROJECT
FOUR MORE YEARS WE HAVE A
PROJECT CALLED THE GIMIGNANO
PROJECT WE'RE WORKING WITH
CHILDREN OF AFRICAN ANCESTRY.
K. THROUGH FOURTH GRADE
TEACHING THEM THEIR CULTURAL
IDENTITY AND HERITAGE THEY BALK
LONG TERM AND DEBILITATING
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES IN
MONTEREY COUNTY THE DISPARITY
FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS WITH LOW
NUMBERS IF SO MUCH GREATER THAN
EVERY OTHER GROUP THAT OUR
CHILDREN ARE DYING AT. ALARMING
RATE IN TERMS OF LOW BIRTH
WEIGHT AND EVERY IMAGINABLE
DISPARITY THAT YOU CAN THINK OF
HEALTH WISE THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY IT HAS IT IN
GREATER NUMBERS BASED ON OUR
POPULATION WE ARE ACTUALLY
SAVING THE LIVES OF ALL THE
KIDS THAT WERE WORKING WITH AND
THE WHOLE ENTIRE COMMUNITY IN
FACT. THIS IS THE FIRST TIME IN
MARIN COUNTY THAT CHILDREN OF
AFRICAN ANCESTRY GET TO SEE
PEOPLE THAT LOOK LIKE THEM THAT
ARE TRULY HELPING THEM PARENTS
ARE COMING THANK THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HELPING MY CHILD IF IT
WAS NOT FOR YOUR C. R. D. P. IN
ANOTHER SATURDAY SCHOOL PROJECT
I DO NOT KNOW WHAT MY CHILD
WOULD DO BECAUSE KIDS OF
AFRICAN ANCESTRY. IN MONTEREY
COUNTY MAY ONLY SEE TWO OR
THREE KIDS IN A CLASSROOM THAT
LOOK LIKE THEM THESE YOUNG
CHILDREN THAT ARE SHOWING UP
EVERY SATURDAY AND NOW WE'RE
DOING IT VIRTUALLY DUE TO COLD
AT NINETEEN- COME THERE AND
THEY SEE THEMSELVES IN
INSTRUCTORS THAT ARE TEACHING
THEM IN THE CHILDREN THAT ARE.
BASICALLY. KICKED TO THE CURB
WHEN IT COMES TO GETTING THE
NEEDS ART ARE NOT EVEN. GETTING
THE KIND OF EDUCATION THAT THEY
AS A RESULT OF NOT HAVING THE
TECHNOLOGY NEEDS THAT THEY THEY
SHOULD HAVE ALL THE KIDS ARE IN
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM HERE
THAT OUR AFRICAN ANCESTORS ARE
BIG LAW. SO MUCH LEARNING AND
THROUGH THE SATURDAY THAT WE'RE
DOING WITH THEM THEY ARE ABLE
TO UP TO DATE AND- JUST CAN'T.
TELL YOU HOW MUCH. WE REALLY
NEED TO SUSTAIN ALL OF OUR
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE THIRTY FIVE
OTHER GROUPS THAT ARE WORKING
YOU DON'T NEED TO LOOK FURTHER
BUT TO COME AND LOOK AT ALL OF
OUR T. P. C. R. T. T. PROJECT.
TO BE ABLE TO SAY THAT ACTUALLY
WORK BECAUSE IT'S NOT NON
GOVERNMENT INSTITUTIONS THAT-
CONTROLLING MONEY THAT'S COMING
INTO THE COUNTY. WE NEED A SEAT
AT THE TABLE OUR LIVES OUR VERY
LIVES ARE AT STAKE AS COLBERT
NINETEEN HAS REVEALED. AFRICAN
AMERICAN PEOPLE ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY ARE GETTING THE SHORT
END OF THE STICK AND COULD NOT
SEE THAT- FUNDED THE FUNDING
WAS PUT INTO THE BUDGET IS JUST
ATROCIOUS BECAUSE- IT'S
UNBELIEVABLE THAT. OUR PROJECT
COULD POTENTIALLY GO AWAY AND
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO THE KIDS
AND ALL OF OUR PROJECT IF OUR
PROJECTS WERE TO GO AWAY THERE
WOULD BE THE SAME OLD THING. I
JUST WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY I CAN NOT.
EMPLOYEE TO RESTORE OR PUT
MONEY INTO THE BUDGET SO THAT
WE CAN SUSTAIN HELP OUR COUNTY
ARE COUNTY DON'T KNOW HOW TO
WORK WITH PEOPLE OF COLOR
BECAUSE THEY DON'T LOOK LIKE US
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW OUR
PRACTICES- HILL ARE PEOPLE AND
SO WE REALLY NEED YOU. STEP
INTO THE ROLE AND SUPPORT OUR
PROJECT AND I BELIEVE THAT YOU
ALREADY ARE ARE SUPPORTING OUR
PROJECT I REALLY WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO GO ON
AND ON BECAUSE I AM VERY VERY.
DISTURBED BY THE FACT THAT. OUR
PROJECTS ARE IN THE BUDGET AND
THEY REALLY REALLY NEED TO BE
SUSTAINED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR GIVING AN OPPORTUNITY.
THANK. YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND THERE IS NO ELSE
QUEUE AT THE TIME. OPERATOR DO
YOU MIND DOING ONE MORE- SEARCH
JUST TO SEE IF ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
DO HAVE A QUESTION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER FOUR FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING CARE OLOGY MY NAME IS
RITA MEDINA CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHT IN SUPPORT OF I
AM THIRTEEN STRONG SUPPORT AND
WE ARE ENCOURAGED BY THE
OUTLETS AND THE L. A. L. WE
HOPE THAT WE CAN PUSH FOR
MARKET APPRECIATE LEADERSHIP
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
MA'AM. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND
THE NEXT TOTAL LINE THREE
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS BIGGER
BUT I LOOKED AT COMMUNITY
HEALTH PARTNERSHIP A CONSORTIUM
OF PENN COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS FORTY CONNECTING SANTA
CLARA AND SAN MATEO COUNTY. I
AM SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EVAN LOW
PROPOSAL REFERRED AT THE MANY
MANY NAVIGATOR BUDGET REQUEST
WHICH WOULD HELP LOW INCOME
SENIORS ACT THAT THE HEALTH
COVERAGE THEY DESERVE. EACH DAY
OVER A THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
TRANSIT REQUIRED RESULTING IN
OUR STATE HAVING THE MOST
MEDICARE RECIPIENTS IN THE
NATION OVER THE PAST YEAR WE
THOUGHT OF POPULATION AT
GREATEST RISK FROM THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT. MOST AMERICANS
SIXTY FOUR YEARS. SIXTY YEAR
OLD GIRL. THAT ME THINK UNDER.
OF MEDICARE IF YOU HAVE
FACTORED IN LIKE INCOME
EDUCATION DISABILITY AND
LANGUAGE BECAUSE THE COST TO
ENROLL IN YOUR HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE ARE TREMENDOUS. THE
CONSEQUENCES OF BEING UNABLE TO
ENROLL IN MEDICARE AND MEDI CAL
ME NOT BEING AS WILL BE WITHOUT
HEALTH COVERAGE. LATE
ENROLLMENT PENALTIES. ARE
MATCHED WITH PLANTS THAT. MATCH
CLASS AND WRITERS WHO NOT BE
ABLE TO THEIR- HEALTH NEEDS OR
DEVELOPER. HEALTH CONDITIONS
THERE IS OPEN TO AVOID APPROACH
TO THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT I
FUNDING TO MEDICAID AND
MEDICARE. VERIFICATION PROGRAM
OF THE- YEAH I GET IT WILL BE
AS MANY NEGATIVE OUTCOMES AND
DELETED PLEASE DO NOT LET HER
TEARS FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS
PROVIDE THEM WITH THE NAVIGATOR
SO THAT THEY CAN RECEIVE AND
MEDICARE AND MEDI CAL BENEFITS
TO WHICH THEY ARE ENTITLED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT A LITTLE LINE FOR
THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN JOHN
VALENCIA HERE AT THE END OF
YOUR HEARING AN INTERESTING
EXERCISE AWAITING THE
ASSIGNMENT OF NUMBERS A BRIEF
COMMENT ON TWO ITEMS ON BEHALF
OF OUR CLIENT THE ALS
ASSOCIATION WHICH REPRESENTS
THE INTERESTS OF ALL FOUR
ACTIVE CHAPTERS IN THE STATE
SERVING ALL CALIFORNIANS. WE
DID WANT TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE STAKEHOLDER FUNDING
REQUEST MENTIONED EARLIER IN
THE HEARING AS ALL CHAPTERS DID
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN HOWEVER AS
YOU KNOW WE'VE SUBMITTED WHAT
WE REGARD AS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT BUDGET CONTROL
LANGUAGE AND RELATED BUDGET
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. THAT
WOULD INSTITUTE FUNDING
DISTRIBUTION CONTROLS TO BE
RETAINED BY THE STATE.
PERSONALITY IN THE SPENDING AND
TRANSPARENCY AS TO HOW THE
FUNDS ARE EXPENDED. WE'VE
COMMUNICATED THESE ESSENTIAL
CONSIDERATIONS TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ON STAFF. TO CDPH
SENT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE HOPE. IN THIS
FASHION TO AVOID THE ANOMALOUS
OUTCOME WITH THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN FUNDING WHICH WAS
APPROPRIATED IN THE BUDGET. TO
THE AIM OF TROPIC LATERAL
SCLEROSIS ASSOCIATION OF THE
HOLE BUT ULTIMATELY DISTRIBUTED
BY CDPH JUST ONE CHAPTER THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION IN
THIS REGARD. SHIFTING QUICKLY
TO ITEM FIFTY FOUR ON BEHALF OF
ILLUMINA OUR CLIENT WHICH IS A
CALIFORNIA HEADQUARTERED GLOBAL
LEADER IN GENOMICS. WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO
CONTINUE ITS ASSESSMENT OF THE
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE BOARD
FUNDING REDUCTIONS. IN THE
GENETIC DISEASE SCREENING
PROGRAM THAT ARE LARGELY
PREDICATED. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT IT DOES NOT UNDER RESOURCE
THE CAPITAL NEEDS OF ITS
OTHERWISE POSITIVE TRANSITION
TO CELL FREE DNA. NONINVASIVE
PREGNANCY TESTING WHICH IS
ALMOST CERTAIN TO GENERATE
HIGHER QUALITY RESULTS FOR
EXPECTED PARENTS. AND SAVINGS
THROUGHOUT THE HEALTH SYSTEM
THANK YOU AND GOOD EVENING.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MESSALINA FOUR TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHEN I
NOTICED THAT GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS NOT MY BELIEF IS THAT
POLITICAL MANY TADI I AND TO
THE NETWORK DIRECTOR FOR
DEMOCRATS AND COMMUNITY LEADERS
FOR THE JOURNEY COMPROMISSO
ESTABLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND
USUALLY COMPROMISSO STATEWIDE
NETWORK OF OVER FOUR THOUSAND
PROMOCODE ATHLETIC COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS. WHO LIVE AND
WORK IN THEIR OWN COMMUNITY.
BUT GOVERNOR'S BETA FIVE FUND
FOR THAT. IN THE MAYBE IN
SUPPORT OF CLINICS. IT DID NOT
INCLUDE PROMESAS Y. PRIMARILY
AFFILIATED WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE BELIEVE TO MAKE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION IS NOT AN
ADEQUATE INVESTMENT TO SUSTAIN
A ROBUST WORKFORCE. ESPECIALLY
CONSIDERING THE DEVASTATION
BACKORDERED I LAST ON LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. WHICH HAS
COST MANY THEIR LIVES COMPARED
TO OTHER GROUPS. DURING THE
PANDEMIC. WE SAW HOW
INCORPORATING THOUGHT OUT THERE
ME PARK WITH THE OF PUBLIC WITH.
HOW TO LIVE IN IN THE CAN THEY
SERVE. I'M ABOUT TO TRY MR AND
LOW COME. THEIR HIGH EFFECTIVE
REACHING HEAVILY IMPACTED
COMMUNITY ENTER MATH. THINKING
PEOPLE TOOK TRACY. TESTING BACK
TO. AND THE RESTORE. ON BEHALF
OF THE AS A CAL. AND WE URGE
THAT YOU TOOK FOR ABOUT AFTER
PART OF THE PUBLIC STE. AND
INCREASE FUNDING FOR THE PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE IN CALIFORNIA.
NOW THIS IS A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO RE ENVISION AN
EXPANDED PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
COMMUNITY. AND IN ADDITION WE
OFFER SUPPORT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOAD BUDGET REQUEST FOR THE
MEDI MEDI NAVIGATOR PROGRAM.
SHOULD FOR ALL AND THE
EXPANSION OF MEDICAL FOUR
HUNDRED UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS
WHICH. ADDRESS YES CONNECT THIS
IS. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MEXICO
LINES TWO I'M SORRY NEXT ONE
ONE FOR SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD EVENING- MY
NAME IS ALBERT CHLOE FALL- AND
I'M NOT HEALTH ECONOMICS AND
POLICY ADVISER TO CALIFORNIA
COVERAGE AND HEALTH INITIATIVES
AND WE'RE CALLING- TO- SUPPORT
THE BUDGET REQUEST A TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE MEDI
MEDI NAVIGATOR PROGRAM- OUT FOR
ITS EXPANSION ESPECIALLY. IN
TERMS OF- SUPPORTING- DUAL
ELIGIBLES ARE IN THEIR
SELECTION OF- IN THEIR
SELECTION OF MEDICARE PLANS
THIS PROGRAM IS VERY MUCH IN
SYNC WITH THE CALTRAIN PROPOSAL
AND- IT PASSAGE SUPPORT OF- THE
CMA CPA CA- THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PHYSICIAN GROUPS
CHEATER SINAI MEDICAL CENTER.
SHE SACKED- ADVENTIST HEALTH
SYSTEMS AND THE LATINO
COALITION FOR A HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA- WE ARE ALSO WORKING
IN CLOSE PARTNERSHIP WITH- BC
ON THE COMPROMISSO. AND R. THE
PROGRAM IS STRONGLY- LATINO
PAGE- MOST OF OUR MEMBERS AND
BOARDS ARLECCHINO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT COLOR. NEXT
IN LINE FOR THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
AHEAD. THANK YOU THANK YOU-
DOCTOR AND ON THE LAST MY NAME
IS JOHN AND PLAY AND I TO- AND
CALLING ABOUT THE MANY MANY
PROJECT FAMILY PLANNING FOR
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE AND ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
COVERAGE AND HEALTH INITIATIVE-
THAT INDIGNITY ARE STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION FOR THE MEDICARE
MEDICAL NAVIGATOR PROGRAM AND
WE'RE ASKING FOR SUPPORT FOR
THE CHILD MILLION DOLLAR
REQUESTS FROM- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW. AND ARE LOOKING FOR YOU
KNOW ARE HOPING THE THINK IT'S
KIND OF A SMALL AMOUNT BUT BUT
SHE'S A GREAT DEAL THIS FUNDING
IS GOING TO HELP US EXPAND
STRENGTHEN THE MOVE- ONE IT'S
AN EXISTING IN EFFECT HEILIG
PROGRAM TOWARDS SUSTAINABILITY.
I WILL ALSO HELP DRIVE DOWN
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS IN A
ONE TO ONE MATCH. IF YOU
PROBABLY HAVE HEARD PEOPLE SAY
ENROLLING IN MEDICARE IS OFTEN
CONFUSING FOR THE MOST INFORMED
ENGLISH SPEAKERS. BUT WHEN YOU
ADD TO THAT CONFUSION OFF AND-
UNKNOWINGLY TRANSITIONING
MEDICAL ELIGIBILITY RULES FOR
THE ASIAN ABLE- TO THE MEDICARE
SELECTION IT'S- IT'S A REAL
CHALLENGE. UNFORTUNATELY ON.
OUR LOW CONTINUES CHANGE WILL
ACT AS AN ECONOMIC PERIL DURING
THE TRANSITION. WE RECEIVED
REFERRALS FROM CLINICS LEGAL
AID AND OTHER COMMUNITY-
ORGANIZATIONS OFTEN AFTER THE
CONSUMER HAS ALREADY. LOST
THEIR FULL SCOPE MEDIKAL WE
CALL THAT THE TRAIN WRECK. WHAT
WE TRY TO WORK PROACTIVELY WITH
OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO
IDENTIFY LOW INCOME SENIORS
THAT NEED OUR ASSISTANCE WE
MUST EXPAND RESOURCES TO MEET
THOSE NEEDS. THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED TEN
THOUSAND MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES
IN CALIFORNIA THAT TURN SIXTY
FIVE EACH YEAR. WOOD FUNDING WE
CAN BETTER SYSTEMATIZED THE
PROCESS THAT ELIMINATE
DISRUPTIONS IN COVERAGE IN CARE
AS WELL AS MOVE TOWARD
INABILITY OF THAT. PROPERTY AND
THAT MODEL. IN OTHER WORDS WE
WANT TO AVOID THE TRAIN WRECK
BEFORE IT HAPPENS AND THE
TRUCKS CARE WE WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WE THANK THEM REMAIN LOW
FOR HIS SUPPORT IN HIS
PROPOSAL. NUMBER THANK YOU FOR
STAYING UP LATE AT NIGHT HAVE
YOU BEEN. THE LAST PERSON AT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IN
LINE FOR THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIRTY NINE MY NAME IS
LARRY JORDAN I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE KELP AVERAGE AND
HEALTH AND EXITED- I'M CALLING
IN REGARDS TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOTE- I'M READY MANY NAVIGATOR
PROGRAMS- THIS PROGRAM IS VERY
CRUCIAL AND FUNDING WILL HELP
TO EXPAND STRENGTHENED AND MOVE
IN EXISTING AND EFFECTIVE PILOT
PROGRAM TOWARD SUSTAINABILITY.
AS WELL AS WELL AS DROPDOWN
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS AT A
ONE TO ONE MATCH- GENDER
CONVENTIONS AND I'M GOING ON
MEDICARE AT SIXTY FIVE IS VERY
CONFUSING. FOR THE MOST THAT-
FOR THOSE WHO SPEAK ANOTHER
LANGUAGE SO AFTER THAT AND
YOU'RE SAYING TWO DIFFERENT
MEDICAL ELIGIBILITY RULES FOR
THE AGED AND DISABLED AS WELL
AS MEDICARE WORKS A LOW INCOME
SENIORS AND THEY THEY FACE THE
CHALLENGE. BANDILA MEDI MEDI
NAVIGATOR PROGRAMS STATEWIDE
WILL COME UP AND BILITY OF
LOCAL AGENCIES TO ADDRESS BOTH
THE HIGHER NUMBER OF DUAL
ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
TRANSITION TO MEDICARE- MEDI
MEDI NAVIGATOR PROGRAM WILL
HELP BECAUSE THEY- WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT. ALL THE BENEFITS
TO WHICH THEY ARE THEY ARE
ENTITLED BOTH MEDICARE AND MEDI
CAL COVERAGE AND HELP THEM GET
ACCESS TO THE PLANNED- AND
PROVIDERS I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND- WE APPRECIATE YOU
LISTENING TO ALL OUR COMMENTS.
HAVE A GOOD EVENING. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER. A LINE FORCE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DR ARAMBULA
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS ALBUM KIND OF MANDATE FROM
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
COMMUNITY HEALTH INITIATIVES-
AND WE HAVE WE PROVIDE IN OUR
HEALTH INSURANCE ENROLLMENT
SERVICES- ALSO RETENTION
UTILIZATION IN VARIOUS COUNTIES
NAPA COUNTY LOS ANGELES- OPEN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND SOLANO
COUNTY. AND WE'RE ALSO A MEMBER
OF CALIFORNIA COVERAGE AND
HEALTH INITIATIVES AND I AM
HERE IN OUR FULL SUPPORT- TO
QUEENS- ACCEPT THE REQUEST OF A
FAMILY MEMBER- EVAN LOW AND
SHOOTING AT INCLUDE. THE
FUNDING FOR MANY MANY NAVIGATOR
PROGRAM- AS AN ORGANIZATION
THAT PROVIDES DIRECT SERVICES
TO INDIVIDUALS IN THE COMMUNITY
ESPECIALLY TO OUR SENIORS WHO
FIND THEMSELVES- REALLY AND
NAVIGATING TWO OF THE MOST
COMPLEX PROGRAMS- AVAILABLE TO
THEM THEY'RE BEAUTIFUL PROGRAMS
THERE'S A LOT OF SERVICES AND
BENEFITS PACKAGE REALLY
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND HOW TO
NAVIGATE THIS WITHOUT THE-
SUPPORT AND ESPECIALLY THE
SUPPORT COMING FROM NONPROFIT
AGENCIES. THAT PROVIDE THE
CRITICAL AND IMPORTANT OUT
REGIONAL MEANT RETENTION
UTILISATION IT'S ENOUGH TO KEEP
OUT OF THE WORLD THAT EXISTS
BUT THE MEDICAID AND MEDICARE-
MANY ORGANIZATIONS ESPECIALLY
UNDER CALIFORNIA COVERAGE AND
HEALTH INITIATIVES ARE DOING AT
THE DUE DILIGENCE OF
CONNECTING. OUR SENIORS THE WAY
IT IS- RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
THEM IN THEIR COMMUNITIES- BUT-
MORE SO IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW
ESPECIALLY DURING THE PANDEMIC
WE HAVE SEEN OUT HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS FOR HER OUR LOW INCOME
SENIORS AND TO HAVE THE SUPPORT
AND- AND NAVIGATE ALL OF THIS
TO TRUSTED- TRUSTED MESSENGERS
AND MANY OF THESE ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING LIKE MYSELF- ARE
DISTRACTED MESSENGERS TO HELP
OUR SENIORS NAVIGATE- THAT
THEY'RE. NOT ACCOUNT AND
MEDICARE I ATTRIBUTES MENTIONED
THESE ARE COME PROGRAMS THERE'S
LOTS OF STORIES JUST ABOUT THE-
IN- MENTIONED WE WANT TO WE
WANT TO THERE FOR SENIORS TO
PREVENT THEM FROM LOSING TIME.
IN HELP THEM NOW THE VERY TO
CONTACT PROGRAM. ON FEB I THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME
INTERESTING ALSO DEFLATE AND
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT- AS WE
MOVE FORWARD IN IN HELPING AND
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE THIS WORK
IN OUR COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALL
PLEASE. THAT BRINGS LINE FOR
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
KIDDING ME DR RANDALL- IN
OAKLAND MY NAME IS YOLANDA
RANDALL I'M EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE WEST RESIDENTS FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTER WE CAN ONLY
IMPLEMENT A PROGRAM CALLED THE
SWEET POTATO PROJECT WHICH IS
FUNDED THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
DESERT CALOTES CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT.
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES ABOUT
ALREADY SPOKEN THIS EVENING. I
AM HERE TO SUPPORT. AND REALLY
NEED YOUR SUPPORT IN TERMS OF
SUPPORTING OUR REQUESTS WERE
SIXTY THREE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
OUR WORK THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE THIRTY
FIVE PROJECTS. THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE
ALREADY EMBEDDED ALREADY
TRUSTED LEADERS WERE ALREADY
TRUSTED MESSENGERS NOT UNION.
THIRTEEN YEAH- GET. LIKE YOU
KNOW AFRICAN AMERICAN JUST A
WIDE VARIETY OF. CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS WE ARE HERE WE ARE
HERE WE ARE READY TO PARTNER WE
ARE READY TO PARTNER WITH LIKE
TELL ME WITH A STRAIGHT WITHOUT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO ENSURE THAT
WE EXPECTED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. HAVE A GREAT IMPACT
ON OUR COMMUNITY AND
POLITICALLY AND WHAT THE C. R.
D. P. WE NEED TO CONTINUE OUR
WORK AND WE ENCOURAGE YOU
PLEASED. SUPPORT DISCIPLINE TO
CUT ONE MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE
ARE IN NEED OF TO CONTINUE MY
WORK THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU LONG DONE FOR INVITING ME
TO THE HARVEST. OPERATOR NEXT.
WE HAVE AN ONE ELSE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. OPERATOR CAN WE DO
ONE FINAL SWEEP. AND ONCE AGAIN
IF OU HAVE A QUESTION PLEASE
PRESS ONE OUR COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I DON'T HAVE ANYBODY
QUEUING UP THANK YOU OPERATOR
AND WE'LL TAKE THAT AS THE
CONCLUSION OF PUBLIC COMMENT.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE PUBLIC
FOR THEIR ROBUST DISCUSSION
TODAY AS WELL AS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS WHO JOIN ME ON THE
DIETS. BUT ALSO LIKE TO THANK
THE SERGEANTS AND TECH STAFF
WHO HELPED TO PUT ON THIS
HEARING. BUT MOSTLY I WANT TO
THANK ANDREA MARGOLIS WHO
HELPED US TO PUT THIS AGENDA
TOGETHER AND IS ALWAYS DONE A
GREAT JOB AND SOMEONE. WITH
THAT WE WILL CONCLUDE TODAY'S
HEARING. THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH.